ja vielen Dank Constanze abratsky in der
Tat zwischen den beiden
parteitagswochenende liegt ja die Woche
in Deutschland wo alle Bundesländer
gleichzeitig in Ferien sind in den
Sommerferien und dort hat die AFD
trotzdem nicht abhalten lassen hier
einen wichtigen Parteitag abzuhalten den
14 in ihrer parteihistorie verbunden mit
einer europawahlversammlung das geht
über zwei Wochenenden heute morgen und
Sonntag und das gleiche noch mal Freitag
bis Sonntag dann der nächsten Woche dazu
gleich noch mehr die AFD
lebt ja im Moment in einem Umfrage hoch
das ist geprägt die Diskussion in der
Partei die Euphorie ist groß manche
können vor Kraft kaum laufen auch da
liegt ja eine gewisse Gefahr drin aber
diese Einstellung auf dem Weg nach oben
zu sein die wird natürlich auch die
Übertragung hier vom Parteitag prägen
wir werden alles kritisch hinterfragen
und einordnen mit Interviews natürlich
auch mit der Übertragung der
parteitagsdebatten hier was ist
eigentlich alles heute
morgen und am Sonntag zu erwarten gibt
was sie überhaupt in dieser
großversammlung mit 600 Delegierten in
den nächsten sechs Tagen sind es ja zu
erwarten haben das wird Ihnen jetzt
meine Kollegin Katharina kühnschildern
ja vielen Dank Alexander Keller wir sind
hier im
Messegelände in Magdeburg und es sind
nicht ganz 600 Delegierte denn aus der
AFD da gab es Probleme bei der
Aufstellung der Delegierten und deswegen
sind es doch ein bisschen weniger und
wir wollen mal schauen was jetzt ansteht
die nächsten Tage das ist nämlich auch
das ist ähm doch etwas ungewöhnlich ich
hier noch nicht so ganz klar heute erst
einmal ist eben der Bundesparteitag da
geht es um Abstimmungen ob sich z.B die
AFD der europäischen Partei Identität
und Demokratie anschließen möchte es
stehen Satzungsänderungen an aber auch
ähm möchte man neue Mitglieder für das
Partei interne Schiedsgericht wählen und
das ist schon interessant weil die
Partei selber sagt ist nicht so ganz
einfach da immer Kandidaten zu finden
deswegen möchte man dort auch die
Voraussetzungen etwas verändern
interessant wird für uns zum Beispiel
auch sein ob die Spendenaffäre aus den
vergangenen Jahren noch eine Rolle
spielt da gibt es zum Beispiel einen
Antrag dazu ob man sich damit noch mal
genauer beschäftigt das werden wir dann
hier in der Debatte mitkriegen und dann
morgen dann wird es interessant weil es
auch für uns dann etwas unvorhersehbarer
wird da geht's dann nämlich nicht mit
der Bundespartei Tag sondern morgen ist
dann die Europa Versammlung der AFD da
geht es um das Wahlprogramm und die
Bewerber und Ersatzbewerber für die
Europawahl ursprünglich war so geplant
dass es zuerst um das Parteiprogramm
geht und dann über die Kandidaten
abgestimmt werden soll das soll nun
allerdings geändert werden die
Reihenfolge denn der Bundesvorstand
möchte eine rechts sichere Liste
aufstellen so nennt er das und sagt dass
die Listenaufstellung nicht zu lange
über einen zu langen Zeitraum sich
erstrecken darf und deswegen will man
nun damit anfangen dass man zuerst über
die Kandidaten abstimmt und dann erst
über das Programm dafür ist morgen
Samstag und Sonntag eingeplant sowie
nächste Woche noch mal Freitag bis
Sonntag und dann soll das alle stehen
allerdings gibt es da auch schon fragen
ob das so alles klappt denn die AFD
steht wie gesagt in Umfragen sehr gut da
30 Kandidaten möchte man aufstellen denn
die AFD kann momentan Herr hoffen bis zu
20 Sitze im Europaparlament zu bekommen
wenn sie bei den Umfragewerten bleibt
und das muss man sich jetzt mal
vorstellen wenn jeder Bewerber wie
momentan geplant 7 Minuten Redezeit
bekommt dann noch Fragen beantworten
soll dann kann es sein dass das ganz
schön lange dauert das vielleicht sogar
diese fünf Tage nicht reichen und auch
das haben wir hier schon gehört
vielleicht muss es dann noch einen
Sonderparteitag für das Programm geben
wir werden hier zuhören und hoffentlich
durch diesen Parteitag äh manövrieren
immer verstehen worum es geht soweit
aber erstmal ein erster Überblick von
mir und damit zurück zu Alexander Keller
ja danke Katharina wie gut die AFD im
Saft steht kann man unter anderem auch
daran sehen dass es sich doch ein
ziemlich ungelöstetes Führungsproblem
ganz an der Spitze leise es scheint
ebenfalls ungelöst zu sein Stichwort
Björn höcke ante portas er hat ja auf
dem letzten Parteitag in Riesa
durchgesetzt das in Zukunft anders als
bisher auch nur einer Parteivorsitzender
sein kann und alle vermuten dass er da
demnächst nach diesen Sitz auch greifen
wird
kinopala Leben alles weitere an der
Spitze ist jedenfalls Parteivorsitzender
immer noch und wird es auch weiterhin
sein zumindestens bis zum Partei im
nächsten Jahr und der war vor kurzem bei
mir zum Interview
ich denke für Deutschland wäre es gut
wenn wir nicht wussten Kanzlerkandidaten
aufstellen sondern auch für Deutschland
ein Kanzler stellen aber ich denke das
sind Dinge die werden wir dann zur
Bundestagswahl nächstes Jahr Ende
nächsten Jahres auch in der Partei
debattieren aber es ist ganz klar für
uns dass wir natürlich auch irgendwie
Verantwortung kommen wollen und kommen
müssen damit ist Deutschland wieder
besser geht jetzt sind sie im Moment ja
die Umfrage Könige allerdings habe ich
gestern auf dem Presse haben ihre Partei
also von einigen ihrer Parteifreundinnen
und Freunde gehört die gewisse Gefahr
dass jetzt die Euphorie zu groß wird
dass man zu selbstgefällig zu
selbstsicher ist sehen Sie da auch eine
Gefahr dass möglicherweise der Höhenflug
der AFD zu Ende geht hätte natürlich
auch Aufgabe des Bundesvorstand ist auch
der beiden bundesprecher hier mit Demut
natürlich an Umfragen heranzugehen sie
haben vollkommen recht es sind Umfragen
noch keine Ergebnisse wir haben dieses
Jahr zwei wichtige Landtagswahlen noch
vor der Brust das ist in Hessen und in
Bayern erfolgreich abschließen wollen
und dann natürlich nächstes Jahr die
drei ostdeutschen Landtagswahlen aber
auch vor allen Dingen die Kommunalwahlen
die sehr wichtig sind wie Sie wissen
haben wir auf kommunal eben ja Erfolge
vorzuweisen und die wollen wir ausbauen
man kann natürlich die Europawahl also
von daher ist Demut angebracht aber es
ist natürlich auch Motivation für unsere
Wahlkämpfer und Kandidaten vor Ort in
ihrer alten politischen Heimat der CDU
hat der aktuelle Parteichef ziemlich
viel Verwirrung gestiftet mit der
Zusammenarbeit in Sachen Zusammenarbeit
mit der AFD die Schadenfreude bei ihnen
ist ja grenzenlos im Moment darüber aber
jetzt hat er unglaublich viel Widerstand
in der eigenen Partei damit provoziert
musste auch zurückrudern könnte sein
dass ich dadurch ungewollt für Sie die
Brandmauer wieder stabilisiert
nun ich habe ja immer gesagt und gerade
wir als Ostdeutsche kennen hier und
wissen ja was Brandmauern bedeutet diese
brandmaul die Friedrich Merz aufgebaut
hat in mittlerweile ist er Gefangener
der grüne Ideologie selbst weil er muss
dann natürlich mit den
Koalitionspartnern die aktuell da sind
die für Deutschland nichts Gutes
Vorhaben vor allen Dingen grünen Politik
weitergestalten und das werden wir
natürlich gnadenlos auch benennen und
auch seine Doppel gnadenlos benennen
dieses HU und Hot schade natürlich der
CDU aber wissen Sie dass es nicht meine
Aufgabe der CDU Ratschläge zu geben ich
habe immer gesagt dass Friedrich Merz
nicht derjenige ist der die CDU
reformieren wird und es hat sich
bestätigt aber sie brauchen die CDU und
regieren zu können müssen sie am Ende
wollen wir mit den zusammenarbeiten die
es gut mit Deutschland meinen die die
Interessen der deutschen vertreten die
endlich Politik für unsere Mittelstand
für unsere Industrie für unsere Bürger
machen das kann auch SPD Personen sein
wir müssen endlich wieder zusammenfragen
kommen und zur lösungsorientierten
ansetzen wir müssen endlich wieder dazu
kommen Probleme und Ursachen zu lösen
das aber die Menschen dann wird auch die
Politikverdrossenheit in diesem Land
zurück verdrängt das ist ein übrigens
Aufgabe aller demokratischen Parteien
sollten sich die sehr guten
Umfrageergebnisse für die AFD in
Thüringen für die Landtagswahl
bewahrheiten dann wird Björn höcke kaum
noch der alleinige Parteivorsitz in der
AFD zu nehmen sein könnte sein oder
rechnen Sie damit dass Sie im nächsten
Jahr neben Alexander gauland
Ehrenvorsitzender der AFD werden
sein ich bin aktuell sehr zufrieden mit
meinem Bundesvorstand den wir letztes
Jahr hier gewählt haben der hat Ruhe und
Gelassenheit in die Partei gebracht
Geschlossenheit eigentlich in unserer
zehnjährigen Geschichte einzigartig und
das nehmen natürlich auch die Wähler zu
Kenntnis wir müssen jetzt diese
Verantwortung wahrnehmen und wir werden
jetzt keine Personal Debatten noch dazu
öffentlich führen das machen wir intern
so wie wir die letzten Monate gut und
erfolgreich getan haben dass wenn du
auch in Zukunft zu gestalten aber die
Frage Weihnachten höcke dass er bei
erste Gelegenheit nach der Macht greift
vertrauen sie ihm
in der Politik ist Vertrauen ich denke
mal auch dort das falsche Wort ich habe
mit Björn höcke einen guten Kontakt es
ist richtig wie mit allen
Landesvorsitzenden Unternehmer erstmal
sehen ob er überhaupt will ist auch nach
Berlin zu gehen am Ende muss es auch
dahin gehen sein dass wenn man diese
Partei führen will und auch eine
Fraktion führen will dass man dann auch
den Schritt in den Bundestag Wagen muss
ich denke ist in Thüringen gut aufbauen
er macht dort eine gute Landespolitik er
hat doch viel Arbeit und er kann auch
aus Thüringen heraus auch
bundespolitisch wirken die AFD lebt ja
im politischen Schlaraffenland kann man
sagen sie müssen nur den Mund aufmachen
und die gebratene Tauben in dem Fall die
sehr guten Umfrageergebnisse fliegen
immer nur noch rein
jetzt ist ja die Frage
wie wird das weitergehen wenn eine
Partei quasi leistungslos solche tollen
Ergebnisse einfährt sie tut ihr nichts
dafür ja Herr Keller da muss ich Ihnen
natürlich deutlich widersprechen also
dass wir nichts dafür tun ich habe es
hier gerade gesagt erstens mal unsere
Geschlossenheit ist das erste
Aushängeschild wir haben aber
Alleinstellungsmerkmal wie kritisieren
ganz klar die Sanktionspolitik die
mittlerweile ja der Wirtschaft schade
der IWF hat das ja mittlerweile auch
klar definiert dass Deutschland in der
Rezession angekommen ist wegen der
Aktionen auch wegen der Reaktion
natürlich wegen was sonst ich meine
Russland den eigentlich die Sanktionen
haben haben einen Wirtschaftswachstum
das muss man sich vorstellen wir haben
auch EU eben eine über 10 sanktions
Pakete geschnürt und Russland schade
diese sanktions Politik nicht sondern
Deutschland mittelständische
Informationen die Frage ist
immer mehr Unternehmer tragen sich mit
dem Gedanken Deutschland von zu
verlassen also hier muss es endlich
einen Weckruf geben hier muss es endlich
auch einen ein Signal geben Scholz
spricht von einem Wirtschaftswunder der
wohnt wann soll es denn kommen
Krieg bei den Auslöser aber
wahrscheinlich nicht die Ursache
weil sie sagen sie müssen wir
widersprechen sie müssen gar nicht Herrn
Keller widersprechen sondern sie müssen
ja eigentlich im Ehrenvorsitzenden
widersprechen weil Alexander gauland
nämlich gesagt hat das ist nicht das
Verdienst der AFD die guten Ergebnisse
der Fehler der anderen und das muss man
realistisch sehen so hat das nicht
gesagt er hat natürlich gesagt natürlich
haben die anderen ihren Beitrag
geleistet aber wissen das ist wie im
Sport also wenn ich im Fußball gewinne
dann sage ich doch nicht also natürlich
haben die andere Fehler gemacht die
oppositioniert und profitiert immer von
Fehlern der andere das ist ja der
Aufgabe einer Opposition du musst mal
die Frage stellen warum profitieren die
anderen Oppositionsparteien nicht
wirklich davon die CDU er relativ wenig
die Linke überhaupt nicht weil wir die
einzig wahrnehmbare Oppositionen sind
weil wir für die Interessen Deutschlands
auch für die Interessen der Wirtschaft
Politik machen und das erkennen immer
mehr Menschen haben sie damit ziemlich
viel Erfolg im Moment soweit
Kinoprogramm der Bundessprecher der AFD
danke für das Interview sehr gerne jetzt
Bilder aus der Halle in fünf Minuten
etwas soll es losgehen hier in Magdeburg
ist gerade von der Tagungsleitung
angekündigt werden kurzer Hinweis noch
mit mir von mir noch zu Beginn das
Interviews da gab es ein technisches
Problem meine Frage die erste Frage
lautet der ob die AFD damit rechnet
bereits 2025 ins Kanzleramt einzuziehen
und die Antwort von kinoprophaler die
haben sie dann gehört so wie gesagt noch
vier fünf Minuten alles Wichtige was wir
jetzt zum ein paar Tage noch mal wissen
müssen was da ab geht von Katharina kühn
ja und man muss sagen dass so ein
Parteitag nicht pünktlich startet das
kennen wir auch von anderen Parteien das
ist durchaus nicht ungewöhnlich bis man
sich hier zusammengefunden hat an beiden
Parteitagen oder an beiden Tagen soll es
um 10 Uhr losgehen wir sind dort noch
ein bisschen gespannt weil morgen heute
Abend findet nämlich auch noch eine
Feier statt die AFD feiert die
zehnjähriges Bestehen und da sind wir
doch ein bisschen gespannt ob dann am
Samstag hier alle Delegierten pünktlich
um 10 Uhr dann auch auf der Matte sind
aber wir lassen uns dann natürlich gerne
überraschen hier stehen einige Anträge
zur Debatte die wir ganz spannend finden
denn es wurde schon gesagt die AFD ist
in bundesweiten Umfragen so gut wie seit
fünf Jahren nicht ähm und natürlich auch
mit Ausblick auf die kommenden Jahre auf
das nächste Jahr kann sich die AFD
glücklich schätzen sie in drei aus
Bundesländern wird gewählt wo die Partei
traditionell stark ist Brandenburg
Sachsen Thüringen und da ist es
besonders interessant dass sich viele
Anträge allerdings mit finanziellem
beschäftigen
denn so obwohl die Partei eben sehr
Umfrage stark ist ist es nicht immer so
einfach mit den Mitgliedern diesen
Eindruck bekommt mann die Partei hat
auch nicht unbedingt bei Mitgliedern
zugelegt die Zahlen vom Juli 2022
sind
28.671
und es gibt eben verschiedene Anträge
wie man die Zahlungsmoral hier noch
einmal hochhalten kann unter anderem
fordert der Bundesvorstand dass der
Delegierten Schlüssel nicht mehr einfach
anhand der Mitglieder berechnet wird
sondern anhand zahlender Mitglieder das
bedeutet also der Bundesvorstand möchte
dann auch die Landesverbände
ermutigen sage ich mal mehr darauf zu
pochen dass die Mitglieder auch ihre
Beiträge zahlen und auch bei den
Europaabgeordneten der AFD gibt es
Klärungsbedarf eigentlich sollten diese
einen
mandatsbeitrag zahlen das ist eine
Zusatzabgabe zum Mitgliedsbeitrag der
eben eigentlich monatlich abgegeben
werden soll das passiert wohl auch nicht
immer und deswegen soll das hier noch
mal extra
wenn die Satzung aufgenommen werden auch
gibt es hier einen Antrag dass die
Mitgliedschaft erst beginnen soll wenn
ein der Mitgliedsbeitrag bezahlt wurde
wiederum ein anderer Beitrag möchte dann
doch das aber keine mahnungsgebühren bei
versenden Zahlungen hier genannt werden
und dann ich habe es schon mal gesagt
ist steht auch zur Debatte ob die
Spendenaffäre noch einmal gesondert
betrachtet wird ob noch mal extra
in der Berichterstattung des
Bundesvorstandes in den finanz
speziellen Teil des Tätigkeitsberichts
auf die Spendenaffären eingegangen wird
inwieweit diese Affären die Partei was
das insgesamt gekostet hat ob es eine
Möglichkeit gibt Regress zu fordern und
auch ob die Spender mittlerweile bekannt
sind und deren Intention da liest man
aus dem Anträgen aus dem Antrag doch der
zum großen Teil übrigens aus von
Mitgliedern aus Baden-Württemberg
verfasst wurde ließ man dort
etwas Unmut darüber dass die meisten
Informationen aus der Presse zunehmen
sind und wir schauen noch mal nach vorne
es geht anscheinend los wir hören mal
dem Podium so
parte
i und 11:15 Uhr und möchten einigermaßen
pünktlich mit dem 14 Bundesparteitag der
AFD hier in Magdeburg beginnen
das hat vor allen Dingen den Hintergrund
dass wir heute abend sie wissen dass sie
sind alle herzlich eingeladen schon dazu
die Jubiläumsfeier 10 Jahre AFD hier auf
diesem Messegelände ab ca 19 Uhr
beginnen wollen
und in dem Rahmen dann auch die
erstmitglieder von 2013 die heute hier
anwesend sind mit einem ehrenpräsent
Bedenken wollen und auch noch mal dann
jubiläumsreden der Bundessprecher mit im
Programm haben
wir haben ein straffes Programm wir
haben eine volle Tagesordnung
deswegen bitte ich sie jetzt Platz zu
nehmen damit Bundessprecher Tino krupala
den 14 Bundesparteitag anschließend
eröffnen kann vielen Dank
[Musik]
also auch nochmal die Mahnung dass man
sich nun auf den Platz begeben soll von
Hans Holger mess dann wird Tino propala
einer der beiden
Parteichefs der AFD diesen Parteitag
eröffnen wir hatten ihn ja auch schon im
Interview auch das ist Usus das nicht
beide Partei Sprecher den eröffnen
sondern einer Alice Weidel haben wir
schon gesehen die wird auch hier
natürlich davon gehen wir aus noch
sprechen dann stehen erstmal ein paar
Wahlen an auch das ist Usus eines
Parteitags der Versammlungsleiter muss
gewählt werden ein Protokollführer die
zielkommission muss gewählt werden damit
natürlich auch über die Abstimmungen ähm
jemand Wachen kann es muss auch drüber
abgestimmt werden ob die Partei
elektronische Stimmgeräte nutzt um hier
die Auszählung Vorgänge zu beschleunigen
es gibt das Grußwort des gastgebenen
Landesverbandes das erwarten wir und es
sind auch einige ausländische Ehrengäste
geladen die sind auf der Tagesordnung
noch nicht angeführt wir wissen schon
dass von Flames Belang
jemand sprechen wird von der
portugiesischen Partei scheger aber es
gibt ähm einige großworte die wir später
hier erwarten und danach wie ich schon
angekündigt habe ist die Frage ob die
Partei also die AFD der europäischen
Partei Identität und Demokratie
beitreten wird da gibt es pro und Cons
der Bundesvorstand möchte das gerne
allerdings gibt es auch Gegenstimmen die
sagen die AFD würde als deutsche Partei
ihre Eigenständigkeit verlieren wenn sie
sich in so eine europäisches Partei
Gefüge
sein lässt in der im Europäischen
Parlament da ist die AFD schon Teil der
Fraktion Identität und Demokratie und da
geht es jetzt aber wie gesagt noch
einmal darum ob sie auch in dieser
Partei mit Sitz in Paris Mitglied wird
und danach ich habe es auch schon gesagt
steht die Wahl von Richtern und
ersatzrichtern des Bundes
Schiedsgerichtes an das ist das oberste
parteiinterne Gericht der AFD auch dort
gibt es einige
Überlegungen die das einfacher zu machen
es geht nämlich zum Beispiel darum dass
bisher wenn jemand z.B für einen
Bundestagsabgeordneten arbeitet dass er
dann nicht Richter am
Bundesschiedsgericht der AFD werden kann
wenn er dafür bezahlt wird dass wenn man
jetzt etwas auf lockern um den Kreis der
Kandidaten zu erweitern
guten Morgen wir beginnen jetzt und ich
darf um Ruhe im Saal bitten
damit Bundessprecher Tino propala mit
Tagesordnungspunkt eins Eröffnung und
Begrüßung des 14 Bundesparteitages
diesen Bundesparteitag eröffnen kann
bitte jetzt die Gespräche einstellen
bitte nehmen sie jetzt ihre Plätze ein
und stellen die Gespräche ein wir
möchten beginnen vielen Dank
so Bundessprecher Tino krupala wird
jetzt auf die Bühne kommen und die
Tagesordnungspunkt 1 diesen 14
Bundesparteitag eröffnen und sie
begrüßen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
ja liebe Delegierte
ich merke alles in aufgeregt alle freuen
sich auf die nächsten Wochen endlich
begrüße sie auch im Namen des gesamten
Bundesvorstandes recht herzlich zu
unserem 14 Bundesparteitag den ich auch
hier mit eröffne und Stelle als
allererstes die ordnungsgemäße
Einberufung fest
diese wurde vor sechs Wochen am 12 juni
einberufen zu unserem Bundesparteitag
regt sich dagegen Widerstand das kann
ich nicht wahrnehmen damit ist der 14
Bundesparteitag hier im wunderschönen
Magdeburg eröffnet und ich bitte Sie
jetzt wirklich die Gespräche
einzustellen
[Applaus]
Platz zu nehmen Sie wissen alle ihr
wisst alle wir haben ein straffes
Programm wir haben zwei vollgepackte
Wochenenden wir wollen Programmarbeit
leisten wir wollen unser Verantwortung
gerecht werden und den Wählern hier auch
zeigen für was wir stehen mit welchen
Kandidaten wir stehen und mit welchen
Kandidaten wir zur europawahlversammlung
antreten wollen also von daher bitte ich
wirklich um Disziplin und das ist auch
der Aufruf des gesamten Bundesvorstandes
an sie an euch dass wir diese zwei
Wochenenden in Disziplin in Einigkeit in
Harmonie so wie wir es das letzte Jahr
bereits Leben auch hier heute und
nächste Woche gestalten wollen liebe
Freunde
ich möchte mich
bevor ich einige inhaltliche Punkte hier
ansprecher zu allererst natürlich bei
den Organisatoren auch denjenigen
Gedanken von der Bundesgeschäftsstelle
die es möglich gemacht haben diesen
Bundesparteitag so auszuschaffieren und
auch diese Vorbereitung zu treffen was
mittlerweile in den heutigen Zeiten sehr
schwer und schwierig ist was viel Mühe
und Anstrengung bedeutet auch mit vielen
ehrenamtlichen Helfern für die ich mich
hier im Namen des gesamten
Bundesvorstandes bedanken möchte ich
möchte mich aber auch
gleichwohl
[Applaus]
bei der Polizei bedanken die uns und für
uns die Sicherheit hier gewährleistet
eine demokratisch legitimierten Partei
diesen Parteitag hier zu ermöglichen
dass wir diesen hier auch durchführen
können und abhalten können dafür vielen
Dank an die Polizei für die Sicherheiten
auch für die nächsten Tage
ja und ich habe es eingegangen gesagt
wir sind jetzt zehn Jahre alt hinter mir
stehts diese zehn Jahre heißen natürlich
auch für uns dass wir erwachsen geworden
sind mittlerweile sind wir nicht mit die
junge Partei wir sind eine
gesamtdeutsche eine neue Partei aber
nicht mit die junge Partei aber was
haben die erreicht wir haben keinen
Streit mehr in der Öffentlichkeit keine
entzweihung mehr in Sachfragen
stattdessen Harmonie und Einigkeit und
was wir damit erreichen können was wir
damit erreichen können
[Applaus]
sehen wir in aktuellen Umfragen 22
Prozent bei Inseln stärkste Partei in
Deutschland wenn man die kleinspartei
CSU abrechnet
[Applaus]
ja sogar in Baden-Württemberg sehen und
stehen wir laut einer swr-umfrage bei 19
Prozent und den Umfragen
zur Europawahl stehen bei über 20
Prozent das zeigt wie der Erfolgskurs
der Bundespartei auf ganz Deutschland
ausstrahlt und allen Mitgliedern die
natürlich ihren Anteil haben unsere
Mitglieder unserer Partei zugute kommen
und auch für die vielen ehrenamtlichen
die überall für uns parteipolitisch
aktiv sind auf der Straße möchte ich
mich im Namen des gesamten
Bundesvorstands bedanken auch ihr habt
daran den größten Anteil vielen
herzlichen Dank
ich möchte mich aber auch gleich wohl an
den gesamten Bundesvorstand richten und
mich auch im Namen meiner
co-sprecherin Alice Weidel wenn gesamten
Bundesvorstand für die letzte für das
letzte Jahr bedanken was mit Harmonie in
unserem Bundesvorstand und der super
Zusammenarbeit die ich so vorher noch
nicht kannte wirklich darstellt und was
auch zum Erfolg dieser Partei
beigetragen hat
auch mit der Zusammenarbeit mit meiner
großsprecherin als
Fraktionsvorsitzende aber auch als
Bundessprecherin ich muss wirklich sagen
ich hätte nicht gedacht oder ich habe es
natürlich gedacht aber es hat sich
besser dargestellt als es jetzt
mittlerweile ist diese Harmonie werden
wir auch in die nächsten Wahlkämpfe
tragen und lieber alle ist ich danke dir
und ich freue mich auf die weitere
Zusammenarbeit für die anstehenden
Wahlkämpfe wir werden genau damit Erfolg
haben liebe Freunde
[Applaus]
aber Umfragen sind keine Ergebnisse auch
das muss man klar sagen was die Bürger
was die Wähler mittlerweile von uns
erwarten und was sie zu Recht erwarten
dass wir diese Verantwortung natürlich
und dieser Verantwortung auch gerecht
werden das geht hier um Glaubwürdigkeit
und deshalb bitte ich auch alle darum
diese Umfragen auch mit ein Stück weit
Demut zu betrachten mit Demut zu nehmen
wir müssen genauso weitermachen wir
müssen weiterkämpfen der Kurs ist der
richtige das Personal ist das richtige
lasst uns gemeinsam genauso öffentlich
weiter nach vorne treten intern
diskutieren intern streiten das hat uns
stark gemacht und dazu sollten wir auch
weiter beitragen jeder für sich und auch
die nächsten Tage auf unserem Partei
sagt
und deswegen ist es wichtig und dürfen
wir uns auch auf diesen guten Werten
eben nicht ausruhen da wäre ich auch
immer wieder den Finger in die Wunde
legen genau das eben nicht zu tun in
Bayern und Hessen werden im Herbst neue
Landtage gewählt und nächstes Jahr
können wir in Sachsen Thüringen und
Brandenburg stärkste Kraftwerke können
Regierungsverantwortung übernehmen und
die Wände zum Guten bewirken wir sind
bereit für mehr das ist unser sloggen
dieses Parteitages
und wie ist eingangs sagte müssen wir
dabei eine Devise verfolgen genauso
weitermachen weiter so wir dürfen uns
nicht in zweien das könnte auch das
Motto übrigens des 14 Parteitages wie es
hinter mir steht auch sein und soll es
sein dieses weiter so der Weg den wir
seit Riesa gegangen sind ist genau der
richtige Weg wir haben uns nicht beirren
lassen und auch nicht durch unkenberufe
und Umfragen sollten wir uns auch nicht
beirren lassen es hieß wir hätten unsere
Potenziale ausgeschöpft es hieß wir
seien immer nur die dagegenpartei nein
liebe Freunde wir haben mit Strategie
und Programmarbeit haben wir in kurzer
Zeit genau neue Potenziale erschöpft wir
haben gezeigt dass wir die dafür Partei
sind und auf der Seite der Zukunft
stehen die anderen sind von gestern wir
sind von morgen und das erkennen immer
mehr Bürger in diesem Land liebe Freunde
ja und sogar Friedrich Merz will
mittlerweile lieber Parteichef der AFD
sein
er nennt er nennt die CDU eine
Alternative für Deutschland mit Substanz
und kürzlich sagte er noch dazu im
Sommer Interview ich zitiere es gibt
eine Regierung und es gibt zu dieser
Regierung natürlich eine Alternative für
Deutschland ja Herr Merz da haben sie
natürlich vollkommen Recht diese
Alternative die gibt es und ich bin
stolz ihr bundesprecher zu sein aber
diese Alternative ist einzigartig und
unnachahmlich wir sind das Original
liebe Freunde und niemand anderes
und Friedrich Merz hat es richtig
erkannt es war falsch eine Brandmauer zu
unserer Partei zu errichten es war
falsch für Deutschland und vor allen
Dingen auch falsch für die CDU durch die
Brandmauer hat sich März auf Koalitionen
festgelegt die unserem Land Schaden wer
Brandmauern baut lieber Herr Merz bleibt
ein Gefangener grüner Ideologie und das
merken immer mehr Menschen in diesem
Land
und nicht umsonst stemmt sich grünen
Chefin Ricarda lang mit vollen Gewicht
allen Versuchen entgegen die Mauer
umzuwerfen aber die Bürger haben genug
von den Grünen sie haben genug von Krieg
und sanierungszwang von
d-industrialisierung und deshalb rufe
ich allen Patrioten in der CDU zu reist
diese schwarz-grüne Mauer nieder
wir sollten aber nicht den Fehler
begehen uns auf die CDU als einzige
Koalitionsoption festzulegen wir
koalieren mit jedem und das sage ich
ausdrücklich der bereit ist Politik im
Interesse der Bürger zu machen mit
Interesse für diejenigen die es gut mit
Deutschland die ist gut mit unserem Land
meinen und das bedeutet aber auch wir
fließen ganz klar eine Koalition mit den
Grünen aus liebe Freunde
[Applaus]
denn eins ist Fakt und eins ist klar und
auch das sehen immer mehr Bürger in
diesem Land die Grünen sind die
gefährlichste Partei Deutschlands das
zeigen sie in ihrer Regierungsarbeit sie
wollen aus einer Industrienation ein
Trümmerfeld machen sie wollen
einfamilienhaussiedlungen in Bund der
Plattenbauten umbauen sie wollen den
Bürger den Saft abdrehen und die
Identität nehmen die Grünen wollen Krieg
mit Russland und mit China dieses Grün
liebe Freunde ist nicht grasgrün sondern
olivgrün und blau und grün gehen nicht
zusammen das zeigt sich
wir sind Protest und programmpartei
gegen eine Scheiße Regierungspolitik
gehen wir mit den Bürgern zusammen auf
die Straße und bringen auf dem
Bürgerwillen in die Parlamente das war
immer unsere Aufgabe als Alternative für
Deutschland darauf bin ich stolz und
diese straßenbewegung werden wir auch
weiterhin vollumfänglich unterstützen
weil genau das ist unser wichtigstes Ohr
in die Bürgerschaft in das Volk und
darauf bin ich stolz und das werden wir
auch weiterhin forcieren und vertreten
liebe Freunde
wir haben erfolgreich gegen Impfpflicht
und lockdowns demonstriert mit 100.000
Bürgern haben wir die Impfpflicht
abgewendet während des ukrainekriegs
demonstrieren wir gegen Kriegstreiberei
und Waffenlieferungen und für Frieden
durch Verhandlungen und dabei
präsentieren wir und repräsentieren wir
die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung im
Deutschen Bundestag ja wir sind das Volk
liebe Freunde
aber wir tun noch viel mehr wir
formulieren Konzepte für eine bessere
Politik für eine echte Politik Wende als
einzige Partei in Deutschland vertreten
wir eine interessengeleitete Politik das
sind unsere Alleinstellungsmerkmale und
nicht nur die Fehler der anderen
Parteien das merken immer mehr Bürger
dass wir uns um das weh und Wohl unserer
Bürger kümmern dass wir für Deutschland
kämpfen dass wir die wirkliche einzige
Alternative für Deutschland sind denn
wir sagen Politik muss die Interessen
der Bürger verfolgen wir müssen uns um
gute Beziehungen mit alle Ländern der
Welt kümmern und bemühen anstatt ihnen
westliche Werte aufzuzwingen wir sagen
nein zu Wirtschaftskrieg und Sanktionen
und ja zu freien und friedlichen Handel
mit aller Welt wir fordern das andere
Länder unsere Lebensweise respektieren
umgekehrt lassen wir aber auch andere
Länder so leben wie sie es für richtig
halten und wie Sie es wollen das nenne
ich Respekt und nur darauf lässt sich
eine friedliche Ordnung aufbauen Respekt
und Frieden statt Einmischung und Krieg
und genau diese Werte geleitete Politik
der Grünen ist respektlos und verletzt
die Interessen der Bürger die Grünen
wollen andere Ländern erklären wie sie
zu leben haben bundesaußenministerin
bärburg beweist es ja immer wieder in
ihren außen und Auslandsreisen und sie
wird immer häufiger von Staatschefs oder
von ihren Amtskollegen gar nicht mehr
persönlich empfangen etwa in Brasilien
oder auch in Südafrika offenbar hält sie
das Auswärtige Amt mittlerweile für eine
nicht Regierungsorganisation für
feministische Außenpolitik und genau das
ist falsch
genau das ist falsch ein Außenminister
Deutschlands muss allen Staaten mit
allen Staaten respektvoll umgehen das
erwarten wir von einem deutschen
Außenminister diese Werte geleitete
Außenpolitik hat Deutschland in den
Ukraine Krieg mit hineingezogen ansteht
neutral zu vermitteln hat die andere
Regierung einseitig Stellung für den
Westen bezogen sie missachtet die
Sicherheitsinteressen Russlands und tut
so als wäre der Krieg 2022 aus heiterem
Himmel ausgebrochen dabei haben genau
unsere vorgehenden
Kanzler wie zum Beispiel ex-kanzlerin
Angela Merkel und Ex-Präsident Francois
doch zugegeben dass minsker-abkommen
hatte 2015 vor allem einen Zweck Zeit zu
schaffen Zeit zu schaffen um die Ukraine
für den Krieg aufzurüsten jetzt sterben
junge Ukrainer in deutschen Panzern im
Kampf gegen Russland das liebe Freunde
ist eine Tragödie und ich fordere
ich fordere Respekt für die Ukraine
ebenso wie Respekt für Russland tatsache
ist nämlich auch dass wir nicht mehr
günstiges Gas aus Russland importieren
ist eben keine Reaktion auf den Ukraine
kriegt Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck hat den Krieg zum Anlass genommen
um die Importe zu stoppen aber er hat
dieses Ziel bereits 2016 verkündet und
zwar Zitat weil wir ein Energiewende
Land sind und ohne den Krieg hätten die
Bürger aber nicht hingenommen dass wir
die Lebensader unserer Industrie
durchtrennen das wusste er jetzt liegt
nordstream gesprengt von den USA und
Norwegen oder von der Ukraine auf dem
Meeresgrund und wir importieren teures
dreckiges trekkinggas aus Amerika die
Ampelkoalition hat das Verbot von Gas
und Ölheizungen beschlossen und was
macht die EU
die plant den wärmepumpenzwang für alle
Mitgliedstaaten und hier muss ich noch
mal an die doppelzünigkeit und die
Doppelmoral der CDU anknüpfen Herr Merz
sagt er ist gegen dieses Öl und
heizungsverbot was macht aber seine
Kollegin Ursula von der Leyen in Brüssel
in Sachsen plakatiert die CDU
heizungsverbot stoppen was für eine
Doppelmoral genau die gleichen Politiker
wollen dieses Gesetz sogar noch
verschärft im EU-Parlament durchsetzen
und genau dagegen müssen wir auch auf
europäischer Ebene vorgehen und diese
Doppelmoral benennen
und dann schauen wir uns die Geldflüsse
an schauen wir uns die Profiteure an
dieser ganzen Gesetzgebung es ist zum
Beispiel Carrier global der US-Konzern
der das wärmepumpengeschäft des
deutschen Familienunternehmens Viessmann
gekauft hat in havix
Wirtschaftsministerium läuft genau
dieser grüne Sumpf zusammen eine frühere
Blackrock Mitarbeiterin leitet die
Grundsatz Abteilung Staatssekretäre
kommen aus dem Netzwerk des us-investors
hellhörig deswegen legen wir den Sumpf
trocken wenn es die Medien nicht
schaffen muss ist die Alternative für
Deutschland machen das ist unsere
Aufgabe
und wir sehen es wir sehen es in
Deutschland wir sehen es an unseren
Unternehmen diese grüne Energiewende
macht Energie unerschwinglich und
zerstört unsere Industrie sie macht die
Bürger Arm und führt uns in einseitig
Abhängigkeit vom Westen die Beziehung
auf dem Kontinent Europa sind
mittlerweile unterbrochen im Kontinent
steckt ein Keil die USA haben den Keil
in den Kontinent getrieben und die
polnische Regierung treibt ihn mit einer
aggressiven Politik gegenüber
Deutschland und Russland immer tiefer
hinein und unsere Aufgabe liebe Freunde
besteht darin diesen Teil zu entfernen
wir müssen das Netz an Lebensadern und
Transportwegen in Europa und Asien
erneuern das und nichts anderes sind wir
der Welt schuldig liebe Freunde
ja und nach Russland wollen die Grünen
sich nun China vorknöpfen die Pläne für
einen Wirtschaftskrieg mit China liegen
schon längst in den Schubladen der
Grünen Ministerien nicht nur von Gas und
ölausrüstung sondern auch von Rohstoffen
und Hightech unseres wichtigsten
Handelspartners sollen wir uns
abschneiden lassen und warum um den
geostrategischen Zielen der USA
vorauseilen zu dienen die Ampel hat nun
jetzt eine china-strategie
veröffentlicht diese Strategie trägt
glücklicherweise nicht nur die
Handschrift der Grünen aufwendige
investitionsprüfungen China sind nicht
vorgesehen und eine Abkopplung auch
nicht gut so muss man dazu erstmal sagen
diese Fragen
Zukunft von strategischer Bedeutung und
oftmals wichtiger als die Frage welcher
Parteienfamilie rechnet sich ein
Politiker zu das sage ich ja ganz
deutlich und deshalb auch im
Europaparlament geht es häufig um
Handelsabkommen um Lieferketten die
wertepolitiker mit
menschenrechtsvorbehalten verschießen
wollen das ist nicht im Interesse
deutscher Bürger liebe Freunde und
dieses Interesse steht im Zweifel auch
über Fraktionsdisziplin jeder
Wirtschaftskrieg gegen den Osten ist
abzulehnen wir wollen Freien und
friedlichen Handel mit aller Welt liebe
Freunde
[Gelächter]
auch wenn wir unser 14 Bundesparteitag
im Zeichen der Europa Listenwahl die
morgen ja beginnt steht haben wir heute
eine Vielzahl von wichtigen
Satzungsänderungen auf den Weg zu
bringen wir haben bundesschiedsrichter
und Rechnungsprüfer zu wählen wir sind
in den letzten zwei Jahren zu einer
wichtigen Kraft in Europa geworden wir
haben in Europa wertvolle Zeit verloren
auch das müssen wir selbstkritisch
einräumen wir als Partei um einen kurzen
Ausblick auf das bevorstehende
Wochenende zu geben noch paar
abschließende Worte dazu der Erfolgskurs
der Bundespartei ist in Brüssel eben
noch nicht vollständig angekommen die
Politik der europa-delegation liebt zu
lange der Meuten Ära verhaftet was wir
im Bund und in den Ländern erreicht
haben das müssen wir jetzt nach der
Europawahl 24 auch ins Europäische
Parlament tragen und auch diese Ziele
dort erreichen wir müssen Politik machen
die allein an den Interessen der Bürger
orientiert ist dazu ist eine
generationwechsel
notwendig und die heutige EU ist mit
Frau von der Leyen federführend in einer
desaströsen Migrationspolitik und mit
wirtschaftsfeindlichen
sanktionspolitiken dafür steht diese EU
unter der Präsidentin denn die werden
nämlich genau dort gemacht 11
sanktionspakete gegen Russland wurden
beschlossen sie alle Schaden im Bürgern
in der EU mehr als Russland und das
haben wir von Anfang an kritisiert und
bemängelt und die Schaden vor allem
Deutschland zu allererst und wir sehen
die Zahlen der IWF trocknet
prognostiziert das mittlerweile und sagt
es auch dass die deutsche Wirtschaft
weiter schrumpfen wird die hohen
Energiepreise zerstören Existenzen und
haha Weg spricht allen Ernstes von
German Angst wir Freunde das ist die
verächtigungmachung des
Bundeswirtschaftsministers gegenüber der
deutschen Wirtschaft der Industrie der
kmuos den Frieden fleißigen Handwerkern
letztlich von uns allen und deshalb rufe
ich auch hier heute deutlich alle
Interessenverbände
handwerkerverbände Industrieverbände auf
sich endlich lauthals dagegen zu wehren
die Zeit der Kompromisse ist vorbei sie
werden die Kurs sonst nicht ändern
[Gelächter]
denn fest steht auch Sanktionen
schädigen dauerhaft die guten
Beziehungen zwischen Nationalstaaten
machen wir also nicht den Fehler auch
hier Russlands zu früh abzuschreiben in
Südamerika Afrika und Asien entziehen
sie Staaten mittlerweile diesen
Sanktionen sie gründen neue
Organisationen und setzen der unipolaren
Weltordnung eine multipolare entgegen in
dieser Ordnung wird Russland auch in
Zukunft eine wichtige Rolle spielen und
deswegen sage ich auch hier deutlich ja
zur Diplomatie aber auch hier muss man
bei aller berechtigter Kritik am besten
eingestehen das auch Russland bislang
Angebote zu Vermittlungen und
Verhandlungen beispielsweise von China
nicht wahrgenommen hat jedoch ist dieser
gegenseitige Respekt in einer
multipolaren Welt unabdingbar denn
Multipolarität bedeutet nicht mehr eine
einzige Weltmacht beherrscht die Welt
mit ihren Werten sondern mehrere
gleichberechtigte Mächte setzen in ihren
Regionen ihre Vorstellungen von Recht
und Ordnung durch und deshalb früher
oder später wird diese multipolare
Weltordnung auch Europa erreichen und
dann bietet sich die Gelegenheit
einseitige Abhängigkeiten abzustreifen
und neue Optionen zu eröffnen wollen wir
dann
wollen wir dann diejenigen sein die
Brücken gesprengt haben oder wollen wir
diejenigen sein die Brücken gebaut haben
wir wollen als Alternative für
Deutschland Brücken erhalten Brücken
aufbauen das ist unsere Vision für
Europa und dafür kämpfen wir auch im
EU-Parlament
und wir dürfen vor allem die nationale
Frage und die europäische Frage eben
nicht länger getrennt betrachten wenn
wir in Deutschland die Wände zum Guten
bewirken wollen dann müssen wir unsere
Arbeit im Bundestag in den
Landesparlamenten und in den kommunalen
Räten in Brüssel und Straßburg auch dazu
flankieren es wird nämlich keine Wende
in nur einem einzelnen Staat Europas
geben entweder europa-staaten erlangen
gemeinsam die volle Souveränität zurück
und bestimmen wieder selbst über ihre
Geschicke oder europa bleibt in Gänze
ein Anhängsel des Westens das ist die
bittere Wahrheit liebe Freunde meine
Damen und Herren in der wir uns stellen
müssen Europa Politik ist von enormer
Bedeutung hast du einen Opa dann schick
ihn noch Europa so hieß es mal
bitte Devise gilt aber schon lange nicht
mehr in Brüssel laufen sie unter dem
Brennglas die weltpolitischen
Entwicklungen zusammen die auch unsere
Politik in Berlin in Dresden in Erfurt
in Mainz in Wiesbaden oder in München
beeinflussen wollen wir mit unserem
erfolgshaus auch einer Alternative für
Europa sein und werden dann müssen wir
in Straßburg und Brüssel unsere
Interessen geleitete Politik vital und
selbstbewusst vertreten deshalb lasst
uns auch die nächsten zwei Wochenenden
kämpfen dafür für dieses
europawahlprogramm für unsere Kandidaten
aber auch auf unserem Bundesparteitag
für Freiheit für Souveränität für
Frieden wir sind bereit liebe Freunde
vielen herzlichen Dank
ich setze gleich den Top 2 unser
Tagesordnung fort und zwar komme ich
jetzt zum zur Wahl des
Versammlungsleiter und zweiers der
vertreterversammlungsleiter zuerst zur
Wahl des Versammlungsleiters der
Bundesvorstand schlägt Christoph Basedow
als
Versammlungsleiter vor ich frage in die
Versammlung gibt es weitere Vorschläge
das kann ich nicht wahrnehmen dann frage
ich in die Runde ob wir auch über diesen
Versammlungsleiter offen abstimmen
können wenn das der Fall ist dann bitte
ich jetzt um die blaue Stimmkarte wer
für den Versammlungsleiter Christoph
Basedow stimmt
vielen Dank gibt es Gegenstimmen
gibt es Enthaltungen das kann ich nicht
sehen damit ist Christoph basedower
unser Versammlungsleiter vielen Dank für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit und ich übergebe das
Wort an Christoph badedot
sagt gib mir ab
ja jetzt ist der Versammlungsleiter auch
noch gleich gewählt worden liebe
Zuschauer liebe Zuschauer jetzt beginnen
die geschäftsordnungsfragen die jeder
Parteitag egal welcher Partei zu klären
hat bevor es inhaltlich losgeht wir
nutzen diese Zeit mit zwei bewerten
Kolleginnen Kollege über den
afd-parteitag über die AFD und auch über
die Rede von kinoprophaler zu reden an
Katrin Müller vom Spiegel und Alexander
von der Neuen Zürcher Zeitung ja ähm
ich habe ja vorhin schon gesagt die AFD
ist ein Hochgefühl von
Umfrageergebnissen das war jetzt hier
gerade so ein politischer Rundumschlag
mal nicht das Gefühl dass ich die
nocropalla zurücknimmt wie würden Sie
den ersten Eindruck dieser rede jetzt
vor dem Hintergrund der aktuellen
Situation sehen schon ganz interessant
man versucht also man sagt man solle
demütig sein und bitte das Umfrage auch
nicht für selbstverständlich annehmen
und so tun als würde das jetzt immer so
weitergehen aber gleichzeitig tritt man
eben dann doch sehr selbstbewusst
beziehungsweise bei nicht auf
ähm die AFD ähm
wie gesagt im Moment steht sie sehr gut
da Umfragen sind keine Wahlergebnisse
hat man hier schon so eine Tendenz
rausgehört dass man glaubt dass das
wirklich immer weiter nach oben geht
also ich habe schon mehrere reden von
Herrn erlebt auf Parteitag und auch
sonst war die Selbstbewusstsein Rede die
ich erlebt habe von ihm die
kämpferischste auch die die versucht hat
möglichst viele verschiedene
Themenfelder anzusprechen von der innen
auf die Außenpolitik und zu wieder auf
die Innenpolitik online Donald Trump gab
es den Sumpf trockenlegen Anleihen bei
der DDR Bürgerrechtsbewegung wir sind
das Volk oder natürlich hat er den Elfer
den Herr Merz eben auf den Punkt gelegt
hat verwandelt mit dieser
seltsamen Formulierung wir sind nicht
eine tiefe Substanz konnte er sagen wir
sind die wahre Alternative und Ihre
Frage zu beantworten man fühlt sich eben
Hochgefühl des Triumph ist man will ja
ganz klar nächstes Jahr
Regierungsverantwortung übernehmen das
hat er mehrfach gesagt dass sehe ich
jetzt noch nicht aber es geht doch darum
dass die Partei sich hier Mut macht und
er muss jetzt wirklich schauen dass die
Leute von Mut nicht in Übermut
überwechseln aber dass der eigentliche
rohrkriptier davon Friedrich Merz dieses
diese Begriffe auch um die Brandmauer
aber diese wir sind die Alternative für
Deutschland mit Substanz ohne dass
irgendwie zu differenzieren und die
Leute eigentlich erst im Moment gar
nicht wussten sie die CDU meint
ja also das war ein großer Fehler dann
gab es ja davor schon dieses Agenda für
Deutschland was ja abgekürzt auch AFD
heißt dann noch das Brandmauer Ding also
man fragt sich wirklich was das soll
wenn man sich Kleidung gleichzeitig
immer wieder distanzieren will so ein
bisschen ein irrlich dann da Kurs von
Herr märz und das hat natürlich genutzt
interessant war auch eine Formulierung
von kinopropalla gerade wir hätten uns
sozusagen
ohne nachzudenken auf die Seite des
Westens geschlagen z.B in der Diskussion
über Russland und den Überfall auf die
Ukraine ich dachte eigentlich dass wir
seit 1949 sowieso auf der Seite des
Westen stehen da müssen wir gar nicht
mehr hinschlagen ist hier sozusagen das
weil ich eine Position die ja eigentlich
eher Putin nah erscheint und in der
Partei ja auch weit verbreitet ist also
ähm hoppala ist ein bisschen der
Gefangener teilweise auch der Strategen
die ihm zu arbeiten und die immer wieder
animieren das war von der Multipolarität
in den Raum zu werfen hat ja wirklich
gesagt Europa dürfen nicht in Gänze
Anhängsel des Westen bleiben und der
West ist euch oft einfach eine Schiffe
für Amerika also ohne Anti-Amerikanismus
kommt man momentan bei der AFD nicht
durch das muss man ganz klar sagen kann
auch in dieser Rede gemerkt gleichwohl
gibt es nach wie vor die transatlantica
es ist ja nicht ausgeschlossen dass es
morgen eine kampfkanatur geben wird um
Platz 1 bei der
spitzenkandidaturwahl zum
Europa-Parlament also es gibt schon noch
versprenkte wirtschaftsliberale
transatlantica den hat er ein zwei
kleine Zucker hingeworfen aber der
Mainzer Partei ist schon Amerika Kritik
Skepsis am besten und Respekt für
Russland hat er wirklich so formuliert
die Amerikaner in der Partei die fand es
wahrscheinlich ganz cool dass sie jetzt
auch noch quasi in einem Satz die
Energiewende mit dem
us-wirtschaftsimperialismus verbinden
konnte es ging um eine amerikanische
Firma die Wärmepumpen herstellt auch das
ist ja etwas das heißt der
AFD gelingt es auch praktisch jede jedes
politische Feld auch diese
Auseinandersetzung ist anders mit dem
Ostens der Osten der Westen als
Kriegstreiber der Osten von Russland als
Opfer reinzubringen
ja also wir müssen ja sehen dass schon
letzten Herbst ist eine ziemlich
entscheidende wie ich finde Rede von
Bernd höcke gab in Gera da hat er sehr
weit ausgeholt und hat das eben alles
also den besten quasi als ein veraltetes
Modell
beschrieben als regenbogenimperium war
da sein Wort für und dass man sich jetzt
eben eigentlich an den Osten wendet weil
da die alten Werte des bestens angeblich
nun sein was ich absolut nicht sehe aber
das war so die Rede und dem Volk die
Partei dann schon auch in anderen
Versatzstücken und anderen Worten da
merkt man auch wieder wer da sozusagen
auch Stichwort gäbe oft für diese Sachen
ist weil auch da wurde das schon mit der
Energiekrise und den Erneuerbaren
verbunden gut wir werden nachher
weiterreden es gibt auch noch vieles
grundsätzliches zu besprechen wie die
Partei die Erklärung warum sie so gut da
steht was das für das politische System
die anderen Parteien bedeutet und wie
weit die AFD auch inhaltliche Kompetenz
gewinnen kann oder auch nicht ich
bedanke mich erstmal bei ankathrin
Müller und war Alexander liebe Zuschauer
liebe Zuschauer wir zeigen uns noch mal
ganz kurz einen Beitrag aus dem ZDF
Morgenmagazin von heute morgen noch mal
die wichtigsten Aspekte des Parteitags
und der Diskussionen innerhalb der AFD
zusammengetragen und eine Bewertung der
Position der derzeitigen Position der
AFD in unserem Parteiensystem
dieses Bild macht momentan die Runde in
der AFD eine rissige Mauer schon so tief
zerfurcht dass ihr Einsturz nur noch
eine Frage der Zeit ist und freiwillige
Muse für dieses Bild das AFD la fleißig
in den sozialen Netzwerken Teilen
Friedrich Merz CDU-Chef der im
zdf-sommer-interview dies sagte
es ist jetzt in Thüringen ein Landrat
gewählt worden und natürlich ist das
eine demokratische Wahl das haben wir
doch zu akzeptieren und natürlich muss
in den Kommunalparlamenten dann auch
nach Wegen gesucht werden wie man
gemeinsam die Stadt das Land den
Landkreis gestaltet damit entfachte März
riesen Ärger in seiner CDU und helle
Begeisterung in der AFD co-partei Chefin
Weidel sagte der Süddeutschen Zeitung
die CDU kommen nicht umhin das
Kontaktverbot zur AFD aufzuheben die AFD
will mehr und ist bereit für mehr
behauptet sie zumindest im Slogan den
sie sich in ihrem zehnten Jahr verpasst
hat und in dem es für sie so gut läuft
wie noch nie in Umfragen klettert sie
Woche für Woche oben und im
thüringischen Sonneberg gewann sie
erstmals eine Landratswahl
zeigt sich auch was es bringt Mauern
aufzubauen die Grünen einzustreichen was
machen die Bürger gerade hier in
Thüringen in Sachsen in Ostdeutschland
im Mitteldeutschland die stellen einen
Ausreiseantrag zu AFD und das ist hier
heute
[Applaus]
die AFD strotzt vor Kraft das Prinzip
immer dagegen scheint aufzugehen wir
haben Alleinstellungsmerkmale wir
vertreten die Interessen der Bürger also
wir haben keine Werte geleitete Politik
sondern interessengeleitete Politik wir
stellen uns klar gegen die
Wirtschaftssanktionen gegen Russland
aber auch die zukünftigen Sanktionen die
schon gegen China geplant sind ein
weiteres Alleinstellungsmerkmal
die als gesichert rechtsextremistisch
etwa den thüringischen Landesverband
sowie den dortigen kurvorsitzenden Björn
höcke zu ihm nach Erfurt reiste
koopertal-chefin Weidel demonstrativer
Schulterschluss und Beweis fürs macht
jeder interne Widerstand gegen ihn ist
Geschichte
dem Zuspruch in den Umfragen tut dies
keinen Abbruch gleichzeitig aber lehnt
die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung mehr
Einfluss für die AFD ab
43% der Befragten wollen keine
Zusammenarbeit das sind 9% Punkte mehr
als noch im Oktober 2017
33% sind der Meinung die Parteien
sollten von Fall zu Fall entscheiden 17%
sind für eine Zusammenarbeit
die AFD klemmt fest zwischen Umfrage
hoch und Ablehnung Erfolg durch
Radikalisierung für die Partei ist das
stand jetzt Segen und Fluch zugleich
ja wir sind zurück im Saal live in
Magdeburg beim AFD Parteitag und bei mir
am Interview Set inzwischen Bernd
Baumann angekommen der erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
afd-fraktion im Deutschen Bundestag aber
man die haben ja gerade der Rede von
kinopropalla gelauscht da viel mehr als
erstes auf dass er gesagt hat die
Impfpflicht abgewendet das sei das
Verdienst der AFD also wenn ich mich sie
waren ja Bundestag selbst bei diesen
Debatten dabei wenn ich mich da richtig
erinnere waren das auch noch andere
Fraktionen die FDP z.B in großen Teil
ich glaube auch aus der Union haben sich
viele gegen die Impfpflicht gewendet
heften sie sich da ein Erfolg an die
Fahnen der eigentlich den auch andere
sozusagen
mit verursacht haben die Frage wer hat
das als erster sozusagen zum Gespräch
gemacht wird das als erster auf die
Agenda geschrieben und das waren wir die
das eindeutig gemacht haben wie bei
allen anderen wichtigen Politikbereiche
Migration Energie sind wir die einzige
Opposition wir sehen das so die CDU ist
das schon lange nicht mehr auch in dem
Fall nicht
vielleicht noch ein anderer Aspekt sagen
gegen die trickstreiber will die AFD
vorgehen wenn meinen sie dann damit ist
da tatsächlich der besten Gemeinden wir
sollten uns ja nicht unbedingt auf die
Seite des Westen schlagen sagt Tino
Kraller aber seit 1949 sind wir Westen
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland war Teil
des Westens Teil der NATO ich war
Bundeswehrsoldat auch Teil der NATO
jetzt ist aber die ost-westspaltung zu
Ende seit 1989 jetzt sind völlig neue
geopolitische geostrategische Grundlagen
geschaffen wir müssen uns neu
positionieren auch als Europa innerhalb
der Welt da braucht mehr Souveränität
Europas biopolitisch aber auch
Deutschlands innerhalb von Europa das
ist damit gemeint aber die
ost-westspaltung haben wir ja wieder
ausgelöst durch Vladimir Putin ja das
ist ausgelöst durch Vladimir Putin das
den Krieg angeht aber die Diplomatie vor
den Krieg die diplomatische Krise da ist
der Westen da sind die USA mit dran
beteiligt und der Schlüssel für den
Frieden hängt großen Teils auch in den
USA es geht nicht um ein Frieden jetzt
Ukraine Russland das wird so nicht geben
das muss eine internationale
Sicherheitsarchitektur geben die wir
schon mal hatten die weltweit sozusagen
klar macht die Räume absteckt und
gemeinsam Frieden und Stabilität wieder
schafft was jetzt gerade gesagt haben
weiß das auch Wladimir Putin haben sie
da Informationen ich habe keine
Informationen bei Vladimir aber die
Russen haben Interessen legitime
Interessen wie andere auch legitim
Interessen haben natürlich ist das ein
angriffskriechen völkerrechtswidriger
das macht die Sache jetzt schwieriger
aber langfristig können wir Frieden in
Europa nur haben mit Russland das ist
seit Jahrhunderten so aber ich ziehe
immer den Parteivorsitzenden andere
Lehrer wir sollten andere Länder so
leben lassen wie sie es wollen es geht
um Respekt und Frieden statt Einmischung
und Krieg wenn man sich das jetzt mal
auf den äh auf den Überfall der Russen
auf die Ukraine
ansieht also die Russen lassen ein
anderes Land nicht zu leben wie es will
Respekt und Frieden davon kann keine
Rede sein sondern Einmischung Krieg und
klassenmord sind das die alternativen
Fakten die man immer bei der AFD
vermutet heute nicht wir haben dir sagen
doch das ist ein völkerrechtswidriger
Angriffskrieg mit allem was das bedeutet
zutiefst zu verurteilen was er im Grunde
meint ist diese Werte geleitete
Außenpolitik von Frau bärburg was
überhaupt nicht funktioniert es gibt auf
der Welt ganz unterschiedliche
Kulturräume auch Kulturräume die nichts
mit unserer europäischen sehr wenig in
unserer europäischen Kultur
Menschenrechte und so weiter zu tun
haben auch die Chinesen haben eine
eigene Kultur die ist innerlich anders
aufgebaut die müssen wir akzeptieren das
ist damit gemeint wir müssen
interessengeleitete deutsche und
europäische Außenpolitik machen und
nicht die Welt belehren nach
europäischen Werten die die nicht haben
und die die nicht wollen
bedeutet diese Interessen geleitete
Politik Deutschlands auch dass wir zum
Beispiel Menschenrechtsfragen
ausschließen sollten aus dieser
interessensgeleiteten Politik die sieht
nicht ausgeschlossen aber die stehen
nicht im Vordergrund wie haben nicht die
Welt zu belehren die Welt zu
missionieren die folgt uns auch nicht
die Chinesen 1,4 Milliarden mit einer
eigenen 2.500-jährigen Geschichte die
haben anderes System nicht individuelle
Menschenrechte und das funktioniert auch
ich finde unser System besser das
westliche das europäische des
bürgerliche aber die Welt ist in großen
Teilen anders organisiert das müssen wir
akzeptieren die zu belehren und unsere
Außenpolitik darauf zuzuschreiben dass
wir die bekehren und belehren ist Unsinn
das ist ein Teil dessen was wir
kommunizieren aber im Kern müssen wir
unsere Interessen wahrnehmen geoprische
Interessen wir müssen Energieversorgung
sicherstellen Absatzmärkte und mit den
müssen wir zusammenarbeiten selbst mit
arabischen sozusagen klaren beherrschten
Unternehmen wie Saudi Arabien oder so
müssen wir vernünftige Politik betreiben
wir können nicht die weltmissionieren
ist ein absolutes Missverständnis von
außen Politik was Frau baerbock und die
links-grüne Regierung machen aber dann
müssen wir die
Menschenrechtsverletzungen Saudi-Arabien
und China akzeptieren nicht akzeptieren
wir können ja versuchen darauf
hinzuwirken wir können da Frau dafür
werben aber wie können sie nicht zwingen
durch Sanktionen durch Belehrungen
aufdringlich werden das können wir nicht
das sind selbstständige Kulturen die in
sich ruhen Jahrtausende alt anders
organisiert sind die Welt ist nicht voll
von Europäern und europäischer Kultur
das ist ein ganz bestimmter Kreis das
hält uns auch zusammen im Westen
Menschenrechte Bürgerlichkeit Freiheit
Demokratie aber große Teile der Welt
sind anders organisiert und die wollen
auch anders organisiert bleiben es gibt
andere Möglichkeiten sich zu
organisieren da sehen sie in China
ungeheuerer Erfolg Wohlstand Milliarden
Menschen aus dem Elend geholt in kurzer
Zeit ohne unsere Version von
Bürgerlichkeit Menschenrechten
Demokratie das ist möglich wo die
wirtschaftlichen Bedingungen in China
haben sich ja verschlechte in den
letzten Monaten gar nicht ich würde sie
gerne noch auf eine Sache Hinweise sie
haben ziemlich sicheren Job weil nicht
geplant ist dass der Bundestag
abgeschafft werden soll ist mir
jedenfalls nicht bekannt was sie aber
planen ist ein anderes Parlament
abzuschaffen nämlich das EU-Parlament
jetzt gibt es hier einen sechstägigen
doch sehr aufwendigen partei-tag zur
Wahl von Kandidaten für dieses
Europäische Parlament die nach Brüssel
fahren und dann alles dafür tun dieses
Parlament dann abzuschaffen also
shopkiller in eigener Sache zu sein so
ungefähr wie geht das zusammen nein die
EU muss grundsätzlich reformiert werden
wir haben uns das jetzt jahrzehntelang
angeguckt am Anfang war alles prima die
Wirtschaftsunion sozusagen
Sicherheitspolitik miteinander zu
betreiben freie Märkte alles völlig okay
aber jetzt hat sich ein Zentralismus in
Brüssel ausgebildet der so nicht geht
der so nicht funktioniert und auch das
EU-Parlament ist ja keine wirklich
demokratische Veranstaltung die
einzelnen Länder haben ja ganz
unterschiedlich Abgeordnete Deutschland
hat nicht entsprechend seiner
Bürgerschaft Abgeordnete im Europäischen
Parlament da ist nicht one man Code
sondern die Deutschen sind
unterrepräsentiert wie die anderen
großen Länder auch das ist sozusagen
Vehikel von Demokratie wie das
EU-Parlament organisiert ist und so geht
das nicht weiter gut das ist jetzt ihre
Analyse der europäischen Parlamente es
gibt ja es gibt in der Tat ja auch den
Versuch das noch zu ändern da müssen
aber alle mit an einem Strang ziehen
aber im Moment ist Europa in weiten
Teilen auch nicht Europa die EU wir sind
die Europäer wir sind zutiefst Europäer
hier von der AFD aus nur die EU sie im
Moment vorgeht und wieso Menschen
strukturiert ist ist für uns ein großes
Problem weil es auch keine Probleme löst
Migration Außengrenzen Energie ist ja
ein Desaster was wollen sie die
zerschlagen
sind alles so fürchterliche Begriffe wir
wollen das neugründen wir wollen
sozusagen eine neue Gründung das Ding
muss europäisch neu gedacht werden die
Solidarität die Loyalität die Tiefe
Verwandtschaft der europäischen Nation
muss Ausdruck finden in der gemeinsamen
Organisation in der gemeinsamen
Verbindung und da ist die jetzige Jugend
hier weg wir müssen das neugründen
zutiefst reformieren wenn die neuen
Abgeordneten der AFD in Brüssel eine
Menge zu tun haben 26 andere Länder noch
davon überzeugen
ich bedanke mich bei Bernd Baumann für
das Gespräch ja
so liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer
jetzt glaube ich wird uns Katharina kühn
noch klären was jetzt in den nächsten
Stunden weiter passiert wie gesagt wir
bleiben da dran es gibt dann auch alle
Hinweise es geht um die Wahl des
Versammlungsleiters das haben sie
mitbekommen der Rechnungsprüfer der
Protokollführer aber Katharina wird uns
das jetzt kurz oder wird uns kurz ins
Bild setzen
ja vielen Dank und wir sind noch gar
nicht bei den
sondern noch bei Wahlen eben die
Versammlungsleitung wurde schon gewählt
auch so die stellvertretenden
Versammlungsleiter und auch die
Protokollführer dann gab es hier eine
kurze Unterbrechung bei der Wahl der
zielkommission die wurde nun erst einmal
zurückgestellt und bis gerade eben wurde
über die Verwendung elektronische
Stimmgeräte
informiert denn natürlich gibt es dort
auch Bedenken sind diese elektronischen
Stimmgeräte mit dem Internet verbunden
oder nicht das sind sie nicht deswegen
werden genau jetzt die Abgeordneten hier
abstimmen ob Sie elektronische
Stimmgeräte nutzen wollen das stimmt sie
jetzt natürlich noch mit ihren Karten ab
und gerade eben wurde gesagt also die
elektronischen Stimmgeräte werden hier
genutzt wenn über z.B die Tagesordnung
abgestimmt werden soll das steht nämlich
als nächstes an die dür allerdings in
diesem Fall nicht so lang diskutiert
werden es gibt nur wenige
Änderungsanträge zwei um genau zu sein
einmal geht es darum wann ein Antrag zum
Beitritt der AFD in die idee-partei
besprochen wird und dann noch einmal ich
hatte schon erwähnt geht es um die Frage
der Spendenaffären inwieweit dort dann
auch noch mal drüber debattiert wird
also ich gehe davon aus dass die
Tagesordnung hier sehr schnell
beschlossen wird dann steht noch der
Bericht der mandans Prüfungskommission
an aber wie gesagt die Wahl der
zielkommission steht auch noch an und
deswegen nutzen wir die Zeit für eine
politische wissenschaftliche Einordnung
und mit Alexander Keller
mit Ann-Kathrin Müller vom Spiegel und
Alexander Kistler von der 90er Zeitung
wir sind ja gerade kurz unterbrochen
worden auch durch das Interview mit
Bernd Baumann ja lass uns vielleicht mal
grundsätzlich auf die Frage Alexander
Kessler gucken wird die AFD eigentlich
immer mehr zu einem Rätsel der deutschen
Politik oder bildet sie in Wirklichkeit
einen Trend ab der in vielen Ländern
schon in Europa vor allen Dingen gang
und gäbe ist nämlich quasi ein scheinbar
Unabhängigkeit unaufhaltsamer Ausstieg
der das Rechtspopulismus ja ich denke
die AFD ist dabei sich zu enträtseln
dieser gärige Haufen dem immer sagt er
ist er oft noch im Motors im
Umgangsformen in gewissen sehr
grenzwertigen Anträgen als Ganzes
allerdings hat der Opal da schon einen
Punkt gemacht ist sie da geht sie
wesentlich geschlossener man kann sie
momentan auf absehbare Zeit auch aus dem
auch deutschen Parteienspektrum nicht
wegdenken und wir haben natürlich ein
ganz Europa Rechte rechtspopulistische
strammenrechte wie man sie es nennen
wollen Parteien und momentan gibt es
Leben sowohl von den bisherigen
konservativen der CDU als auch von den
eher linksorientierten Regierungen jede
Menge Vorlagen die die AFD verwandeln
kann wenn sie einfach Ruhe bewahrt und
und schaut wie die anderen teilweise
schlecht regieren teilweise keinen
Konzepte haben ein Konservatismus für
das 21 Jahrhundert auszuformulieren also
sie hat ja mal formuliert Deutschland
aber normal sie gehört vielleicht nicht
vom inhaltlich politischen aber von der
Relevanz für Deutschland mittlerweile
zum normalen Spektrum dazu das müssen
wir anerkennen da würde ich
widersprechen wenn ich darf
dir wirklich nicht mehr
rechtspopulistisch nennen das ist ähm
dann doch verharmlosen wenn man sich
anguckt was die Politikwissenschaftler
definiert in Europa damit einem Begriff
finden
extrem rechts oder in großen Teilen
rechtsextreme das kann man durch so
formulieren ich würde sie auch nicht
konservativ nennen denn konservative
Werte sind für mich grundsätzlich etwas
Positives und nicht Demokratie
feindliches insofern müssen wir da
glaube ich noch aufpassen dass wir das
benennen was hier sich im Raum befindet
und das ist normal eine extrem rechte
Partei also einfach neu entsteht gehören
immer Vater und Mutter beteiligt sein
die AFD kann ihr Glück kaum fassen weil
sie politische Gegner hat wie Friedrich
Merz
also ich halte das für zu vereinfacht
nur zu sagen nur weil die beiden Fehler
machen ist jetzt das Umfrage hoch da
wenn man auch damit Experten spricht die
schon sehr lange in diesem Gebiet eben
wissenschaftlich arbeiten dann sieht man
dass es eben Grundlagen gibt also dass
die AFD genau da stark ist wo die NPD
schon stark war das war vorher habe ich
und märzzeiten oder bei den alten März
Zeiten sozusagen
es ist natürlich so dass wenn man das
gerade das Gefühl hat dass viel nicht
gut läuft und dass man verunsichert ist
und dass man wirtschaftliche Sorgen hat
dass man dann dahin wandern kann aber es
ist jetzt vielleicht nicht dass einzelne
heizungsgesetz oder ähnliches weil reden
wir noch Alexander haben den ähm Union
und Ampel überhaupt noch die Kraft zu
einer Umkehr man erwartet ja von ihnen
bürgernahe Entscheidungen in der Energie
in der Migration in der
Wirtschaftspolitik man sollte eigentlich
die Sorgen der Bürger zum
koalitionsprogramm machen das sind alles
jeder auch aus diesem Parteien sagt ja
machen wir aber
offensichtlich funktioniert nicht so
richtig ist diese Kraft noch da also
momentan sehe ich bei der Ampel nicht
die Kraft zu einer Umkehr man müsste ja
Abschied nehmen von gewissen Lebenslügen
eine besteht darin dass alles was man
macht komplett richtig ist und das eben
das hohe Ziel auch gewisse Mittel
rechtfertigt die also gegen
Bürgerinteressen verstoßen wenn ich
teilweise Debatten sehen um LNG vor
Rügen oder wie teilweise mit
navigationspolitik agiert werden einfach
eine wachsende Minderheit oder teilweise
eine Mehrheit den Eindruck da werden wir
nicht mehr gefragt auch die Linkspartei
können Sie beispielsweise das
Partizipationsprozesse gerade unter
diese Ampel die auf Augenhöhe als
respektregierung angetreten ist
geschliffen werden also es ist schon ein
Problem das glaube ich die Ampel
wirklich noch mal innere Klausur gehen
müsste und schauen müsste er hat sie
wirklich diese Erzählung noch diese den
Bürgern verkaufen will als
erfolgsrechtlich und B ist sie auch
bereit hier und da auch Korrekturen
Ihres Kurses vorzunehmen dann zumindest
wenn man sagen will wir möchten einen
Teil dieser Wut Wähler sage ich mal
zurück gewinnen weil ein Film neulich zu
sehen im Fernsehen von einem Marktplatz
ich glaube einer Kleinstadt in Thüringen
Wochenmarkt aber ein Stand der AFD der
da ist da regelmäßig als
Bürgersprechstunde da werden sicherlich
auch ideologische Inhalte der AFD gleich
mitvermittelt und eine Frau sagt ins
Mikrofon nur die AFD kommt hier
regelmäßig hier zum Wochenmarkt die
anderen Parteien sehen wir nur wenn
Wahlkampf ist und das ist glaube ich
nicht nur in dieser thüringischen
Kleinstadt so was machen die oder was
machen sie falsch die anderen Parteien
können sie nicht anders wollen sie nicht
anders man sagt ja immer machen ist wie
wollen nur krasser was läuft da also ist
natürlich eine Frage der
Prioritätensetzung oder die AFD hat sich
entschieden eben sehr nahbar wirken zu
wollen oder zu weinen eben sehr viel
ansprechbar sehr viel auf dem Marktplatz
zu sein die anderen Parteien haben sich
dann vielleicht eher für die Facharbeit
entschieden also tatsächlich merkt man
ja sowohl im Bundestag als auch in den
Landtagen als auch eben in den
Kommunalparlamenten das jetzt da so viel
schriftliche von der AFD nicht geleistet
wird und die Zeit muss ja irgendwo
herkommen deswegen kann man schon sagen
es wäre gut wenn die anderen Parteien
sichtbarer und ansprechbarer werden aber
man muss trotzdem sehen dass das zum
Teil auch eben eine Art von
politiktheater ist dass die AFD dann ja
bei bis zu 20 Prozent in Umfragen gut
wie werden sehen wie das bei den
Wahlergebnis wirklich aussieht Alexander
warum kommt die AFD mit alternativen
Fakten so gut durch mit ihrem framing
das ist ja Fakten Verdrehung zum Teil
sogar völlig falsche Informationen die
da manipulativ übermittelt werden
trotzdem verfängt das bei eigentlich
immer mehr Leuten wenn man das sieht
können ja gleich auch noch über die
diskursverschiebung sprechen aber warum
verfängt das so gut er war natürlich
einerseits sehr komplexe aus politische
Lager natürlich die man mit sehr
einfachen Erzählungen beispielsweise
Russland Ukraine Konflikt
herunterbrechen kann und sagen wir sind
halt einfach dagegen dass narrativ
stimmt nicht einfach was die Mehrheit so
sagt wir sind alternativ also eine
gewisse mechanische alternativbegriff
was die Mehrheit sagt müssen wir
ablehnen und der sogenannten
schweigenden Mehrheit zum Durchbruch zu
verhelfen zum anderen widerspricht sich
natürlich auch die amtierenden Regierung
sehr oft wenn Sie irgendwelche Kosten
durchrechnen was wird es nun Kosten die
heizungswände für den Einzelnen
teilweise hat wird ja auch noch kurz
erwähnt haben einige Bürger noch in die
schlechte Erfahrung mit der
corona-politik wo also sie teilweise vom
Einkommen abgeschnitten waren wo sie
lange gewartet haben auf ersatzhilfen
vom Staat etc also auch die Regierung
handelt die Wahrheit nicht immer
derselben harten Münze wie es nötig wäre
insofern haben wir da oftmals zwei
verschiedene Arten von subjektiven
speziell im Ukraine Russland Konflikt
wird natürlich extrem überdreht von der
AFD und teilweise auch mit mit gefakten
Videos gearbeitet wirklich nicht auf
eine Ebene stellen würde also natürlich
wird in der Politik auch von allen
anderen Parteien gelogen und natürlich
mag auch die Regierung Fehler machen und
mal irgendwie die Zahl nehmen die ihnen
am besten passen aber trotzdem ein
Unterschied ob man regelmäßig mit Lügen
und oder Ressentiments arbeitet oder ob
man sozusagen in einzelnen Projekten da
eben vielleicht mal ich will gar nicht
die Regierung so verteidigen aber ich
würde das nie auf eine Stufe stellen
und ich kann trotzdem verstehen dass
vielleicht warum das verfängt also
natürlich ist sind ist die Bevölkerung
müde ja es gab Krisen danach Krisen es
gab Corona es gab den Krieg es gab die
Energiekrise es gibt viel Verunsicherung
im Land man wünscht sich dass es der
nachfolgenden Generation immer besser
geht wenn man merkt dass es vielleicht
nicht sein könnte dann noch jemand Krise
oben drauf dann ist es natürlich schön
wenn man eine Partei hat die einem immer
eine einfache Lösung präsentiert das
versteht man schon Frage ist nur ob die
Lösung dann auch was bringen könnten auf
den letzten paar Tage in Riesa ist er
beschlossen worden die Doppelspitze die
bis dahin ja statt Hut war in der Partei
auch in eine einzelne ein Mann eine Frau
Spitze umzuwandeln
da gibt es jetzt Diskussionen
personeller Art zu alles weiter und Tina
ganz oben stehen
sind die beiden eine Art personelle
Brückentechnologie bis zur nächsten
Vorstandswahl im nächsten Jahr das ist
ja schön formuliert Brückentechnologie
bei der AFD her ist das kann man schon
so sehen weil wenn eine Entscheidung
fallen wird bis dahin oder diesen
Zeitpunkt rum vertikanz der kein Natur
übernimmt er läuft ja fast alles auf
Verwaltung hinzu ist die Frage ob dieses
Konstruktor nicht in sich selbst
kollabiert wenn der ein oder die eine
vermutlich kannst der Kandidatin ist und
andere macht ein bisschen
dann würde ich auch schlechte Karten
ziehen für eine Propeller sich da einer
zweierspitze zu halten und wenn es in
einer Spitze wäre lief dann stand heute
alles auf Frau Weidel die mutmaßliche
Kanzlerkandidat hinzu es war ja nur ein
anderer Aspekt gemeint mit meiner Frage
nämlich der Name erst hier aufkreuzen
wird wird er denn der Versuchung
widerstehen können gleich nächstes Jahr
schon nach der Macht in der Partei zu
greifen als alleiniger Vorsitzender
hat ja sehr viel politische Strategie
bewiesen bis dass er immer nur dann
Dinge versucht hat eigentlich wenn sie
auch geklappt haben und wir alle wissen
dass das mit der Kanzlerkandidatur ein
reines Schauspiel ist also natürlich
wird das nicht nach der nächsten
Bundestagswahl einen
apb-kanzlerkanzlerin geben insofern ist
das auch eine Debatte die sich irgendwie
selbst überholt und ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass Björn höcke diesen
Versuch wagen würde möglicherweise wird
aber in Thüringen einiges versuchen nach
der Landtagswahl im September des
nächsten Jahres zu bewegen aber das ist
vielleicht ein Merkposten für unser
nächstes Interview hier auf den
Parteitag soweit an Katrin Müller vom
Spiegel Alexander von der 90er Zeitung
bedanke mich bis hierhin so und wir
lassen uns jetzt weiter auf den neuesten
Stand bringen was hier hinter uns gerade
läuft von Katharina kühn
und hier ist man direkt in der Debatte
über die Tagesordnung welche Anträge da
noch aufgenommen werden oder nicht und
gerade geht es um einen
Sachantrag ob es Mahngebühren bei
versäumten Zahlungen geben soll und
inwieweit da auch in schreiben ein
wertschätzender und freundlicher Ton
gegenüber den Mitgliedern aufgegriffen
werden soll oder nicht und wir hören mal
rein
kommen wir zur Abstimmung den Antrag sn6
zu keinem Mahngebühren bei versäumten
mitgliedsbeitragszahlungen als 9
Tagesordnungspunkt 19 in die
Tagesordnung aufzunehmen und die
Schlusswort und Nationalhymne würde sich
entsprechend auf Top 20 verschieben wer
ist für diese Erweiterung der
Tagesordnung
danke schön wer ist dagegen
danke Enthaltungen
so da war die Kollegen nicht ganz
aufmerksam noch mal die fürstimm Bitte
wärst für die Erweiterung der
Tagesordnung und diesen Antrag
hier wird also noch einmal abgefragt wir
können das übrigens leider auch hier
nicht ideal verfolgen weil wir doch
eingeschränkt sind hier in der
Bewegungsfreiheit auf dem Parteitag für
die Presse gibt es hier einen
abgesteckten Bereich so dass wir z.B
nicht zwischen den Delegierten hin und
her laufen können und deswegen nun auch
nicht richtig und selber hier ein Bild
machen können zumindest nur ein recht
unvollständiges vom Abstimmungsverhalten
allerdings muss man auch sagen dass auch
die Versammlungsleitung sich nicht ganz
klar ist wie hier abgestimmt wurde
deswegen wird es jetzt hier zur
Verwendung elektronische Stimmgeräte
kommen eine Abstimmung möchte ich Ihnen
noch nachtragen die hier schon
stattgefunden hat über die Tagesordnung
und zwar gegen ist da um die die Frage
ob der Bundesvorstand auch noch mal
gesondert über die Zahlen der
Spendenaffäre informieren soll
Hintergrund ist ja das im März das
Oberverwaltungsgericht
Berlin-Brandenburg ein Urteil des
Verwaltungsgerichts von 2021 bestätigt
hat dass die AFD
396.000 Euro zahlen muss an Bußgeld da
ging es um die Spendenaffären Alice
Weidel ehrlich hatte eine Spende von
zwei Unternehmern aus der Schweiz
bekommen damals argumentiert dass das
eine Spende direkt an sie war aber das
hat ähm das Gericht anders gesehen und
damit viel diese Spende unter das
Parteien gesetzt und dieses Gesetz
verbietet Parteien anonym spenden
anzunehmen und die Strafe ist dann der
dreifache Spendenbetrag und so wurde
dieser Spendenbetrag erst einmal eben
vom Verwaltungsgericht 20 21 festgesetzt
dagegen hatte die Partei Berufung
eingelegt das über Verwaltungsgericht
hat dieses Urteil nun aber bestätigt und
da gab es hier einen Antrag ob darüber
noch einmal gesondert informiert werden
soll allerdings gab es eben auch
Gegenreden dazu unter anderem war das
Argument dass man nicht vor laufenden
Kameras dieses Thema debattieren möchte
und so hat sich dann haben sich dann die
Delegierten hier dagegen entschieden
hier findet jetzt eben weiter diese
Abstimmung Stadt ob hier ein neuer
Tagesordnungspunkt aufgenommen wird wir
nutzen diese Pause für ein weiteres
politisches Gespräch
jawoll wir werden wie gesagt das alles
mitverfolgen im Moment sind wir noch im
geschäftsordnungsbereich innerlichen
Diskussionen und die spannende Sachen
die kommen noch
Treue Phoenix Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer die kennen ihn vor allem auch
von afd-partei sagen aber auch von
anderen politischen Ereignissen
Professor Wolfgang Schröder von der
Universität Kassel und gleichzeitig
tätig fürs Wissenschaftszentrum in
Berlin wir wollen über die AFD als
solches noch mal sprechen auch über die
aktuelle die auch die grundsätzlichen
Fragen hat die AFD denn ihren Höhepunkt
ihres Stimmen Zuwachses ihrer Resonanz
ihrer Zustimmung in der Bevölkerung
erreicht das ist eine offene Frage weil
wir hätten ja vor über einem Jahr gesagt
die AFD ist auf dem absteigenden Arzt
zwei Jahre nur weil die Niederlagen aus
einem Landtag herausgefallen wenn wir
vor einem Jahr die Frage spekulativ
angegangen werden hätten wir mit großer
Skepsis vor allen Dingen nach den
Ergebnissen des Rieser Parteitags
begutachtet wie es weitergeht und die
Entwicklung ist schwer einzuschätzen
weil klar ist die Unzufriedenheit der
Bevölkerung ist dramatisch hoch die
Herausforderung sind ebenso groß und
wenn man jetzt mal schaut die
wirtschaftliche Krise fängt ja erst an
die Frage der Migration immer größere
Bedeutung zu und insofern ist schon zu
erwarten dass die eine Weile auf diesem
Niveau fahren können gleichzeitig ist es
so dass Regierungen in der Hälfte der
Legislaturperiode immer eher die
schlechteren Begutachtungen bekommen und
insofern kann man darauf hoffen dass die
Regierung sich natürlich berappelt und
in der Lage ist hier wieder eine bessere
Performance ein besseren Auftritt hin zu
bekommen das hätte auch einen Einfluss
auf die Zuneigung zu AFD und beschäftigt
sich die Politikwissenschaft ja sehr
stark mit Demoskopie mit Statistik mit
bezahlen wie groß ist denn das Potenzial
noch dass die AFD erschließen könnte
gibt es da
Gedankenspiele oder Berechnungen ja also
ganz interessant ist die
afd-wählerschaft setzt sich ja aus zwei
Hauptgruppen zusammen einerseits die
überzeugten die wirklich der Auffassung
sind also dieses System ist inakzeptabel
kompromisse sind so nicht
nachvollziehbar ist alles zu kompliziert
und im Hintergrund sind irgendwelche
Eliten die man nicht
vertrauenswürdig begleiten mag und dann
hat man aber diejenigen die er
konjunkturell an die Sache rangehen die
also merken dass läuft nicht so wie ich
mir das vorstelle ich verstehe das
gerade nicht und der Teil ist größer
geworden in den letzten Monaten und
interessant ist jetzt wo kommen die her
und die kommen nicht unbedingt stark von
der CDU von der SPD von der FDP in grün
sondern sehr stark aus dem nicht Wähler
Lager also Leute die eigentlich von
politischen System sich schon ein Stück
schnell wieder verschwinden die können
schnell verschwinden die können auch von
den anderen wieder gewonnen werden
insofern ist das sehr volatil was wir da
erleben
heißt es sind ja die man jetzt
protestwählerinnen und Wähler nennen da
gibt es auch ein Streit woher kommt
eigentlich oder was sind das für
Wählerinnen und Wähler die der AFD ihre
Stimme geben das heißt wenn ich Sie
richtig verstanden habe diese
Protestwahl Verhalten diese Wut diese
Verärgerung über das was jetzt gerade im
Lande passiert ist schon sehr stark
unter dieser Wählerschaft vertreten die
jetzt vor hat es war mir alles Umfragen
die wir gehört haben die jetzt vor hat
bei den nächsten Wahlen die AFD zu
wählen ja also erstens mal das haben sie
ja jetzt auch angedeutet ist natürlich
die Prognose ist nicht gleich das
Ergebnis aber es gibt so eine gewisse
Normalisierung dass man das gar nicht
mehr so dramatisch findet dass da eine
Partei als rechtsextreme klassifiziert
wird dass da eine Partei als eigentlich
nicht regierungsfähig lassen sondern man
schaut stärker auf die Funktion die
haben für uns die Funktion den Prozess
deutlich zu machen die anderen zu
verschenken und zu sagen so geht's nicht
weiter und das wirkt ja auch das kann
man an der CDU ja sehr schön machen es
gibt
politische zum Teil gefärbt also bei den
Linken heißt bei den bei den
Konservativen Liberalen heißt er also
das sind Protest werden die können wir
wieder zurückgehen die Linken sind da
eher skeptischer sagen klar der Fall
wäre AFD Welt da kann sich nur um ein
rechtes Weltbild um neue Rechte oder
rechte Überzeugungen handeln was ist an
diesem Argument dran naja zunächst mal
die empirischen Umfragen zeigen ja dass
der Anteil geschlossen rechtsextreme
denkender und fühlender Menschen in
Deutschland zurückgegangen ist in den
letzten Jahren
erstens zweitens man muss natürlich
immer in Rechnung stellen dass wir ein
großes Potenzial von Menschen haben die
mit Politik wenig zu tun haben die aber
doch irgendwie Zugriff auf das
politische System haben soll in dem
Sinne so kann man das nicht machen und
so ist das falsch und dann sind schon
Werthaltungen dahinter die durchaus
problematisch sind im Bereich Rassismus
im Bereich Antisemitismus im Bereich
doch tiefgreifender Demokratie
Unzufriedenheit aber gleichzeitig ist es
nicht so geschlossen und verhärtet dass
man diese Menschen nicht wieder zurück
gewinnen könnte durch gutes Regieren
durch
vertrauensprozesse und eben durch eine
bessere einbinden das spielt die
Zivilgesellschaft auch eine wichtige
Rolle weil man muss sehen diese
Veränderung die wir in den letzten
Jahren erlebt haben die es nicht einfach
durch Berlin zustande gekommen sondern
auch durch eine Schwächung der
Zivilgesellschaft durch eine Veränderung
der Medienlandschaft und das führt dann
auch zu Orientierungsproblemen die man
im früheren Jahrzehnten bei ähnlichen
Problemen langsam so nicht gehabt der
Erfolg hat der bekanntlich viele Väter
und Mütter Mütter und Väter der
biserfolg da will eigentlich keiner für
zuständig sein da wollen wir aber die
anderen Parteien mal nicht aus der
Verantwortung entlassen Stichwort
ampelchaos ich nenne es mal so plakativ
was inwieweit haben die eine Mitschuld
am Aufstieg der AFD am Aufstieg der AFD
kann man das nicht so klar
klassifizieren aber deutlich ist die
Ampel hat einen Anteil weil die Art und
Weise wie sie ihre Gesetzesvorhaben
kommuniziert hat hat bei einem Teil der
Bevölkerung
Ängste ausgelöst und diese
Ängste sind natürlich zustande gekommen
weil auch Medien das sehr stark nach
oben gejuckt haben weil es entsprechende
narrative gegeben hat so eine SED die
jetzt im Keller nachschaut was für
Heizungen man hat die also den Eindruck
erweckt da wird ab nächste Woche schon
eine andere Realität gesetzt da werden
enorme Kosten auf einen Zukunft wenn man
das frühzeitig angegeben hätte wenn man
Etappen baut wenn man soziale
Kompensation technologische Offenheit in
einem überschaubaren und etappenförmigen
Sinne angeboten hätte wäre dieses
Desaster so nicht passiert das heißt mit
anderen Worten die Regierung hat einen
Anteil und muss besser regieren lernen
Stichwort Schlingerkurs der Union
welchen Anteil hat das am Erfolg den
unfreiwilligen Anteil am Erfolg der AFD
wenn man das Interview von Herrn März
nimmt das sommerinterview dann kann man
ja Prozesse der Normalisierung
feststellen und diese Prozesse der
normal sind ohne Not weil es ist doch
klar auf kommunaler Ebene da hat man
immer wieder ähnliche Position aber in
ähnlichen Positionen in einem Verhältnis
zu einer als nicht demokratisch
klassifizierten Partei ist doch ganz
einfach zu sagen wir stimmen genauso ab
wie die haben aber einen eigenen Antrag
wir haben eine eigene Begründung und
sind infolgedessen überhaupt nicht auf
diese Gruppe angewiesen wir werden auch
mit dieser Gruppe keine gemeinsame Sache
machen in dem Sinne dass wir die Ideen
gemeinsam entwickeln so eine Art
Königsweg für die anderen Parteien
gerade im kolonialen Bereich gibt es ja
auch wenig parteipolitische Kontroversen
wir wollen uns mal ganz kurz ähm die
Frage in einem kurzen Filmbeitrag Liebe
ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer ansehen
ob man und wie man da die AFD
möglicherweise mit ganz spitzen Fingern
fest oder ob man mit ihr möglicherweise
doch kooperiert oder auch kooperieren
muss
Kooperation ein Miteinander im
Einzelfall darf es nicht geben soll es
nicht geben Brandmauern sind hochgezogen
gegen die AFD und doch schon überwunden
in Bautzen etwa im vergangenen Jahr
Landrat Udo witchers verhilft da im
Kreistag einem afd-antrag zur Mehrheit
hat fast die ganze CDU-Fraktion hinter
sich insofern kann ich das begrüßen dass
dort zumindest auf kommunaler Ebene auch
bei der CDU-Politiker sind die im Sinne
ihres Kreises handeln und sich nicht der
Partei Doktrinen aus Berlin unterordnen
im Sinne des Kreises soll es für
bestimmte Asylbewerber weniger Leistung
geben eine Maßnahme laut Flüchtlingsrat
mit eher populistischem Wert notabene in
einem Landkreis in dem wenige Wochen
zuvor eine geplante
Flüchtlingsunterkunft angezündet wurde
doch der Antrag sei so der Landrat
inhaltlich anstandslos also zur
unterstützen in der Landeshauptstadt
hätte man lieber einen eigenen Antrag
der CDU gesehen und Friedrich Merz für
der live-fälle eigentlich
parteiausschlüsse
anders in Thüringen der debattiert die
SPD Anfang diesen Jahres ob es gegen
zwei Mitglieder ein Partei Verfahren
geben soll weil sie mit der AFD
gemeinsame Sache machten im Stadtrat von
Hildburghausen dieser war das
amtierenden Bürgermeisters überdrüssig
die Bürger sollten ihn abwählen können
den Antrag dazu unterstützt sie die
Mehrheit im Stadtrat neben CDU und SPD
auch die AFD zusammen abgestimmt wird
oft aber der Fall ging zu weit
je politischer eine Entscheidung wird je
größer die Tragweite und eine Abwahl
eines demokratisch gewählten Bürgers
Bürgermeisters ist eine riesige
Tragweite dort wird es immer relevanter
ob man jetzt sage ich mal da gemeinsam
mit der AFD agiert oder sie wählt wie in
raguhns Hannes Lot ist hier seit wenigen
Wochen der erste hauptamtliche
Bürgermeister der AFD in Deutschland im
August nimmt er die Arbeit auf
der AFD Polarisierung vielleicht aber
ansonsten versuche ich recht
ausgesprochen zu sein und auf alle
Seiten zuzugehen zuzuhören zwei seiner
parteilosen gegen Kandidaten wie der
Ängste Verfolger Nils Naumann kündigten
schon an dass sie jede vernünftige
Politik des afd-bürgermeisters
unterstützen und Stadträte könnten sie
gar nicht anders und die Wähler würden
es womöglich gar nicht verstehen
Brandmauer vs Pragmatismus kommunal
scheint an der AFD kein Vorbeikommen ein
Miteinander erfordert
Fingerspitzengefühl Ostdeutschland
deswegen meiden ein Ministerpräsident
der besorgt ist aber nicht ohne Hoffnung
gab darauf bereits die Antwort
ja wir sind zurück in Magdeburg live auf
dem Parteitag da sieht eben von den
Kommunen das alles immer oder in den
Kommunen ganz anders aus als von Berlin
aus noch ein kurzer Hinweis hier gerade
gab es eine Abstimmung über Ausschluss
der Öffentlichkeit vom partei-tag und
zwar während der Bericht des
Rechnungsprüfers vorgestellt wird der
ist allerdings abgelehnt worden dieser
Antrag Herr Professor Schröder
es gibt ja immer wieder diese die
Behauptung die AFD hätte es hingeht so
eine Art diskursverschiebung
hinzukriegen was vor zwei Jahren noch
riesen Schlagzeilen gemacht hat nimmt
man jetzt Schulterzucken hin ist da was
dran da ist auf jeden Fall was dran das
kann man in verschiedenen
Themenbereichen sehen im
Migrationsbereich ganz eindeutig den
gleich Mann hier auch feststellen muss
das ist jetzt nicht die Eigenleistung
der AFD sondern Vorbehalte gegen
Migration Vorbehalte das ist zu viele
sind dass die falschen kommen und so
weiter gab es natürlich immer aber die
AFD hat selbst vermocht dieses Thema so
zu mobilisieren dass es weit über ihren
Bereich dann auch Resonanz und
handlungsfähig geworden ist ähnlich hat
man das zum Beispiel auch in der
Thematisierung des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks ja also
sie heißt ja immer von der AFD das darf
man in der Öffentlichkeit gar nicht mehr
sagen in dem Moment sagt man sie
eigentlich indem man das behauptet das
heißt also in der Tat ist diese
diskussverschiebung in der
Öffentlichkeit tatsächlich spürbar die
ist spürbar und ist für die Demokratie
auch ein Problem weil demokratie lebt
von Voraussetzungen die sie selbst gar
nicht so herstellen kann im Augenblick
und wenn diese Voraussetzung permanent
in Frage gestellt werden dann gehen
damit nicht nur viele Probleme einher
nervositäten Irrationalitäten und viel
Orientierung aber das Prinzip der AFD
ist ja um das noch mal auf den Punkt zu
bringen dass sie sehr geschickt Probleme
die ja real sind aufgreift und sie zu
universellen Menschheit
Herausforderungen kristallisiert ohne
aber selbst eine Perspektive anzubieten
wie man konstruktiv mit diesem Problem
umgehen kann das gilt möglicherweise
nicht für alle Fragen es wird ja immer
gesagt die AFD ist halt zum Teil schon
der Mitte der Gesellschaft angekommen
das wird oft mit einem kritischen
Unterton versehen jetzt eine neue
Umfrage besagt dass 42% der Menschen in
Deutschland die migrationspolitischen
Überzeugungen der AFD gut heißt das
heißt dass die
Flüchtlingsströme nach Deutschland auf
jeden Fall
eingedämmt werden müssen 42 %, das sind
doppelt so viele wie in den günstigsten
Umfragen gerade die AFD eigentlich
wählen wollen das heißt bei dem Thema
ist die AFD tatsächlich in der
weitgehend in der Mitte der Gesellschaft
angekommen ich wäre vorsichtig mit der
Formulierung in der Mitte der
Gesellschaft es gibt eine Zustimmung
wenn man sagt also da muss was getan
werden das kann nicht so weiterlaufen
aber wenn man dann in die Details
hineingeht sieht es auch schon wieder
anders aus und dieses Thema ist insofern
halt hoch problematisch
weil wir ja eine bestimmte Rechtsordnung
haben wir haben eine europäische
Rechtsordnung wir haben eine deutsche
Rechtsordnung und auf dieser Grundlage
als Rechtsstaat müssen wir handeln und
wenn man der Auffassung ist dass die
bestehenden Rechtsnormen nicht in der
Lage sind die Lösungsfähigkeit im
gegenwartsbereich herzustellen muss man
für andere Normen kämpfen aber das wird
man nicht dadurch erreichen indem man
sagt wir machen das Land zu weil die
sind Exportnation wir sind stolz darauf
dass es durch schenken eine Freiheit
innerhalb Europas gibt und man muss sich
klar machen wenn man den Vorstellungen
der AFD folgen würde dann wäre dieses
Land eine kleine isolierte Schutzburg in
Europa und auf der anderen Seite ist
klar wir brauchen eine Regulierung und
das Land hat viel zu spät die
Regulierung begonnen also die Debatten
über das Deutschland ein
Einwanderungsland sein sollte und sich
entsprechend aufstellt die haben in den
80er Jahren begonnen das ganze ist aber
erst umgesetzt worden
20 Jahre später und mithin hat dieses
Land auch keine richtige Disposition wie
sie eigentlich mit Einwanderung kreativ
positiv umgeht und weil wir ja ein älter
werdendes Land sind sind wir auf
Zuwanderung angewiesen und Zuwanderung
ist nicht gleich Zuwanderung das heißt
wir brauchen Regulierung und da ist eine
ziemlich unübersichtliche Situation so
dass also wenn jemand hört das geht so
nicht weiter dann wird er sagen ja ja da
haben die alle vollkommen recht aber ich
würde es nicht einfach der AFD Gutschein
ich würde auch nicht davon sprechen dass
sie in der Mitte so präsent sind wie Sie
das für sich vorstellen zur Fakten
Möglichkeit noch dazu das 49% bei dieser
Umfrage gesagt haben sie leben die
Migrationspolitik mit
migrationspolitischen Ansichten der AFD
ab aber trotzdem das ist sind ja relativ
nah beieinander die Zahlenwerte und die
Ampel war ja auch nicht in der Lage sich
wirklich zu den Asyl Komponist der
Europäischen Union zu bekennen gut wir
werden an dieser Stelle einen kurzen
Break machen bedanke mich erstmal bei
ihnen Wolfgang Schröder und Katharina
kühn bringt uns jetzt auf den Stand der
Dinge was bisher geschah in der Halle
von Magdeburg
ja was bisher geschah ein Teil hat sie
ja schon erwähnt einmal ging es um die
Frage ob hier die Öffentlichkeit
ausgeschlossen werden soll wenn der
Bericht der Rechnungsprüfer stattfindet
unter anderem wurde dort gesagt dass es
ähm eben keine man das nicht
verlaufenden Kameras auch wieder machen
muss andere haben debattiert dass die
AFD als Partei sich nicht verstecken
müsste und dann eben haben sie es
vielleicht gehört meine Damen und Herren
im Hintergrund das ist kurz relativ
enthusiastischen Applaus und da ging es
um die Ehrengäste die hier noch sprechen
sollen es sind fünf Gruß Worte
angekündigt aus Belgien Portugal
Bulgarien Rumänien und Österreich gibt
es persönliche Grußworte oder eine Video
großbotschaft
die sollte
abgestimmt um 16 Uhr stattfinden und
dann war die Frage
inwieweit
koppelt man diese Grußworte an die Frage
ob die AFD der europäischen Partei
Identität und Demokratie Beitritt man
hat sich dazu entschieden dass nicht
aneinander zu koppeln so dass eventuell
nun diese Abstimmung vor den
europäischen Partnern stattfindet unter
anderem kam dann eben dieser große
Applaus nachdem hier ein Delegierter
gesagt hat wir sind eine deutsche Partei
wir brauchen keine ausländischen
Grußworte also eine klare Haltung dazu
dass diese Grußworte nicht irgendwie die
Entscheidung hier beeinflussen sollten
es gab wieder ein bisschen
Schwierigkeiten die zielkommission zu
wählen was wir allerdings schon mal
wissen dass er momentan 518 kreditierte
stimmberechtigte hier in der Messe Halle
in Magdeburg sind 600 dele gierte sind
zugelassen ich habe schon am Anfang
gesagt neun können
hier nicht dran teilnehmen und zwar von
der sah AFD weil es dort formale Fehler
bei der Aufstellung der Delegierten ging
und jetzt ähm läuft gerade hier
das ähm
der Bericht
jetzt bin ich gerade verwirrt aber wir
schauen mal nach vorne denn Martin
Reichert sprich schon Landesvorsitzender
von Sachsen-Anhalt und das wollen wir
natürlich nicht verpassen
Umfragewerten
diese Erfolge haben beim politischen
Establishment eine Welle von Hass und
Hetze ausgelegt eine Welle liebe Freunde
die selbst unsere in vielen stürmen
erprobte Partei bisher noch nicht erlebt
hat aber eines kann man von hier aus
auch sagen diese Welle der Hass und des
Hasses unter Hetze die wird nicht den
etablierten nützen sondern die Menschen
im Lande erkennen diese Welle ist eine
Welle die das Volk ergreift eine Welle
die uns nach vorne fühlt und die uns
einen Sieg bei der Europawahl und bei
den Wahlen in diesem Jahr Herr bescheren
wird liebe Freunde
[Applaus]
und davor davor hat man Angst der
Präsident des wohl am weitesten
degenerierten sogenannten
Verfassungsschutzes Kramer aus Thüringen
nannte große Teile unserer Wähler
braunen Bodensatz und der gescheiterte
ehemalige ostbeauftragte wanderwitz
forderte ein Verbot unserer
demokratischen Partei das ist eine polit
[Musik]
ische Geist der Altparteien und wir
alleine sind die die dem entgegenstellen
liebe Freunde
aber anders als die Altparteien wird uns
eins gelingen wir werden diese
widerliche antidemokratische
anti-deutsche und volksfeindliche Hetze
auf diesem Parteitag und an diesem
Wochenende inhaltlich Stellen liebe
Freunde denn wir haben Inhalte die
anderen haben keine
[Applaus]
wir werden hier einen Parteitag abhalten
der wichtige Weichen stellt einen
Parteitag der auch vom äußeren Ambiente
her in einem unter einem guten Stern
steht denn es ist ein Parteitag wenn wir
uns die Gegendemonstrationen angucken
tausende haben sie angekündigt ein
kleines Häuflein unentwegter linker
Spinner stört uns ein wenig aber wir
schreiten daran vorbei lasst sie wählen
die AFD Karawane zieht weiter
und darum können wir hier auch heute
eines sagen von diesem Parteitag und von
diesem Wochenende und auch vom kommenden
Wochenende wird eine Listenwahl für das
Europaparlament ausgehen die wir unter
das Motto stellen können europa wir
kommen um Deutschland zu retten liebe
Freunde
ja und wir hier in Sachsen-Anhalt wir
dürfen mit Stolz sagen dass wir nicht
zum ersten Mal Ausgangspunkt eines
beispiellosen Siegeszuges unsere AFD
sind 2016 haben wir mit 24,3 Prozent das
erste Mal ein machtvolles Zeichen
gesetzt das uns in Sachsen-Anhalt zu
einer Positionierung brachte die heute
die gesamte AFD für sich in Anspruch
nehmen kann und muss wir sind
Volkspartei liebe Freunde
und mit der Gewissheit die einzige echte
deutsche Volkspartei zu sein werden wir
an diesem und am nächsten Wochenende die
Weichen für einen fulminanten
europawahlkampfstellen unsere
europa-kandidaten werden Garanten für
eine Politik sein die getragen ist von
einer tief empfundenen Achtung für alle
europäischen Völker und diese tief
empfundene Achtung sie erweckt uns aus
dem reinen Herzen unserer Partei deren
dessen höchstes Gut die Liebe zum
eigenen Volk und die Liebe zur eigenen
Nation ist und das Können und das können
nur wir als AFD
[Applaus]
denn nur denn nur wer die Liebe zur
eigenen Nation kennt kann glaubhaft die
Liebe anderer Völker und Nationen zu
sich selbst anerkennen und achten diese
Emotion diese emotionale Bindung
unterscheidet die Patrioten Europas von
globalistischen Mehrwert Fetischisten
und linken Hetzern denen alle Nationen
Europas verhasst sind und die sie
deshalb in einer bürgerfeindlichen EU
auflösen wollen und darum werden auch
die europäischen Patrioten immer stärker
und diese Europawahl wird die Europawahl
des Patriotismus in Europa
[Applaus]
und den auflösungsbestrebungen die gegen
die europäischen Nationen gerichtet sind
erteilen wir eine klare Absage unser
Europa ist ein Europa souveräner
Nationen und um es mit schade Gold zu
sagen ein Europa der Vaterländer liebe
Freunde
und im Interesse der Freiheit der Völker
Europas sagen wir ganz besonders jenen
politischen Kräften den politischen
Kampf an die mit verkommenen
Protagonisten wie Robert Habeck
Vaterlandsliebe stets zum Kotzen fanden
solche deutschlandhasser und Nationen
Verächter gehören in keine Regierung
liebe Freunde
[Applaus]
denn denn und das gilt es hier auch zu
beachten solche linksgrüne Missachtung
der Nationen ist ja nicht nur eine
Missachtung der deutschen Nation sondern
es ist eine Missachtung aller Völker
Europas und es ist eine Verachtung der
ganzen Menschheit und so etwas darf nie
wieder eine steuergröße deutscher
Politik werden liebe Freunde
[Applaus]
und darum
begehen wir gemeinsam diesen Parteitag
mit unserem unverbrüchlichen Bekenntnis
zur Freiheit Bürgerrechten und
Demokratie in diesem Sinne liebe Freunde
kämpfen wir gegen linksgrünen
Totalitarismus und seine
pseudokonservativen Steigbügelhalter
kämpfen wir politisch für die Freiheit
der Völker Europas kämpfen wir politisch
für ein Deutschland und ein Europa das
auch kommende Generationen noch als
blühende Heimat unserer Kinder und
Enkelkinder vorfinden können in diesem
Sinne wünsche ich uns einen ruhigen und
gelungenen Parteitag vielen Dank
vielen Dank für unsere
Landes
[Musik]
seit 2017 ist ja auch Mitglied des
Deutschen
Bundestags die AFD er war hier schon
einmal in Magdeburg 2018 auch zu ihrer
damaligen Europa Versammlung damals
natürlich noch mit anderen
spitzenpersonalen Jörg Meuthen der
damalige Bundesvorsitzende wurde zum
Spitzenkandidaten gewählt mittlerweile
ist sie eher aus der Partei ausgetreten
Simon Arndt dr Burkhard Kirchhoff tim
ist die Bartisch Samanta Flak Gregor
Maria Wladimir klund Alexander Apache
Christoph grim Sebastian Deffner Agnetha
Niemann eine dominikkaufmann Daniel
pomarek dr Stefan Brand nämlich Michael
Albrecht Silvia Bothe Angelika Wöller
Gestik Konstantin bernardos oder Gläser
Maria alt Helmut Vogt Kurt Hermann
Hannes Ernst Gabriel del Rio hecklau
Michael Meister Heike Kunzelmann Annett
dingethal Jacqueline Kretschmer Bernhard
Sturm Catherine Schmidl
die Namen der Wahlhelferinnen und
Wahlhelfer vor die sich hier selber
vorgeschlagen haben oder vorgeschlagen
wurden darüber muss hier noch abgestimmt
wir werden danach steht hier der
Tätigkeitsbericht des Bundesvorstands
für das zweite Halbjahr 2022 und das
erste Halbjahr
2023 an mit dabei ist auch der
finanzielle Teil natürlich auch dort
wird es in dem Sinne um die
Spendenaffäre gehen dass ein Posten da
drin ist wie viel die Partei nun zahlen
musste
so dass diejenigen die sich damit
beschäftigen wollten hier auf dem
Parteitag zumindestens kurz da die
Gelegenheit haben da eine Information zu
bekommen
die Grußworte ausländischer Ehrengäste
so wurde das ja abgestimmt steht gegen
16 Uhr an das hat er organisatorische
Gründe weil einige von ihnen hier
persönlich vor Ort sind und natürlich
wahrscheinlich auch noch andere Termine
haben oder die Rückreise antreten müssen
also das ist gegen 16 Uhr dann wird die
Partei wahrscheinlich vorher schon
darüber abstimmen ob sie der
europäischen Partei Identität und
Demokratie Beitritt ist stehen Wahlen
von Richtern des bundesschichts
Gerichtes an und einige Änderungen der
bundes-gerichtsordnung sowie an der
Finanz und Beitragsordnung und dann
noch dann der Wahl und Geschäftsordnung
da werden wir zum jeweiligen Zeitpunkt
darauf kommen was hier die Delegierten
vorschlagen im Vorfeld hatten wir hier
einen anonymisiertes Antragsbuch
mittlerweile können wir aber auch sehen
aus welchen Landesvorständen und von
welchen Delegierten hier die Anträge
eingebracht wurden
und dann bevor es zum Schlusswort und
der Nationalhymne kommt das haben die
Abgeordneten hier abgestimmt wollen sich
die Delegierten noch einmal mit den
Mahngebühren beschäftigen also wenn ein
Mitglied versäumt seine Beiträge zu
zahlen und dann Mahngebühren erhoben
werden sollen oder nicht und der
Parteitag ist dann zu Ende mit Top 20
Schlusswort und Nationalhymne aber die
Partei möchte ja dann auch noch ein
bisschen feiern vor 10 Jahren wurde sie
gegründet und das möchte man am Abend
dann noch einmal gebührend
gewürdigen
[Musik]
so das dauert einen kleinen Moment wir
bitten kurz um ein wenig Geduld
[Musik]
und wir nutzen die abstimmungspause um
mich zu verbessern ich habe nämlich
gesagt dass Julian Flack hier gerade
diese Abstimmung leitet das ist
Christoph Basedow Verzeihung an dieser
Stelle wenn Sie allerdings schon
häufiger die Parteitage der AFD mit uns
verfolgt haben wissen sie dass Julian
Flak auch sehr häufig die Versammlungen
hier leitet daher bitte ich diesen
Verfahren zu entschuldigen
also die Abstimmung zu den Wahlhelfern
dauert nun doch etwas länger als wir das
erwartet haben auch das kann natürlich
immer wieder passieren und da nutzen wir
dann jetzt die Zeit und schauen doch
schon mal auf einige Anträge die hier
eingebracht wurden im Vorfeld ist
natürlich viel über das mögliche Europa
Programm der AFD berichtet worden möchte
die AFD nun die EU auflösen oder nicht
möchte sie sie reformieren oder gleich
ähm soll es einen dexit geben also einen
Austritt der EU ursprünglich stand
nämlich in der Forderung des
Parteivorstands im Leitantrag dass die
AFD die geordnete Auflösung der EU
fordere das wurde aber ein redakt
soziales versehen dann genannt und die
der Bundesvorstand hat hier einen
eigenen Änderungsantrag zum Leitantrag
dann gestellt denn der Leitantrag konnte
nicht mehr geändert werden aus
fristgründen also gibt es dort nun einen
Änderungsantrag in dem der
Bundesvorstand die Delegierten bitten
wird den Satz wieder zu streichen und
die
Parteichefin ko-chefin Alice Weidel
hatte zum Beispiel im Interview mit dem
Stern gesagt die spreche lieber von
einem Rückbau der EU natürlich gibt es
aber auch einige
Parteimitglieder und auch
selbstverständlich Delegierte hier die
durchaus nichts dagegen hätten dass so
deutlich in den Leitantrag zu schreiben
dass man eine Auflösung der EU möchte
das wird aber wie gesagt dann erst in
den kommenden Tagen besprochen
ich bleibe hier etwas vage weil
eigentlich wird das Programm morgen
besprochen aber man hat im
Bundesvorstand ja den Wunsch die
Tagesordnung zu ändern so dass morgen
ist nur um die Kandidaten geht und nicht
schon um das Programm und dann würde um
das Programm
nächste Woche in nächster Woche
debattiert werden wenn man dann
durchkommt es kann wie gesagt oder sein
das noch mal ein
sonderpartei-tag organisiert werden muss
wo über das Programm gesprochen wird das
ist eine ungewöhnliche Situation für die
Kandidierenden die sich morgen
aufstellen werden denn das bedeutet dass
sie hier dem Programm das Programm
unterstützen sollen dass sie noch gar
nicht kennen
und
es geht hier noch weiter mit der
Abstimmung allerdings gibt es jetzt hier
ein Ergebnis wer hier helfen kann so
dass ich meinen Gedanken noch zu Ende
führen kann das nämlich die
Kandidierenden wenn Sie sich bewerben
versichern müssen falls sie gewählt
werden als Kandidat der AFD ohne
jegliche Einschränkungen das
europawahlprogramm der AFD anzuerkennen
und das ist eben besonders interessant
weil sie ist ja noch gar nicht kennen
weil über dieses Programm ja erst noch
debattiert werden muss also
wäre es meiner Meinung nach durchaus
möglich dass ein Kandidat zwar gewählt
wurde aber sofern er unzufrieden ist mit
der darauffolgenden Debatte über das
Programm dann durch doch wieder
zurücktreten können
[Musik]
stehen sie diese Wahl an nimmt an
dann frage ich Frau hentury Becker Frau
tourid Becker nehmen Sie die Wahl an
ja nimmt auch an Frau Thury Becker
Martin Kellner habe ich schriftlich
Pauline Knudsen
Pauline Knutzen
zweiter Aufruf Pauline Knutzen mal zur
zirkkommission
und dritter und letzter Aufruf
nehmen Sie die Wahl an
nicht angenommen damit abgelehnt
Frau Knutzen fürs Protokoll dann frage
ich Jakob brogele nehmen Sie die Wahl an
ja
nimmt an
[Musik]
und den Rest habe ich wieder schriftlich
gut dann stelle ich fest haben wir 59
mitgliedkommission gewählt vielen Dank
für die unterstützungsbereitschaft und
ich schließe damit auch den
Tagesordnungspunkt 4 und rufe auf den
Tagesordnungspunkt 8 und das macht
Kollege Flaggen
und die frisch gewählte zielkommission
bitte sich im hinteren linken Bereich
des Saales dort drüben einzufinden um
mal mit den Wahlleitern die notwendigen
Vorkehrungen zu besprechen die
zielkommission wurde gewählt und das
bedeutet dass der Tätigkeitsbericht des
Bundesvorstand für 2022 und 20 23 hier
nun
abgelegt werden kann
so einen wunderschönen guten Tag noch
mal von dieser Stelle wir fahren fort
mit dem
Tagesordnungspunkt 8 allerdings muss ich
vorab feststellen dass es insgesamt
etwas unruhig im Saales lassen Sie bitte
arbeitslautstärke einkehren insbesondere
in den hinteren Bereichen ist der
Diskussion sonst schwer zu folgen bitte
einmal etwas Ruhe einkehren lassen und
dann fahren wir fort
und zwar im Tagesordnungspunkt 8 unter
Punkt A dem Tätigkeitsbericht des
Bundesvorstands für das Jahr 2022 vom
18.06 bis
31.12 von nach der Neuwahl bis zum 28
Juli dieses Jahres das ist der heutige
Tag es handelt den Tätigkeitsbericht
gemäß Paragraph 11 Absatz 7 Satz 1
unserer bundesratsung und ich erteile
tino-
ja sehr geehrte Delegierte das ist der
politische Teil des
Rechenschaftsberichts unseres
Bundesvorstandes wenn es danach auch zu
den einzelnen Punkten oder zu
politischen Themen und noch zu
politischen Aktionen Fragen gibt steht
der gesamte Bundesvorstand natürlich
dann auch zur Verfügung gemäß auch das
geschäftsverteilungsplanes des
bundesvorstandesrede gesagt vor über
einem Jahr hatten wir den 13 und letzten
Bundesparteitag in Riesa
die Stimmung die ich damals zu Druck war
teilweise gedrückt teilweise
erfahrungsvoll die zwei beleihenden
Jahre des Bundesvorstands unter der
Führung von Professor Jörg Meuthen waren
Hemd und in Riesa bekundeten die
Delegierten deutlich den Willen diese
bleierden Jahre ein für allemal auch zu
beenden damals standen wir bei Forsa in
Umfragen bei neun Prozent bundesweit in
den ein Jahr später wie wir es jetzt
sehen stehen wir bei Forza bei 90% in
anderen Umfang bei 20 und darüber hinaus
bei der Umfrage zur Europawahl haben wir
die 20 Prozentmarke mittlerweile schon
gerissen in Hessen und Baden-Württemberg
stehen wir aktuell so gut da wie nie man
sieht auch hier und das war ja auch eine
Maßgabe und Vorgabe des Bundesvorstandes
dass die Initiative westfrüchte getragen
hat und dass der Bundesvorstand hier
nicht nur verspricht dass er auch den
entsprechend auch liefert und gerade der
friedenskurs während des Ukraine Kriegs
war auch abgestimmt dass er die Wähler
im Westen und im Osten auch
gleichermaßen ansprach wir haben uns als
Friedenspartei profiliert die
Bundesgeschäftsstelle hat den
Landesverbänden in Bayern in Hessen in
Brandenburg und Sachsen-Anhalt auch
dabei unterstützt
Friedensdemonstrationen im April 2023
mitzuorganisieren wir waren mit der eine
der ersten Parteien die genau das
thematisiert haben das Motto war damals
den Frieden eine Chance wir haben
finanzielle Unterstützung gewährt und
kampagnenmittel auch zur Verfügung
gestellt dafür möchte ich mich auch im
Namen des gesamten Bundesvorstandes bei
den Landesverbänden recht herzlich
bedanken für die Unterstützung aber auch
für die Durchführung dieser
Demonstration
noch wichtiger ist aber die klare
politische Ausrichtung gewesen
wir sagen klar auch
Aktionen in Land aber auch mit der
Bundestagsfraktion Nein zu
Waffenlieferungen und ja zu einem
Frieden zu durch Verhandlung mit dieser
Interessen geleiteten Politik bewegen
wir uns auf einer Wellenlänge mit
realpolitikern wie zum Beispiel Ungarns
Ministerpräsident auch Viktor Orban das
vertritt auch diese Erfolgskurs musste
mit Argumenten durchgesetzt werden und
nein sage ich deutlich auch das hat
mittlerweile dieser Bundesvorstand
gezeigt unter der Ärger wäre das so
niemals möglich gewesen als Alternative
für Deutschland stehen wir mittlerweile
als einzige
Partei auf der Seite Deutschlands und
der deutschen Interessen und zur
Interessen geleiteten Politik unserer
erneuerten Bundespartei gehört der Kampf
auch gegen die Teuerung der Kampf für
günstige Energie und faire Preise am 8
September 2022 haben wir deshalb die
Kampagne Energiesicherheit und Schutz
vor Inflationen gestartet dazu gehörten
umfassende Werbemittel und finanzielle
Unterstützung für die Landesverbände und
auch eine Demo am 8 Berlin am 8 oktober
in Berlin mit über 10.000 Teilnehmern
die deutschlandweit auch für uns
Aufmerksamkeit gebracht haben und die
damit eigentlich auch der Startsignal
für unsere Umfrageergebnisse waren die
Bürger haben gesehen dass wir uns für
deren Interessen einsetzen unser Motto
war damals unser Land zuerst was
weiterhin auch Früchte trägt und was wir
auch weiterhin als Motto beibehalten im
Gegensatz zu früheren Kampagnen war
diese Kampagne auch direkt an den
Bedürfnissen und Interessen der Bürger
ausgerichtet sie war auch der Zahnung
mit der Politik der Bundestagsfraktion
und der Landtagsfraktion so war das auch
möglich gewesen dass wir deutschlandweit
auch in die Länder gewirkt haben mit
diesen Themenschwerpunkt konnten wir
schon bei der Landtagswahl in
Niedersachsen am 9 Oktober die
Trendwende erreichen mussten wir noch
unter dem alten Vorstand darum fürchten
in diesen Flächenland und das war die
große Befürchtung in Niedersachsen
überhaupt einzuziehen gelangen uns der
sichere zweistellige Einzug mit elf
Prozent dieses Ergebnis hat zur
gesündigung auch des Landesverbandes
Niedersachsen beigetragen liebe Freunde
die Energieversorgung war bei der Wahl
in Niedersachsen das wichtigste Thema
allgemein Preissteigerung und
Energieversorgung waren für die Wähler
der Alternative für Deutschland dort das
wichtigste Thema wir fordern einen
breiten Energie-Mix und freie Wahl der
Energieträger auch Gas und Öl aus
Russland sollen wieder verfügbar sein
wir leben in den Wirtschaftskrieg gegen
Russland ab wer auch immer hinter dem
Anschlag auf Nordstemmen steckt muss
bestraft werden wir sagen ganz klar auch
diese Anschlag muss aufgeklärt werden
auch diese Politik betreiben wir mit der
Bundestagsfraktion verzahnt mit der
Bundespartei hier sagen wir ganz klar
diejenigen auch die Mitesser müssen zur
Rechenschaft gezogen werden liebe
Freunde und das
bedeutet die Politik im Interesse
unserer Bürger wir lassen uns niemals
durch Erwartungen der sogenannten
politischen Korrektheit treiben wir
legen unsere Schwerpunkte dorthin wo die
waren Probleme bestehen dorthin wo die
Bürger sorgen umtreiben das Problem der
unerwünschten Zuwanderung ist das beste
Beispiel dafür
Probleme liebe Freunde und das hat nicht
nur die AFD stark gemacht das
thematisiert sie immer wieder ist seit
europäisch noch national und deshalb
müssen wir dort weiter und werden wir
dort weiter die Finger in die Wunde
legen
auch im Rahmen der Kampagne unser Land
zuerst haben wir eine kleine Kampagne
die blitzeinwirkung gestartet dazu
gehörte ein einzelfallticker der
Kriminalfälle wertungsfrei auf einer
Webseite anzeigt dazu gehört ein
Faltblatt in kostenfreier Startauflage
von über 100.000 Exemplaren für die
Landesverbände aber auch
großflächenpakate wie auch in der
Energiepolitik war diese Kampagne eng
mit der Politik unserer Fraktionen
als die Pläne für ein Verbot von Gas und
Ölheizungen bekannt wurden haben wir
unter dem Titel heizhammer stoppen
weitere Kampagnen Elemente im Internet
aufgenommen wir arbeiten daran
keine Gegenöffentlichkeit herzustellen
wir nutzen immer mehr eigene Kanäle
jetzt auf tiktok aber auch die eigene
neue Plattform afd-tv um unser Programm
weiter zu verbreitern wir kooperieren
mit alternativen Medien und etablieren
auch eine eigene Talkshow so wollen wir
das Meinungsbild auch in Deutschland
weiter verändern wir wollen
Parteifunktionäre Schulen auch dazu
lässt alles weidelt ein
Kompetenznetzwerk entwickeln in dem
qualifizierte Mitglieder ihre
Fähigkeiten entfalten können online in
Tagungsstätten oder in der
Bundesgeschäftsstelle sollen diese
Mitglieder Schulungen abhalten zu
verschiedenen großthemen die Umgang mit
dem Verfassungsschutz Parteiprogramm
Rhetorik Pressearbeit oder
Verhandlungsführung und
Konfliktmanagement die Planungen dabei
sind Folgen sind in vollem Gange und
genau das ist auch wichtig für uns als
Partei denn solange unsere Stiftung
berechtigt dieses Geld verwehrt wird
werden wir als Partei handeln um auch
unsere Nachwuchs dementsprechend
zu schulen
zum Thema Verfassungsschutz das war ja
bereits heute schon im Grußwort von
Martin reichert das Themas hier versucht
dieser unter Thomas Halden waren nach
wie vor unsere Partei zu schaden er hat
dabei aber immer weniger Erfolg immer
mehr Bürger begreifen dass die
Extremismus Einstufung
Experiment und Instrument im
parteienkampf missbraucht wird unsere
juristische Gegenwehr war mehrmals
erfolgreich das zeigt es lohnt sich wenn
wir uns wehren aber die juristische
Vorgehensweise muss mit der politischen
Strategie und Kommunikation besser
abgestimmt werden als es sicherlich in
der Vergangenheit vielleicht das ein
oder andere Mal der Fall war nach der
Vorstellung des
verfassungsschutzberichts sagte Herr
Haldenwang tatsächlich im ZDF und diese
Aussagen muss man sich einfach auf der
Zunge zergehen lassen
nicht
alleinschutz
zuzusenken und genau das heißt im
Umkehrschluss der Verfassungsschutz ist
dafür zuständig unsere Umfragewerte zu
senken das ist ein absoluter Skandal und
hat mit demokratischer Willensbildung
und mit demokratischen Wettbewerb nichts
mehr zu tun hier fällt die Maske der
Verfassungsschutzes
[Applaus]
und deswegen haben wir auch hier ganz
klar juristische Hebel angesetzt und
einmal an allen Wagen im Mai abgemahnt
als der Teil unserer Partei unterstellte
Extremismus zu fördern in Deutschland
Hass und Hetze zu verbreiten wir haben
auch Dienstaufsichtsbeschwerde erhoben
weil haldenwangsäußerung unserer Ansicht
nach auf eine Wahlempfehlung gegen
unsere Partei hinausliefen die junge
Alternative hat gegen das Bundesamt für
Verfassungsschutz geklagt nachdem sie
als erwiesen extremistisch eingestuft
worden war bis zur Entscheidung im
Hauptsache Verfahren war auch diese
juristische Auseinandersetzung für die
junge alternative erfolgreich und
deswegen musste halten waren diese
Einstufung auch zurücknehmen liebe
Freunde
mit dieser Willfährigkeit der Regierung
gegenüber hat Thomas heidenbank die
Einordnung seiner Behörde in den Augen
der Bürger weitgehend die legitimiert
als politische Waffe ist der
extremismusvorwurf mittlerweile stumpf
aber er bedroht natürlich weiterhin alle
Beamten in unserer Partei und kann als
Aufhänger herhalten für Maßnahmen oder
Verfahren gegen uns und daher werden wir
auch in Zukunft mit
absoluter Entschiedenheit juristisch
dagegen vorgehen wir werden uns immer
wieder auf den Rechtsstaat berufen und
wir werden weiter Siegen das ist unsere
Herangehensweise und wir werden dort
nicht locker lassen die Stigmatisierung
der al Deutschland ist gebrochen überall
in Deutschland haben wir einen starken
Mitgliederzuwachs zu verzeichnen in
Riesa mussten wir noch
10.000 Abgänge beklagen heute und darauf
bin ich sehr stolz darauf ist der
gesamte Bundesvorstand sehr stolz kann
ich Ihnen mitteilen dass wir die Zahl
von
32.187 Mitglieder nennen können wir sind
attraktiv wir sind Volkspartei liebe
Freunde wir sind so viele Mitglieder
wie nur noch knapp die Hälfte der Bürger
gibt bei einer insel-umfrage an niemals
AFD zu wählen der neue Bundesvorstand
hat eine Marke repariert die mancher im
alten Bundesland Vorstand für ihre
Parabel gehalten hat auch das ist ein
Erfolg unserer Mitglieder unserer
Landesverbände darauf bin ich stolz
darauf bin ich dankbar für jedes
Mitglied die das mit erreicht hat die
uns aber auch als Bundesvorstand
dahingehen unterstützt hat manche einer
hielt Professor Meuthen für ein
bürgerliches Aushängeschild ohne dass
unsere Partei nicht bestehen können
dieser die heute ist ausgetreten und
bezeichnet unsere Protest und
programmpartei heute Zitat völlig lang
erhoffe Zitat dass die Brandmauer der
Union hält unser Umfragewerte würden
wieder fallen es bestehe keine reale
Macht Option so seine Worte die Wahrheit
ist
wenn ihr euch morgen heute parteiche
wäre dann stünden wir in den Umfragen
höchstwahrscheinlich einstellig da dann
würden wir uns immer noch in
innerparteilichen kämpfen aufreiben
anstatt uns mit Lösungen für die
Probleme der Bürger politisch zu
befassen und eine reale Machtoption wird
es in Bälle ohne uns nicht mehr geben
und deshalb
dass sie programmatische
[Musik]
programmatische politische Ausrichtungen
für unsere Partei sich auszahlen und das
auch Zusammenhalt in dieser Weise
unserer Partei nicht schaden im
Gegenteil
nützt und darauf bin ich stolz darauf
können wir alle stolz sein als
Alternative für Deutschland ich habe
immer an unsere Partei geglaubt und ich
glaube auch heute weiter an unsere
Partei wir werden Deutschland verändern
und die Wände zum Guten bewirken zuerst
in einem Land im Osten dann im Westen
und dann im Bund darauf können wir alle
bauen liebe Freunde
[Applaus]
und wir werden genau diese verbalen
Brandmauern auf diesen Weg dorthin
beseitigen und auch in Europa werden wir
mit unserem Leitbild einer
interessengeleiteten Politik vorangehen
wir sind erwachsen wir sind
selbstbewusst und wir befinden uns auf
dem Weg nach oben jetzt müssen wir genau
diese Umfragewerte in den Wahlen
natürlich noch bestätigen und deswegen
heißt meine Forderung nach wie vor
behalten wir die Disziplinen die
Einigkeit und den guten Willen ich danke
allen Mitgliedern des Bundesvorstandes
für die gute und konstruktive
Zusammenarbeit und freue mich auf die
zweite Hälfte unserer gemeinsamen
Amtszeiten ich sage nur wir sind bereit
weiter so vielen Dank liebe Freunde
[Applaus]
vielen Dank sehr Propeller
gibt es
erst einmal Ergänzungen von den Kollegen
jenseits des finanziellen Teils der
kommt ja gleich noch separat
ist erst einmal nicht der Fall dann
eröffne ich die Aussprache zum
Tätigkeitsbericht für den Zeitraum
18.06.20 bis zum 28 Juli 23
gibt es Wortmeldungen an den
samikrofonen oder auch hier vorne
jawohl da haben wir eine Wortmeldung am
roten saalmikrofon bitteschön
ja so wir Wolf Kreisverband
Oberspreewald Lausitz
Kino das war jetzt noch Ausführung wie
die Partei mehr oder weniger außen nach
außen da steht ich fand es natürlich
schade dass dieser Antrag dass die
Presse ausgeschlossen wird leider hier
nicht die Mehrheit gefunden hat denn
manchmal denke ich ist es schon wichtig
dass wir für uns sein sollten weil
gerade diese Sache untergräbt eigentlich
die Möglichkeit dass man auch wirklich
kritische Fragen parteiintern hätte
intern auch klären können
meine Frage ist wie der Bundesverband in
Richtung innerhalb der AFD agiert das
wäre eine Nachfrage denn ich weiß nicht
wer das mitbekommt
wir laufen in Zukunft die Gefahr dass
wir mehr oder weniger unsere Grundsätze
ja ich will jetzt nicht sagen missachten
aber zumindest ein bisschen einschränken
wir wollten gegen Berufspolitiker
dauerhaft sein den parteienfilz und die
Vetternwirtschaft unterdrücken und die
Gefahr die ich jetzt mehr oder weniger
auch morgen sehe ist dass wir oder das
auch ich sag mal Mitglieder des
Bundesvorstand versuchen ihre ihre
Angehörigen morgen zum Beispiel auf der
Liste unterzubekommen dass wir Leute in
die
wichtigen
mandatsträgerpositionen reinkriegen die
eine Grundvoraussetzung haben sollten
dass sie zumindest eine Berufstätigkeit
erlernt haben sollten dass er ihr
Studium mindestens abgeschlossen haben
sollten und das im mindestens ein Hauch
von dem mal erarbeitet haben um ihren
Lebensunterhalt zu bestreiten hier sind
Arbeiten Bevölkerung die wir vertreten
und auch so Leute sollten wir auch
letztendlich niemandatspolition ich habe
selbst erlebt wir gehen wirklich die
Gefahr dass wir genau das jetzt
missachten und ich glaube nicht dass
jeder Einzelne von uns in die AFD
eingetreten ist
um Leute die Partei
ihre zu zu ebenen um ich sage mal ihr
ganzes Leben vielleicht noch nie
gearbeitet haben und dann mit einem
richtig fetten Gehalt nach Hause zu
gehen das ist nicht der Schritt und was
wie steht die wie steht die der
Bundesvorstand zu dieser Sache und wird
er sowas unterstützen dass wir hier
unsere Grundsatz unsere Grundsätze
letztendlich missachten danke
ja dazu Tino propalla
Herr Wolf das war ja schon fast eine
Grundsatzrede natürlich sind viele
Fragen darin die du gerade jetzt hier
selbst jemals auch dahin gehend wie du
auch morgen gerne genau diesen
Kandidaten stellen kannst grundsätzlich
sage ich auch als Bundesvorsitzender und
auch im Namen des Bundesvorstand dass
diese Grundsätzen natürlich auch
weiterhin Bestand haben das ist ganz
klar wir wollen nicht die Partei der
Grünen werden wir sollten immer darauf
achten dass Berufsabschlüsse das
Studienabschlüsse oberste Priorität
haben dass wir Leute auch finden und
auch entsenden in europa-parlamente aber
auch in Landesparlamente
die haben die natürlich auch ein Stück
weit schon was geschafft haben und die
auch mit Recht und Zug die Interessen
der Bürger vertreten also an diesen
Grundsätzen wenn wir weiter beibehalten
ansonsten die Fragen die Du hier heute
gestellt hast die Stelle bitte morgen
den Kandidaten wo du meinst und denkst
dass das vielleicht nicht der Richtige
wäre dann können diese sich auch darin
gehen äußern vielen Dank
vielen Dank dann noch mal Herr Wolfram
roten seine Mikrofon
entschuldigung dass ich nachher leider
habe ich morgen eben nicht die
Möglichkeit das zu beeinflussen ich will
jetzt nicht die Wahl bei uns im
Delegierten
Delegierten Parteitag jetzt hier
auseinander Krise aber wortwörtlich hat
einen Mitglied des Vorstandes
bei der Aufstellungsversammlung
wortwörtlich kundgetan das genau diese
Grundsätze er dafür stehen wird und
sorgen wird dass diese abgeschafft
werden
gibt es weitere Wortmeldungen zum
Tätigkeitsbericht des Bundesvorstands
das kann ich nicht erkennen dann
schließe ich den Tagesordnungspunkt 8a
die Versammlung hat den
Tätigkeitsbericht des Bundesvorstands
für den genannten Zeitraum zur Kenntnis
genommen wir kommen dann zum
Tagesordnungspunkt 8 Berta B den
finanziellen Teil des Tätigkeitsberichts
des Bundesvorstands für das Jahr 2022
und dann folgt danach der Bericht der
Rechnungsprüfer für das Jahr
2021 gemäßbar auf 11 Absatz sieben Satz
2 unserer Bundes-
[Musik]
wenn das anders gesehen wird bitte ich
um entsprechende Anträge und erteile
jetzt erst einmal das Wort unserem
Bundesschatzmeister Carsten Hütter
ja herzlichen Dank ich bitte dann um die
Einblendung der Präsentation zum
vorläufigen tätigkeitsbrief finanziellen
Teil 22
wunderbar so meine Damen und Herren
vorab der Rechenschaftsbericht 21 hatte
ich vorhin schon mal in einem anderen
Redebeitrag mitgeteilt ist bereit
bereits veröffentlicht ist letztendlich
auch von der deutschen
Bundestagsverwaltung schon bearbeitet
nichtsdestotrotz habe ich hier vorne am
antragstisch noch mal einige Exemplare
des Rechenschaftsbericht 21 ausgelegt
falls dort Interesse besteht unsere
Rechnungsprüfer werden auf den 21er
Bericht noch einmal eingehen ich werde
mich hier heute auch aus Zeitgründen auf
die aktuellen Zahlen auf den
22er vorläufige Bericht fokussieren so
bitte um die Folie Nummer 2
meine Damen und Herren es geht hier um
die Eckpunkte für die Jahre 2122
Ergebnisrechnung fürs Jahr 22
Vermögensbilanz für 22 und die
Erläuterung zur ausgewählten Positionen
in der Vermögensbilanz bitte um die
Folie 3
meine Damen und Herren die Mitglieder
der Gesamtpartei im Jahr 22 betrug
29.105 sie haben vorhin vom Vorsitzenden
gehört dass wir dort deutlich im Aufwind
sind die Anzahl der Förderer betrug
1048 es wurde ein überschuss- bzw ein
Minus von
292.400 im Berichtsjahr geschrieben wir
haben ein Reinvermögen zum Stichtag
31.12 22 in der Höhe von 14 Millionen
171.000 und
49 entschuldigung ich bitte um die Folie
Nummer 4
meine Damen und Herren die Einnahme des
Bundesverbandes in 22
vorläufig mit aller Deutlichkeit
Mitgliedsbeiträge 2,7 Millionen
mandatsträgerabgaben und gehen an die
Bundesebene in Höhe von 53.000 Euro
regelmäßige Beiträge das sind Förderer
analog 1 Mitgliedsbeiträge 90.000
Spenden von natürlichen Personen knapp
1,6 Millionen da habe ich mir etwas mehr
gewünscht aber sie wissen selber was im
Jahre 21 22 alles vorgefallen ist und es
war nicht einfach Spenden einzuwerben
Spenden von juristischen Personen 36.000
Einnahmen aus Unternehmenstätigkeit das
sind vor allen Dingen die Lizenzen im
Shop den wir jetzt gerade wieder als
Partei übernehmen in der Höhe von 11.000
Euro Einnahmen aus sonstigen Vermögen
512.000 Einnahmen aus Veranstaltungen
etc 1200 Euro staatliche Mittel das ist
die teil Finanzierung vor der
Ausschüttung an die Landesverbände von
8,8 knapp 3 Millionen Euro sonst die
Einnahmen 10.000 ca 10.000 Euro und
Zuschüsse von Gliederungen das sind die
20 Prozentanteile an den Bundesverband
von den LVS mit die den Selbsteinzug der
Beiträge durchführen eine Gesamteinnahme
von 13 Millionen knapp 600.000 Euro
bitte um die Folie Nummer 5
jetzt kommen zu dem leidigen Thema der
Ausgaben meine Damen und Herren wir
haben da zunächst die Personalausgaben
mit 3,18 Millionen dann Sachausgaben des
laufenden Geschäftsbetriebes von 3,1
Millionen für politische Arbeit 2,6
Millionen für Wahlkämpfe
98.944 Euro diese Summe ist im Jahr 22
so gering weil kaum Wahlkämpfe
stattgefunden haben für die
Vermögensverwaltung einschließlich der
sich herausgegebenen Zinsen 170.000
sonstige Zinsen Null Ausgaben Rahmen der
Unternehmertätigkeit Null sonstige
Ausgaben 500 Euro Zuschüsse an
Gliederung Ausschüsse der Landes der
landesverbandsanteile staatliche
Teilfinanzierung und Beiträge in der
Größenordnung von 4,6 Millionen
Gesamtausgaben nach den Nummern 1 bis 3
meine Damen und Herren 13 Millionen
knapp 900.000 Euro das macht ein Defizit
im Jahre 22 von
20092.400 Euro meine Damen und Herren
willkommen zur foliennummer 6
vielen dank besitzposten des
Bundesvorstandes Anlagevermögen
Sachanlagen Haus und Grundvermögen
385.000 das bezieht sich vor allen
Dingen um zwei Grundstücke aus aus
Erbschaften einmal in der Höhe von
275.000 einmal in der Höhe von 110.000
dann die allgemeine
geschäftsstellenausstattung der neuen
Geschäftsstelle in der Größenordnung von
310.000 Finanz-
[Musik]
56.163 so gesamtbesitzkosten sind dann
22 Millionen
110 Euro wir kommen zur Seite 7
[Musik]
das ist die vorläufige
Vermögensbilanz aus 22 sagt ganz extra
dabei vorläufig weil die Zahlen noch
nicht alle komplett zusammengestellt
sind das sind einmal diese
Rückstellungen was ich gerade schon
erwähnt habe in der Höhe von 6,59
Millionen Verbindlichkeiten
gegenübergliederung in der Größenordnung
586.000 das ist vor allen Dingen aus dem
beitragsanteilen des vierten Quartals
weil wir haben ja einen stichtag-prinzip
das heißt wenn am 31.12 im Grunde das
noch nicht ausgezahlt ist sondern im
Januar dann findet sich das hier halt
als Verpflichtung wieder des Weiteren
sonstige Verbindlichkeiten dass das auch
zurückzuführen auf dem stichtags-prinzip
in der Höhe von 296.000 Euro die
Gesamtschule Kosten betragen damit 7,936
Millionen Euro so mit errechnet sich das
Reinvermögen der Partei momentan auf
14.000.173 Euro
und ich denke das ist ein Betrag da
können wir alle miteinander stolz darauf
sein und ich bedanke mich bei jedem und
bei allen die die Partei nicht nur auch
durch Spenden so gut unterstützt hat
vielen Dank meine Damen und Herren
so vielen Dank für die Erläuterungen
kurz einzublenden
nee der ist offensichtlich nicht da so
meine Damen und Herren ich würde es
eventuell so vorschlagen dass jetzt die
beiden bundesrechnungsprüfer zu 21 so
wie in der Tagesordnung vorgesehen
berichten und wir dann im Nachgang im
Grunde anderer Vorschlag ja der
Vorschlag wäre jetzt einmal kurz die
Aussprache zu 22 zu öffnen falls es dazu
Fragen gibt und danach dann die
Rechnungsprüfer mit 21 und Entlastung
Gott da machen wir das so ich öffne die
Aussprache zum finanziellen Teil des
Tätigkeitsbericht für das Jahr
gibt es Wortmeldungen dann bitte an den
Mikrofonen
kann nicht erkennen dass es da
Wortmeldungen gibt dann schließen wir
die Aussprache auch bereits wieder und
kommen dann zum Bericht der
Rechnungsprüfer für das Jahr 2021 gemäß
Paragraph 11 Absatz 7
der Bundesrat die Rechnungsprüfer bitte
so Herr Brett unter Schlösser herzlich
willkommen
sie haben das Wort
ja vielen Dank
wir machen jetzt eine kleine Zeitreise
wir gehen zurück in das Jahr 2021 und
stellen den rechnungsprüferbericht vor
den wir am
10 Juli per E-Mail final an die
Bundesgeschäftsstelle versandt haben
Voraussetzungen für die Abfassung des
rechnungsprüferberichts ist immer die
sogenannte Vollständigkeitserklärung des
bundesgeschäft des bundesschatzmeisters
ja die lag uns am
21.06.2023 vor vorher können wir kein
rechnungsprüferbericht erstellen und ich
rate auf allen Rechnungsprüfern in den
Untergliederungen kein
rechnungsprüferbericht zu erstellen wenn
nicht die Vollständigkeitserklärung des
Schatzmeisters vorliegt
Vollständigkeitserklärung bedeutet der
Schatzmeister bestätigt schriftlich dass
er den Rechnungsprüfer und alle ihn
bekannten und geführten konnten
vorgelegt hat und jedenfalls die
Möglichkeit zur Einsichtnahme gestanden
ob wir dann immer Einsicht nehmen ist
eine andere Frage wir haben dann zehn
Ausfertigung am 18.07 an die
Bundesgeschäftsstelle übersandt so
nächste Folie wieder
also nochmal zum Stand der
Rechnungsprüfung sie haben uns im Kalkar
gewählt Herr Brett und nicht zu
bundesrechnungsprüfern wir haben dann in
der Folge im Jahr 21 und 22 für die
prüfjahre 2019 und 20 pro 5 Prüftermine
in Berlin wahrgenommen davon eine
goldinventur die leider abgebrochen
werden musste weil die Banken uns dort
mehr oder weniger die Bank uns
rausgeschmissen hat am Bundesparteitag
in Riesa haben Sie dann den Vorstand
entsprechend bis
31.12.2020 entlastet nächste Folie
wieder
so wir haben uns vorgenommen wenn wir
prüfen weil wir nur zwei Personen sind
können wir nicht alles prüfen das ist
sachlich fachlich nicht möglich wir
haben uns also bestimmte Schwerpunkte im
Vorfeld des prüfjahres setzen das waren
hier für das Jahr 2021 die große
goldinventur und die Prüfung der
mandatsträgerbeiträge und die Kosten der
rechtlichen Vertretung das ist also das
worauf wir uns konzentriert haben wir
haben natürlich auch eine ordentliche
stichprobenartige Prüfung durchgeführt
auch da kann ich vorwegnehmen gab es
keine Auffälligkeiten nächste Folge
bitte
so und die Prüfung ist wie folgt
abgelaufen wir waren also im
Monatswechsel Mai Juni 2022 im September
und im Mai in der Bundesgeschäftsstelle
vor Ort und haben dort entsprechend
Belege gesichtet die große goldinventur
fand dann im Februar 2023 statt wir
hatten auf diese große goldinventur
bestanden auch wenn es da
Sicherheitsdenken gab weil wir denken
das gehört zum ordentlichen
Geschäftsablauf dazu und es ist
tatsächlich auch so dass auch im
Vorstand die Geheimhaltung ist da sehr
groß eben immer mal die Frage Aufgaben
gibt es das Gold in wirklich ist das da
nächste Woche
übrigens die große goldenen Tour ist
auch einer der Gründe warum wir hier
darum gebeten haben das ganze möglichst
ohne Öffentlichkeit zu machen weil wir
einfach auch nicht Lust haben irgendwann
mit einer schwarzen Kapuze über den Kopf
irgendwo entführt zu werden und man dann
glaubt man könnte von uns die Bahnen
haben das geht also nicht wir haben
auch entsprechend von der
Vollständigkeitserklärung gedeckt sieben
konnten es gab ursprünglich 3
Paypal-Konten davon sind nur noch zwei
übrig jetzt in etwas Punkt wo ich ein
bisschen stolpere wir selbst haben 16
personenbezogene Kreditkarten konnten
geprüft warum ist das
warum ist das ein Punkt wo ich stolpere
letztes Mal waren das noch elf und in
der Vollständigkeitserklärung des
bundestagsmeisters wird von 12
Kreditkarten konnten gesprochen wir
haben das jetzt noch mal im Vorfeld
ausdrücklich geprüft also wir haben
tatsächlich einen Ordner zur Einsicht
gehabt mit 16 personenbezogene
Kreditkarten konnten wir haben das aber
nicht zum Anlass genommen jetzt keinen
Bericht zu machen weil ich sag mal wir
haben im Zweifel mehr konnten gesehen
als der
Schatzmeister uns letztlich abgezeichnet
hat deswegen haben wir keinen Grund hier
kein Bericht abzugeben es lagen
Immobilien vor Wertpapiere Gold was
nicht vor lag war Fremdwährung obwohl
das mal angedacht war ist aber 2021
nicht realisiert wurden es werden keine
Zertifikate gehalten
und wir haben auch keine explizite
erbschaftsprüfung 2021 durchgeführt
der rechnungsprüferleitfaden den hatten
wir jetzt erstmal schon durchgestellt
durch vorgestellt der ist inzwischen so
durchgesetzt oder hat sich so
durchgesetzt dass selbst der
Finanzdirektor und der Schatzmeister und
auf die Einhaltung des
rechnungsprüferleitfadens hinweisen das
natürlich in Ordnung nächste Folie bitte
die Bundesgeschäftsstelle das will ich
nur anreißen hat fünf Mitarbeiter zwei
Buchhalter ein Abteilungsleiter ein
referente Berichtswesen Finanzdirektor
und das ist auch alles angemessen
wir haben die Gold Inventur durchgeführt
zwei Tage lang das war eine sehr
sensible
Thematik
wir möchten hierüber nur jetzt kurz
informieren hören Sie doch bitte zu das
ist jetzt von zentraler Bedeutung für
unsere Partei
wir haben hier ein Foto dabei
die das Gold fliegt
sicher bei einem Unternehmen es ist
dokumentiert und es ist sowohl von der
Erbschaft angefangen bis zu den
empfangsannahme der Transport die
Aufbewahrungen der Zugang sind lückenlos
insofern kann da überhaupt nichts
passieren die
das Auszählen war auch nicht ganz
einfach sie sind hier im Bild es waren
sechs Leute immer dabei und es war
ständig mit Videos überwacht also da
geht keine Büroklammer verloren so
nächste Folie bitte
die physische Prüfung war im ständigen
bei seinen der beiden Rechnungsprüfer
des bundesschatzmeisters und das
bundesgeschäftsführers sowie zwei
vertreten zwei Vertreter des Instituts
und wie gesagt ständige Videoüberwachung
die Prüfung hat zwei Tage gedauert in
der nächste Folie
es gab
Goldbarren und Krügerrands die
Goldbarren waren mit 500 und 1000 Gramm
jeweils die krügerens mit einer Unze die
sind jetzt in sogenannten safepacks
verpackt und sind auch in Zukunft läuft
zu prüfen
bitte die nächste Folie
wir haben auch
geprüft ob das Gold echt ist allerdings
die Goldwaage die uns zur Verfügung
stand ging nur bis 250 Gramm wir konnten
deshalb nicht die Kilo waren prüfen ob
die echt sind die Goldmünzen sind die
haben wir geprüft und wir sollten das
von einer Firma prüfen lassen die
Bundesgeschäftsstelle hat ein Angebot
eingeholt mit etwas über 10.000 Euro und
dann kann das eine Firma auf den
echtheitsgehalt prüfen wir gehen davon
aus dass es echt ist trotzdem empfehlen
wir die Prüfung weil das doch unser
hauptvermögen darstellt bitte weiter
also die Inventur war fehlerlos es war
alles was geprüft
was vorlag war da es war wurde neu
verpackt alles die zukünftige Inventuren
werden schneller gehen
so nächste Folie bitte
wir schlagen vor dass wir in Zukunft die
Inventur im Abstand von zwei Jahren
machen damit Ordnung in der Bilanzierung
da ist
und auch wenn es einen Vorteil wenn es
ein Wechsel gegeben hat beim
Finanzvorstand oder bei den
Rechnungsprüfern das ist eines unserer
sensibelsten Themen
die
Goldbestände liegen jetzt noch an zwei
verschiedenen Orten
wir schlagen vor das zusammenzuführen
und dann eine jeweils eine einheitliche
Inventur durchzuführen hören Sie doch
bitte zu es gibt interessanteres als
Prüfungsberichte aber glauben Sie mehr
es ist für unsere Partei von zentraler
Bedeutung
also die echtheitsprüfungen haben
darüber gesprochen und
die Goldbestände sollten wir auch so
belassen wir wissen nicht was zur Zeit
noch kommen und dann haben wir eine
sichere Bank bitte weiter
[Musik]
so jetzt können wir zum Jahr 20 und 21
ich wiederhole nochmal die Zahlen von 20
wir hatten also Einnahmen
insgesamt 26 Millionen das ist auch der
Betrag der für die anderen Jahre in etwa
gilt
davon sind 15% Mitgliedsbeiträge
8 Prozent
mandatsträgerbeiträge und das ist schon
ein erstes Thema wir haben als Partei zu
wenig Mandatsträger Beiträge wir sollten
das mittelfristig zumindest
mittelfristig erhöhen
zwei Millionen für fast 100
Bundestagsabgeordnete und 100
Landtagsabgeordnete und und sechs oder
sieben Europaabgeordnete ist
betragsmäßig zu wenig
spätestens sind sehr unterschiedlich
waren 20
25%, die staatliche Teilfinanzierung ist
wie bei allen Parteien und hören Sie
jetzt bitte ganz exakt zu die staatliche
Teilfinanzierung ist Frauen gebaut
stutzig Prozent wenn wir als uns also
Fehler in der Buchhaltung erlauben
werden wir in Zukunft diese 40 Prozent
nicht mehr bekommen wir brauchen die
staatliche Teilfinanzierung wie sie auch
alle anderen Parteien auch brauchen und
dann gab es also noch sonstige Einnahmen
mit Erbschaften und sonstigen mit 13
Prozent bitte die nächste Folie
ich darf einmal ganz kurz dazwischen
gehen meine Damen und Herren Herr Brett
hat es gerade schon auch ganz zurecht
angemahnt es ist wieder etwas zu laut
geworden bitte Gespräche nach draußen
verlagern und hier in der Halle ruhig
sein damit alle dem Vortrag unter
Diskussion Folgen können vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Vorsitzender
ist zu 21 kommen da sehen sie wieder
jetzt in die mandatsträgerbeiträge noch
gesunken jetzt sind sie nur zehn Prozent
das sollte man wenig bei diesem
Parteitag denn beim nächsten mal
diskutieren die sind in der Zahl in der
Tat am untersten Land was die Parteien
die im Bundestag vertreten sind von
ihren Mandatsträgern verlangen
die staatliche Teilfinanzierung ist hier
44% sie sehen also die Bedeutung der
staatlichen Teil Finanzierung bitte zur
nächsten Folie
bitte zur nächsten Natur ja
die
mandatsträgerbeiträge der
Europaabgeordneten Genia an die
Bundesgeschäftsstelle in den
Bundesverband die haben wir geprüft die
sind betragsmäßig richtig bezahlt worden
wenn auch zum Teil
etwas verspätet die Empfehlung zu
mandatsträgerbeiträgen haben wir ja
schon gesagt
und in Zukunft muss sichergestellt
werden dass bei allen man das Regeln die
mandatsträgerbeiträge im laufenden Monat
kommen und dass das nicht am Ende des
Jahres dann bezahlt wird die
Bundesgeschäftsstelle und die
Landesverbände brauchen auch Liquidität
wenn
Mitglieder von Parlamenten weniger
mandatsträgerbeiträge zahlen wollen dann
ist das auch wie bei der
Einkommensteuererklärung nachzuweisen zu
sagen ich habe fünf Kinder vor dem muss
ich Unterhalt bezahlen und wenn dann im
laufenden Jahr ist nur noch vier sind
weil einer fertig geworden ist dann muss
er von sich aus das mitteilen und eben
dann wieder mehr bezahlen
ein europäischer Abgeordneter unser
vormaliger Freund Last Patrick Berg ist
zum 12 Mai 21 aus der Partei ausgetreten
und hat für das gesamte Jahr keine
mandats-bundestagsabgeordneten der in
Verzug war oder ist bitte weiter
so jetzt kann man zum zweiten heiligen
Thema neben Gold nämlich zu den
Erbschaften
der Landesverband München
der Landesverband Baden-Württemberg
fehlt im Jahr 21 eine
Spende zu mittelgroße Spende in Form
einer Erbschaft
das war eine Eigentumswohnung im
Kreisverband Ludwigsburg
bei der Erbschaftssteuer bei der
Erbschaftsannahme bei der Verwertung der
Wohnung sind
Umstände zu Tage getreten die nach
unserer Auffassung noch eingehen zu
prüfen sind
in dieser Sache ist auch ein Prozess
anhängig die Wohnung wurde dem Käufer
oder auch nicht Käufer
vorzeitig übertragen
alles was mit diesem Wohnung
zusammenhängt ist
kann man nur den Kopf schütteln
das heißt dieser Vorgang muss weiter
geprüft werden von den neuen Prüfern
bitte weiter
die Bundesgeschäftsstelle hat eine
Tochterfirma gegründet aber erst im
ersten Januar 22
GmbH wir werden Sie dann dazu noch ab
nächstem Jahr prüfen
da will ich noch mal was dazu sagen und
zwar die wir leiten den Bericht
natürlich vorher der Bund
Geschäftsstelle zu mit der Möglichkeit
noch mal Stellung zu nehmen und das hat
sie in diesem Fall auch gemacht und hat
uns darauf hingewiesen dass die
alternita anders heißt inzwischen und B
auch mit einem weiteren Spektrum
gegründet worden ist als wir das im
Bericht erwähnt haben wir haben das
jetzt nicht geändert einfach aus dem
Grunde sie war für uns nicht
prüfungsrelevant weil sie wurde erst im
November gegründet es war es wurde uns
zugesichert es waren keine nennenswerten
Vorgänge dort und die eigentliche
Geschäftsbetrieb wurde erst im Folgejahr
aufgenommen deswegen haben wir uns noch
nicht reingehängt man ich will aber eins
vorneweg sagen es gab ja
Zeitungsberichte Bild-Zeitung die die
gruppengeschäfte der AFD oder ähnliches
mit der alten Miete als nichts krumm die
ist ganz normal im Handelsgewerbe
Handelsregister eingetragen das ist
alles öffentlich einsehbar und auch uns
gegenüber als Rechnungsprüfung ist von
Anfang an die Existenz dieser GmbH
offengelegt wurden und da ist also
nichts merkwürdiges drin im Gegenteil
dass wir begrüßen das wir sehen uns
Prüfer positiv dass wir versuchen hier
eigene Strukturen zu schaffen da wo wir
vielleicht keine Anbieter finden oder wo
wir sagen wollen wir wollen Leistungen
für alle Landesverbände und alle
Kreisverbände einheitlich anbieten also
da ist gar nichts verkehrt dran
so bitte weiter
so jetzt tragen wir die Einnahmen nicht
alle wieder vorzulesen 21 und 22 wir
haben das mal auf die gesamtparteien auf
dem Bundesverband gemacht die Zahlen
sehen Sie alle wenn sie dazu nachher
Fragen haben stehen wir zur Verfügung
würden Sie bitte weitermachen
die nächste Folie
so
Ausgaben der Gesamtpartei
also wir geben deutlich zu viel Geld für
Rechtsberatung aus in im Bund vor allem
aber in den Ländern also da ist viel
Potenzial zum Sparen dabei
vor allem in den Landesverbänden auch es
ist unverständlich dass wenn dort
Streitigkeiten sind dass man das vor
ordentlichen Gerichten ausführt und
nicht
vor den Landesschiedsgericht oder
unterschiedlich was kostenlos ist also
die Bundesgeschäftsstelle hat zwei
Juristen die kann da auch vieles lösen
bitte weiter
also auch das haben wir im Vorfeld
natürlich der Bundesgeschäftsstelle
zugeleitet und die hat dort noch mal
explizit Stellungen genommen das ist
auch eine Sache die kann man anders
sehen
die hat uns zum einen darauf hingewiesen
dass der Haushaltsansatz höher war
250.000 Euro und man sozusagen unterhalb
dieses haushaltsansatzes geblieben ist
das völlig richtig und zum anderen haben
Sie hier die komplette wörtliche
Stellungnahme der Bundesgeschäftsstelle
es darf nicht vergessen werden dass 2021
Bundeskampf Wahlkampf war ganz klar
und die Aussage des startbereichsrechts
hier zu erstens Rechtsberatung haben wir
nicht den Anspruch genommen sondern nur
Prozessführung des zweitens an deutschen
Land Gerichten herrscht Anwaltszwang so
dass auf die Anzahl der hier
Beschäftigten Folge Juristen nicht
zurückgegriffen werden kann das stimmt
gibt dann sogenannte
syndi-anwälte die dürfen dann eben vor
Land Gerichten nicht vertreten des
völlig richtig und dann als drittes
Anwälte die uns vertreten sind dass die
gesetzlichen Gebühren in der Regel nicht
ausreichen auch das ist völlig richtig
es ist auch gar kein kreditpunkt dass
wir unsere Anwälte nicht gut bezahlen
und dass wir die auch nicht unbedingt an
den gesetzlichen nach den gesetzlichen
Gebühren bezahlen sondern in der Regel
gerade bei den
personenrechtspersonenrechtlichen
Streitigkeiten etc da ist es völlig
üblich dass Fachanwälte auf
Stundenbasis oder minutenbasis bezahlt
werden aber die Gesamtausgabe die
Gesamtaussage von uns bleibt die Kosten
sind insgesamt zu hoch es gibt
Möglichkeiten dort anders vorzugehen
insbesondere halten es für ganz
ungünstig wenn wir nur eine Handvoll
Anwälte oder Anwalt oder eine
Anwaltskanzlei und konzentrieren und wir
halten es auch nicht für richtig dass
wir keine anderen Anwälte finden wir
denken hier muss gestreut werden und
wenn wir nach außen sagen würden was wir
Anwälten Bezahlen im Stundenlohn dann
würden die hier Schlange stehen da
würden die auch politische Bedenken
zurückstellen das ist also unsere
Stellungnahme wir bleiben dabei es wird
zu viel ausgegeben und wir wissen die
Aufträge breiter ver geben
so bitte die nächste Folie
also es wir machen das so haben es ja
vorher gemacht wir haben ihnen gesagt
was die Prüfungsschwerpunkte sind die
künftigen Prüfungsschwerpunkte sollen
nach unserer Auffassung sein alles was
mit Erbschaften zusammenhängt das ist
ein sehr heikles Thema das zu müssen wir
genau untersuchen die Reisekosten muss
man noch mal exakte untersuchen das
haben wir jetzt weniger gemacht aber das
müssen wir bei der nächsten Prüfung mal
machen und auch dazu die
reisekostenrichtlinie die wird nicht
immer angewandt über die
Rechtsberatungskosten haben wir schon
gesprochen
Punkt Reisekosten den haben wir explizit
deswegen noch mal aufgenommen weil die
Geschäftsstelle oder bzw Vorstand sich
eine reisekostenrichtlinie gegeben hat
und wir sind das Gefühl hatten dass die
noch nicht überall angewandt wird und
das auch als sage ich mal Hinweis an die
neuen Rechnungsprüfer wir wissen ja
nicht ob wir wieder gewählt werden da
sollte man dann hinschauen das wirklich
alles sich an diese Reisekosten Ordnung
auch gebunden fühlen und entsprechende
Belege und entsprechende Listen
beibringen was der Zweck der Reise war
und so weiter
die Kosten bei den
landesgeschäftsstellen sind deutlich zu
hoch da ist erheblich eine
Potenzial noch da und wie gesagt die
über die alternita muss man dann noch
sprechen bitte nächste Folie
was auch bei der nächsten Bericht zu
prüfen sein wird ist der Wechsel des
Wirtschaftsprüfers ab
Wechsel wir hatten zehn Jahre den
gleichen Wirtschaftsprüfer das ist immer
ein bisschen
sensibel da müssen wir sonst nächste mal
drüber sprechen bisherig von dem neuen
noch kein Bericht vor
das zweite was man unbedingt noch im
Auge behalten muss ist die Korrektur des
Unrecht des unrechtlichen
Rechenschaftsbericht 2017 dieses
Verfahren ist zwar in den weiteren
Rechenschaft berichten geändert worden
aber das muss noch mit der
Bundestagsverwaltung in Detail
besprochen werden so das nächste
also die Überschrift die müsste
eigentlich nicht weitere Prüfungspunkte
sondern eher strittige Prüfungspunkte
heißen weil das ist sage ich mal der
Punkt wo wir mit der Geschäftsstelle mit
der Bundesgeschäftsstelle am weitesten
auseinander sind also die
Bundesgeschäftsstelle sagt der
Wirtschaftsprüfer das ist sozusagen ein
Punkt der da haben wir keine Befugnis
uns sage ich mal einzumischen wir sehen
das ein bisschen anders zumal uns wie
gesagt die Wahl des Wirtschaftsprüfers
die plötzliche Wirtschaft überrascht hat
eventuell ist das auch ein Punkt den man
den prüfungsleitfaden künftig mal ändern
müsste und das andere ist der Fortgang
zu Korrektur des unrechtlichen
Rechenschaftsbericht da sagt die
Bundesgeschäftsstelle ganz zutreffend
wir haben diese Unrichtigkeit im
Rechenschaftsbericht 2021 angegeben und
unser Standpunkt ist dazu ein ganz
vorsichtiger einfach nur dass wir sagen
solange wir von der Bundestagsverwaltung
kein Schreiben haben dass die
ursprünglich unrichtige Verbuchung keine
finanziellen Folgen für uns hat behalten
wir es auf den Tisch und sagen nicht ist
erledigt ja
das ist deshalb von zentraler Bedeutung
für uns
sie haben ja vorher gesehen wir haben 26
Millionen Einnahmen im Jahr 40 Prozent
bekommen mehr staatliche
Teilfinanzierung also 10 Millionen wenn
uns die fehlen würden dafür zum schlecht
gehen und deshalb müssen die Buchhaltung
hundertprozentig in Ordnung sein bitte
die nächste Folie
so jetzt zu unserer eigenen Situation
wir sind derzeit zwei Rechnungsprüfer
das ist deutlich zu wenig
wir bitten Sie wenn Sie heute wählen
dass sie noch drei weitere wählen dass
wir fünf würden
die Prüfungen wenn man das richtig macht
sind sehr zeitintensiv also wir haben
jetzt ein
prüfungsmechanismus entwickelt wir sind
jedes Quartal ein Wochenende oder
Freitag samstags machen wir es immer in
der Bundesgeschäftsstelle und Prüfen des
Quartal dann muss das Ganze abgefasst
werden und im Prüfbericht dann gibt es
möglicherweise Sonderprüfungen bei
Landesverbänden die Teilnahme an der
staatsmeisterkonferenz im Bund und auf
Partei Tagen also wir haben mal
zusammengerechnet wir brauchen für
Prüfer etwa 10 Tage im Jahr volle Arbeit
kann auch ein bisschen mehr sein
also für die die sich nachher bewerben
bitte kommt aber ihr müsst wissen zehn
Tage im Jahr das muss man machen sonst
ist es keine Prüfung wir sind hier in
mittelständischer Betrieb bitte weiter
und wenn Sie
rechnungsprüfe wenn Sie das Erwägung
ziehen ist es ganz wichtig dass wir auch
eine solide
hinter sich stehen dass sie auch mal
wenn es diese Auskunft steht ja nicht zu
dass sie dann doch vielleicht drauf
waren ich bin immer ganz froh dass ich
den Eberhard Brett habe weil er das mit
mit innenbrunst vertritt ich bin da eher
so ein bisschen Harmonie süchtig also
sie müssen auch wirklich in der Lage
sein wenn ihnen die Geschäftsstelle sagt
dann hast du keinen Einblick dann sagen
sie doch mein ich bin nur der
Mitgliederversammlung Rechenschaft
wichtig und ihr könnt mir das gerne
heute nicht geben die die Einsicht aber
dann besprechen wir es auf der nächsten
Mitgliederversammlung also man darf da
nicht dazu neigen schnell einzuknicken
aber wir trotz allem mehr empfehlen die
Entlastung der Bundesvorstandes für die
Finanzen für das Jahr 21 vielen dank
vielen Dank beim Bundestag ne
das war also der Rechnung
berichtet natürlich eine Weile hier
gedauert hat und mit zum Schluss auch
noch mal der Bitte es steht auch in der
Tagesordnung Top 13 ist Wahl von
Rechnungsprüfern das also hier noch mehr
Rechnungsprüfer gewählt werden die die
Finanzen der Parteien prüfen
liebe Freunde die zwei Bemerkungen
machen die erste Bemerkung ist ein
außerordentliches Lob und eine
Anerkennung für diese akkurate Arbeit so
wie ich sie erlebt habe wie wir sie
erlebt haben
das ist ganz wichtig dass wir als diese
andere Partei in diesen Fragen
blitzsauber sind und deshalb ist es ganz
wichtig dass diese Struktur steht und
wenn die zwei Herren das in der
mühevollen Arbeit gemacht haben eine
große Anerkennung ich glaube auch die
Anerkennung des Parteitages dass das
erste das zweite ist das Thema unserer
Finanzbasis da haben sie ja kluge
Gedanken dazu gemacht vielfach auch die
Abgaben der Abgeordneten angesprochen
meine Frage an Sie geht wir haben seit
Gründung der Partei das sind zehn Jahre
keine Veränderungen der
Mitgliedsbeitrags bezahlen gemacht keine
zehn Jahre da ist nur mehr seit drei
Jahren eine Inflation dazwischen eine
gewaltige Inflation dazwischen und dort
liegt natürlich ein kernfeld unserer
Einnahmen also Frage und die
Rechnungsprüfer müssen wir nicht
seriöser Weise
ist schon wegen Inflation ich will gar
nicht von struktureller Erhöhung
sprechen müssen wir nicht an der
Schraube drehen und erzielen wir nicht
dort sehr viel mehr Einnahmen die an
allen anderen Schrauben herzlichen
dank
recht
wenn man anschaut wir haben das ja auch
geprüft wie viel Mitglieder noch 30 Euro
im Jahr bezahlen das ist das nicht gut
also
da gibt es auch Professoren dabei oder
sonst was die sagen ich bin Renten und
sagen nordrhein- also wir sollten
unbedingt den
Mindestbeitrag erhöhen auch die 120 €
sind jetzt nicht die Welt das
hundertprozentig recht aber ich habe
heute schon genügend Pfeile auf mich ja
einwirken lassen deshalb haben wir das
ein bisschen zurückgenommen aber
hundertprozentige Zustimmung
vielen Dank dann machen wir weiter am
roten sein Mikrofon bitte schön ja schön
guten Tag Volker Kraft steht
Landesverband Berlin Bezirksverband
Steglitz Zehlendorf ich hätte noch mal
eine Frage zu den Rechtskosten
handelt es sich dabei ausschließlich um
Rechtskosten die in Auseinandersetzung
mit Dritten etwa wegen
presseveröffentlichen und dergleichen
entstanden sind oder sind hier auch in
Kosten entstanden in innerparteilichen
Auseinandersetzung etwa auch durch
Rechtskosten vor den innerparteilichen
Schiedsgerichten das würde mich noch mal
interessieren
bitte schön
also verbessern Sie mich wenn ich Ihnen
das jetzt nicht richtig beantwortet die
Akustik ist wirklich ausgesprochen
schlecht gewesen ich habe sie
möglicherweise möglicherweise nicht ganz
verstanden
habe also ähm wir haben
Rechtsberatungskosten einmal alles was
Verfassungsschutz angeht und da ist
jedes Mal richtig ausgegeben da bekommen
die Anwälte die das machen auch
ordentliches Honorar ist kein Thema das
zweite Thema ist aber worüber wir
gesprochen haben dass wenn Sachen die
man in der Geschäftsstelle machen könnte
ein bisschen viel aussortiert also da
können wir wenn Sie wollen was dazu
sagen aber das müssen wir jetzt nicht in
dieser Breite machen aber wir haben zwei
Volljuristen im Haus und die
Bundesgeschäftsstelle ist
außerordentlich gut besetzt das wollen
wir mal sagen und da haben Mic ist
allererste Sahne wir können da nur
dankbar sein dass wir ihn haben
was dann noch Geld rausgeworfen wird ist
bin in den Landesverbänden mit
Parteiausschlussverfahren und sonstige
Sachen da werden Rechtsanwälte
beauftragt dann wird das Porträt uns
Verfahren aus dieser Verfahren
zurückgenommen und ähnliches also das
schlimmste Fall hatten wir vor drei
Jahren oder so in einem unser kleinsten
Landesverbände die hatten einen Etat von
100.000 € und habe davon 60 000 vor
Prozesse ausgegeben ich meine es wird
dort nie mehr vorkommen und es waren
Einzelfall aber sie sehen die
Problematik das kann man alles über
landesschitzgerichtete lösen wir haben
so viel Juristen unter uns dazu muss man
nicht 60 Prozent vom etwa ausgeben danke
schön
das ganz große hat gerade noch mal
gehalten ist wirklich für die
verfassungsschutzverfahren und jetzt
muss mal gucken was wir als
Rechnungsprüfer auch prüfen können und
sollten wir gucken halt das ordentlich
beauftragt worden gibt es einen
entsprechenden Mandatsvertrag und sind
ist dann auch entsprechende Rechnungen
abgerechnet worden nee wir haben
natürlich intensiv also viel gestritten
über entsprechende Verfahren aber ohne
Folgen dass du sagen können da ist etwas
unrechtmäßig oder nicht in
Übereinstimmung mit der Finanz-
vielen Dank dann machen wir weiter am
Roten salmikrofon und danach am blauen
salmikrofon das war die Reihenfolge wie
ich die Damen und Herren da gesehen habe
als Meisterin des Kreisverbandes
Westthüringen ich habe eigentlich nur
noch eine Frage zu dem finanziellen Teil
des Tätigkeitsberichts 2022 ich musste
da eben noch mal nachschauen ob ich was
verpasst habe mir ist aufgefallen dass
die Zahlen sich von dem unterscheiden
was uns vorliegt und es ist auch nicht
aktualisiert von daher hätte ich die
Frage ist es möglich uns da die
aktualisierte Version so wie heute
vorgestellt noch mal zur Verfügung zu
stellen
der Schatzmeister sagt ja danke so dann
machen wir weiter am blauen salmikrofon
bitte schön
Abgeordnete aus Berlin sie haben es
schon angesprochene Brett wir haben eine
hohe Zahl an Mitgliedern die verminderte
Beiträge zahlen können Sie das mal
konkret in Zahlen fassen danke so und
erst einmal lassen wir bitte noch einmal
wieder hier die Lautstärke runter
[Musik]
drehen Gespräche bitte nicht hier in der
Halle führen bekomme
vermehrt Rückmeldungen dass im hinteren
Bereich mal den Seiten der Diskussion
schwer zu folgen ist ich würde sagen
also
und dann haben sie das Wort bitteschön
wir können das jetzt wir sind darauf
jetzt nicht vorbereitet
wir haben das mal gemacht in dem einen
oder anderen Landesverband also ich sage
Ihnen so aber das muss dann geprüft
werden bis zum nächsten Mal machen wir
das ich würde sagen 25
%. dann weiter am Blauen Saal Mikrofon
bitte schön
ich habe mal eine Frage und zwar sie
hatten
der Abgaben angesprochen die liegen ja
jetzt allgemein bei 8 % und für jedes
Kind kann man einen Prozent sein
herunterrechnen wie sehen Sie das sollen
die
mangasträgerabgaben erhöht werden zum
Beispiel auf zehn Prozent allgemein
gesehen oder soll
eventuell auch und das wurde ja glaube
ich schon mal ein Konvent gesprochen
dieser Kinderfreibetrag von diesem einen
Prozent weggenommen werden wie sehen Sie
das
also das mit den mit den
Kinderfreibeträgen das sind teilweise
schon Kapriolen deswegen haben wir auch
explizit aufgenommen dass Änderungen
während der Legislaturperiode oder als
man eine Regelung findet dass das
unverzüglich mitzuteilen ist denn ich
sag mal hat manche das Gefühl der
tauchen dann plötzlich noch irgendwo
Kinder auf und man rechnet sich
sozusagen Arm und es besteht auch nicht
wirklich die Möglichkeit dass letztlich
zu prüfen und es ist so dass man
tatsächlich in der Menge gucken muss ob
man ab einer bestimmten Zahl Kinder
nicht abschmilzt dass man dann sagt also
irgendwann ist Schluss ne weil es ist
das besteht tatsächlich die Möglichkeit
wenn man sehr viele Kinder hat dann sehr
günstig da wegzukommen
und man hat ja trotzdem wenn man Kinder
hat auch viele Unterstützung
staatlicherseits und so weiter
vielen Dank dann noch eine Nachfrage
noch ich die Frage war auch sehen Sie
zum Beispiel einer Anhebung sehen Sie
eine Anhebung von acht auf zehn Prozent
positiv
Antwort lautet
natürlich Freundschaften
aber ich denke zehn Prozent ist wäre
immer noch sehr gering also wenn man mal
schaut was bei der CDU die
Landesverbände verlangen die machen das
ja nicht auf ihre bundeseben ist sondern
Ebene oder bei der SPD oder bei den
Grünen das kann schon ein bisschen mehr
sein aber wie gesagt ich sag dazu nicht
es ist keine Frage vom Prüfer aber
sowohl die Mitglieder als auch die
Mandatsträger könnten ein bisschen mehr
bezahlen
vielen Dank weitere Wortmeldungen
hierzu sehe ich nicht der
Rechnungsprüfer selbst Herr stresser
bitte ja ich habe noch eine Ergänzung
und zwar bevor hier der Eindruck
entsteht wir machen hier merkwürdige
Vorschläge wir hatten als einen
Vorschlag gesagt wir sollten unbedingt
das Angebot der Prüfung der Goldreserven
annehmen das sind 10.000 Euro das ist
ein erheblicher Betrag dass Sie
verstehen warum wir das empfehlen der
das Unternehmen dass die Verwahrung für
uns durchführt hat uns gesagt wir sollen
um Gottes Willen aufpassen dass wir alle
Zertifikate die die Goldbarren mit sich
nehmen aufheben die haben wir auch
aufgehoben die haben wir sehr verwahrt
und er hat uns gesagt dass die
Zertifikat und jede Echtheitsprüfung
durch Fachpersonal am Markt tatsächlich
den Goldpreis für die einzelnen Bahnen
die wir behandeln im Prozentbereich
beeinflusst also diese 10.000 € die wir
da bezahlen die haben wir nachher wenn
wir es tatsächlich mal verkaufen müssen
locker wieder drin also wir sind nicht
verrückt weil wir sagen bitte prüfen für
10.000 Euro , das Geld ist am Ende
wieder drin
vielen Dank
dann prüfen der Blick in die Runde
weitere Wortmeldungen hier zu sehe ich
nicht dann kommen wir jetzt als nächstes
zum Antrag auf Entlastung erst einmal
auch dort die Frage beantragt ist
gestellt von den Rechnungsprüfern die
Frage ob hierzu noch Wortmeldungen sind
zum Thema der Entlastung ich werde
gleich noch eine recht einige
rechtlichen Ausführungen hier zu machen
gibt es zum Thema der Entlastung
aussprachebedarf ich sage Ihnen
ansonsten vorab einmal kurz Venus
betrifft und was das bedeutet oder eine
Entlastung versteht man den Verzicht der
Partei
zivilrechtlich Regressforderungen
geltend zu machen gegen die Personen die
dort im Vorstand angehörten für einen
bestimmten Zeitpunkt für alle diejenigen
Sachverhalte die bekannt sind ebenso für
Dinge die fahrlässig vielleicht noch
sonst wie passiert sein möge
Abstimmung steht und an wir haben es
gehört auch bei den Fragen natürlich
wird hier auch von der Delegierten
hinterfragt ob die Ausgaben so von der
Partei angemessen
umgesetzt wurden oder nicht besonders
interessant dort die Hoden Ausgaben für
die Rechtsberatung die auch direkt im
Bericht der Rechnungsprüfer angesprochen
wurde da geht es unter anderem um die
Rechtsberatung aufgrund der Beobachtung
durch den
Verfassungsschutz aber auch um interne
Streitigkeiten und das ist hier auch für
diesen Parteitag interessant denn die
Gerichte und die Schnelligkeit des
Schiedsgerichte wie sie arbeitet das wie
sie arbeiten das ist auch in den
diversen Anträgen hier interessant weil
einige Delegierte und auf der
Bundesvorstand Versuchung mit Anträgen
die Arbeit der Schiedsgerichte zu
beschleunigen einerseits in dem es
einfacher wird Richter an einem der
schiedsgerichtet zu werden und es gibt
zum Beispiel auch einen Antrag in dem
gefordert wird dass wenn ein
Schiedsgericht Schwierigkeiten hat ein
bestimmtes Verfahren voranzubringen dass
dann dieser Fall an ein anderes
Schiedsgericht überwiesen werden kann
diese Anträge die werden demnächst in
der Tagesordnung beraten
[Musik]
einmal kurz die anderen Namen die das
ganze betrifft
die dürfen sich auch gleich wie gesagt
an der an der Abstimmung nicht
beteiligen das sind Tino propala dr
Alice Weidel Stefan Brandner Beatrix von
Storch Carsten Hütter Joachim Kuhs dr
Silvia Limmer Jochen Hauck Stefan
proczka dr Alexander Wolf und Joachim
Paul diese Person gehörten einen der
bundesvorstände im Jahr 2021 an und
dürfen sich an der Abstimmung gleich
nicht beteiligen sofern sich hier den
Delegierte sind die entsprechenden
Nachbarn mögen in den Sitzreihen damit
ein Auge drauf haben gibt es noch
Wortmeldungen zum entlastungsantrag
wenn sie denn dann dem
Mitgliedern der Bundesvorstand des
Jahres 2021 mit Ausnahme von Professor
Dr Jörg Meuthen und Johanna Kotal
Entlastung erteilen möchten für das
gesamte Jahr 2021 darf ich sie jetzt um
die blaue Stimmkarte bitten
so diejenigen genau dort vorne die jetzt
erst letztes Jahr reingewählt wurden
können dort mit Stimmen gibt es
Gegenstimmen
kann ich keine erkennen Enthaltungen
einige einzelne Enthaltungen dann ist
ansonsten einstimmig Entlastung erteilt
für das Jahr 2021
für den genannten der Bundesvorstand
wurde entlastet interessant noch mit
Jörg mointen und Joanna Cotta beides
hochrangige Politiker Jürgen ja
ehemaliger Bundesvorsitzender die
mittlerweile nicht mehr in der AFD
Mitglied sind
zwei Satz 6 des Parteiengesetzes mit
Erörterung das Wort
erhält ihr bundestagsmeister
Hinweis weitere einige Exemplare des
rechenschaftsrechts liegen auch vorne am
neben dem antragstisch aus wer also
nochmal ein solches vom Fleet sich
genauer in Papierform ansehen möchte
kann das sich dort abholen Herr hüttern
gut wir hatten vorhin in meiner
Vorstellung des Rechenschaftsberichtes
bzw vorläufige Rechenschaftsbericht ist
22 schon kurz über 21 gesprochen sie
haben ja auch den Bericht der
Rechnungsprüfer zu 21 gehört 21 ist
mittlerweile seit ja liebe Zuschauer
liebe Zuschauer unterbrechen mal ganz
kurz hier die Debatte im Plenum des
Parteitags nachdem wir ja auch teilhaben
konnten an den Goldschätzen der AFD hier
optisch ins Bild gesetzt diese
technischen administrativen Fragen ich
bin bei jeder Partei eine Rolle das ist
bei jedem Bundesparteitag neu zu
diskutieren aber sie verpassen nichts
Wesentliches und jetzt haben wir Robert
lamber bei uns sind Spitzenkandidat der
AFD in Hessen für die Landtagswahl am 8
Oktober
sind sie eigentlich neidisch auf die
Spitzenkandidaten der AFD in Sachsen und
Thüringen für nächstes Jahr denn wir
könnten ja den Einzug in die
Staatskanzlei schaffen das würde man in
Hessen wahrscheinlich kaum erwarten aber
Herr Keller vielen Dank für die
Einladung ich freue mich dass ich
Spitzenkandidat in Hessen bin das ist
meine Wahlheimat ich bin seit 2008 in
Hessen erst in Frankfurt und jetzt seit
zehn Jahren schon in Wiesbaden also ich
fühle mich pudelwohl für die AFD in
Hessen der Spitzenkandidat zu sein
anders als in Thüringen wird es aber
wahrscheinlich keine Möglichkeit geben
die bisherige Koalition aus Schwarz-Grün
oder Jamaika sozusagen zu verhindern da
sind sie weit davon entfernt jetzt ist
er die Frage gerade in den westlichen
Bundesländern auch wenn ihre Umfrage
Ergebnisse gerade ziemlich gut sind wie
wollen sie sich da profilieren da haben
sie doch noch Luft nach oben wenn Sie
sich mit den ostdeutschen
Landesverbänden vergleichen also die
Umfragewerte in Ostdeutschland und in
Westdeutschland die sind hauptsächlich
deswegen unterschiedlich weil in
Ostdeutschland halt viele Menschen noch
die DDR erlebt haben und die haben viel
feinere Antenne für Entwicklungen die
ins Negative gehen wir sehen aber auch
jetzt bei den bundesweiten Umfragen wo
die AFD mittlerweile stabil egal welches
meinungsinstitut bei 20% oder mehr steht
dass ich gerade in Westdeutschland
gewaltig etwas bewegt und wie weit das
noch trägt das ist gar nicht abzusehen
sagen die feineren Antennen der Menschen
in Ostdeutschland wegen ihrer
ddr-sozialisation das heißt die im
Westen haben gar nicht nur noch nicht so
richtig begriffen was eigentlich gut für
sie ist gerade was die Politik der AFD
angeht also meine Wahrnehmung ist dass
es sich gerade in Westdeutschland für
die Partei dreht wir haben eine
unglaubliche Mitglieder Eintrittswelle
und der Schwerpunkt dieser
Eintrittswelle der legt auf den
westdeutschen Landesverbänden deswegen
ist es schwer zu sagen wie sich die
Wahlergebnisse am 8 Oktober darstellen
werden bisher hat halt gegolten dass die
Ostdeutschen da wesentlich kritischer
waren wesentlich feinen Antennen hatten
aber ich glaube dass viele westdeutsche
Bürger aufgewacht sind die Energiepreise
sind mit die höchsten in Europa und der
Welt und eine Mehrheit der Menschen ist
für den Weiterbetrieb von
Kernkraftwerken die AFD ist fast die
einzige Partei die diese politische
Position tritt
wenn man von den bundesweiten
Wahlergebnissen ausgeht das hätte die
hessische
Menschen Umfragen sind nicht weit weg
davon ich meine ich bundesweite
Wahlergebnis sondern Umfragen so um die
20 knapp unter 20 Prozent heißt der das
auch 80 Prozent eben nicht AFD wählen
wollen
die Wahrnehmung der AFD gerade im Westen
ist noch nicht so stark wie im Osten da
gehört sie ja sozusagen zu den ganzen
gesellschaftlichen Abläufen im Westen
doch nicht so sehr liegt das vielleicht
auch daran dass für manche Wessis die
Ostdeutschen Landesverbände zu radikal
sind oder zu radikal daherkommen also
ich sehe in Ostdeutschland dass die 40
Jahre
unterschiedlicher Sozialisation einfach
auch ein bisschen unterschiedliche
Mentalitäten hervorgebracht haben und
wenn sie bei den anderen Parteien gucken
sind die Ostdeutschen Landesverbände
dort auch ein bisschen kerniger das ist
keine Spezialität der Alternative für
Deutschland
jetzt scheint ja bei der AFD auch etwas
Partylaune zu herrschen nicht nur weil
heute Abend noch zehn Jahre AFD gefeiert
wird sondern auch wegen der guten
Umfrageergebnisse auch wegen der Fehler
die die Konkurrenz im Umgang mit der AFD
macht sind sie Gefahr dass die Partei
möglicherweise da etwas zu euphorisch
wird auch zu selbstgefällig zu sie
gesichert und das böse Erwachen kommen
dann am Wahlabend also Wahlumfragen sind
keine Wahlergebnisse das ist etwas was
die Grünen ja immer wieder erleben die
da sehr überschätzt werden und dann
Wahlabend viel geringer abschneiden
ich besprechen mit meinen Kollegen schon
seit längerem dass
Wahlumfragen in dieser Höhe wie wir sie
in Hessen haben erst einmal eine enorme
Verpflichtung sind da sind viele
Menschen die setzen ihre Hoffnungen in
uns die haben sehr stark das Gefühl dass
es gegen sie geht das immer weniger Geld
im Geldbeutel bei ihnen übrig bleibt
dass sie oft nicht mehr wissen
Monatsende wie sie sich das Geld
einteilen sollen die Energiekosten sind
hoch sie sehen bei der Ampel das wenig
Rücksicht genommen wird und sagen dann
wähle ich jetzt mal die Alternative für
Deutschland und dieser Verantwortung das
ist ganz ganz wichtig wir müssen wir uns
dann auch als gerecht erweisen Boris
rein der Spitzen kann ja der Union und
amtierende Ministerpräsident der hat ja
gesagt die Brandmauer zur AFD steht der
meinte natürlich den ersten die
Landespolitik sollte jetzt zum Beispiel
was ja nicht unwahrscheinlich ist
Schwarz-Grün keine Mehrheit mehr haben
nach der Wahl werden Sie Boris rein
trotz dieser Absage und den Stühlen vor
die Tür stellen sondern die losgespräche
anbieten also er ist einmal gilt es war
in Deutschland noch nie eine gute Idee
Mauern zu errichten
Boris rein hat von uns einige Themen
übernommen er möchte die
Grunderwerbsteuer in Hessen
reduzieren er ist für den Weiterbetrieb
oder die Wiedereinstieg in die Kernkraft
grundsätzlich in vielen Punkten in einer
Richtung wo ich ganz klar sage das kann
er inhaltlich am besten mit der AFD in
Hessen Umsetzen in einer Neuauflage der
schwarz-grünen Koalition eher nicht und
insofern ist es eine Frage ob er sich
von solchen ideologischen
Überlegungen löst und dann ist die
Alternative für Deutschland eigentlich
thematisch am dichtesten bei seinen
politischen Vorstellungen dran aber er
hat die Brandmauer gerade erneut
bekräftigt ja wenn Boris rein genau
schaut dann gibt es auch in Hessen
bereits auf kommunaler Ebene die eine
oder andere Zusammenarbeit zwischen der
CDU und der AFD
möglicherweise auch noch mit anderen
Parteien die man das so hört bei uns war
Robert Land Bru der Spitzenkandidat der
AFD in Hessen für die Landtagswahl im
Oktober danke dass sie da waren
dank schön so jetzt macht Katharina kühn
weiter was in der zwischen in der
Zwischenzeit geschah
danke wir sind in der Zwischenzeit in
der Beratung und Beschlussfassung über
Änderungen an der Satzung und den
Ordnung des Bundesverbandes in Bezug auf
Wahlen und hier geht es wie schon
häufiger angesprochen um die
Schiedsgerichte und gerade wird hier
über einen Antrag des Bundesvorstands
debattiert ob nämlich Mitglieder der
Schiedsgerichte auch ähm
auch zum Beispiel für ein Mitglied des
Europäischen Parlaments oder des
Bundestags oder eines Landesparlaments
arbeiten dürfen bislang ist das nämlich
ein ausschussgrund das soll jetzt aber
gestrichen werden damit mehr Menschen
sich für die Tätigkeit eines
Schiedsrichters interessieren und wir
hören am besten mal in die Aussprache
rein
wir fahren in der Debatte vor der Glaser
herzlichen Dank herr Präsident meine
Damen und Herren ich bin angenehme
überrascht dass das bundesheetsgericht
in der Tat an der Stelle kritisch ist
denn die Unabhängigkeit der
Schiedsgerichte ist eine heilige
Angelegenheit und deshalb war ich sehr
erstaunt über diesen Antrag dass er so
gestellt worden ist dass also
Abhängigkeiten die es nun mal gibt
zwischen Bediensteten der Fraktion und
einer Schiedsgericht Tätigkeit dass man
die tatsächlich auch ja berücksichtigt
in einer Inkompatibilität das heißt bei
allen Respekt davor Leute zu finden die
das schwierige Geschichte treiben ist
alle
Intelligenz gut investiert aber nicht an
dieser Stelle müssen wir Objektivität
geht sondern bin ich der dritte der
ebenfalls sagt bitte den Antrag ablegen
wir setzen Vorteil dr Spaniel ja ich
möchte meine Vorredner in dieser
Hinsicht unterstützen wir müssen
sicherstellen dass in unserer Partei
Schiedsgerichte nicht genutzt werden als
Machtbasis für entsprechende Fraktions
Arbeitgeber und auch entsprechende MdB
wir haben in unserer Partei ohnehin das
Thema dass viele
Schiedsgerichtsverfahren das ein oder
andere Mal genutzt werden zu anderen
Zwecken als den sie eigentlich gedacht
waren und deshalb sollten wir unbedingt
hier diese Abhängigkeit an dieser Stelle
unterbinden und den Änderungsantrag so
wie hier auch der Vorsitzende des
bundesschichtsgerichts gerade eben
gesagt hat wir sollten das auf gar
keinen Fall in unserer Satzung neu
fassen wir sollten das so lassen wie es
war
nur kurz zum Verständnis mir liegt kein
Änderungsantrag vor
Herr Bollmann haben sie einen
änderungsanteil gestellt nein es gab
keine Änderungs korrigieren auf den
Vorschlag der kommunalen Volksvertretung
das war ja eine Idee die möchte ich mich
aber nicht so eigen machen und wir reden
ja wir reden jetzt aber nur über die
Unvereinbarkeiten bei den
Schiedsrichtern wir setzen die Debatte
vor der Brockmann
ja liebe Freunde wir wollen noch mal
nicht so tun als ob die Schiedsrichter
die wir haben immer so unabhängig also
auf mich gewirkt haben unabhängig davon
wo sie angestellt sind oder nicht wir
haben hier ein Riesenproblem ausreichend
Schiedsrichter zu bekommen auch in den
Ländern und hier hat das Schiedsgericht
wie ich finde eine gute Lösung
entwickelt im Einklang mit dem Partei
Gesetz ja im Einklang mit dem
parteigesetz uns eine breitere Auswahl
an Schiedsrichtern zu bieten so dass wir
auch noch Schiedsrichter auswählen
können ich kann mich nämlich am
Parteitage erinnern da hatten wir gar
keine Wahl mehr weil letztendlich nur
noch ein Volljurist zur Verfügung stand
und ich glaube dann wählen wir uns
lieber aus mehreren Volljuristen
entsprechende Kandidaten aus vielen Dank
erstmals eine für Rede für diese Antrag
des Bundesvorstand jetzt gibt es ein
Geschäftsordnung
[Musik]
Schleswig-Holstein ich stelle den Antrag
auf Ende der Debatte die Geschichte ist
im Grunde genommen klar wir müssen die
innere parteiliche Ordnung
aufrechterhalten die Gewaltenteilung
muss weiterhin gewährleistet sein durch
diesen Antrag werden sie verletzt
deswegen ist der andere abzulegen vielen
Dank aber sie stellen den Antrag auf
Ende der Debatte ja aber sie haben
gerade zusammengesprochen deswegen
können sie nicht den anderen Ende der
Debatte stellen
so dann stellen Sie dort hinten der
junge Mann wunderbar den Antrag auf Ende
der Debatte ergibt es eine Gegenrede zum
Ende der Debatte
bitte schön
Ende der Rednerliste wäre angemessen
sind ja so persönliches
sagen haben und das sollte einfach noch
mal weiter diskutiert werden weil wir
diese Not in den Schiedsgerichten können
haben gut wir stimmen über den
weitergehenderen Antrag zuerst ab das
ist der Antrag auf Ende der Debatte wer
ist für das Ende der Debatte
danke schön wer ist dagegen
danke schön wer enthält sich dann ist
der Antrag mehrheitlich angenommen
worden wir kommen zur Abstimmung über
den Antrag sgo2 zur Annahme des Antrags
ist eine zwei drittelmehrheit
erforderlich wer dem Antrag ist CO2 des
Bundesvorstandes seine Zustimmung
erteilen möchte den bitte um das
Kartenzeichen
danke schön wer ist dagegen
so da brauche ich jetzt mal noch mal den
Herrn Base durch hier damit er sich das
zusammen mit mir anschaut das war aus
meiner Sicht nicht eindeutig genug
so dann dann stimmen wir jetzt noch mal
ab wer ist für die Annahme des Antrages
sgo2
Dankeschön wer ist dagegen
vielen Dank enthält sich
so meine Damen und Herren jetzt haben
wir die folgende Problematik wir sind
uns nicht sicher ob die zwei Drittel
Mehrheit erreicht wurde und gleichzeitig
haben wir leider eine Vorgabe des der
bundeswahlleiterin die da sagt dass wir
bei satzungsabstimmungen nicht mehr
elektronisch abstimmen dürfen
das hat dann jetzt leider zur Folge dass
wir diese Abstimmung mit Hilfe der
zielkommission jetzt hier im Saal
ausziehen müssen ich darf also darum
bitten dass die zielkommission sich
versammelt und dann werden wir gleich
noch einmal die Abstimmung erneut
durchführen bitte setzen sie sich auf
ihre Plätze kommen sie zur Ruhe wir
werden dann auch gleich noch mal die
Türen schließen und entsprechend werden
wir dann auszählen
also das ist jetzt ein etwas
langwieriger Vorgang die
Sitzungsleitung konnte hier nicht direkt
feststellen ob die zwei Drittel Mehrheit
ich hier erreicht wurde um die
Schiedsgerichtsordnung zu verändern
Hintergrund ist wie in der Debatte hier
auch gesagt dass die
afd-partei Schwierigkeiten hat Richter
für die Schiedsgerichte zu finden sowohl
auf Bundesebene als auch in den
Landesverbänden und deswegen Sie hier
einen Vorschlag gemacht hat dass es
weniger Restriktionen gibt wenn sich ein
Mitglied der Partei für einen solchen
Posten interessiert das eben die diese
paar dieses Partei Mitglied auch dann
Schiedsrichter werden kann wenn er oder
sie z.B für einen Mitglied des
Europäischen Parlaments des Bundestags
oder eines Landes Parlaments oder auch
einer kommunalen Vertretung arbeitet
das war dann eben nicht ganz einfach
hier festzustellen interessant übrigens
weil die meisten Wortbeiträge dann doch
deutlich gegen diesen Antrag gesprochen
haben denn natürlich besteht die
Schwierigkeit da drin wenn jemand
einerseits als Richter arbeitet und
andererseits aber in einem direkten
Arbeitsverhältnis zu einem Abgeordneten
z.B steht dass dann die Frage ist in wie
weit dort von einer Gewaltenteilung die
Rede ist so wie das hier auch in der
Debatte angeklungen ist
nicht der 10kommission angehören setzen
sich bitte auf ihre Plätze
und es gibt gerade noch den Hinweis die
c-kommission versammelt sich von mir aus
gesehen rechts von ihnen ausgesehen
links neben dem Podium hinten
wir sind hier noch relativ am Anfang des
partei-tags nach diesen
Änderungsanträgen an der Satzung stehen
noch weitere Änderungsanträge an an der
Bundessatzung aber auch eine
Schiedsgerichtsordnung das hier ist ja
jetzt erst einmal
eine Änderung die sich auch Wahlen
beschäftigt aber auch die
finanzbeitragsordnung soll hier noch
debattiert werden und
zum Beispiel auch die Frage wie die
Delegierten Schlüssel berechnet werden
für die Partei Tage das wird hier auch
noch debattiert werden insgesamt ist
allerdings mein Eindruck dass die Partei
hier sehr schnell
voranschreitet was wir auch gesehen
haben die Debatte zu den
Tagesordnungspunkten ist hier relativ
zügig vollzogen worden es gab einige
Anträge die entweder abgelehnt wurden
oder man beschlossen hat sich nicht
damit befassen zum Beispiel einen Antrag
über den Aufbau eines AFD freundlichen
TV Senders den einige Delegierte hier
gefordert haben da hat man beschlossen
sich damit nicht zurück nicht zu
beschäftigen oder auch einen Antrag zur
eine zu einer Resolution zur Bundeswehr
und Ukraine auch dieser wurde
zurückgezogen das wäre natürlich eine
interessante Debatte gewesen für einige
Abgeordnete denn in dieser Resolution
war der erste Satz der Krieg gegen die
Ukraine ist ein völkerrechtswidriger
Angriffskrieg Russlands den wir scharf
verurteilen sehr deutliche Töne gegen
diesen Krieg und gegen Russland die ja
auch einige in der AFD erfordern und
sich wahrscheinlich gewünscht hätten
dass hier der Parteitag diese Resolution
hier auch verabschiedet
[Musik]
wir schauen noch mal was dann auch noch
demnächst ansteht wie gesagt wurde hier
schon
debattiert und abgestimmt das Grußworte
gegen 16 Uhr hier
festgesetzt werden sollen das dann eben
verschiedene
Vertreter anderer Parteien Europas hier
sprechen werden und das wird dann
bedeuten dass über den Beitritt zur
Partei Identität und Demokratie zur
europäischen Partei das darüber
wahrscheinlich vor den Grußworten
abgestimmt wird aber es stehen wie
gesagt auch noch andere Anträge an zur
Bundessatzung unter anderem geht es da
wann Mitgliedschaften beginnen also ob
Mitgliedschaften erst
beginnen wenn eine Zahlung eingetroffen
ist oder wenn wie bisher der
Mitgliedsantrag gestellt wurde und
es gibt auch also ein Antrag zum
Beispiel vom Bundesvorstand der fordert
dass es möglich ist
eine Begründungspflicht
einzufordern also dass
auf Verlangen der Vorstand hier noch
einmal von Landesverbänden zum Beispiel
begründen muss wenn ein Mitglied des
Antrag abgelehnt wird dass das begründet
werden muss warum dieser Antrag
abgelehnt wurde denn da gibt es die
Kritik dass das eventuell ohne
nachvollziehbare Gründe abgelehnt wurde
und damit möchte sich hier die Partei
beschäftigen wie gesagt jetzt sind wir
aber hier noch in einer Abstimmung zur
Ordnung die sich damit beschäftigt wann
und wie die Richter des Partei Gerichts
gewählt werden können das ist nicht so
einfach denn es braucht eine zwei
Drittel Mehrheit dafür
wir haben es gesehen die Delegierten
stimmen mit Zetteln ab und das ist dann
nicht so einfach das zu sehen jetzt
läuft hier die zielkommission in den
Raum gut sichtbar an den warmen Westen
die können wir vielleicht mal einfangen
oder sie sehen Sie schon wie sie jetzt
zwischen den Reihen Anfang werden hier
Stimmzettel einzusammeln wir
Journalistinnen und Journalisten dürfen
uns nicht in den Rhein aufhalten wir
haben hier ein paar gesonderten Raum ein
gesonderten abgesperrten Bereich in dem
wir hier uns aufhalten können auch die
Interviews führen mit den Politikern und
Politikerinnen die hierher kommen
518 akkreditierte stimmberechtigte gab
es heute morgen die jetzt hier ihre
Stimmen abgeben das wird eine Weile
dauern und diese Zeit nutzen wir jetzt
für einen weiteres politisches Gespräch
und das führt Alexander Keller ja bei
uns ist wieder Professor Wolfgang
Schröder Universität Kassel und
Wissenschaftszentrum Berlin lassen und
vielleicht weiterfahren wo wir gerade
aufgehört aber es geht ja um eine
grundsätzliche Einordnung der Partei in
der Politik in Deutschland und auch was
wir hier am Parteitag erleben vielleicht
bleiben wir mal etwas grundsätzlich oder
Diskussion über die AFD in der
Öffentlichkeit es wird ja der AFD von
vielen vorgeworfen sie planen die
Abschaffung von Demokratie Rechtsstaat
im Parlamentarismus sozusagen ihr
entziel gibt heute der Süddeutschen
Zeitung eine Blaupause dazu wie das
ablaufen könnte Stichwort leise
schleichend effizient manche glauben ja
vor allem aus der linken politischen
Richtung es gibt diese Pause ja längst
nämlich die von 1933
klingt ziemlich abwegig was plant die
AFD eigentlich wie geht sie mit dem
politischen System ich habe jetzt die
Eckpunkte genannt Demokratie Rechtsstaat
Parlamentarismus um was wie sie da
ändern
sie hat sehr weitreichende Vorstellungen
davon wie dieses System verändert werden
soll sie ist ja zunächst mal
klassifiziert als rechtspopulistische
Partei und den Teilen rechtsextreme der
Rechtspopulismus definiert sich durch
die Gegenüberstellung von Volk und
Regierung von Volk und Establishment
oder in der Sprache der AFD die globalen
Eliten und dann kommt bei der AFD hinzu
das drinnen und draußen was eben
bedeutet wir sind wir wollen ein
homogenes Volk sein und dieses homogene
Volk setzt voraus dass wir den Prozess
der Zuwanderung stoppen dass wir dafür
Sorge tragen dass dieses Land wieder
seine eigenen Wurzeln Geschichte und
fahrt Abhängigkeit einnimmt weil das was
wir in den letzten 40 Jahren erlebt
haben ist eben ein Irrweg der
abgeschafft werden muss und dann kommt
hinzu was die Frage der
Kompromissbildung angeht dass wir in den
Umfragen sehr klar sehen dass AFD an
weniger Wähler große Probleme damit
haben das Verfahren der
Kompromissbildung was konstitutiv ist
für Demokratie in unserem Verständnis
dass sie da große Skepsis haben und
große Probleme was sie da gerade
skizziert haben ist das schon per se
verfassungswidrig rechtfertigt dass die
Beobachtung durch den Verfassungsschutz
also man muss hier auch wiederum trennen
also wenn man die programmschriften der
AFD sich anschaut dann kann man im
Großen und Ganzen ersten sagen das
bewegt sich innerhalb des
verfassungsrahmens und ist erstmal nicht
verfassungsfeindlich zweitens kann man
durchaus feststellen dass der Umgang mit
den Grundrechten durchaus so angelegt
ist dass hier bereits eine gewisse
Relativierung vor allen Dingen das
Artikels eins also die Menschenwürde
vorliegt und daraus resultiert ja dann
man muss sich andere Quellen anschauen
und die anderen Quellen die der
Verfassungsschutz sich angeschaut hat
sind die Äußerungen der einzelnen
Politiker in Schrift und Wort und sie
kommen dann ersten dazu dass die AFD
irgendwann zum prüfball wurde und seit
2021 ist die AFD Verdachtsfall und als
Verdachtsfall darf der Verfassungsschutz
auch die Abhörung der Telefone das
Einschleusen von V-Leuten verantwortlich
um genauer heraus zu bekommen ob der
Verdachtsfall sich erhärtet über das
Prüfungsverfahren die Frage ist das
schon alles hinreichend die AFD
möglicherweise sogar mit einem
Verbotsverfahrens überziehen der
Landesverband in Thüringen ist ja gilt
als Gesellschaft rechtsextreme jetzt
sind das Äußerungen von einzelnen
Politikerinnen und Politikern der AFD
möglicherweise bilden sie aber einen
Mainstream in der Partei ab aber da eine
logische Argumentationskette zu finden
zu sagen diese Partei ist
verfassungsfeindlich die muss verboten
werden solche Forderungen gibt es ja zum
Beispiel aus der CDU ähm ist das
hinreichend zurzeit ist es noch nicht
hinreichend deshalb auch mein Hinweis
auf den Verdachtsfall der Verdachtsfall
würde dann wenn die entsprechenden
Dokumente offengelegt werden dazu führen
dass durch die drei zentralen Quellen
also Bundesregierung
Bundestag oder Bundesrat müsste ein
Verbotsverfahren eingeleitet werden hier
ist man sehr vorsichtig weil wir haben
zwei Verbotsverfahren hinter uns gegen
die Ente das erste scheiterte an der
unklaren Rolle die die
V-Leute innerhalb der NPD eingenommen
haben und das zweite an der
Potenzialität also inwiefern diese
Partei also in dem Fall die NPD wirklich
eine Gefährdung für die Demokratie
darstellt im Sinne kann sie das
überhaupt durchsetzen was sie da vorgibt
zu werden der Potenzialität ist ja bei
der AFD etwas anders gelagert genau und
da haben wir jetzt die einflugscheiße
weil wenn der Verfassungsschutz seine
Berichte zum Verdachtsfall vorliegen das
muss er ja irgendwann tun dann ist die
Frage der Potenzialität nicht mehr so zu
beantworten wie bei der NPD gleichzeitig
haben die zentralen Gewalten die das
Verfahren in Gang setzen können
natürlich sehr große Bedenken geht das
gut aus oder ist es am Ende so dass wir
hier eine märtyrerbewegung generieren
weil dahinter ja doch mittlerweile je
nachdem wie man rechnet und wie man die
Dinge bewertet eben 20% der Bevölkerung
stehen und das ist dann immer auch die
Frage wer hafte Demokratie ist ja eine
präventive Intervention des Staates und
der Gesellschaft und es kann irgendwann
sein dass es zu spät ist also insofern
ist das eine Ablehnung über die
politische Opportunität der anderen der
Parteien die einen Antrag stellen das
Verfassungsgericht kann ja nicht von
sich aus tätig werden wo kein Kläger da
natürlich auch kein Richter wenn wir
jetzt ähm aber was sie gerade
angesprochen haben die Bedeutung der AFD
ihre politische Stärke 15 bis 20% auf
Bundesebene schwankt ja auch zum Teil
zum Teil fast ein Drittel in manchen
ostdeutschen Ländern und Regionen
stärkste Partei in Ostdeutschland bei
den letzten beiden Bundestagswahlen
unter den jungen Männern muss man sagen
aber immerhin sehr stark jetzt in
Thüringen und Sachsen bei der letzten
Bundestagswahl stärkste Partei kann man
sich überhaupt noch bei dieser Stärke
der AFD bei ihrer Potenzialität die Sie
gerade angesprochen haben überhaupt noch
ein Verbotsverfahren leisten oder muss
man befürchten dass aller pegida und
anderen Protestbewegungen es zu
richtigen Massenprotesten auf der Straße
kommen die auch die öffentliche
Sicherheit in Ordnung gefährlich weil
wenn die wehrhafte Demokratie bei einem
klaren Befund nicht handelt die
legitimiert sie sich selbst wenn sie
handelt und am Ende aber durch das
Bundesverfassungsgericht in die
Schranken gewesen wird hat sie auch ein
Problem und das ist der Korridor in dem
sich Politik in den nächsten ein zwei
drei Jahren bewegen wird gibt natürlich
eine andere Möglichkeit dass die AFD
selbst den Weg zurückfindet auf den Pfad
der Tugend und einsieht das bestimmte
Position von ihr nicht das ist
fraktionsweg sind und eine mit der
Demokratie nicht ver wunderbare
Situation schaffen Signale aus der AFD
zu einem Weg zurück auch um Bündnisse zu
ermöglichen mit anderen Parteien um dann
tatsächlich auch in
Regierungsverantwortung zu kommen sehe
ich bei der AFD nicht das muss man sehr
eindeutig sagen die kraftvollen regen
die hier heute morgen gehalten worden
sind die mit viel Beifall bedacht wurden
sind reden der selbstverharmlosung weil
das ist ja genau das Kennzeichen der
neuen Rechten dass sie
Anschlussfähigkeit anstrebt indem sie
die Begriffe und Bilder der
repräsentativen Demokratie der direkten
Demokratie das heißt also Beteiligung
mit Sprache für sich reklamiert und auf
der anderen Seite aber die Verfassung
neu definieren will und in der neu
Definition der Verfassung käme nicht
mehr die repräsentative Demokratie mit
gewissen Elementen der Präsidenten
Beteiligung heraus sondern es käme eine
stärker autoritäre Demokratie heraus das
kann man eben auch feststellen wenn man
sich anschaut was sind denn die
Vorbilder der AFD und da sind wir sehr
stark das ist ja auch Gegenstand des
europakongresses hier sehr stark bei der
Frage ist man in Richtung Amerika
orientiert oder in Richtung Russland und
das Bild ist hier ganz klar in Richtung
Russland starker
us-skeptizismus und starke Russland
Freundlichkeit prägen die Positionierung
der AFD wenn man sich die Vorbilder
einmal anschaut an denen man sich
orientieren will oder wo man am ehesten
Bezugnahme für das eigene Weltbild die
eigene Programmatik die eigene Ordnung
von gesellschaftlich wir haben gerade
von Blaupausen gesprochen wäre da die
aktuelle Entwicklungen in Israel in
Polen in Ungarn auch etwas was wir mit
der AFD in Regierungsverantwortung
erwarten könnten das kann man auf jeden
Fall sagen also wir haben das ja ein
Ungarn gesehen wenn eine solche Kraft an
die Regierung kommt dann muss sie ja ein
Stück weit ihr Programm realisieren weil
sonst kann sie nicht vor der eigenen
Mitgliedschaft der eigenen Mission
bestehen und das führt dazu das zunächst
mal die unabhängige Justiz außer Kraft
gesetzt wird dass die Medien unter Obhut
gestellt werden und das ist dann nicht
mehr die Demokratie für die dieses Land
in den letzten 70 Jahren gekämpft hat
und die sich als mehr oder weniger
glückliche erfolgreiche repräsentative
Demokratie auch bewährt dann gerade in
Amerika Skeptizismus und die Russland
Freundlichkeit angeschlossen das sind
Stichworte für unsere nächste
interviewen die wir dann was die Außen
in Europa Politik angeht vertiefen
wollen soweit vielen Dank Wolfgang
Schröder und wir geben gleich weiter zu
Katharina kühn
vielen
bitte hier wurden die Stimmen gezählt
von den
wahlhelfenden aber hier wird erst einmal
der nächste Antrag aufgerufen verbundene
Einzelwahl ermöglichen und wir hören mal
zu Vorsitzender wir haben uns mit einer
Situation zu beschäftigen gehabt
die tatsächlich einschneiden ist nämlich
dass die bundeswahlleiterin im letzten
Jahr
herumgeschickt hat ein Schreiben das den
Parteien sagt wie oder vor allen Dingen
wie nicht sie Satzungen ändern dürfen
deshalb haben wir jetzt hier gerade
diese Auszählung statt einfach das ganze
elektronisch zu machen wie wir es immer
gemacht haben wir haben
weiterhin das Verbot Vorstände zu wählen
per elektronischen abstimmgeräten wenn
es nach der bundeswahlleiterin geht
jetzt kann man natürlich sagen was
schert uns das was die sagt das ist
parteiinterne Organisation aber in dem
Augenblick wo wir mit einem gewählten
Vorstand ein Wahlvorschlag einreichen
kann der natürlich dort an der Stelle
erst einmal vorläufig gekippt werden und
dieses Risiko wollen wir nicht eingehen
das heißt in der Partei werden momentan
bei Vorstandswahlen mutmaßlich keine
elektronischen abstimmgeräte mehr
eingesetzt und wir haben uns überlegt
wie wir an bestimmten einzelnen Punkten
die Wahlordnung so ändern können dass
das Verfahren zumindest etwas
beschleunigt wird und wir nicht komplett
alles in einzelnen Wahlgängen
beispielsweise machen müssen deshalb
haben wir deshalb beantragen wir die
sogenannte verbundene Einzelwahl zu
ermöglichen dass also mehrere Wahlgänge
zusammen durchgeführt werden das kann
man mit etwas Auslegung auch heute schon
machen gerade bei der Besetzung von etwa
Wahlkreisen bei Kommunalwahlen haben
auch ich das schon als
Versammlungsleiter häufig durchgeführt
das ging auch immer problemlos durch bei
der Prüfung der Wahlvorschläge und das
ganze ist aber sinnvollerweise zu
kodifizieren wir beantragen also in den
Paragraph 6 der Wahlordnung den im
Antragsbuch abgedruckten Absatz 2a neu
einzufügen so dass man immer wenn es
dort nur einen Bewerber gibt man
tatsächlich diese Position
zusammenführen kann sobald man
Kampfkandidaturen hat hört man damit auf
wir machen also nur die kleine Lösung
weil man auf diese Art und Weise schon
genügend Beschleunigung hinbekommen es
gibt ganz viele Wahlen bundesweit wo man
tatsächlich nur einen Bewerber einmal
und dann kann man diese Bewerber
tatsächlich diese Wahlgänge
zusammenfassen in einer verbundenen
Einzelwahl bitten um Zustimmung um
tatsächlich diese Partei arbeitsfähig zu
halten und um uns unnötigen Zeitverlust
auf Partei Tagen zu ersparen vielen Dank
war das hat hier für den
satzungsausschuss gesprochen für die
Aussprache zum Antrag wo 1 Herr Salz ja
vielen Dank
das seien wir erschließt sich aber nicht
welche Auswirkungen das bei
wahlkreisbewerbern haben wird wo wir ja
regelmäßig nur eine Position zu besetzen
haben diese Regelungen ist aber eine
Vorlage um Absprachen die getroffen
werden die wir aber eigentlich nicht
haben wollen dann auch in der Praxis zu
verwirklichen Beispiel es sollen drei
Stellvertreter im Bundesvorstand oder
vier Beisitzer gewählt werden mehrere
Gruppen haben sich abgesprochen bei der
normalen Vorgehensweise weiß man nicht
wenn die erste Position besetzt wird und
es heißt hier soll Gruppe A zum
zugekommen ob sich die anderen dann bei
den nachfolgenden Positionen daran
halten werden das ist gut so weil
dadurch scheitern dann viele Absprachen
doch noch nämlich an der Realität dass
sie nicht eingehalten werden nach diesem
Modell könnte sofort offengelegt werden
ob man sich an die Absprachen hält ob
die Leute nur dort Kandidaten ins Rennen
schicken was abgesprochen ist und dann
kann man das auch als vorher auf dem
Tisch liegt
umsetzen das ist ein Beitrag zur
oligarchisierung der Partei und wird von
mir definitiv abgelehnt danke
so Herr Nolte weil es nächster dran
genau ich muss sagen ich bin ein wenig
entsetzt dass es hier in unserer Partei
so was wir Absprachen geben soll kann
ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen
nein
also ich halte den Grundgedanken für
sinnvoll und bloß weil wir uns diese
Option in der Wahlordnung geben heißt es
ja nicht dass wir Sie auch bei jedem
Parteitag anwenden müssen ja deswegen
plädiere ich also dafür dass wir das
annehmen um uns zumindest die Option zu
eröffnen ob es dann die einzelnen
Landesverbände bei ihren einzelnen
Wahlen auch anwenden das ist der
Versammlung dann überlassen
Herr Flak ja zwei Punkte einmal zu dem
was Thomas Seitz gesagt hat dieses
Argument zieht ganz einfach nicht in dem
Augenblick wo es eine Absprache gibt wir
nehmen mal das Beispiel was genannt
wurde es gibt drei Lager diese drei
Lager schicken für drei Stellvertreter
jeweils einen Kandidaten ins Rennen ob
diese Wahlgänge mit jeweils einem
Kandidaten nacheinander stattfinden oder
gemeinsamen können trotzdem sich eine
Gruppe nicht an Absprachen halten der
einzige Unterschied ist der dass man in
einem anderen Fall vielleicht etwas
früher merkt oder nicht man kann darüber
hinaus und das schließt an das an was
erneute gerade gesagt hat man kann sehr
einfach dieses Verfahren stoppen und
zwar jedes einzelne Mitglied man muss
nur sagen ich kann die Tiere dort auch
sobald in einem Wahlgang zwei Kandidaten
sind wird dieser Wahlgang nicht mitten
eine verbundene Einzelwahl aufgenommen
gerade um dort nicht die Basis in
irgendeiner Form auszubauen nicht ich
kann in etwas reinzudrängen wo er nicht
drin sein möchte es geht dort rum um die
Wahlen wo man beispielsweise 25
Wahlkreise zu besetzen hat als Vorstand
der dich darum kümmert dort Kandidaten
zu finden froh ist 25 Kandidaten
gefunden zu haben jeden Wahlkreis
besetzt zu haben dass man dort das
problemlos verbinden kann oder aber auch
in anderen Stellen wo man mehrere
Positionen hat und nach viel Suchen eh
nur einen Kandidaten hat sobald es zwei
Kandidaten gibt wird das hier
automatisch rausgenommen der Wahlgang
und von daher bestehen diese Gefahren
nicht aber die Vorteile überwiegen ganz
ganz stark wir können viel Zeit sparen
wir können arbeitsfähig bleiben auch
ohne elektronische Stimmgeräte bitte
eindringlich um Zustimmung
wir setzen Sie die Debatte fort Herr
Krämer ja Christa Krämer KV Köln
bekanntermaßen liegt das in NRW wir
haben das auch bei uns in NRW wir haben
das auch sehr erfolgreich praktiziert
beispielsweise in Köln müssen wir sehr
sehr viele kommunaler Kandidaten
aufstellen weil die Stadtrecht groß ist
das hat überhaupt die Wahlversammlung
erst managebar gemacht im Sinne der Zeit
Ersparnis und der Effizienz wir wollen
ja auch das noch ein paar autonomalus
und nicht nur Funktionäre und abhängig
Beschäftigte oder Mandatsträger zu
unserem Partei Tagen kommen sollten wir
das hier auch in die Wahlordnung mit
reinnehmen das ist Effizienz der
Wettbewerb äh bleibt erhalten der hat
das gerade da gelegt deswegen kann ich
nur für diese Wahl für diesen
Änderungsvorschlag plädieren vielen Dank
muss ich mir jetzt noch
nicht ich versuche es gerade in den
Antrag richtig inhaltlich komplett zu
verstehen das heißt ich habe eine
Vorstandswahl beispielsweise in einem
Kreisverband und dort habe ich zwei
Kandidaten die sagen ich kandidiere als
stellvertretender Kreisvorsitzender
Kreisvorsitzender und auf allen anderen
Positionen kandidiert sonst nur eine
Person das heißt ich mache dann einen
Wahlgang vom Vorsitzenden bis zum
letzten Beisitzer und lasse nur den
ersten stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden
raus wo gegebenenfalls mit zwei der
besten Mitglieder im Kreisverband
kandidieren die ansonsten gegebenenfalls
irgendwo also bisher ist es ja so da
kandidieren zwei tolle Kandidaten als
erster kreisversitzender es kann nur
einer werden dann kandidiert der nächste
Teil der zweiter Kreisvorsitzender der
zweite stellvertretender
Kreisvorsitzender und das wäre dann
damit komplett ausgeben wenn ich das
richtig sehe oder
vielen Dank als nächstes Herr Flak nein
wird es nicht es gibt eine Reihenfolge
das steht auch im Text genauso drin eine
Reihenfolge der Position aufgerufen
werden und dieser Reihenfolge ändert
auch diese Antrag nicht wenn also auf
dem kreissparteitag üblicherweise erst
der Vorsitzende an der Stellvertreter
dann der Schatzmeister und dann noch 25
Beisitzer gewählt werden dann ist das
auch jetzt noch so und wenn es dann für
den Stellvertreter eben zwei gibt dann
hört halt die verbundenen Einzelfall
nach einer Position schon wieder auf und
für den Stellvertreter es gibt ganz
normale Einzelhandel aber wenn es nur
einen gibt und erst bei den be
isitzern die Daten oder beim
schätzenmeister dann hat man schon mal
mehrere Positionen
zusammenfassen können und spart sich
ausziehen Vorgänge also das Problem ist
berücksichtigt
vielen Dank ich sehe nicht dass es
weitere Wortmeldungen gibt ich schließe
also die Aussprache wir kommen zur
Abstimmung wer dem Antrag wo eins auf
Seite 10 des antragsbuches seine
Zustimmung erteilen möchte den bitte ich
um das Kartenzeichen
danke schön wer ist dagegen
danke schön dann ist der Antrag mit
einer Enthaltung
dann ist der Antrag mit einer sehr
deutlichen zwei drittelmehrheit
angenommen worden also das bedeutet dass
die AFD jetzt auch
einzelwahlen zusammenfassen kann
Stimmen waren 282 Stimmen Nein stimmen
waren 114 Stimmen das entspricht einer
Zustimmung von 71,2 Prozent damit ist
die erforderliche zweite Mehrheit
erreicht
das möchten wir natürlich noch einmal
hier nachtragen also das auch
Schiedsgerichte nun andere Regelungen
haben wann jemand dort im mitglied
werden kann nämlich auch wenn die Person
z.B für ein Mitglied des Europäischen
Parlaments arbeitet nun wollen wir aber
die Möglichkeit demnächst nutzen
natürlich auch noch mal auf das
Geschehen zu blicken
mit einem
Gesprächspartner wir sehen hier gleich
noch einmal die Delegierten
und hier macht dann Herr Basel weiter
ja vielen Dank
wir sind im Tagesordnungspunkt 11
angekommen und haben dazu
die Anträge in der Sache Antrag SN1 und
SN2 das sind die Anträge seit der 38 bzw
nun kommen wir dazu was ich eben schon
angekündigt habe wir haben nämlich ein
Gesprächspartner am
et ja liebe Zuschauer liebe Zuschauer
bei uns ist live Erik Holm
Bundestagsabgeordneter wir sprechen aber
gleich über etwas ganz anderes wir
hatten eigentlich auch Robert Sesselmann
den Landrat des Landkreises Sonnberg der
neulich die Wahl zum Land hat gewonnen
hat angefragt er hat uns gesagt er hätte
kein Interesse einen Interview er mein
Wahl Gewinner sie waren an Wahl
verlieren sie sind angetreten um den Obi
Oberbürgermeister Posten in Schwerin
haben verloren waren aber trotzdem in
diesem in diesem Wahlkampf aktiv im
Kommunalwahlkampf in Schwerin was
braucht es denn für eine gute
Kommunalpolitik nicht nur für die AFD
sondern überhaupt was ist da wichtig
ja also erstmal ist mir natürlich
wichtig dass wir die Wahl in Schwerin
nicht verloren haben in der roten
Verwaltung Stadt für Schwerin ein
Drittel stimmt zu holen das war schon
ein Ausrufezeichen und eine Woche später
hat der Robbe Robert zesselmann das dann
klar gemacht mit dem Landratsamt in
Thüringen wozu man nur herzlich
gratulieren kann ich glaube es ist
wirklich wichtig dass wir auf kommunaler
Ebene Weiterkommen dass wir dort auch in
Verantwortung gelangen wir sind jetzt in
der zweiten Dekade unsere Entwicklung
und wir müssen jetzt in
Regierungsverantwortung hineinwachsen
wir haben als Protestpartei begonnen wie
das bei vielen Parteien in die
Entwicklung so ist und dann muss man in
die Schuhe hereinwachsen in den
Parlamentarismus und das muss Natur
gegeben erstmal auf der kommunalen Ebene
passieren wir haben auch im nächsten
Jahr vor wegen dem Osten Kommunalwahlen
und die bereiten jetzt sehr akribisch
vor und deswegen sind solche
Ausrufezeichen
erstmal von dem anderen zu halten hat
und deswegen redet man ganz anders
miteinander und beispielsweise haben wir
auch in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern gemeinsam
mit anderen Fraktionen in der
Bürgerschaft in Stralsund einen Anti
genderantrag durchbekommen es passiert
überall in der Republik auf der kleinen
Ebene und das ist wichtig jetzt sagen
sie zurecht also Oberbürgermeister
Landrat das sind ja verwaltungsschefs
das eignet sich nicht für politische
zahlenschlachten nur wenn man jetzt die
Reaktion gehört hat hier auf dem
Parteitag wird das eigentlich als Sieg
der AFD als parteipolitische Sieg der
AFD bezeichnet den Bürgermeister in
Sachsen-Anhalt den Landrat in Thüringen
es kamen Herr krupala und ähm Herr höcke
und Herr Brandner zur Siegesfeier nach
Sonneberg in Thüringen das ist bei
anderen Parteien unvorstellbar das will
ich mehr oder Olaf Scholz bei einer
Landratswahl auftaucht das heißt die
Partei hat das sehr stark auf ihre
Partei politischen fahren geschrieben
also es geht nicht nur um
Kommunalpolitik
naja es ist das erste Mal dass wir an
solchen Erfolg hingelegt haben gegen
alle Widerstände die wir in diesem Land
erleben von allen anderen
kartellparteien und da ist es doch klar
dass wir natürlich froh sind dass dieser
Durchbruch das erste Mal geschafft ist
der Damm ist da gewissermaßen gebrochen
wir haben absolute Mehrheiten an Stimmen
generiert das ist das erste Mal dass wir
soweit gekommen sind das ist also ein
riesengroßer Erfolg für uns und das ist
natürlich wegweisend wenn wir weiter
gestalten wollen wir sehen uns ja in der
Aufstellung als Volkspartei und wenn wir
diese Aufstellung haben dann wollen wir
nach Mehrheiten irgendwann generieren in
dem Zusammenhang war es natürlich auch
interessant dass Herr Merzig so geäußert
hat wie er sich geäußert hat weil das
glaube ich wichtig ist und die Bürger
erwarten auch eine konstruktive
Zusammenarbeit führen sie denn die
Brandmauer in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern in
Schwerin ja es gibt die Brandmauer
natürlich auf den oberen Ebenen sage ich
mal sowohl im Landtag als auch im
Bundestag wobei hinter den Kulissen auch
vernünftige Gespräche geführt werden
gerade in der Union das ist ja zu spüren
dass viele mit dem Linkskurs der mit
Frau Merkel eingesetzt hat man sehr
viele unzufrieden sind aber es ist eine
sehr heterogene Gemengelage ganz
offensichtlich in der Union und der März
hätte meines Erachtens da als
Vorsitzender auch mehr Schmackes
reinlegen müssen und nicht nach einem
halben Tag umkippen müssen er muss die
Union konservativer positionieren sonst
bleibt er in der Geiselhaft der Linken
und der Grünen das ist glaube ich
gefährlich für die lohnen das ist das
Interview etwas abkürzen weil jetzt ein
ganz wichtiges Thema auf den Parteitag
besprochen wird live Erik Holm von der
afd-bundestagsfraktion danke dass sie da
waren
so und wir gehen sofort weiter zu
Katharina kühn vielen Dank hier hat
gerade die Debatte angefangen ob die
beitreten soll der Bundesvorstand
befürwortet das hat einen Antrag dazu
eingereicht es gibt aber auch einen
Antrag mit dem Titel keinen Beitritt zur
Idee Partei und für diese
die gegen Meinung also dass die AFD dem
eben nicht beitreten soll spricht jetzt
Roland hart ist
Verpflichtungen sind die
Veröffentlichung des Logos und des
Programms die idee-partei auf unserer
Webseite
dieses Programm entspricht in vollem
Umfang unsere Ausrichtung
es lehnt die Bildung eines
eu-superstaates vehement ab
betont die Souveränität der
Nationalstaaten und Völker
wendet sich gegen unkontrollierte
Zuwanderung
und will die Identität der Völker und
Nationen Europas bewahren
und schließlich
sollte in Zukunft wirklich irgendeines
der heute von manchen
befürchteten Gespenster vom Dachboden
herabsteigen und Wirklichkeit werden
dann können wir als AFD nach einem
entsprechenden
Parteitagsbeschluss auch jederzeit aus
dieser idee-partei wieder austreten
was aber spricht nun für einen Beitritt
im Vordergrund steht die weitere
Vernetzung mit unseren europäischen
Schwesterparteien
insbesondere mit solchen
die schon in ihren Ländern
Regierungsverantwortung übernommen haben
oder übernehmen werden
mit Ihnen wollen wir gemeinsame
Politiken entwickeln und im
Europaparlament und in den nationalen
Parlamenten umsetzen
gegen uns stehen gewaltige
Organisationen
fast unbegrenzte Finanz-
Haushalt zur Umsetzung ihres Programms
dass sich ihnen gerade auch schon
vorgestellt habe und zwar abhängig von
der Anzahl der Europaabgeordneten ihrer
mitgliedsparteien
warum bitte sollen wir diese
Möglichkeiten nicht für unsere
politischen Ziele nutzen
die einst neißel verage für seine
brexit-kampagne
und sollte die EU eines Tages
tatsächlich
transnationale Listen teilweise oder
sogar ausschließlich für die
Europawahlen einführen dann hätten wir
als Mitglied der id-partei zumindest
eine Teilnahme Option
und deshalb bitte der Bundesvorstand sie
dem Beitritt zur idee-partei zuzustimmen
vielen Dank
vielen Dank an Herrn Dr Hartwig für die
Begründung des Antrags SN1 für den
Bundesvorstand wie schon angekündigt am
Anfang zwar dagegen argumentiert aber
dann doch für den Bundesvorstand also
argumentiert die das die afd-fraktion
der Partei Identität und Demokratie
beitreten soll
meine Damen und Herren wir haben jetzt
viele Vorteile gehört für diesen Antrag
aber die muss man revidieren wir haben
heute viel vom Europa der Vaterländer
gehört das ist unsere Position die
wollen wir auch weiterhin nach außen
tragen ist uns aber dann bewusst dass
die Satzung die eigentlich gar keine
Satzung muss ein querverordnung unter
der Prämisse EU-Verordnung
204 und 2003 sich darunter unterwirft
das heißt wir anerkennen diese EU und
wollen sie das tatsächlich dass wir
unsere Glaubwürdigkeit als
exit-partei oder veränderungspartei der
EU verlieren wollen
wollen wir uns dem schlöten Mammon
unterwerfen wie damals in Erfurt wo uns
erzählt wurde eine Stiftung bekommt viel
Geld vom Bund bis heute sind keine
Gelder geflossen die Frage stellt sich
wollen wir wieder in die gleiche Falle
treten nur um diese Idee zu verfolgen
und dann frage ich die Antragstellerin
warum diese Satzung nicht hier
diskutiert wurde der id-partei sondern
sie wurde nur mehr oder weniger
hervorgehoben und warum hat die
idee-partei eine Woche vor diesen
Parteitag Ihre Homepage abgeschaltet
damit man die Ziele lesen kann und jeder
der hier über Ziele spricht kann die gar
nicht vorweisen es gibt nur eine
Antwerpener Resolution die ganz andere
Werte aufruft als die hier vorgeführten
deshalb meine Damen und Herren diese
idee-partei ist eine schlechte Idee und
muss auch nicht vollzogen werden wir
verlieren unsere Würdigkeit und die
Glaubwürdigkeit ist die einzige Position
die uns jetzt in den letzten Jahren nach
vorne gebracht hat nach vorne gebracht
auf die Position nämlich 22 Prozent zu
erreichen bundesweit und in jedem
Bundesländern geht es aufwärts und jetzt
stelle ich die Frage wollen wir uns
tatsächlich einem Zentralstaat wegen
einem stöden Mammuts unterwerfen ich
denke das sollten wir nicht tun die
Argumente gegen diese idee-partei sind
für die idee-partei sind keine tragenden
Argumente und sie gehören mehr oder
weniger
ins abseitigen nur eine Anmerkung diese
Entscheidung ist so weitragend dass ich
meine dass dort eine zwei Drittel
Mehrheit
bindend ist vielen Dank
Emil Sense war das Vorsitzender der AFD
in Baden-Württemberg und damit starten
jetzt mit der Aussprache der Delegierten
bitte sehr sicher Liebe
was haben wir gemeinsam für harte Kämpfe
gefochten in der Vergangenheit um eine
Alternative für Deutschland zu bleiben
Lucke wollte unsere Ideale verraten um
uns
koalitionsfähig zu machen Petri auch und
auch Meuthen und es waren harte Kämpfe
die wir gemeinsam gefochten haben weil
wir uns nicht an andere Parteien oder
Gruppierungen anbiedern wollen weil wir
wirklich für Souveränität Freiheit und
Demokratie einstehen und es da keine
Kompromisse und keine Anbiederung geben
darf
die anderen Parteien bestehen aus
Europäern und setzen sich für Europa ein
wir die AFD sind die einzige Partei die
von ihrem Selbstverständnis her sich aus
Deutschen besetzt und sich für
Deutschland einsetzt wir liebe Freunde
sind der Anwalt des deutschen Volkes
wir stehen für unsere Kinder unser Land
und unsere Mitbürger bedingungslos ein
wir stehen momentan bei über 20 Prozent
weil wir geradlinig sind und nicht
käuflich und jetzt sollen wir unseren
Markenkern aufgeben eine rein deutsche
Partei zu sein die kompromisslos für die
deutschen Eintritt wir sollen uns
verkaufen nur weil irgendwer in Brüssel
mit dem checkbuch winkt damit wir
demnächst ein paar Flyer mit einem Logo
der Idee die in Deutschland eh keiner
kennt verteilen können vielleicht noch
mit einer Widmung gesponsert durch die
EU liebe Freunde geht noch wir sind die
Alternative für Deutschland nicht die
Alternative für Europa treten wir eine
europäischen Partei bei und das weiß
jeder von euch der Partei Erfahrung hat
dann muss man Kompromisse an die anderen
Mitglieder in dieser Partei machen
die Mehrheit dominiert in Parteien immer
die Minderheit und jeder Kompromiss und
das muss ganz klar gesagt werden jeder
Kompromiss den wir dort machen ist ein
Verrat an den deutschen Wäldern
wir wollen die EU nicht und wir wollen
nicht unsere Seele führen paar Almosen
aus Brüssel verkaufen liebe Freunde
lasst uns die Alternative für
Deutschland bleiben der Anwalt des
deutschen Volkes und dazu passt auch
dass jeder Delegierte hier einen Button
gekriegt hat unser Land zuerst lasst
unser Land zuerst weiterhin unser Motto
sein vielen Dank
vielen Dank Martin aus Bayern aus dem
Landesverband Bayern hier mit einer Rede
gegen den Eintritt
bestellt wurde ist wir würden uns
verkaufen wenn wir eine europäischen
Partei beitreten einer europäischen
Partei ist zum Beispiel jemand wie ein
Arsch beigetreten man kann ihn glaube
ich vieles unterstellen aber man kann
ihn ganz bestimmt nicht unterstellen
dass sie sich an die EU verkauft hat
und es ist ehrlich gesagt auch ziemlich
unverschämt dass unseren Freunden
national oder von der FPÖ zu
unterstellen die immer
die immer das will ich mal betonen an
unserer Seite gestanden sind von Anfang
an als wir noch eine kleine unbedeutende
Splitterpartei waren bis heute und was
ist das für ein Zeichen dass wir heute
setzen dass wir sagen nein mit euch
wollen wir nicht zusammenarbeiten meine
Damen und das wäre unverantwortlich es
wäre dumm
und es wäre der größte gefallen den wir
unseren Gegnern und den Altparteien in
Deutschland und Europa machen können wir
brauchen starke Partner alleine können
wir Europa nicht verändern vielen
danke schön
bevor wir eine Debatte fortfahren
[Musik]
kein Antrag dann am roten salmikrofon
noch mal bitte sehr
meine Lieben Partei von ich kann den
Vorredner nur zustimmen wir sind nicht
alleine in Europa wir wollen ein Europa
der Vaterländer und darum müssen wir mit
den anderen Parteien in Europa
zusammenarbeiten ist das beste Beispiel
dafür dass der die Europäische Union die
Möglichkeiten dort genutzt hat um die
Souveränität seines Landes wieder
herzustellen und eine Sache die möchte
ich euch auch noch kurz erklären wir
haben hier in Deutschland den
schlimmsten Inlandsgeheimdienst
überhaupt den Verfassungsschutz und ihr
glaubt ja wohl nicht dass sie uns auch
noch irgendeiner Form verbieten können
wenn wir Mitglied in dieser europäischen
Partei sind dann haben wir sozusagen den
Schutz der anderen um Politik für dieses
Land zu machen zweiter Punkt ist ich
sage auch Nummer eins Perspektive ab 20
25 kommt der Bundeskanzler oder die
Bundeskanzlerin aus diesem Saal aus der
AFD da müssen wir auch zeigen dass wir
mit den anderen europäischen Ländern
zusammenarbeiten wollen das heißt nicht
dass wir im Gegensatz zu den Altparteien
und ausverkaufen wollen
wir werden den Zeiten das ist ein
anderes Deutschland gibt eine Europa
deutsche und Europa der gesicherten
Grenzen aber wir werden mit denen dann
zusammenarbeiten müssen auf Augenhöhe
nicht als wirklich nicht als aus
unintelligible für deutscher Interessen
aber wir brauchen diese Seriosität und
deswegen kann ich nur dafür appellieren
der Partei beizutreten vielen Dank
danke schön Herr Dr
Herr Dr Spaniel bitte ja vielen Dank für
das Wort wir haben nun einige Argumente
gehört die dafür sprechen dieser Partei
beizutreten und wir haben einige
Argumente gehört die dagegen sprechen
das ist eine für unsere Partei
weltanschaulich sehr wichtige
Entscheidung und in einer so wichtigen
Frage wie dieser ist unsere Partei und
das hat man hier an dem applausbild auch
denke ich ganz gut gehört doch nicht
einig zumindest nicht so einig wie sie
sein müsste um hier mit einer
geschlossenen Meinung einer Zeichen von
Stärke herauszugehen und ich möchte alle
bitten die dafür und dagegen geredet
haben Verständnis dafür zu haben wir
müssen uns heute und hier nicht
entscheiden zu diesem Thema und ich
bitte alle ich bitte alle doch hier in
dieser fundamental wichtigen Frage die
ich nicht mit der Brechstange auf diesem
Parteitag durch drücken wir kennen viele
Argumente pro und kontra nicht wir haben
die Möglichkeit diese Frage bis zu
Europawahl in unseren Gremien zu
diskutieren und ich spreche sicherlich
für die Mehrheit der Delegierten hier
dass alle Argumente drohen kontra den
aller wenigsten ich möchte fast
behaupten fast niemandem geläufig sind
teilweise kennt man die Argumente und
ich plädiere dafür und das ist jetzt
mein Antrag hier und heute salomonisch
mit nicht Befassung rauszugehen vielen
Dank ich stelle diesen Antrag auf nicht
Befassung
wirklich Spanien war das und wir sehen
dass diese Debatte erhitzt dann doch die
Gemüter es gibt noch viele Redner die
hier anstehen die sich noch zu dieser
Debatte äußern wollen ob die AFD eine
europäischen Partei Beitritt
mit den Anträgen SN1 und 2
liebe Freunde wir müssen uns mit diesem
Antrag befassen denn wir brauchen in
Europa starke Partner
[Applaus]
wir sind nicht mehr so klein
wir wollen keine randständige Partei
sein wir wollen in Europa Mehrheiten
haben gegen die etablierten Parteien die
sich Europa zur Beute gemacht haben
darum plädiere ich für Befassung und
Abstimmung bei diesen Antrag
vielen Dank wir haben damit die
Gegenrede gehört und kommen zur
Abstimmung des Antrags auf nicht
Befassung mit den Anträgen SN1 und 2 wer
ist dafür sich nicht mehr weiter mit
diesen Anträgen zu befassen
danke wer es dagegen und möchte darüber
weiterverhandeln
Dankeschön Enthaltungen danke das war
eine deutliche Mehrheit gegen die nicht
Befassung wir beraten weiter am roten
Saal Mikrofon geht's weiter ja vielen
Dank Stefan Kreuter kreisverwalt Essen
liebe Freunde ich Vertreter bei der
Parlamentarischen Versammlung der OSZE
unsere Bundestagsfraktion und wenn ich
dort tätig bin spüre ich regelmäßig dass
wir als afd-vertreter eines Skepsis
entgegenschlägt eine Skepsis weil viele
unserer europäischen Partner das
Bekenntnis zu der konservativen
Wertegemeinschaft der europäischen
Parteien der europäischen Partner
vermissen aber auch eine Skepsis weil
sie durch viele andere Vertreter gerade
der CDU gestört werden nach dem Motto
wenn ihr mit konservativen redet redet
mit uns lass die AFD außen vor das hat
schon zur Ausladung geführt das führt zu
Ausgrenzung und es ist eine
Sisyphusarbeit dafür einzutreten dass
wir als AFD als konservative Kraft ernst
genommen werden dieses Vertrauen was wir
uns hier bei der OSZE Organisation für
Sicherheit und Zusammenarbeit in Europa
aber auch im Europarat mit unserem
konservativen Partnern zusammen
erarbeiten das dürfen wir nicht
gleichwertig verspielen deshalb plädiere
ich dafür lasst uns hier ein klares
starkes Zeichen setzen wir geben unsere
Eigenständigkeit nicht auf dass wir mit
unseren konservativen Partnern in Europa
diese Europäische Union wieder von dem
Kopf auf die Füße stellen wollen
lasst uns Teil dieser europäischen
Konservativen Revolution sein und die
deutschen Beitrag dazu liefern und
nebenbei das letzte Schwert was diese
Regierung mit ihrem instrumentalisierten
Verfassungsschutz noch hat ist ein
Verbotsverfahren und wenn wir unter dem
Schutz stirbt unsere starken
europäischen Partner sind die häufig
schon die Mehrheiten in ihren Ländern
stellen und an Regierung beteiligt sind
dann wird das ein unmögliches Vorhaben
ich plädiere dafür lasst uns unter den
europäischen Schirm unserer
konservativen Partner schlüpfen und
lasst uns unseren konservativen Beitrag
leisten vielen Dank
vielen Dank nächster auf der Rednerliste
ist noch mal das rote Saal Mikrofon
hallo Martina
bösf DBW ich habe gerade gehört wir
schlüpfen unter den Schirm unserer
starken Partner wer unter einen Schirm
schlüpft ist der noch selbstständig
zweitens es ist doch einfach etwas sehr
wagemutig die Katze im Sack zu kaufen
wenn ich einen Vertrag mit jemanden
schließe dann habe ich die essential ja
negozi i davor ansonsten habe ich blind
zugestimmt das ist doch logisch und
natürlich wollen wir mit unseren
europäischen Partnern agieren aber dazu
unter werfe ich mich doch nicht im
Vorfeld das mache ich doch nur dann wenn
ich noch was zum Verhandeln habe und
deswegen würde ich dafür plädieren dass
wir diese Frage durchaus diskutieren
vielleicht auch später gar nicht
ablehnen oder hinten anstellen das wäre
Quatsch ganz alleine vorzugehen das ist
Harakiri aber doch bitte sauber und
solide und nicht mit einer Art Überfall
vielen Dank
vielen Dank zur Geschäftsordnung der
Kollege
also ich denke die Argumente sind
ausgetauscht unser Bundesvorstand hat
hier ein klares Statement abgegeben ich
glaube wir wollen auch mit einem Herbert
Kickl weiter zusammenarbeiten und auch
eine Bank die unter einen Schutzschirm
steht bleibt eigenständig der wird nur
geholfen wie es eben angedacht wurde
deswegen stelle ich den
Geschäftsordnungsantrag Ende der Debatte
und sofortige Abstimmung über den Antrag
Gegenrede Karsten
steht Antrag Aufschluss der debat
Gegenrede sind noch nicht alle Argumente
ausgetauscht aus meiner Sicht es gibt
viele hier in diesen Saal die in der in
diesem Beschluss dass wir dieser Idee
Partei beitreten sollen schon die
Grundlage dafür sehen dass wir unser
Parteiprogramm aufweichen und in unserem
Parteiprogramm zumindest in unserem
Wahlprogramm stand steht seit Dresden
dass wir aus dieser korrupten EU
austreten wollen und wenn wir jetzt
dieser Idee verteilt beitreten ist das
die Grundlage um diese Programmpunkt
aufzuweichen
weiter zu debattieren Kurve gekriegt
vielen Dank dann kommen wir zur
abstimmungsantrags Aufschluss der
Debatte zu den Anträgen ist eins und
zwei wäre es für Schluss der Debatte
jetzt sofort
wir sind alle wahnsinnig
danke wer ist gegenschluss der Debatte
danke Enthaltungen
dankeschön das war eine Mehrheit für
diesen Antrag die Debatte ist
geschlossen willkommen zur Abstimmung
des Antrages SN1 und im Falle dessen
Ablehnung des Antrages SN2 ich bitte den
Antrag SN1 einzublenden
damit auch für jeden klar ist wo
bewerben sind der Antrag des
Bundesvorstands dass die AFD der
europäischen Partei Identität und
Demokratie beitritt
Beitritt zur idee-partei seine
Zustimmung erteilen möchte den bitte
jetzt um die blaue Stimmkarte
danke wer ist gegen diesen Antrag
danke Enthaltungen danke schön wir
stellen fest das war eine deutliche
Mehrheit für den Antrag der Antrag ist
angenommen
damit tritt die
AFD eine europäischen Partei bei
und möchte damit also sich mit
europäischen Partnern zusammen tun um
gemeinsam für eine Sache zu kämpfen
natürlich ist dort eine gewisse Ironie
dabei bei dieser Partei die
zum Teilen die Europäische Union
abschaffen möchte
alle gewählten Mitglieder der
zielkommission sich hier vorne im
auszählbereich einzufinden um die
Wahlgänge dann jetzt hier schon
organisatorisch vorzubereiten die
zielkommission bitte zum auszählbereich
und dann jetzt beginnen wir mit der Wahl
des der Richter und Ersatzrichter zum
Bundes
[Musik]
so jetzt muss hier erst einmal ein wenig
organisiert werden die zielkommission
muss sie hier wieder einfinden denn es
steht die Wahl von Richtern und
ersatzrichtern des Bundes
Schiedsgerichtes an
da werden wir jetzt noch mal gleich auch
sehen wer sich hier vorstellt
denn die Debatte um den Eintritt der AFD
in die Idee war jetzt doch etwas
verkürzter als wahrscheinlich hier von
einigen vermutet eben weil es dann einen
Antrag aufschließt
Beendigung der Debatte gab
12 Wahl von Richtern und ersatzrichtern
des Bundes Schiedsgerichts weil
haben wir zuerst auf der Tagesordnung
den Tagesordnungspunkt 12a das ist der
Bericht des Bundes-
so noch einmal der Hinweis an die
Mitglieder der c-kommission diese können
sich auch wenn es bis zum ersten
Wahlgang noch ein paar Minuten dauert
bitte schon einmal hier vorne einfinden
damit dort auch Einweisungen an
Einweisung noch erfolgen kann Absprachen
getroffen werden können über den Ablauf
wird alle Mitglieder der zielkommission
in den auszählbereich und das Wort für
den Bericht des unterschiedsgerichts
erhält der Präsident gereon Bollmann
bitteschön vielen Dank Herr noch ganz
schnell vorweg mal es ist ja vorhin so
ein bisschen auch bis zu mir
durchgedrungen dass du eine gewisse
Überraschung da war dass ich hier als
Berichterstatter gegen ein Vorschlag des
Bundesvorstands rotiere
ich bin hier weder Freelancer noch
tanzen
kommen sofort dran weil ganz kurz
meine Damen und Herren
des bundesschützgerichts und da darf ich
erwarten wir dürfen alle erwarten dass
dafür Ruhe hier herrscht ja bitte lassen
Sie Ruhe einkehren Gespräche können Sie
nach draußen
können Sie nach draußen verlegen hier
bitte Ruhe Herr Bollmann ich kürze das
mal ab nur damit sie liebe Freunde damit
alle klar sind und nicht frieren ich bin
absprachefähig wenn Absprachen getroffen
werden halte ich die dieser Vorschlag
war nicht mit mir abgesprochen das zu
Erklärung mal schnell so also ich komme
dann satzungsgemäß das ist ja neu das
haben wir ein riesiger besprochen
zu der Aufgabe hier als Präsident
Stellung zu nehmen zu der Arbeit des
Gerichtes im letzten Jahr im Grunde
betrifft das nicht nur eingeschränkt
denn ich bin erst seit November letzten
Jahres Präsident aber ich kann natürlich
insoweit auch hier ausführen für das
gesamte Jahr seit dieser machen und
insofern ist für den ersten Part
eigentlich noch Herr Wissenbach
zuständig aber wie wir alle wissen hat
er ja die Partei verlassen
wir haben seinerzeit in Riesa vier
Richter gewählt neu gewählt in das
bundesheetsgericht Frau haarmächer meine
Wenigkeit Herrn Ulbrich und dr dittges
mit dieser Mannschaft sind wir dann
gestartet wir haben drei Kammern
gebildet in der ersten Kameras der
Kollege Brockmann dr dittges haben wir
reingenommen und zunächst einmal bin ich
auch in die erste Kammer gegangen weil
Herr Wissenbach noch Präsident war in
der zweiten Kammer war Herr Wallander
Herr Ulbrich Frau Dr Maser klinkemann
die war am Anfang noch aktiv und wie wir
alle wissen ab 7 Dezember letzten Jahres
war das nicht mehr möglich weil sie in
einer Nacht und Nebelaktion ich sag mal
salopp aus dem Verkehr gezogen wurde wir
wissen sie ist bis heute in Haft und
kann also nicht mitwirken in der dritten
Kammer dann der damalige Präsident
Wissenbach Herr Gall und Frau hächer wir
hatten auch eine
ersatzrichterliste aufgestellt nämlich
dr Stienen Herrn Golombeck und den
Rechtsanwalt vier Fuß
am 14 November bin ich dann zum
Präsidenten gewählt worden das hieße
automatisch mussten wir die Kammer
Zusammensetzung dann ändern das ist
alles nach unserer Geschäftsordnung
geschäftsordnungsgemäßig abgelaufen
erste Kammer braucht man dr dittges und
Herr Golombeck ist dann nachgerückt und
Herrn Ulbrich in die zweite Kammer Herr
Schreckenberger haben wir hier
reingeholt aus Bayern Frau mahlsack
Winkelmann die dann sagte ich eben
gerade drei Wochen später in haften
gehen musste in der dritten Kammer Herrn
Gall Bollmann meine Wenigkeit und
verheimliche die ersatzliste war dann
erschöpft das ist das große Problem
wir werden hier über die Probleme
bundesschütze Gerichte mit Richtern zu
besetzen auch noch sprechen jetzt wollen
wir aber die Gelegenheit nutzen für eine
politische Einordnung des bisher
geschehenden das macht natürlich
Alexander Keller
ja liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer
nicht nur Einordnung des bisher
geschehen sondern schon ein Ausblick auf
den morgigen Tag
geht es ja um die Nominierungsliste für
die Bundesliste der AFD zur Wahl zum
Europäischen Parlament im Mai des
nächsten Jahres und über diese Themen
Europa westliches Bündnis
Selbstverständnis der AFD zu diesem
westlichen Bündnis zur Westbindung der
Bundesrepublik würde das morgen wichtige
und möglicherweise auch kontroverse
Diskussionen geben und darüber wollen
wir jetzt schon mal sprechen mit
Professor Wolfgang Schröder ein Ausblick
auf den morgigen Tag geben
sie haben es vorhin schon im in den
letzten Interview mit ihnen gesagt diese
Partei prägt einerseits eine Amerika
Skeptizismus und auf der anderen Seite
eine russlandfreundlichkeit bleibt bei
dem ersten Begriff Amerika Skeptizismus
woher kommt der in der Partei die ja
auch durchaus westdeutsch geprägt ist
jedenfalls von der Herkunft der
Mitglieder die haben alle die
Nachkriegszeit erlebt die haben erlebt
wie Marshallplan und Einbindung des
westliche Bündnis ja unter anderem für
Freiheit und Wohlstand gesorgt haben und
jetzt wird die USA quasi pauschal zum
Belzebub gemacht woher kommt dieser
Wandel woher kommt diese
politische Transformation in den
Gedankengängen dieser Leute man kann
hier zwei zentrale Punkte benennen der
erste ist die USA Freundlichkeit die
waren natürlich in der deutschen Rechten
nie vorhanden weil sie die USA als die
Macht erlebt haben die den Faschismus
besiegt hat und in diesem Sinne war die
deutsche Rechte immer und das ist die
alte Rechte vor allen Dingen skeptisch
gegenüber den USA bis feindlich ablehnt
und jetzt kommt zweitens hinzu dass ich
das Projekt der neuen Rechten ja sehr
stark ideologisiert hat im Sinne des
Versuches die Macht über den Stammtisch
und in den Köpfen zu erreichen haben sie
eine eigene Idee von der Gesellschaft
diese Idee der Gesellschaft heißt sie
muss homogen sein sie muss sich
anwertene orientieren und sie muss eine
klare laund oder Perspektive haben da
sieht man die Entwicklung der
amerikanischen Zivilisation wenn man das
so will als ein Negativbild das mit
allen Mitteln vermieden werden muss für
das was die AFD selbst will die USA
trotzdem noch die den Wirtschaftsmacht
doch dieses melting-ports wie das da
heißt also das heißt quasi dass viele
Völker zusammenkommen das hat der USA ja
zumindest bisher eine sehr genutzt das
gilt aber hier als abschreckendes
Beispiel auf jeden Fall weil man sagt
diese Heterogenität ist ein Stück weit
komplex ist schwierig und neigt zum
Zerfall weil so kriegen wir keine
gemeinsame Idee von Gemeinschaft hin und
wenn wir eine gemeinsame Idee von
Gemeinschaft hinbekommen weil im Sinn
des Volkes dann ist das was die USA uns
vorlebt und vormacht genau das Gegenteil
von dem was wir wollen jetzt haben sie
gesprochen dass die deutsche Rechte die
Niederlage 1945 nie verbunden hat Schuld
ist unter anderem die USA Aussehen sich
allerdings auch Sieger macht und jetzt
kommt jetzt diesen Kuriosum selbst wenn
die Mehrheit hier in der AFD sicherlich
das als Niederlage sieht 8 mai 1945 sind
ja zwei wichtige Politiker Dino und
Alexander gauland zur Siegesfeier in die
russische Botschaft dieses Jahr gegangen
gelangen am 9 mai wird ja in Russland
gefeiert da haben in der AFD einige
gesagt man hätte vor den Vergewaltigern
gekniet das wären mongolenstürme gewesen
die 1945 über Deutschland hinweggefegt
sind diese Doppelbödigkeit diese
doppeltsügigkeit dieses ja quasi auf
verschiedenen Klavierspielen kriegt die
AFD da die Kurve hin also die AFD ist
von Anfang an wenn man so will eine
Kampfzone zwischen atlantikern und
Russland Freunden das hat man in der
Anfangsphase gesehen wo die AFD noch so
eine honoration Partei gewesen ist die
sehr neoliberale eingestellt war und da
war eigentlich die Gruppe um Lucke sehr
stark daran interessiert ein gutes
Verhältnis zu den USA als Grundlage für
die Entwicklung der AFD der AFD ins
Stammbuch zu schreiben und da hat
gauland sehr früh interveniert und er
hat interveniert mit dem Hinweis Leute
unsere Bastion ist der Osten und wenn
wir im Osten realisieren wollen dann
benötigen wir eine Russland freundliche
Diktion und deine amerikaskeptische und
das hat er
2013/14 in Auseinandersetzung mit dem
atlantikflügel durchgesetzt weil man das
damals wohl auch nicht so wichtig
geachtet und gesagt wir müssen es auch
Europa konzentrieren wir müssen es auf
den Kampf gegen den Euro konzentrieren
und das ist eher so ein Nebenschauplatz
der für die Identität der Partei gar
nicht so wichtig ist das hat sich
natürlich als ganz anders herausgestellt
wenn man die geopolitische Lage jetzt
sieht weil da muss man Farbe bekennen
muss klar sagen ist man für Russland
oder ist man im Sinne der aggressiven
Kriegsführung der Russen eben gegen
Russland in dieser Situation und da ist
die die AFD Anwalt der Interessen
derjenigen die sagen nein wir wollen es
uns mit Russland nicht verderben und
zwar auch aus der Perspektive hier
werden Sanktionen vollzogen diese
Sanktionen sind gegen das eigene Volk
gerichtet und da kommt wieder diese
Perspektive hier das Volk und doch die
globale Elite die irgendwas macht was
sie für richtige geachtet aber sie
schaut gar nicht was das eigentlich für
das Volk ist Alex
vier Jahren einen Antrag auf Austritt
der NATO hier bei einem afd-parteitag ja
abgeblockt hat oder abgeschmettert mit
dem Argument man muss fest im westlichen
Bündnis stehen um sich möglichst weit
nach Osten raus zu beugen der Satz ist
angeblich von Alfred drecker
stahlhelm-fraktion der früheren CDU das
heißt da hat gauland ja durchaus eben
auf diesen beiden Klaviaturen gespielt
auf jeden Fall und man kann auch hier
erkennen also der
Austritt aus der NATO ist nicht
unbedingt das Thema der AFD sondern das
Thema der AFD ist so eine Äquidistanz
auf der einen Seite in der jetzigen
machtpolitischen Situationen auf der
anderen Seite eine klare kulturelle
ideologische Ablehnung der USA und damit
versuchen sie deutlich zu machen wo sind
unsere Freunde wo sind unsere
Bündnispartner und das ganze wird dann
auch pragmatisch übersetzen und dann
sagt na ja Russland ist das
rohstoffreiche Land Russland war immer
schon für Deutschland in der Geschichte
wichtiger Partner und das eigentlich die
Rolle Deutschland jetzt hier ein
Interessensausgleich herzustellen und
das ist insbesondere auch auf die
Deutungen von gauland zurückzuführen der
hier maßgeblich gewirkt ist sie sagen
jetzt eine ideologisch kulturelle
Ablehnung der USA das sozusagen parallel
läuft zu einer ideologisch kulturellen
Nähe zu Russland erklärt das auch dass
hier bei der AFD bei vielen in der AFD
außer bei einigen Nebensätzen wo das
dann erwähnt wird auch ausgeblendet wird
das Putin Kriegsverbrechen in der
Ukraine begeht das wird ausgeblendet mit
der Perspektive dass man sagt das war
heute morgen in der Rede von propala
auch drin der Frieden von Minsk hat
eigentlich nur dazu gedient dass die USA
die Ukraine aufgerüstet haben ist doch
klar dass diese Aufrüstung bei den
Russen zu Angst zu defensiven Verhalten
führt was irgendwann in der Offensive
umschlägt und das ist natürlich eine
vollkommene Bekennung der ideologische
strategischen Verhaltensweise Russland
gegenüber der Ukraine weil diese
Verhaltensweise gegenüber der Ukraine
als gewissermaßen Kolonie als Land der
Russen ist ja nicht erst 2015 folgende
geboren worden sondern hat eine lange
Geschichte die man bei Putin selbst seit
den 90er Jahren zurückverfolgen kann und
ist ideologisch strategisch bestens auch
dokumentiert weil man ja sagen muss dass
vor Minz war ja schon die
völkerrechtswidrige Annektion
bliebig man ist jetzt eine Fortführung
der Frage die ich gerade schon gestellt
habe auch nicht nur mit kulturell
ideologischen Versatzstücken sondern
eben auch dass man sich das autoritäre
System von Putin auch als Vorbild nimmt
für eine mögliche staatliche
Umgestaltung hier ist das bei vielen
afd-anhängern und auch funktionieren in
den Köpfen naja jetzt kommen auch
innenpolitische Bilder wieder zum Tragen
wenn wir den Kongress danach auswerten
wer ist eigentlich der Hauptfeind dann
ist der Hauptfeind die Grüne Partei und
das dahinter stehende denken einer
geschlechterparität eines behutsam
Distanz mit der Natur mit einer anderen
Wirtschafts- und demokratieform und das
wird ein Stück weit auf Russland
übertragen und sagt also genau die haben
begriffen dass das die eigentlich große
Gefahr ist und höcke der Chefideologe
auf der politischen Seite hat ja in
seiner Rede im Herbst letzten Jahres
sehr deutlich gemacht dass der Kampf
eigentlich dem Regenbogen Imperium geht
das Regenbogen Imperium sind eben all
die Kräfte die zulassen das
Gleichberechtigung auf allen Ebenen
stattfindet diese aggressiven Attacken
auf die
frühere Angela Merkel war ja vielleicht
auch nicht nur ihrer Flüchtlingspolitik
z.B geschuldet sondern da war ja auch
ein auch an den Äußerungen die man zum
Teil von AFD Politikern gehört hat auch
sowas wie frauenfeindlichkeiten mit
dabei das Gehörte da mit dazu das heißt
man hat zwar irgendein Thema
angesprochen in Wirklichkeit aber etwas
ganz anderes gemeint also die
Frauenfeindlichkeit scheint mir
strukturell in dieser Partei zu sein der
Anteil der Frauen in der Partei liegt
bei 17 Prozent hier bei dem Kongress ist
eine Frau bisher aufgetreten und das war
Frau Weidel das heißt also das ist eine
Bühne für Männer eigentlich
wie ist es jetzt mit Europa das andere
wichtige Thema was ja morgen auf jeden
Fall eine Rolle spielt es geht ja um den
um die Listenaufstellung für die Wahl
zum Europäischen Parlament im nächsten
Jahr da steht ja immer noch drin eine
geordnete Auflösung der Europäischen
Union ist angeblich versehentlich drin
geblieben es gibt ja auch die Vermutung
dass es kein Zufall wann ist sie noch
nicht einig wo wird denn da die AFD
hingehen oder vielleicht auch sogar
hinten naja interessant war gerade die
Auseinandersetzung um den Antrag des
Bundesvorstandes zum Beitritt in die
europäische Partei Identität und
Demokratie der Bundesvorstand hat einen
Antrag vorgelegt wir sollten Mitglied in
dieser Partei werden und sie begründen
es mit zwei Argumenten erstens damit
dass man durch die Akkreditierung in
dieser Partei zusätzliche Fördermittel
der EU erhalten kann die die
Handlungsfähigkeit der Partei verbessert
zweitens mit dem Argument wir können
dann uns wesentlich besser vernetzen
gegen die EU und unseren Kampf diese
Abschaffung der EU so wie sie jetzt
existiert effektiver durchführen das ist
so eine sag mal pragmatisch
machtpolitische Linie wie man die eigene
Strategie befördern will der Gegenantrag
wer sagt ja das ist eigentlich nicht in
unserem Interesse weil wir bekämpfen ja
Europa und wenn wir uns jetzt in eine
europäische Partei einlassen dann sind
wir Teil dieser europäischen
Institutionen Ordnung und in dem wir
Teil der europäischen Institutionen
Ordnung werden geben wir unsere
Souveränität auf und tun das Gegenteil
von dem was wir hier die ganze Zeit
behaupten nämlich souverän sein zu
können
das heißt aber das vielleicht der erste
die erste Strategie die
erfolgversprechende ist oder als
Maulwürfe die aber ganz offen also
oberhalb der Grasnarbe sozusagen und
nicht im Untergrund marschieren in die
EU um sie von ihnen auszuholen und zu
zerstören ist ja eigentlich auch eine
Frage was ich sage warum engagiert man
sich in Europa wenn man Europa in dieser
Form eigentlich gar nicht mehr haben
will wenn man engagiert sich in Europa
weil Europa wesentlicher Rahmen für die
Ordnung der politischen Dinge ist
zweitens weil es Präsenz bedeutet und
immer wichtiger wird auch für die AFD
vor allen Dingen jetzt wo die
ideologischen Kämpfe etwas in den
Hintergrund getreten sind da sind Jobs
zu vergeben und in dem Maße in dem Jobs
zu vergeben sind gibt es auch eine
leichte Verschiebung von den
ideologischen kämpfen hin zu den Kämpfen
der beutegemeinschaften und die
funktionieren noch mal etwas anders
heute Gemeinschaft Stichwort in dem im
Bereich der konservativen rechtskonferen
tiefen Parteien in Europa Ungarn Polen
z.B die wollen ja die EU gar nicht
loswerden denn die sind ja an den
Fleischtöpfen der EU das Spiel in
Deutschland vielleicht weniger eine
Rolle das heißt da gibt es auch unter
den befreundeten Parteien auch in der
Parteienfamilie Identität und Demokratie
durchaus Anlass für zukünftige Konflikte
da gibt es deutlich unterschiedliche
Akzente das kann man auch in der
zurückliegenden Legislaturperiode des
Europaparlaments sehen dass die meisten
anderen rechtsextrem
rechtspopulistischen Parteien eigentlich
auf der Seite der Allianz gegen Russland
stehen diese antragslage hat die AFD
nicht bedient auf der Ebene des
Europaparlaments und sie haben auch in
anderen Fragen der Anerkennung der Union
eine Sonderstellung und die drückte sich
auch in dieser kleinen Kontroverse die
um diesen Antrag hier geführt wurde noch
einmal aus Sonderstellung hatte auch der
mögliche Spitzenkandidat der Partei
Maximilian kahl im Umgang mit der
französischen Präsidentschaftswahl er
hat ja nicht die
hat ja nicht die Marine pennen also die
bei ihm in der Parteienfamilie mit ist
oder bzw der Fraktion im Europäischen
Parlament unterstützt sondern deren
Gegner den noch radikaleren Eric simor
dafür ist er ja suspendiert worden
vorübergehend aus der Partei das heißt
die AFD kann sich eigentlich einreihen
wo sie will im Europäischen Parlament
wenn es ihr nicht passt in den
politischen also in Bezug auf
Deutschland dann schätze ich schon mal
aus und arbeitet auch gegen die eigenen
Leute so kann man das sehen also das
europäische Plenum wird eigentlich
relativ wohl und touristisch bedient da
gibt's keine klare Strategie es sei denn
man hat Möglichkeiten Ressourcen sich
anzueignen und das ist jetzt die Idee
des Bundesvorstandes zu sagen da stehen
Ressourcen zur Verfügung die können
unsere Handlungsfähigkeit verstärken und
in diesem Sinne sollten wir das machen
das kommt im Prinzip immer auf dieses
Konzept heraus dass man sagt das ist der
versucht die Mittel der vorhandenen
demokratischen Strukturen zu nutzen um
diese demokratischen Strukturen zu
unterminieren und sie enorm unter Druck
zu setzen damit man auch durchaus
streichistisches Verhalten im
Europäischen Parlament in Kauf wenn man
dieses Doppelspiel treiben kann das kann
man also tagtäglich sehen soweit
Professor Wolfgang Schröder bis hierhin
das Gespräch liebe Zuschauer liebe
Zuschauer es geht hier weiter es geht
hier weiter wahrscheinlich so bis 18 18
Uhr 30 ich glaube die AFD ist im Moment
ziemlich im Zeitplan dafür gibt es
natürlich ein triftigen Grund heute
Abend um 19 Uhr feiert man hier das 10
jahresjubiläum da gibt's ja jetzt aus
Sicht der AFD auch einiges zu feiern
wir Volken der Diskussion hier in der
Messehalle in Magdeburg alles weitere
von Katharina kühn
und hier steht gerade eine Abstimmung an
denn es gab einen Antrag auf Änderung
wie jetzt die Schiedsrichter gewählte
werden wir erinnern uns vor einiger Zeit
haben hier die Delegierten dafür
gestimmt dass es keinen
Ausschlusskriterium mehr ist für ein
Kandidaten des bundesschichtsgerichts
oder eines anderen Schiedsgerichts der
Partei wenn er oder sie z.B für ein
EU-Abgeordneten arbeitet und nun gab es
aber den Änderungsantrag dass in diesem
Fall bei dieser Wahl das noch einmal
abgefragt wird also es ist kein
Ausschlusskriterium mehr aber es gibt
hier Delegierte die möchten ganz gern
trotzdem wissen ob ich hier jemand
finanziell bezahlt
wird von zum Beispiel ein Mandatsträger
zum Beispiel des Bundestags und da
konnte hier die Sitzungsleitung nicht
ganz klar feststellen wie die
Mehrheitsverhältnisse sind deswegen
stimmen jetzt die Abgeordneten
elektronisch noch einmal darüber ab
allerdings sehen wir es haben noch nicht
einmal 300 Delegierte abgestimmt von
daher
warten wir noch ein bisschen
bis ich hier alle entweder für eins oder
Nein gestimmt haben oder auch drei ja
nein oder Enthaltung nämlich ob es eine
pflichtabfrage gibt
[Musik]
und jetzt sehen wir auch das Ergebnis
also es ist kein Ausschlusskriterium
mehr aber die Delegierten möchten ist
trotzdem wissen wenn hier Kandidaten für
das
Bundesgericht sich vorstellen ob der
Kandidat oder die Kandidaten
für einen Mandatsträger arbeiten oder
gearbeitet haben
Abstimmungen sind bitteschön vielen Dank
ich hätte nur eine kurze Nachfrage sie
sagt neben zum Wahlverfahren dass wir
die Richterinnen und Richter schriftlich
wählen meine Frage wäre gibt es eine
Vorgabe von der bundesweite darin oder
können wir auch die Richterinnen und
Richter übers elektronische wählen das
würde uns ja sehr viel Zeit sparen
können Sie das vielleicht noch mal
erläutern vielen Dank
ja eine sehr gute Frage darf ich sagen
also in der Tat sieht
die bundeswahlleiterin bei quasi allem
was in der parteilich so abzustimmen ist
diese elektronischen abstimmen Geräte
kritisch und würde gerne alles
schriftlich haben ich darf an dieser
Stelle auch einmal sagen dass wir das
auch ich glaube in der Partei kann man
das in Gänze sagen für ganz großen
Kokolores halten aber bei den
ein bisschen die Macht des Faktischen
dass wir als Partei wo wir
Wahlvorschläge einreichen natürlich
uns vorsorglich daran halten und deshalb
vorstellen und so weiter aktuell nicht
mit den elektronischen abstimmen Geräten
wählen für die Richter und erst recht
für die Ersatzrichter sehen wir als
Präsidium und das ist auch hier im
Vorfeld einmal kurz mit dem Vorstand
gesprochen worden dieses Risiko als
überschaubar und vertretbar an
gleichwohl auch um ein Probelauf zu
haben für morgen empfehlen wir Ihnen die
Richter die vier zu wählen sind einmal
schriftlich zu machen das ist ein
überschaubarer Aufwand und die
Ersatzrichter dann elektronisch soweit
wie wir heute kommen ich glaube damit
ist auch zeitlich in vernünftiger
Kompromiss gefunden also unsere unsere
Rechtsauffassung ist man könnte alles
elektronisch machen die Wahlleiterin mag
das anders sehen aber die hat keine
unmittelbare juristiktion über unsere
Parteien
gut dann
kommen wir zum
so dann will ich keine weiteren
Wortmeldung oder Anträge dann kommen wir
zur Abstimmung
Antrag lautet vier Schiedsrichter werden
gewählt schriftlich 9 Ersatzrichter bis
zu dann elektronisch vier Minuten
vorstellungszeit zwei Fragen 30 Sekunden
Fragezeichen 60 Sekunden Antwort Zeit
vorstellungsreihenfolge und
Fragensteller werden ausgelost und wir
werden Nachfragen von Amts wegen ob
die Befähigung zum Richteramt besteht
also der Bewerber Volljurist ist
außerdem aus welchem Landesverband er
kommt weiterhin wie eben gerade von
ihnen beschlossen werden wir fragen ob
bisher eine Unvereinbarkeit nach
§ 3 Absatz 2 Nummer 2 der
schiffsrechtsordnung Alter Fassung
bestand
wenn Sie diesen Verfahrensantrag im so
zustimmen möchten dann bitte ich sie
jetzt um die blaue Stimmkarte
danke schön wäre das nicht möchte bitte
die rote Stimmkarte
ein paar Enthaltungen und eine Reihe von
Enthaltungen dann ist das mit großer
Mehrheit so angenommen
gewählt werden übrigens wurde vorher
auch schon angemerkt dass maximal drei
Richter aus einem Landesverband kommen
dürfen also hier auch ein
regionalproports gebaut werden soll es
gibt schon zwei Rechte aus
Sachsen-Anhalt und hier einen aus
Niedersachsen Schleswig-Holstein und
Bayern
für alle richterposition beschließen
möchten
Karte danke schön Gegenstände mit der
roten Stimmkarte
sehe ich spontan keine und auch nicht
spontan Enthaltungen
einzelne Enthaltungen dann ist das
einstimmig bei wenigen Enthaltungen so
beschlossen wir kommen dann zum ersten
Schiedsrichter den wir heute
wählen Vorschläge machen Sie bitte an
den salmikrofonen
oder auch hier oben am Mikrofon geht
auch nach unserer Geschäftsordnung ganz
wie Sie mögen gesucht wird ein
Schiedsrichter Herr Reusch mit dem
ersten Vorschlag ich schlage Christian
wird vor
Christian wird ist vorgeschlagen
gibt es weitere Vorschläge für den erst
heute erst zu wählenden Schiedsrichter
das sehe ich nicht dann bitte ich Sie
mir die Schließung der
Kandidatenliste mit der blauen
Stimmkarte zu bestätigen dafür die
schließen können
Gegenstimmen
Enthaltung das ist die Kandidatenliste
geschlossen wir haben einen Kandidaten
das ist Christian wird Herr wird möge
sich bitte einmal an einem der Mikrofon
erklären ob er zur Kandidatur bereit
steht
steht bereit dann kommen sie nach vorne
sie haben dann die Gelegenheit zur
Vorstellung wird ist Landesvorsitzender
der AFD im Saarland und Mitglied des
Deutschen Bundestags er sitzt dort im
Ausschuss für Inneres und Heimat
dort können Sie
während der vorstellungszeit und auch
noch kurz danach
Fragen einwerfen wir werden immer einmal
prüfen denn
ein prüfenden Blick werfen ob noch
jemand zuordnen unterwegs ist dort dann
bitte Ihre Mitgliedskarte oder falls es
dort ein Problem gibt eine andere Karte
im Scheckkartenformat einwerfen die ohne
steht am antragstisch
[Musik]
Herr wird ist fast da
so dann herzlich willkommen guten Tag
Herr Wirth an sie dann zuerst die drei
Fragen die wir zu stellen haben zum
einen in welchem Landesverband gehören
sie an Saarland den Saarland
verfügen sie über die Befähigung zum
Richteramt jawoll und bestand eine
Unvereinbarkeit und würde ein
Unvereinbarkeit bestehen mit dem alten
Paragraph drei Absatz zwei Nummer zwei
der schiedsrechtsordnung nein
so und eine Sache müssen wir glaube ich
noch einmal nachholen einen Augenblick
bitte
so einen Augenblick bitte noch
[Musik]
das heißt
darf man
hier kommt es ein bisschen zu
Verzögerungen das gibt mir natürlich die
Möglichkeit Ihnen schon etwas zu
erzählen
zu Christian wird denn er war schon
einmal Präsident des AFD
landesschichtsgerichts im Saarland ist
wäre also keine komplett neue Aufgabe
für ihn zumindest auf Landesebene hat er
dort Erfahrung
er ist auch
Jurist und das wurde ja vorher auch
schon gesagt in jeder Kamera darf es
nämlich maximal einen nicht Volljuristen
geben das geht zwar nicht für die
Ersatzrichter aber für die
Richter die sich jetzt bewerben
[Musik]
sie zwei der Bundessatzung sagt das
Absatz 14 Satz 2 entsprechend geht und
der lautet das
vorschlagsberechtigt fünf
Stimmen berechtigte
Versammlungsteilnehmer sind das heißt
wir benötigen fünf
stimmberechtigte Versammlungsteilnehmer
die die Kandidatur von Christian wird
unterstützen die haben wir problemlos
bei Samen vielen Dank
geklärt werden und nun kann es zur
Vorstellung gehen vier Minuten hat
Christian würtze sich vorzustellen
bitteschön ja vielen Dank die werde ich
nicht brauchen schönen guten Tag liebe
Parteifreunde mein Name ist Christian
Wirth ich bin Rechtsanwalt und sitze
seit 2017 mit meinen tollen Kollegen in
der Bundestagsfraktion und Binnen dort
im Innenausschuss und macht zum Beispiel
auch Verfassungsrecht und Grundrechte
und ähnliche Sachen
ich war ich habe auch eine gewisse
Vorbildung ich war von 2015 bis 2017
Präsident des Schiedsgerichtes im
Saarland von 2017 bis 2019 war ich im
unterschiedsgericht schon mal zuletzt
als Vorsitzender der erste Kamera ich
bin damals 2017 angetreten und habe ein
Dezernat mit 90 Altfällen geerbt habe
die alle abgearbeitet neben den
einkommenden Verfahren und bin mit einer
Handvoll laufender Verfahren damals
wegen Zeitablaufs ausgeschieden wir
müssen alle ein erfolgspartei wie wir
sind wir brauchen eine funktionierende
Schiedsgerichtsbarkeit das ist nicht
unbedingt das Amt das am angenehmsten
ist in einer Partei auch nicht das mit
dem man sich mal Freunde macht und mit
Sicherheit keines wo man sich ausruhen
sollte aber nicht der Pflicht nur zu
genüge aus diesem Grunde trete ich heute
hier abermals an ich bin willig und
bereit zu arbeiten vielen Dank
ja vielen Dank dann
schaue ich einmal ob es schon Fragen
gibt die eingeworfen wurde in die Urne
so bislang keine Frage noch jemand
unterwegs der eine Frage stellen möchte
dass kann ich
nicht erkennen dann ist der Kandidaten
mit dank entlassen und wir treten in
Kürze in einen Wahlgang ein für den dann
die Türen geschlossen werden das heißt
wir schließen in 90 Sekunden die Türen
90 Sekunden ab jetzt werden die Türen
geschlossen die zielkommission nimmt
schon einmal Aufstellung nehmen Sie
bitte schon mal ihre Plätze ein
die Vorbereitung für den Wahlgang sie
bekommen gleich einen Stimmzettel
ausgehändigt auf diesen Stimmzettel
steht der Name des Kandidaten Dr
Christian Wirth weiterhin steht dort die
Möglichkeit mit Nein gegen den
Kandidaten zu rotieren oder sich der
Stimme zu enthalten sie haben nur eine
Stimme das heißt beim
einzelfallverfahren in diesem Fall ein
Kreuz für den Kandidaten gegen den
Kandidaten oder für sich zu halten
so noch 30 Sekunden bis die Türen
geschlossen werden wer noch mitstimmen
möchte möge bitte reinkommen noch 30
Sekunden
so letzte Gelegenheit in den Saal zu
kommen die Türen werden sogleich
geschlossen wenn die wir jetzt noch rein
huscht kann dies noch und dann bitte die
Türen schließen Ausgang kann schon mal
geschlossen werden unter Eingang dann
bitte auch und dann bitte kurzes kurze
Rückmeldung
so bitte die Türen schon mal schließen
Wahlgang beginnt in Kürze Türen bitte
schließen
hier ist jetzt eindeutig Ruhe eingekehrt
wobei zumindest von meinem Platz hier
keine Tür geschlossen wurde um hier
sehr Aufforderung der Sitzungsleitung
nachzukommen erst dann beginnt der
Wahlgang wenn die Türen geschlossen
wurden so wird es angesagt allerdings
wie gesagt hier stehen zumindest noch
bei der Pressetribüne die Türen offen
ein Schiedsgericht ist keine
vergnügungsidee der AFD sondern laut
Parteiengesetz sind die Parteien dazu
verpflichtet Schiedsgerichte einzusetzen
zu bilden die Mitglieder dürfen für
höchstens vier Jahre gewählt werden und
auch das steht im Parteiengesetz sie
dürfen nicht Mitglied des Vorstands der
Partei sein weil dann eben geflüchtet
wird dass die Unabhängigkeit da
eingeschränkt sein könnte
die Richter sind unabhängig und nicht
Anweisungen gebunden auch so gesagt ist
das Parteiengesetz
so da war noch kurz etwas abzuklären
aber es gibt dann schon mal als kleinen
Teaser morgen eine kleine Überraschung
für sie was das andere betrifft
ansonsten die Türen sind geschlossen
die Tür dort hinten geschlossen Türen
bitte jetzt schließen
Tür bitte schließen und uns eine
Rückmeldung geben
Julian flacke wartet dass hier noch die
Türen geschlossen werden von meiner
Position aus kann ich aber nicht sehen
dass dem jemand nachkommt welche steht
auch niemand an den Türen der sich
schließen könnte das verzögert natürlich
hier den Wahlgang
bis hier
die Delegierten darüber abstimmen können
ob Christian wird
in das bundesheetsgericht gewählt wird
oder nicht ansonsten scheint mir aber
die
AFD sehr pünktlich in ihrem
Zeitplan voranzukommen auch das ist
alles andere als
selbstverständlich
dass
mitunter dann doch die Delegierten sehr
viel länger auf einem Parteitag aus
Haaren müssen weil es eben erhöhten
Redebedarf gibt oder
es zu Verzögerungen kommt
und auch Wahlkabinen aufgestellt die
können Sie dann aufsuchen immer nur mit
dem Saal bewegen wenn hier oben eine
blaue Folie eingeblendet ist wenn eine
rote Folie eingeblendet ist dann nicht
mehr und dann werden die Stimmzettel
nachher wieder am Platz eingesammelt
und ich schätze aufgrund der
klimatischen Bedingungen hier im Raum
will man hier die Türen nicht schließen
jetzt wurde hier ein Absperrband vor der
vor der Tür aufgebaut so dass eine
kleine physische Barriere da ist es ist
ziemlich warm hier in der Messe
Magdeburg deswegen wollte man diesen
Luftzug wohl jetzt nicht auch noch in
keinem ersticken
mit der Nummer 1
sobald die Stimmzettel ausgeteilt sind
haben Sie die Möglichkeit Wahlkabinen
aufzusuchen
dann können wir jetzt
so dann bitte die rote Folie einblenden
bitte bleiben Sie jetzt an ihrem Platz
wenn sie nicht zur zielkommission oder
sonstigen funktionspersonal gehören
bitte einmal die rote Folie weil dann
läuft bleiben wir an ihrem Platz und
dann kamen die Austeilung der
Stimmzettel beginnen zeigen Sie dazu
bitte ihr blaues Delegierten Armband
geht los
so nun werden also hier die Stimmzettel
ausgeteilt für die Wahl eines
bundesschiffsrichters die
Schiedsgerichte in den Parteien habe
beschäftigen sich ja unter anderem mit
parteiausschlüssen das ist natürlich
besonders in der AFD ein Thema oder war
in der AFD auch immer wieder Thema ob
eben solche rauswürfe
rechtens waren oder nicht in der
Vergangenheit gab es da immer wieder
Debatten da drüber
[Musik]
da diese Wahl nun etwas dauert schauen
wir noch einmal auf auch noch
anstehenden Debatten die heute hier auch
noch Thema sein werden es gibt ja auch
noch Debatten und Änderungen an der
Bundessatzung oder am schieds an der
Schiedsgerichtsordnung ich hatte schon
erwähnt dass es unter anderem mehrere
Änderungsanträge zu den
Mitgliedsbeiträgen gibt weil man da z.B
die Aufnahme eines neuen Mitgliedes
davon abhängig machen möchte ob dieses
Mitglied auch schon die Beiträge gezahlt
hat und nicht wie jetzt das der Antrag
alleine dazu führt dass ein Mitglied
aufgenommen wird sondern da wird dann
auch darauf
achtet ob dort auch die finanzielle
Hinwendung zur AFD vorhanden ist und ein
anderer Antrag der von fünf Delegierten
eingereicht wurde beschäftigt sich zum
Beispiel mit
parteiausschlüssen von
Mandatsträgern wenn diese aus der
Fraktion
aus einer Fraktion ausgetreten sind und
aber ihr Mandat mitnehmen also zum
Beispiel ein
Bundestagsabgeordneter der aus der
Fraktion oder aus der Gruppe vom
Europaparlament austritt dann möchten
die
antragsstelle dass dies aufgrund des
starken Verlustes an Glaubwürdigkeit die
da der dadurch entstanden ist und auch
aufgrund des Schadens an der Partei den
die Antragsteller sehen dass dann dieses
Mitglied sofort aus der Partei
ausgeschlossen wird
[Musik]
gab es nämlich diesen Fall dass zum
Beispiel einen Mitglied gesagt hat
sie bleibt das Mitglied bleibt Teil der
afd-partei aber nicht unbedingt der
Fraktion oder auch in Baden-Württemberg
kam es jetzt zu diesem Fall dass ich
eine zweite Fraktion zusammengeschlossen
hat auch ähm unter dem Logo der AFD und
ist dann praktisch zwei afd-fraktionen
gab und das möchte man nun künftig
verhindern
mit diesem Antrag der wird wie gesagt
hier am Nachmittag beraten
eröffnet 15 Uhr bitte knicken Sie den
Wahlzettel einmal
[Musik]
und zeigen sie auch beim Einsammeln
wieder ihr Delegierten Armband vor
der stimmeinwurf muss persönlich
erfolgen
[Musik]
und natürlich wählt auch das
sitzungspräsidium es wurde ja vorher
schon debattiert dass diese Wahl
schriftlich vonstatten gehen muss also
nicht elektronisch was es ja hier auch
vorgeschlagen wurde dass man etwas Zeit
sparen könnte diese Wahl elektronisch
durchzuführen
das geht aber aufgrund von Bestimmungen
der bundeswahlleiterin nicht deswegen
helfen und hier die Wahlhelfer bei der
Abstimmung bei der Wahl eines rundes
Schiedsrichters hier aus der
afd-fraktion ich habe schon gesagt im
Zeitplan ist die AFD momentan sehr
pünktlich das musste sie auch sie hat ja
viel vor an diesem Wochenende morgen
beginnt dann die Europa Versammlung der
wird wahrscheinlich der Tagesordnung die
Tagesordnung so geändert dass sie erst
über kann die Daten
abgestimmt wird und erst danach über das
Programm
das würde bedeuten dass an diesem
Wochenende wahrscheinlich nur über
Kandidaten gesprochen wird eventuell
sogar auch noch nächstes Wochenende die
Kandidaten im Mittelpunkt stehen und das
Programm dann erst auf einem
Sonderparteitag beschlossen wird aber
eventuell klappt es auch dass
über das Programm Ende nächster Woche
debattiert diskutiert und dann
abgestimmt wird die Wahlhelfer verlassen
hier schon den Saal mit den Urnen das
ist man kann die Auszählung beginnen
und ich darf darauf hinweisen dass die
Auszählung versammlungsöffentlich ist
sie dürfen also zuschauen aber nicht
stören
während die Auszählung läuft rufe ich
bereits auf den nächsten
Schiedsrichter schiedsrichterposition
der heute zweit zu wählen der
Schiedsrichter ich bitte um Vorschläge
an den Mikrofonen
Vorschlag für den Nächsten zu wählenden
Schiedsrichter
so dann haben wir einen Vorschlag am
Roten salmikrofon
aus Berlin ich möchte Tobias Gall
vorschlagen Tobias Gall ist
vorgeschlagen wird die davorschlag von
mindestens fünf stimmberechtigten
Personen mitgestellt bitte einmal
Handzeichen wer ebenfalls für Herrn Gall
eins zwei drei vier fünf sechs sieben
jawohl dann haben wir auch dort das
Forum erfüllt
fünf Versammlungsteilnehmer sind mit
dafür wir haben einen Antrag zur
Geschäftsordnung da bin ich gespannt ja
schönen guten
tagstraße Rheinland-Pfalz wir haben ja
vorhin gerade beschlossen dass die
verbundene Einzelwahl möglich sein soll
wenn man jetzt sieht wie lange ist
jeweilige Wahl von hier dauert würde ich
den Antrag stellen dass wir für die
restlichen drei Schiedsrichter das
Wahlverfahren noch mal bitte ändern auf
verbundene einzelwahlen weil so wie es
aussieht scheint es keine
Gegenkandidaten zu geben und wir könnten
entsprechend Zeit sparen vielen Dank
einen Augenblick
einen Augenblick wir kommen da gleich
zur Aussprache müssen einmal einmal kurz
etwas dazu klären
[Musik]
und hier verzögert es sich weiter das
gibt uns Gelegenheit zum nächsten
Vorschlag ihnen etwas
anzureichen Tobias geil ist aus dem
Bezirksverband Charlottenburg
Wilmersdorf
und jetzt geht es hier weiter mit einmal
Ruhe einkehren lassen
[Musik]
wir würden nämlich gerne fortfahren
also beantragt ist dass eben
beschlossene Verfahren der verbundenen
Einzelwahl hier zu verwenden das handelt
sich aber um eine Zusatz
Möglichkeit wenn die Einzelwahl
beschlossen ist wie es hier der Fall ist
da ist es ja soweit das Verfahren der
einzige was Anwendung kommt tut's hier
können mehrere Positionen nach Beschluss
der Versammlung in einem Wahlgang
verbunden werden verbunden Einzel war
das müssten also gar nicht alle sein
die Positionen werden Reihe nach
aufgerufen und so weiter das wäre also
zulässig dazu öffentlich die Aussprache
am roten salmikrofon
soweit ich mich erinnere war die
Kandidatenliste noch nicht geschlossen
ne nein noch nicht dann würde ich hier
ein kandidatenvorschlagen machen ich
schlage vor den ehemaligen Vorsitzenden
Richter des landesschichtsgericht
Hohmann
so damit wäre die verbundene Einzelwahl
für diesen Wahlgang wenn er denn wenn es
denn entsprechend
gleich Zustimmung dazu gäbe bzw genügend
Antragsteller
diesen genügend Delegierte diesen
Vorschlag unterstützen dann könnten wir
die Einzelfall für diesen Wahlgang
sowieso nicht durchführen aber die Frage
ist beantragt ist die Richter Wahlen so
habe ich einen Schatten
in verbundener Einzelwahl durchzuführen
auch die und die Ersatzrichter auch oder
die separat weil für die die
elektronische Abstimmung beschlossen
hatten
diese parat also die Schiedsrichter
waren und ich würde es mal gerade ja die
schiedsrichterwahlen in verbundene
Einzelwahl die Einzelhandel beschlossen
haben hier zu verbinden ist beantragen
bitte schön am roten Seil Mikrofon also
so sympathisch mir der Vorschlag ist
wegen der Zeitersparnis aber ich halte
das für äußerst problematisch da wir
bereits in Einzelwahl ein Richter
gewählt haben ich glaube nicht dass wir
mitten im Verfahren des Wahlverfahren
ändern können
also wir würden das Verfahren insoweit
nicht ändern als das Verfahren die
Einzelwahl ist und der ab neu eingefügte
Absatz 2a der Wahlordnung nur sagt so
weit das Verfahren der einzige was
Anwendung kommt können mehrere
Positionen verbunden werden also
Verfahren als solches würde nicht
geändert werden schlage aber vor kommen
sofort an komm sofort auch dran Schlag
aber vor das war einmal prüfen ob denn
für Herrn Hohmann entsprechend der
Kandidaten Kandidatur Unterstützungen
vorliegen weil wenn das der Fall ist
dann können wir zumindest die nächste
Position sowieso nicht in der
verbundenen Einzelwahl wählen weil es
mehr als ein Kandidaten gäbe das frage
ich erst vorgeschlagen ist Gerald
Thomann aus Schleswig-Holstein wird
dieser Vorschlag von mindestens fünf
vier weiteren Delegierten unterstützt
eins zwei drei vier fünf sechs sieben
Jahre das sind ausreichend das heißt wir
haben für diesen Wagen sowieso zwei das
heißt der Antrag von den Partner würde
sich dann noch beziehen können auf die
Positionen drei und vier
galt sie zurück okay Herr galt sie
zurück für diesen Wagen wobei wir ein
Homer noch gar nicht gefragt haben ob
überhaupt zur Verfügung steht
aber wir führen die Debatte einmal kurz
fort bitteschön am blauen da Mikrofon
und werden das gleich entwirren ja
Görlitz ich möchte noch mal deutlich
dafür werben dass wir die Möglichkeit
nutzen die wir uns gegeben haben mit der
verbundenen Einzelwahl entweder gibt es
nur einen Kandidaten
entweder
also ich möchte noch mal deutlich dafür
werben dass wir die Möglichkeit der
verbundenen einzelwahlen Nutzen denn wir
haben uns das beschlossenes eröffnet uns
nur die Möglichkeit Zeit sparen zu
arbeiten wenn es mehr Kandidaten gibt
kommt es halt nicht in Frage wenn es nur
eingibt dann haben wir uns die Zeit und
erzählkommission unheimlich viele Meter
gespart und deswegen spricht überhaupt
nichts dagegen das zu tun
die Delegierten auf dem afd-parteitag
diskutieren über eine mögliche
Zeitersparnis in dem über die bundesschi
zu Errichter über die Kandidaten
gemeinsam abgestimmt wird wenn es keine
Kampfkandidaturen gibt das dauert hier
ein bisschen und wir wollen dann auch
die Zeit nutzen um Ihnen heute noch
einmal das Interview mit
afd-chef Tino krupala zu zeigen dass
Alexander Keller heute morgen geführt
hat und seine erste Frage war ob
tinopala den Chancen sieht dass die AFD
2025 ins Kanzleramt einziehen kann
ich denke für Deutschland wäre es gut
wenn wir nicht wussten kannst da
Kandidaten aufstellen sondern auch für
Deutschland ein Kanzler stellen aber ich
denke das sind Dinge die werden wir dann
zur Bundestagswahl nächstes Jahr Ende
nächsten Jahres auch in der Partei
debattieren aber es ist ganz klar für
uns dass wir natürlich auch Andy
Verantwortung kommen wollen und kommen
müssen damit ist Deutschland wieder
besser geht jetzt sind sie im Moment ja
die Umfrage Könige allerdings habe ich
gestern auf dem Presse haben ihre Partei
so von einigen ihrer Parteifreundinnen
und Freunde gehört es besteht eine
gewisse Gefahr dass jetzt die Euphorie
zu groß wird dass man so selbstgefällig
zu selbstsicher ist sehen Sie da auch
eine Gefahr dass möglicherweise der
Höhenflug der AFD zu Ende geht das
natürlich auch Aufgabe des
Bundesvorstand ist auch der beiden
bundesprecher hier mit Demut natürlich
an Umfragen heranzugehen sie haben
vollkommen recht es sind Umfragen noch
keine Ergebnisse wir haben dieses Jahr
zwei wichtige Landtagswahlen noch vor
der Brust das ist in Hessen und in
Bayern erfolgreich abschließen wollen
und dann natürlich nächstes Jahr die
drei ostdeutschen Landtagswahlen aber
auch vor allen Dingen die Kommunalwahlen
die sehr wichtig sind wie Sie wissen
haben wir auf kommunal eben ja Erfolge
vorzuweisen und die wollen wir ausbauen
und dann natürlich die Europawahl also
von daher ist Demut angebracht aber es
ist natürlich auch Motivation für unsere
Wahlkämpfer und Kandidaten vor Ort in
ihrer alten politischen Heimat der CDU
hat der aktuelle Parteichef ziemlich
viel Verwirrung gestiftet mit der
Zusammenarbeit in Sachen Zusammenarbeit
mit der AFD die Schadenfreude bei ihnen
ist ja grenzenlos im Moment darüber aber
jetzt hat er unglaublich viel Widerstand
in der eigenen Partei damit provoziert
musste auch zurückrudern könnte sein
dass ich dadurch ungewollt für Sie die
Brandmauer wieder stabilisiert
nun ich habe ja immer gesagt und gerade
wir als Ostdeutsche kennen hier und
wissen ja was Brandmauern bedeutet diese
brandmaul die Friedrich Merz aufgebaut
hat im mittlerweile ist er Gefangener
der grüne Ideologie selbst weil er muss
dann natürlich mit den
Koalitionspartnern die aktuell da sind
die für Deutschland nichts Gutes
Vorhaben vor allen Dingen grünen Politik
weitergestalten und das werden wir
natürlich gnadenlos auch benennen und
auch seine doppelzügigkeit gnadenlos
benennen dieses HU und hat schade
natürlich der CDU aber wissen Sie dass
es nicht meine Aufgabe der CDU
Ratschläge zu geben ich habe immer
gesagt dass Friedrich Merz nicht
derjenige ist der die CDU reformieren
wird und es hat sich bestätigt aber sie
brauchen die CDU und regieren zu können
müssen sie am Ende wollen wir mit den
zusammenarbeiten die es gut mit
Deutschland meinen die die Interessen
der deutschen vertreten die endlich
Politik für unsere Mittelstand für
unsere Industrie für unsere Bürger
machen das kann auch SPD Personen sein
wir müssen endlich wieder zur Sache
Fragen kommen und zur
lösungsorientierten ansetzen wir müssen
endlich wieder dazu kommen Probleme und
Ursachen zu lösen das aber überhaupt die
Menschen dann wird auch die
Politikverdrossenheit in diesem Land
zurück verdrängt das ist ein übrigens
Aufgabe aller demokratischen Parteien
sollten sich die sehr guten
Umfrageergebnisse für die AFD in
Thüringen für die Landtagswahl
bewahrheiten dann wird Björn höcke kaum
noch der alleinige Parteivorsitz in der
AFD zu nehmen sein könnte sein oder
rechnen Sie damit dass Sie im nächsten
Jahr neben Alexander gauland
Ehrenvorsitzender der AFD werden
sein ich bin aktuell sehr zufrieden mit
meinem Bundesvorstand den wir letztes
Jahr hier gewählt haben der hat Ruhe und
Gelassenheit in die Partei gebracht
Geschlossenheit eigentlich in unserer
zehnjährigen geschichtlich einzigartig
und das nehmen natürlich auch die Wähler
zur Kenntnis wir müssen jetzt diese
Verantwortung wahrnehmen und wir werden
jetzt keine Personal Debatten noch dazu
öffentlich führen das machen wir intern
so wie wir die letzten Monate gut und
erfolgreich getan haben dass wenn du
auch in Zukunft zu gestalten aber die
Frage Weihnachten höcke dass er bei
erste Gelegenheit nach der Macht greift
vertrauen sie ihm
in der Politik ist Vertrauen ich denke
mal auch dort das falsche Wort ich habe
mit Björn höcke einen guten Kontakt es
ist richtig wie mit allen
Landesvorsitzenden und dann nehmen wir
erstmal sehen ob er überhaupt will ist
auch nach Berlin zu gehen am Ende muss
es auch dahin gehen sein dass wenn man
diese Partei führen will und auch eine
Fraktion führen will dass man dann auch
den Schritt in den Bundestag Wagen muss
ich denke ist in Thüringen gut
aufgekommen er macht doch eine gute
Landespolitik er hat doch viel Arbeit
und er kann auch aus Thüringen heraus
auch bundespolitisch wirken die AFD lebt
ja im politischen Schlaraffenland kann
man sagen sie müssen nur den Mund
aufmachen und die gebratene Tauben in
dem Fall die sehr guten
Umfrageergebnisse fliegen immer nur noch
rein
jetzt ist ja die Frage
wie wird das weitergehen wenn eine
Partei quasi leistungslos solche tollen
Ergebnisse einfährt sie tut ihr nichts
dafür muss ich Ihnen natürlich deutlich
wieder sprechen also dass wir nichts
dafür tun ich habe sie gerade gesagt
erstens mal unsere Geschlossenheit ist
das erste Aushängeschild wir haben aber
Alleinstellungsmerkmal wie kritisieren
ganz klar die Sanktionspolitik die
mittlerweile ja der Wirtschaft schade
der IWF hat es ja mittlerweile auch klar
definiert dass Deutschland in der
Rezession angekommen ist wegen der
Aktionen auch wegen der Reaktion
natürlich wegen was sonst ich meine
Russland den eigentlich die Sanktion
gegolten haben haben einen
Wirtschaftswachstum das muss man sich
vorstellen wir haben auf EU eben eine
über zehn sanktions Pakete geschnürt und
Russland schade diese sanktions Politik
nicht sondern Deutschland
mittelständischen Unternehmen
Informationen die Frage ist
immer mehr Unternehmer tragen sich mit
dem Gedanken Deutschland von zu
verlassen also hier muss es endlich
einen Weckruf geben hier muss es endlich
auch einen ein Signal geben Scholz
spricht von einem Wirtschaftswunder der
wohnt wann soll es denn kommen
Krieg bei den Auslöser aber
wahrscheinlich nicht die Ursache
weil sie sagen sie müssen wir
widersprechen sie müssen gar nicht Herrn
Keller widersprechen sondern sie müssen
ja eigentlich im Ehrenvorsitzenden
widersprechen weil Alexander gauland
nämlich gesagt hat das ist nicht das
Verdienst der AFD die guten Ergebnisse
der Fehler der anderen und das muss man
realistisch sehen so hat das nicht
gesagt er hat natürlich gesagt natürlich
haben die anderen ihren Beitrag
geleistet aber wissen das ist wie im
Sport also wenn ich im Fußball gewinne
dann sage ich doch nicht also natürlich
haben die andere Fehler gemacht die
oppositioniert und profitiert immer von
Fehlern der andere das ist ja der
Aufgabe einer Opposition du musst mal
die Frage stellen warum profitieren die
anderen Oppositionsparteien nicht
wirklich davon die CDU er relativ wenig
die Linke überhaupt nicht weil wir die
einzig wahrnehmbare Oppositionen sind
weil wir für die Interessen Deutschlands
auch für die Interessen der Wirtschaft
Politik machen und das erkennen immer
mehr Menschen haben sie damit ziemlich
viel Erfolg im Moment soweit
Kinoprogramm der Bundessprecher der AFD
danke für das Interview sehr gerne
so weit das Interview mit Tino krupala
heute Morgen und hier wird nun gerade
der zweite bundesschiedsrichter gewählt
es gibt zwei Kandidaten die sich jetzt
vorstellen der erste der sich vorstellt
ist ist Nils Rosengarten aus dem
Landesverband Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
ich bin 23 und Student der Geschichte
und Altertumswissenschaften und bewege
mich seit mehreren Jahren im Bereich der
verfassungs- und Rechtsgeschichte und
die studiere an der Universität Rostock
an der Ostseeküste unseres wunderschönen
dunkeldeutschlands
umso mehr bin ich daher
über die historische Unbildung über der
Politiker der Altparteien erschrocken
wie das Bildnis und es reichsgründet ist
und besten Diplomaten seiner Zeit aus
dem Auswärtigen Amt und Fähren oder
Bismarck in erster Linie mit einem
Fischbrötchen in Verbindung bringen
wir Deutschen haben eine
jahrhundertelange parlamentarische
Tradition die bis zum reichspruch von
1231 zurückgeht und diese Tradition
Liebe Parteifreunde kann auch kein
Thomas halten und Co ein Ende machen
aber liebe Parteifreunde ich will nicht
einer Emilia fester werden sondern
erstmal abliefern und ich hoffe dass Sie
mir die Möglichkeit geben
hier genauso wie im Studium abliefern zu
können und man Können unter Beweis zu
stellen
Liebe Parteifreunde es ist wichtig dass
wir in diese Position eine Person helfen
die bereit ist mit Maschine lagern und
Flügeln der Partei zu reden und zu
interagieren und die nicht dort ihre
eigenen ideologischen Interessen
durchsetzen will
dafür trete ich ein Liebe Parteifreunde
lassen Sie mir mich Geschichte schreiben
so sie können noch ganz kurz hier
bleiben falls es Fragen geben sollte
sind Fragen eingeworfen
wenn noch jemand Fragen anmelden möchte
bitte jetzt nach vorne gehen und die
Karte einwerfen
da ist noch jemand unterwegs
zwei Fragen beschlossen 30 Sekunden
Fragezeichen
so Karten sind allein geworfen dann
bitte hier nach vorne bringen niemand
mehr unterwegs
deine Frage anmelden möchte und wir
werden dann jetzt die beiden
Fragesteller und die Reihenfolge in der
wir die Fragen stellen können auslosen
die erste Frage kommt von
Benjamin Nolte
und die zweite Frage von Jan Petersen
beende
dann am blauen salmikrofon für 30
Sekunden bitteschön ja vielen Dank sie
hatten gerade gesagt dass nach der alten
Satzungsregelung Unvereinbarkeiten
bestanden hätten können Sie das
vielleicht mal etwas näher ausführen für
wen sie arbeiten
genau und in welchem Rahmen ich arbeite
neben meinem Studium als Mitarbeiter für
den Landtagsabgeordneten Michael Meister
aus und Paul
danke schön dann kommt die zweite Frage
von Jan Petersen Brendel
der zum rot und sein Mikrofon sprintet
das blaue tut sonst aber auch genauso
bitteschön 30 Sekunden der große wir
haben ihren Ausführungen gerne gelauscht
wir haben uns aber gedacht dabei sie
kandidieren für ein politisches Amt sie
kandidieren allerdings für einen
Richteramt und das lief dann ein
bisschen daneben ich glaube nicht glaube
nicht dass sie die Aufgaben im
Bundesschiedsgericht so erfüllen können
wie wir uns das wünschen
sehen Sie das anders wollen sie das
nachtbereiten ich sehe das anders ich
glaube dass ich mich zurückhalten kann
ich glaube dass ich mich in diese
Aufgabe einarbeiten kann
ich habe jahrelang gelernt mich
zurückzuhalten ich pflege seit fünf
Jahren intensiv meine Großmutter
und ich weiß daher was diese
Verantwortung bedeutet und ich weiß auch
dass das heißt dass sie viel Vertrauen
und mich stecken müssen wenn sie dieses
Abend in die Hände eines Sohn jungen
Mannes geben
ja vielen Dank dann ist auch gar keine
Rosengarten mit dank entlassen und
[Musik]
wir kommen zur Vorstellung von Gerald
Hohmann
so guten Tag Herr Hohmann auch an sie
einmal die Pflicht Fragen zum einen aus
welchem Landesverband stammen sie ich
kenne die Antwort aber
kann doch nicht hören ja
könnten sie noch mal wiederholen so
einmal welchen in welchem Landesverband
sind sie Mitglied einmal für die
Versammlung Schleswig-Holstein sind sie
Volljurist ja und hätte bei Ihnen eine
Unvereinbarkeit nach nein ein paar
Grafen drei absatz 2 Satz 2 Nummer 2 der
schiedlung Alter Fassung bestanden nein
dann haben Sie jetzt bis zu vier Minuten
Zeit für Ihre Vorstellung bitte schön
ja guten Tag meine Damen und Herren sehr
verehrte Parteifreunde
sie haben mich vielleicht schon mal
kennengelernt ich habe schon mal bin
schon mal angetreten für die Wahl zum
bundesschiedsrichter das hat dann sehr
unglücklich geendet die Versammlung war
schon sehr weit fortgeschritten und
wurde dann abgebrochen naja heute haben
sie erneut die Chance also meinen Namen
haben sie schon gesehen ich bin jetzt 64
Jahre alt und bin in Kiel geboren und
wohne auch in Kiel höre also dem
Landesverband Schleswig-Holstein an seit
und dort habe ich auch gleich
verschiedene Parteiämter übernommen in
landesfachausschüssen habe ich viel
mitgearbeitet aber auch als
Schiedsrichter das war ich bei uns vier
Jahre lang über zwei Jahre auch
Vorsitzender des landesschiedsgerichtes
und insofern habe ich dann natürlich
schon eine gewisse Erfahrung wir haben
in der Zeit als ich dort Schiedsrichter
war auch teilweise
einigermaßen spektakuläre Fälle zu
entscheiden gehabt da ging das um
relativ prominente
Parteiausschlussverfahren wenn Sie sich
erinnern können
gut ich habe mich jetzt hier bereit
erklärt doch auch noch mal zu
kandidieren für das Amt eines
bundesschiedsrichters da kann ich mich
eigentlich im Wesentlichen so was die
Einstellung dazu angeht meinem Herrn
Kollegen Dr Wirth anschließen der hier
auf die erste Position gewählt wurde
das ist nicht immer honigflecken dieses
an man muss da einiges reinstecken aber
ich bin noch mal bereit dazu das zu tun
übrigens als Rechtsanwalt bin ich
weiterhin tätig inzwischen seit 35
Jahren
ja und mehr gibt ein wenig zu sagen
danke
vielen Dank dann haben Sie auch hier die
Gelegenheit noch dem Kandidaten Fragen
zu stellen noch jemanden unterwegs der
eine Frage anmelden möchte kann ich
nicht sehen liegen Fragen vor
dann keine Fragen vor sind sie damit
entlassen bevor wir in den nächsten
Wahlgang eintreten
was aber in Kürze der Fall sein wird
also wer an dem Wahlgang teilnehmen
möchte möge jetzt bitte schon mal in den
Saal hineinkommen haben wir ein Ergebnis
aus der ersten Wahlgang der ersten Wahl
zur Wahl als bundesschiedsrichter
Standort Christian Wirth und auf ihn
sind entfallen
371 Stimmen Nein stimmen gab es 53 und
10 Enthaltungen Dr Christian wird hat
damit die notwendige einfache Mehrheit
erreicht und ich frage ihn ob er die
Wahl auch annimmt
herzlichen Glückwunsch
weil ist angenommen
so dann kam die zielkommission
die Stimmzettel ausgehändigt bekommen
und wir schließen die Tür in 90 Sekunden
und während er jetzt hier diese Wahl zum
zweiten
bundesschiedsrichter läuft wollen wir
die Zeit nutzen ihn eine erste aktuelle
Zusammenfassung zum bisherigen Parteitag
zu zeigen und einen Blick auf die
Stimmung in der AFD
die Stimmung war schon mal schlechter
bei der AFD die Partei erfreut sich an
guten Umfragewerten sie stellt den
ersten Landrat und Deutschland
diskutiert wie sollen wir umgehen mit
einer internen rechtsextremen Partei ein
selbstbewusster Vorsitzender kann sich
eine Bemerkung Richtung CDU nicht
verkneifen
er nennt er nennt die CDU eine
Alternative für Deutschland mit Substanz
doch die streitlustige AFD kommt auch
diesmal nicht ohne Streit aus in
Magdeburg geht es auch um die
bevorstehende Europawahl Europa neu
denken so die Theorie aber wie radikal
darf es sein die EU auflösen austreten
nach dem brexit nun der dexit Maximilian
Kraus Sachsen gehört zum rechten Rand
der Partei er sitzt schon im
Europaparlament jetzt will er
Spitzenkandidat werden er will die EU
nicht abschaffen sondern neu erfinden
ich sage immer stärker raus Stecker rein
und neues Betriebssystem also wir
brauchen Europa Politik wir brauchen
europäische Institution aber das was wir
zur Zeit aus Brüssel haben ist für
Deutschland schädlich das heißt also es
geht so wie es jetzt ist sicher nicht
weiter ab morgen wird die AFD Kandidaten
für die Europawahl sie treten an für das
Parlament dass sie abschaffen wollen im
Leitantrag steht die Geduld mit Europa
sei erschöpft die AFD will raus aus dem
Euro und die D-Mark zurück
ich glaube dass dieser
Moloch nicht zu reformieren ist und
deswegen bin ich eigentlich für ein
Austritt aus der EU und der Schaffung
einer neuen Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft
zumindest die aus den Austritt
anzukündigen und einmal zu sehen ob noch
was passiert denn der Druck dürfte
gewaltig sein in Deutschland als mit
Abstand größter Nettozahler sagt wir
treten aus dass er meine Ansicht und
dann hoffen wir das was passiert und
wenn nicht dann gehen wir halt eine
Auflösung der EU und schon ein Austritt
hätten fatale Folgen so sieht es
Politikwissenschaftlerin Sabine Kropp
wohin das führt lässt sich sehr leicht
am Fall von Großbritannien ablesen
nämlich eben gerade nicht zu
Wirtschaftswachstum und die
Verflechtungen sind so eng dass man sich
die damit verbundenen Folgen
voraussichtlich im Augenblick gar nicht
klar macht doch bevor der inhaltliche
Streit gelöst werden kann muss die AFD
ihre Kandidaten wählen das dauert denn
das Interesse ist groß an einem Posten
in Brüssel in einem Parlament dem nicht
wenige hier Misstrauen
die haben hier jetzt weil sie zwei
Kandidaten haben bleiben so weit also
zur aktuellen Stimmung und der
ersten Zusammenfassung hier vom
Bundesparteitag dem 14 Bundesparteitag
der AFD in Magdeburg wo eine neue Wahl
ansteht und Sie sehen ist die
Wahlhelferinnen und Wahlhelfer stehen
schon bereit um hier einen zweiten
bundesschiedsrichter zu wählen ein
wichtiges Gremium für die Partei wenn es
zum Beispiel um
Parteiausschlussverfahren geht wenn die
Partei das Gefühl hat dass ein Mitglied
sich z.B Partei schädigend verhalten hat
dann beschäftigt sich das
bundesheetsgericht damit noch werden
hier aber die Zettel sortiert so sieht
das von hier aus aus so dass hier auch
noch in großen Blättern steht der
Wahlgang beginnt in Kürze und dann
können die Abgeordneten auswählen ob Sie
Gerald Hohmann aus Schleswig-Holstein
oder Nähe zur Rosengarten aus
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern wählen oder ob
sie keinen von den zwei
vorgestellten Kandidaten hier als
geeignet sehen um den Posten eines
Bundes Schiedsrichters anzutreten
wir haben es im Beitrag schon gehört und
auch während des Parteitags kam es ja
immer wo das immer wieder deutlich die
Stimmung in der AFD die ist besonders
gut die
Umfragewerte sehen die Partei bei um die
20 Prozent und das ist natürlich in
diesem Wahljahr vorteilhaft für die AFD
dann entstehen Wahlen an in Hessen und
Bayern
und da möchte ich Sie schon einmal auf
einen Interview hinweisen dass wir gegen
16 Uhr hier am Set führen werden Katrin
Ebner Steiner wird zu Alexander Keller
kommen sie ist eine der zwei
Spitzenkandidaten in Bayern wurde im Mai
auf einem Landesparteitag mit Martin
Böhm zum Spitzen du gewählt beide gelten
als Flügel nah den Flügel diese
Strömung in der Partei der hat sich ja
offiziell
aufgelöst aber ebener Steiner gilt noch
als vertraute höckes der Spitzen Duo
geht doch mit deutlichen Forderungen in
den Wahlkampf unter anderen
warnen sie vor einer Flutung
Deutschlands mit Kultur fremden
Einwanderern
dazu kann dann Alexander Keller
natürlich sie befragen weil sie um 16
Uhr gegen 16 Uhr hier bei uns an Set
kommen wird unter anderem möchten die
Spitzenkandidaten in Bayern auch den
Unterricht so reformieren dass Grund und
Mittelschulen
getrennten Unterricht einführen für
Kinder mit Deutsch als Muttersprache und
Kindern die Deutschen nicht als
Muttersprache haben
während des
hier kommt es weiter zu
Verzögerungen im Wahlgang
können wir auch noch mal nutzen um noch
mal auf die nächsten
Wahlen zu schauen auch da dürfte die AFD
recht positiv in die Zukunft schauen
denn im kommenden Jahr wird in drei
ost-bundesländern gewählt in denen die
AFD doch recht stark traditionell ist
in Brandenburg Sachsen und Thüringen
auch da sind die Umfragen gerade sehr
gut für die AFD
in Sachsen steht sie aktuell in Umfragen
bei
32% Thüringen auch 32% Brandenburg
28%, das sind sehr gute Zahlen für die
AFD und wenn wir mal ehrlich sind für
andere Parteien mittlerweile auch bei
dem
Parteien Veränderungen die es in den
letzten Jahren gehabt
rote Folie einblenden bitte alle ihre
Plätze einnehmen niemand mehr unterwegs
zwei Kandidaten stehen zur Auswahl und
die Wahlhelfer
können hier nun
ihres Amtes tätig werden
so stimmzettelchen ausgeteilt werden
wenn der Wahlleiter
[Applaus]
so und los geht's
und während hier die Wahl stattfindet
nutzen wir mal wieder die Zeit und
schauen auf den morgigen Tag wir haben
es ja schon häufiger erwähnt die
Kandidaten werden wahrscheinlich an
erster Stelle steht aber natürlich wird
auch mit der Auswahl der Kandidaten eine
programmatische Entscheidung wohl
getroffen und da gibt es einige Fragen
die interessant sein werden wie sich die
AFD davor der Europawahl positionieren
wird im kommenden Jahr einerseits
natürlich wie die AFD zur Europäischen
Union steht im Leitantrag war
ursprünglich die Rede dass die AFD die
geordnete Auflösung der EU erfordert
dass er aber ein redaktionelles Versehen
gewesen und da ist man nun von
abgewichen stattdessen soll es eher eine
Art Neugründung geben eine neue
europäische Wirtschaft und
Interessengemeinschaft einen Bund
europäischer Nationen so
Moment ist nun der Bundesvorstand und
greift damit die Idee auf dass es eben
keinen europäischen Bundesstaat gibt
sondern die Mitgliedstaaten die
wichtigen Entscheidungen treffen und
auch das das EU-Parlament nicht mehr wie
jetzt eine
eine so entscheidende Rolle spielt es
gibt auch Forderungen dass das
EU-Parlament insgesamt aufgelöst wird
der Leitantrag vom Bundesvorstand so wie
er jetzt ist
92 Seiten lang es gibt aber auch 78
Änderungsanträge dazu auch die müssen
dann in den kommenden Tagen diskutiert
werden
[Musik]
unter anderem natürlich ist dort auch
die Frage in wie weit wird der russische
Angriffskrieg verurteilt was fordert die
AFD konkret von Deutschland in der Welt
aber auch von Europa in außenpolitischen
Fragen
rotes
ein roter Bildschirm eingeblendet ist
heißt das dass sie sitzen bleiben
und die Abstimmung hier
läuft noch und wir wollen die Zeit mit
einem weiteren Interview erfüllen wir
hatten Bernd Baumann im Interview und
das möchten wir Ihnen jetzt gern zeigen
bei mir am Interview Set inzwischen
Bernd Baumann angekommen der erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
afd-fraktion im Deutschen Bundestag aber
die haben ja gerade der Rede von
Kinoprogramm als erstes auf dass er
gesagt hat die Impfpflicht abgewendet
das hat das Verdienst der AFD also wenn
ich mich sie waren ja im Bundestag
selbst bei diesen Debatten dabei wenn
ich mich da richtig erinnere waren das
auch noch andere Fraktionen die FDP z.B
in großen Teil ich glaube auch dass der
Union haben sich viele gegen die
Impfpflicht gewendet heften sie sich da
ein Erfolg an die Fahnen der eigentlich
den auch andere sozusagen
mit verursacht haben
die Frage wer hat das als erster
sozusagen zum Gespräch gemacht wird das
als erster auf die Agenda geschrieben
und das waren wir die das eindeutig
gemacht haben wie bei allen anderen
wichtigen Politikbereiche Migration
Energie sind wir die einzige
Opposition wir sehen das so die CDU ist
das schon lange nicht mehr auch in dem
Fall nicht
vielleicht noch ein anderer Aspekt sagen
gegen die trickstreiber will die AFD
Vorgehen wen meinen sie dann damit ähm
ist da tatsächlich der besten Gemeinde
wir sollten uns ja nicht unbedingt auf
die Seite des Westen schlagen sagt
kinoprophaler aber seit 1949 sind wir
Westen die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
war Teil des Westens Teil der NATO ich
war Bundeswehrsoldat auch Teil der NATO
jetzt ist aber die ost-westspaltung zu
Ende seit 1989 jetzt in völlig neue
geopolitische geostrategische Grundlagen
geschaffen wir müssen uns neu
positionieren auch als Europa innerhalb
der Welt das braucht mehr Souveränität
Europas geopolitisch aber auch
Deutschlands innerhalb von Europa ist
damit gemeint ja aber die
ost-west-spaltung haben wir ja wieder
ausgelöst durch Vladimir Putin ja das
ist ausgelöst durch Vladimir Putin was
den Krieg angeht aber die Diplomatie vor
den Krieg die diplomatische Krise da ist
der Westen da sind die USA mit dran
beteiligt und der Schlüssel für den
Frieden hängt großenteils auch in den
USA es geht nicht um ein Frieden jetzt
Ukraine Russland das wird so nicht geben
das muss eine internationale
Sicherheitsarchitektur geben die wir
schon mal hatten die weltweit sozusagen
klar macht die Räume absteckt und
gemeinsam Frieden und Stabilität wieder
schafft was jetzt gerade gesagt haben
weiß das auch Wladimir Putin haben sie
da Information ich habe keine
Information aber die Russen haben
Interessen legitime Interessen wie
andere auch legitime Interessen haben
natürlich ist das ein angriffskriechen
völkerrechtswidriger das macht die Sache
jetzt schwieriger aber langfristig
können wir Frieden in Europa nur haben
mit Russland das ist seit Jahrhunderten
so aber ich zitiere mal den
Parteivorsitzenden andere Lehrer wir
sollten andere Länder so leben lassen
wie sie es wollen
es geht um Respekt und Frieden statt
Einmischung und Krieg wenn man sich das
jetzt mal auf den auf den Überfall der
Russen auf die Ukraine
ansieht also die Russen lassen ein
anderes Land nicht zu leben wie es will
Respekt und Frieden davon kann keine
Rede sein sondern Einmischung Krieg und
Massenmord sind das die alternativen
Fakten die man immer bei der AFD
vermutet heute nicht wir haben gesagt
doch das ist ein völkerrechtswidriger
Angriffskrieg mit allem was das bedeutet
zutiefst zu verurteilen was er im Grunde
meint ist diese Werte geleitete
Außenpolitik von Frau bärburg was
überhaupt nicht funktioniert es gibt auf
der Welt ganz unterschiedliche
Kulturräume auch Kulturräume die nichts
mit unserer europäischen sehr wenig in
unsere europäischen Kultur
Menschenrechte und so weiter zu tun
haben auch die Chinesen haben eine
eigene Kultur die ist innerlich anders
aufgebaut die müssen wir akzeptieren das
ist damit gemeint wir müssen
interessengeleitete deutsche und
europäische Außenpolitik machen und
nicht die Welt belehren nach
europäischen Werten die die nicht haben
und die nicht wollen bedeutet diese
Interessen geleitete Politik
Deutschlands auch dass wir zum Beispiel
Menschenrechtsfragen ausschließen
sollten aus dieser Interessen geleiteten
Politik die sieht nicht ausgeschlossen
aber die stehen nicht im Vordergrund wir
haben nicht die Welt zu belehren die
Welt zu missionieren die folgt uns auch
nicht die Chinesen 1,4 Milliarden mit
einer eigenen 2500-jährigen Geschichte
die haben anderes System nicht
individuelle Menschenrechte und das
funktioniert auch ich finde unser System
besser das westliche dass europäische
des bürgerliche aber die Welt ist in
großen Teilen anders organisiert das
müssen wir akzeptieren die zu belehren
und unsere Außenpolitik darauf
zuzuschreiben dass wir die bekehren und
belehren ist Unsinn das ist ein Teil
dessen was wir kommunizieren aber im
Kern müssen wir unseren Interessen
wahrnehmen geoprische Interessen wir
müssen Energieversorgung sicherstellen
Absatzmärkte und mit dem müssen wir
zusammenarbeiten selbst mit arabischen
sozusagen klaren beherrschten
Unternehmen wie Saudi Arabien oder so
müssen wir vernünftige Politik betreiben
wir können nicht die weltmissionieren
ist ein absolutes Missverständnis von
Außenpolitik was roberbock und die
linksgrüne Regierung machen aber dann
müssen wir die
Menschenrechtsverletzungen Saudi-Arabien
und China akzeptieren nicht akzeptieren
wir können ja versuchen darauf
hinzuwirken wir können da Frau dafür
werben aber wie können sie nicht zwingen
durch Sanktionen durch Belehrungen
aufdringlich werden das können wir nicht
das sind selbstständige Kulturen die in
sich ruhen Jahrtausende alt anders
organisiert sind die Welt ist nicht voll
von Europäern und europäischer Kultur
das ist ein ganz bestimmter Kreis das
hält uns auch zusammen im Westen
Menschenrechte Bürgerlichkeit Freiheit
Demokratie aber große Teile der Welt
sind anders organisiert und die wollen
auch anders organisiert bleiben es gibt
andere Möglichkeiten sich zu
organisieren da sehen sie in China
ungeheuerer Erfolg Wohlstand Milliarden
Menschen aus dem Elend geholt in kurzer
Zeit ohne unsere Version von
Bürgerlichkeit Menschenrechten
Demokratie das ist möglich wo die
wirtschaftlichen Bedingungen in China
haben sich ja verschlechte in den
letzten Monaten ja ich würde sie gerne
noch auf eine Sache Hinweise sie haben
ziemlich sicheren Job weil nicht geplant
ist dass der Bundestag abgeschafft
werden soll ist mir jedenfalls nicht
bekannt was sie aber planen ist ein
anderes Parlament abzuschaffen nämlich
das EU-Parlament jetzt gibt es hier
einen sechstägigen doch sehr aufwendigen
parteiag zur Wahl von Kandidaten für
dieses Europäische Parlament die nach
Brüssel fahren und dann alles dafür tun
dieses Parlament dann abzuschaffen also
shopkiller in eigener Sache zu sein so
ungefähr wie geht das zusammen nein die
EU muss grundsätzlich reformiert werden
wir haben uns das jetzt jahrzehntelang
angeguckt am Anfang war alles prima die
Wirtschaftsunion sozusagen
Sicherheitspolitik miteinander zu
betreiben freie Märkte alles völlig okay
aber jetzt hat sich ein Zentralismus in
Brüssel ausgebildet der so nicht geht
der so nicht funktioniert und auch das
EU-Parlament ist ja keine wirklich
demokratische Veranstaltung die
einzelnen Länder haben ja ganz
unterschiedlich Abgeordnete Deutschland
hat nicht entsprechend seiner
Bürgerschaft Abgeordnete
Europäischen Parlament da ist
sondern die Deutschen sind
unterrepräsentiert wie die anderen
großen Länder auch das ist sozusagen in
Vehikel von Demokratie wie das
EU-Parlament um mit organisiert ist und
so geht das nicht weiter gut das ist
jetzt ihre Analyse der europäischen
Parlamente es gibt ja es gibt in der Tat
ja auch den Versuch das noch zu ändern
da müssen aber alle mit an einem Strang
ziehen aber im Moment ist Europa in
weiten Teilen auch nicht Europa die EU
wir sind die Europäer wir sind zutiefst
Europäer hier von der AFD aus nur die
eu-vision Moment vorgeht und wieso
Mensch strukturiert ist ist für uns ein
großes Problem weil es auch keine
Probleme löst Migration Außengrenzen
Energie ist ja ein Desaster was wollen
sie die zerschlagen
sind alles so fürchterliche Begriffe wir
wollen das neugründen wir wollen
sozusagen eine neue Gründung das Ding
muss europäisch neu gedacht werden die
Solidarität die Loyalität die Tiefe
Verwandtschaft der europäischen Nation
muss Ausdruck finden in der gemeinsamen
Organisation in der gemeinsamen
Verbindung und da ist die jetzige Jugen
hier weg wir müssen das neugründen
zutiefst reformieren wenn die neuen
Abgeordneten der AFD in Brüssel eine
Menge zu tun haben 26 andere Länder noch
davon zu überzeugen
ich bedanke mich bei Bernd Baumann für
das Gespräch
soweit das Interview mit Bernd Baumann
hier werden nun noch kandidiert kann die
Daten gesammelt
denn während wir hier dieses Interview
geführt haben wurde für Platz drei nur
ein Kandidat vorgeschlagen
Roman golombe und nun sind wir bei Platz
4 da gibt es allerdings schon zwei
Kandidaten Tobias Gall und Jens görtzen
vielen Dank
zur Verfügung
und gib ein weiteren Vorschlag am roten
Samen Mikrofon
ich schlage als weiteren Volljuristen
aus Schleswig-Holstein Herrn Richard
Albrecht vor dessen schriftliche
Einverständniserklärung dem Präsidium
vorliegt
das ist zutreffend von Herrn Albrecht
liegt uns eine
Erklärung zur Wahl in Abwesenheit vor
und für den Fall der Wahl auch die
Erklärung der Annahme der Wahl
haben wir aktuell dort drei Kandidaten
für die vierte Position gibt es weitere
Vorschläge für den vierten
bundesschiedsrichter
das ist nicht der Fall dann bitte ich
auch hier dass sie mir mit der blauen
Stimmkarte bestätigen dass wir die
Kandidatenliste schließen auch hier
vorbehaltlich der
Personen die sich noch in den
vorangegangenen Wahlgängen
gegebenenfalls befinden
so wer Kenntnisse schließen möchte
entsprechend die blaue Stimmkarte wenn
die Kandidatenliste nicht schließen
möchte wieder die rote Stimmkarte
Enthaltungen dann ist die
Kandidatenliste geschlossen wir haben
jetzt die Situation
dass wir die verbundenen Einzelwahl
beschlossen haben aber auch noch gar
nicht wissen ob wir für Herrn Gollum
Kandidaten gibt oder nicht das wäre bei
der Einzelfall aber auch nicht anders
wir können gleichwohl mit der
Vorstellung fortfahren während die
zielkommission nämlich noch am auszählen
ist
so man kann an der Stelle also sagen wir
haben es versucht mit der verbundenen
Einzelwahl aber es gibt eben mehrere
Kandidaten ich darf dann jetzt Herrn
Golombek nach vorne bitten zur
Vorstellung es gibt hier nur ein
Kandidaten der sie auf dem Platz noch
nicht vorgestellt hat entsprechend kann
die das Auslosen der
vorstellungsreihenfolge entfallen Herr
gollumbeck sie haben die Bühne für die
Vorstellung
Roman gollumbeck aus dem Verband Sachsen
stellt sich jetzt vor
ja einen schönen guten Tag dann darf ich
auch am Sieg zuerst die Pflicht Fragen
richten in welchem Landesverband sind
sie Mitglied
am besten direkt ins Mikrofon dass die
Versammlung sie gut hören kann
Landesverband Sachsen
so es kommt sehr leise rüber müssen
Mikrofon etwas hoch machen und ansonsten
doch bitte an die Tontechnik dort etwas
hoch zu schrauben
also Landesverband Sachsen sind die
Volljurist nein
und
hätte bis zum heutigen Tag eine
Unvereinbarkeit nach Paragraph 3 Absatz
2 Satz zwei Nummer zwei der
Schiedsgerichtsordnung Alter Fassung
bestanden keine Unvereinbarkeit gut dann
darf ich auch in Ruhe bitten für die
Vorstellung von Herrn Golombeck meine
Damen und Herren bitte Ruhe für die
Vorstellung
bitte seien Sie fair allen Kandidaten
gegenüber Dankeschön Herr Golombeck sie
haben das Wort sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren liebe Mitstreiter das ging fix
erst letztes Jahr im Juni wurde mir oft
im Bundesparteitag in dieser euer
Vertrauen für das Ehrenamt eines
ersatzschiedsrichters beim
bundesschichtsgericht ausgesprochen
um bereits im November 2022 als
Schiedsrichter in die erste Kammer des
bundesschichtsgerichtes der AFD
nachzurücken
und heute stehe ich nach diesem
beschlagnenden Jahr erneut vor euch um
einmal mehrere Stimme für das Ehrenamt
eine Schiedsrichters zum Werben zu
meiner Person möchte ich kurz ausführen
denn die beziehungsweise der eine oder
andere Delegierte erinnert sich
vielleicht an meine ausführliche
Vorstellungen auf dem Bundesparteitag in
Riesa oder
hat es aus Medienquellen nachvollzogen
welche Persönlichkeiten heute Magdeburg
auftreten
ich heiße Roman Golombeck bin 46 Jahre
verheiratet und stolzer Vater von zwei
wunderbaren Töchtern
liebe Freunde so manche Erfahrungen auf
meinen Lebensweg hat mich geprägt und
sobald es das Schicksal dass ich im
Januar 2014 die AFD zu sich rief zuerst
organisiert im Landesverband Thüringen
und wie bereits erwähnt heute im
Landesverband Sachsen mit meiner
Bewerbungsrede zum schieds- bzw
Ersatzschiedsrichter auf dem
Bundesparteitag in Riesa gab ich zu
Protokoll
dass ich meine Erfahrung aus meiner
Arbeit in Parteivorständen Ausschüssen
statt im Kreistagsfraktionen einbringen
werde
gewiss allerhand dazu lernen
und dass dies auch so sein möge und
genauso ist es gekommen
zuerst beeindruckt von der Intensität
und dem Aufkommen der Arbeit habe ich
mich eingelesen ausgerichtet mich mit
den Strukturen der Institutionen gemacht
und habe nach besten Wissen und Gewissen
begonnen zu arbeiten heute darf ich
Vorsprechen dass die in meiner etwa 9
Monaten Tätigkeit erschiedsrichter im
Rahmen der Geschäftsverteilung
übernommenen Verfahren bis auf wenige
bearbeitet sind und es ist mir eine Ehre
das bundesschichtsgericht so gut wie mir
eben möglich als nicht Jurist
unterstützt zu haben
Liebe Mitstreiter zuvorsprachig in
meiner heutigen Bewerbung von
Erfahrungen und Lebensweg ich werde
diese Worte weil sie mir beide aufzeigen
dass sich unser Vaterland fortschreitend
in eine Richtungen entwickelt weg von
dem wie wir leben möchten weg von dem
was wir an Wertvorstellungen haben weg
von unserem gesunden und freiheitlich
demokratischen Rechtsverständnis weg von
unseren gewachsen guten Traditionen
Lebensweisen und nicht zuletzt weg von
unserem christlichen abendländischen
Erde
diese Entwicklung ist mir Ansporn hier
und heute erneut um eure Stimme zu
werden und Euch und Eure Unterstützung
zu bitten das Ehrenamt eines Richters
der bundesschichtsgericht eine weitere
Legislatur ausüben zu dürfen und ja es
wäre mir eine Ehre erneut für unsere
gemeinsame Sache
mich auf diese Art und Weise
einzubringen denn auch wenn
Entscheidungen mitunter unpopulär
anmuten so sind sie doch nach
Sachverstand durch ein unabhängiges
Schiedsgericht beschlossen sind für uns
alle zukunftsweisen und lassen uns auf
unseren eigentlichen Auftrag besinnen
parken wir das an holen wir uns unser
Land zurück in einem Europa der
Vaterländer ich gebe mein Bestes denn er
möchte gern als Richter am Bundes-
nun gibt es die Möglichkeit zwei Fragen
zu stellen allerdings gibt es
anscheinend keine Fragen
doch eine Frage gibt es wohl
das müssen wir zumindest wegen der
Reihenfolge losen ich sehe aber nicht
dass noch jemand eine Frage stellen
wollen würde einmal kurz bitte den Namen
sagen und ja wenn Sie mehr Kreisverband
Kaiserslautern dann haben Sie jetzt 30
Sekunden für die Frage bitteschön
auch immer um das Thema Zuverlässigkeit
wir müssen jetzt den Medien leider
entnehmen sie sind der Herr klombach der
in Reichenbach in den Stadtrat gewählt
das ist das richtig
und es wäre ist es richtig dass ich dort
seit einem Jahr nicht mehr aufgetaucht
sind die Frage hätte ich beim eine
stammen keine keine hin und her ja die
Hauptfrage ist Herr glomberg ist es
richtig dass sie seit einem Jahr ihr Amt
im Rat nicht mehr wahrgenommen haben
vielen Dank bis zu 60 Sekunden für die
Antwort die Frage wurde beim letzten
Bundesparteitag bereits durch meine
Person beantwortet das können sie gerne
was mit den Quellen nachvollziehen danke
schön
ja vielen Dank dann sind sie mit dankend
entlassen und wir haben es jetzt 16 Uhr
und zwei Minuten
und sie hatten
vielen Dank sie hatten beschlossen
das Grußwort unserer ausländischen
Ehrengäste auf 16 Uhr zu verlegen und
dazu übergebe ich an Christoph Basedow
hier sind jetzt einige Grußworte
angekündigt und davon sind allerdings
ist nur einer auf Deutsch zwei sind auf
Deutsch angekündigt aber als erstes ist
ja angekündigt Gerolf annemanns von
Flames Belang und für uns heute hier
besonders interessant weil er
Vorsitzender der europäischen Partei
idee-partei ist und das ist genau die
Partei zu der sich nun auch die AFD
bekennen möchte deswegen dürfte ich hier
dieses
diese Rede nun von besonderen Interesse
sein dürfte
in der belgischen Abgeordnetenkammer für
Flames lang seit 2014 Mitglied des
Europäischen Parlaments für Pflanzen und
Mitglied des Vorstands der it-fraktion
und Vorsitzender der
it-partei begrüßen Sie bitte Gerold
annemanns von plans
sehr sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Freunde
was für eine Ehre und Freude mich für
mich persönlich aber auch für meine
nationalparteiflams belangt
hier und heute heute mit Ihnen diesen
Jahrestag fallen zu dürfen und dabei die
Größe parteiflandens und vielleicht
durch Auto noch Belgiens zu vertreten
ein herzlichen Dank der alles und dir an
der Tino für diese freundschaftliche
Einladung
sind tief und innig überzeugt das
Belgien für läufig noch Mitgliedstaat
der Europäischen Union ein historischer
Fehler war und dass wir Flammen in einem
verkehrten und naturwidrigen Staat
geraden sind
wir von Pflanzen sind deshalb bestrebt
diesen Fehler durch die geordnete
Aufteilung Belgiens zu beheben genau wie
die denen
genau wie die Luxemburger die Franzosen
und die Deutschen wollen wir unser
eigenes unabhängigen Staat deshalb
übermittle ich Ihnen hier und heute in
freundschaftlicher und stolzer
Verbundenheit meine herzliche Grüße und
Glückwünsche auch im namens
ich bin ein ich bin ja nicht mehr der
Jüngste und könnte schon lange vor der
Friede Vereinigung von Ost und
Westdeutschland hautnah die politischen
Bestrebungen miterleben Parteien und
Bewegungen in Deutschland zu gründen die
den Begriff kulturell Identität
politisch verankern und das in Zeiten
zunehmender Einwanderung und verstärkter
Zentralisierung der politischen Macht es
war nicht einfach in diesem Umfeld eine
stabile politische Partei aufzubauen die
ein Gefühl der Nähe und Verbundenheit
mit den Wählerinnen und Wähler der
Mittelschicht schafft eine große Partei
die dazu in der Lage ist um endlich die
Machtverhältnisse zu verschieben wie wir
dies schon in Frankreich in Österreich
denn Niederlanden und den Flandern
beobachten könnten
dass die Bestrebungen hier erst einmal
einige Rückschläge hinnehmen mussten und
letztendlich doch gefürchtet haben ist
das größte Verdienst große Verdienst der
AFD und das ist auch der Grund warum wir
sie von ganzem Herzen und mit und
Mitgefühl diesen wohlverdienten
Jahrestag beglückwünschen dürfen
mit der mit der Feier zu ihrem
zehnjährigen Bestehen und in dem Wissen
dass sie nächstes Jahr vor einem großen
Durchbruch stellen möchten wir Sie
weiter in ihrem Mut und Vorhaben
bestärken Deutschland ist ein Vielfaches
größer
Flandern und ihre Verantwortung und Ihre
Herausforderungen haben natürlich eine
andere große
Größenordnung also bei uns das ist uns
sehr bewusst aber wir bringen gerne
unser erfahren mit und unsere
Bereitschaft den Aufbau unserer
europäischen Zusammenarbeit weiter
Vorhand zu bringen auch wenn dies so wie
es in unserer DNA programmiert ist eine
europäischen Zusammenarbeit in
Unabhängigkeit und Freiwilligkeit ist
[Applaus]
denn allen voran und hier spreche ich
als jemand der 40 Jahre lang zielstrebig
am Aufbau einer inzwischen stabilen
rechten Volkspartei für flanderen
gearbeitet hat und sich dabei oft auf
Wagen Terrarium bewegen musste allem
voran bringe ich Ihnen etwas mit das
beim Aufbau einer solche Partei wichtig
und notwendig ist nämlich die
Freundschaft europäischer
Gleichgesinnter die sie in dem unter in
die sie
in dem unterstützen was sie und wer Sie
sind
in immer mehr Mitgliedstaaten haben wir
nun einen mündiger Rechte Kraft im Land
die in der Lage ist die alten Mächte zu
vertreiben und einen neuen Kurs
einzuschlagen die alten machtparteien
fressen Demokraten und Sozialisten die
noch aus dem 19 Jahrhundert stammen und
nicht mehr imstande sind eine klare
Vision für die Probleme des 21
jahrhunderts zu entwickeln sie sind
nicht mehr klar und ihrer angeblichen
politischen Korrektheit lassen sie sich
Liebe von Grünen und teilweise sogar
Kommunisten an die Karren spannenden als
das zu tun was die Bürger wirklich
wollen mit Parteien
mit Parteien mit Parteien wie denn
unsere haben die Bürger jetzt die
Möglichkeit den Wunsch der Arbeiten
Bevölkerung demokratisch durchzusetzen
unsere Idee Fraktion im Europäischen
Parlament und unser europäische
politische Partei Idee mögen in der
angeblich politisch korrekten Welt der
Mächtigen und Medien aus Rebellen gelten
doch der Gesellschaft sind wir eine
immer breitere Strömung die unsere
Länder in die richtige Richtung führt
wir allen in die idee-partei werden in
unseren auffreuen auf den Beitritt
unserer natürlichen deutschen Partner
AFD es ist eine Verstärkung unserer
Zusammenarbeit auf europäische Ebene es
ist natürlich eine Bestätigung der
Grundlage unserer Zusammenarbeit
um im idefraktion des Europäischen
Parlaments und für alle Partner
erst die AFD nicht nur technisch aber
auch politisch eng mit uns verbunden ist
und es auch sein möchte danke
deshalb
deshalb sage ich hier im Namen der
idee-bewegung Fraktion sowie Partei
insgesamt und natürlich auch im Name vom
Flames Belangen es lebe unsere
europäische Freundschaft es lebe die AFD
lang lebe die AFD lang lebe Pflanzen
Deutschland es lebe für anderen
Manns war das von Plans Belang aber vor
allen Dingen auch der Vorsitzende der
europäischen Partei Identität und
Demokratie der Partei der europäischen
Partei der die AFD
beitreten möchte mit Sitz in Paris
und wir schauen uns vom Blick nach vorne
wenden wir den Blick zu unserem Set denn
dort hat Alexander eine neue
Gesprächspartnerin
ja so ist es es geht nämlich um die
Landtagswahl vorhin hatten wir den
Spitzenkandidaten aus Hessen Robert
lambrou und jetzt ist bei uns Katrin
Ebner Steiner sie sind die eine der
beiden Spitzenkandidaten in Bayern für
die Landtagswahl am 8
oktobersteiner wie schwierig ist
eigentlich die
Lage der AFD in Bayern sie haben da ja
einen Ministerpräsidenten der durchaus
im populistischen Besteckkasten wühlen
kann
hatte das Gefühl dass der AFD auch da
kaum Platz zum zum Atmen
dazu kommt ja auch noch dass die CSU im
Moment in Berlin der Opposition ist und
richtig vom Leder ziehen kann inwieweit
belastet dass ihre Ambitionen ihre
Strategie
naja also wir haben in Bayern nicht so
sehr viele Probleme weil die Bürger
wissen dass wir Politik für unsere
bayerischen Bürgerinnen und Bürger
machen es ist so dass wir jetzt laut
aktuellen Umfragen bei 14 Prozent stehen
die Freien Wähler sind bei 11 ci super
38 denke mal unser Hauptproblem ist
Hubert Aiwanger weil er einerseits in
der Regierung ist aber Opposition spielt
und dies das muss man entlarven auf
jeden Fall
guter ist ein gutes Stichwort es ist ja
das ist eine richtige Konkurrenz für sie
da mit Hubert Aiwanger der ja neulich
gesagt hat bei einer grundgebung die
Bürger Bayerns sollten sich die
Demokratie zurückholen der Satz könnte
auch von einem AFD Politikerin sein oder
einem AFD Politiker das heißt da haben
sie große Probleme überhaupt sich gehört
zu verschaffen
deshalb verstehen die Herr verkauft sich
als AFD Leid ist in der regierungsspiel
aproposition genauso war es ja auch mit
der impfdiskussion da hat ja Huber
Hubert Aiwanger auch etwas gehadert hat
sich so als Bad Guy verkauft Söder war
gut guy aber ich denke die bayerischen
Bürger und Bürger wissen was los ist in
Bayern zum Beispiel dieses bayerische
Klimaschutzgesetz wurde auch
verabschiedet mit dem Stimmen der Freien
Wähler und das sind ja die Maßnahmen
noch restriktiver als in der Bundes-
und Kultur fremder Einwanderer
verhindern in Bayern jetzt war
unbenommen dass es in der Tat
illegale Einwanderung in Deutschland
gibt nicht zu wenig das sehen auch viele
andere weit über das AFD Lager hinaus
aber diese Wortwahl ist die wirklich so
klug wenn man denkt wir brauchen ja auch
Zuwanderer und Einwanderer wegen des
Fachkräftemangel schauen sich
Dienstleistungen Landwirtschaft Handwerk
Pflege an stößt das nicht Leute die wir
eigentlich brauchen ab wenn sie mit
solchen Begriffen kommen die irgendwie
Ausländerfeindlichkeit auch auch
implizieren niemand also dieser
Rechtsmissbrauch der seit 2015 in
Deutschland und in Bayern
vorhanden ist die muss einfach ein Ende
gesetzt werden und die AFD ist bekannt
dafür auch dass man mit Marke gesprüchen
durchzusetzen wir wollen natürlich auch
qualifizierte Zuwanderung das heißt wenn
jemand qualifiziert ist wenn er bei uns
arbeitet wenn er Steuern zahlt dann ist
der herzlich Willkommen bei uns aber die
meisten Asylbewerber die derzeit hier
sind die liegen uns auf der Tasche und
das wollen wir nicht wir wollen das Geld
lieber für unsere bayerischen
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ausgeben dort kam
Statistik raus die veröffentlicht worden
ist dass die Hälfte aller Einwanderer
aus dem Jahr 2015 Stichwort
Flüchtlingswelle inzwischen soweit sehr
arbeitsfähig sind in Lohn und Brot
stehen also da hat doch Integration in
den Arbeitsmarkt auch durch diese
Einwanderung geklappt ja da liegen wir
andere Zahlen vor ist aus dem Kopf auf
Asylzentren die zu uns gekommen sind
dass da über 80 Prozent immer noch keine
Arbeit haben das und es muss auch legale
Migration sein es kann nicht sein dass
jemand illegal zu uns ins Land einreißt
es muss alles legal sein um wir wollen
auch nicht dass so viele kulturfremde
Einwanderung hier bei uns sind wir
wollen die Menschen vor Ort unterstützen
wir wollen Asylzentren in Afrika in
anderen Ländern aber nicht hier bei uns
in Deutschland es gab konzidiert das ist
illegale Einwanderung gibt das habe ich
ja gar nicht in Zweifel gezogen meine
Frage war ja sie wollen ja ins
bürgerliche Lager vorstoßen ob solche
Begriffe die Sie verwenden wie Flut und
kulturfremder einander nicht dieses
Lager dass sie eigentlich für sich
gewonnen gewinnen wollen dass das
eigentlich abgestoßen wird von der AFD
da würde ich Ihnen vorschlagen kommst du
mal mit mir auf dem Infostand und hören
Sie mal was die normalen Leute zu ihnen
sagen werden das sind alles ganz normale
Bürgerinnen und Bürger die immer SPD
gewählt haben CSU und freiwähler die
Bürger in Bayern die haben in
Anführungsstrichen die Schnauze voll die
wollen diese illegale Einwanderung nicht
mehr und wir sind Ihr Sprachrohr im
Bayerischen Landtag gut Bayern ist
Bayern wirklich ein
erfolgsversprechendes Terrasse jetzt
gerade gesagt Thema Migration verglichen
mit Thüringen und Sachsen wo die AFD ja
richtig gut da steht sie haben gesagt
14% oder 13% sind im Moment dass sie mit
Abstand geringste Umfrageergebnis für
die AFD bei einer bevorstehenden Wahl
auch in Hessen sind es wesentlich mehr
ist das wirklich so ein
erfolgsversprechendes Terrain wenn sie
gerade also auch mit Themen die
Migration arbeiten die vielleicht in
Sachsen Thüringen relativ gut laufen
aber in Bayern eben viele sind jetzt
zwar Bürger mit denen sie gesprochen
haben aber viele Möglichkeiten doch
abstößt wir haben schon noch andere
Themen man muss sie konzertieren dass in
Bayern die Freien Wähler sind es ist in
Hessen nicht so die stehen bei uns bei
11 Prozent und von daher bin ich
eigentlich schon im Moment sehr
zufrieden mit unserem Ergebnis wir haben
natürlich noch weitere Themen das wäre
die Inflation dann
Thema Heizung
Thema günstige Energie das sind alles
Dinge die die Menschen belasten und da
steht die AFD auch für eine Bürger neue
Politik was kann man sagen dass die
ampelparteien in Berlin ihnen da auch
die Munition liefern bei den Themen die
sie da gerade genannt haben
selbstverständlich liefern die Munition
für uns
in Berlin
passiert der Mann muss auch sagen Söder
ist schuld daran dass wir jetzt eine
links grüne Regierung haben mit den
Angriffen damals im Wahlkampf auf
Laschet Söder ist schuld dass Bayern und
Deutschland in dieser desaströsen Lage
ist
ich habe gesagt Munition wird geliefert
das heißt die AFD muss eigentlich gar
nichts tun legen und zu gucken wie die
anderen ihr Geschäft betreiben
die AFD tut was wir hören zu wir sind
viel auf dem Marktplätzen wir machen
Infostände wir hören die Menschen zu was
Ihnen auf dem Herzen liegt und wenn sie
wenn sie mal dabei sind wenn sie sich
das mal ansehen wie verzweifelt die
Menschen zum Teil sind weil sie die
Gasrechnung nicht mehr bezahlen können
oder letztens war ein Kind im
Bayerischen Landtag berichtet wir wissen
nicht mehr meine Eltern wenn wir
Samstags beim Einkaufen sind wir wissen
nicht mehr wie mir die Einkäufe bezahlen
können und so weiter solche Probleme
sind jetzt auch bei uns in Bayern wir
haben hier Menschen die müssen Flaschen
sammeln das ist erbärmlich und sowas
darf in dem eigentlich reichen Bayern
nicht sein wenn wir jetzt sehen ob die
AFD das irgendwann mal ändern kann
wahrscheinlich werden Sie auch weiterhin
in Bayern in der Opposition bleiben auch
wenn sie stärker sind als die Freien
Wähler ich bedanke mich bei Katrin Ebner
Steiner für das Interview so liebe
ZuschauerInnen Zuschauer jetzt geht
gleich weiter mit Katharina kühn und wie
es jetzt hier weitergeht auf dem
Parteitag
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und
hier im Saal sie werden es schon gehört
haben gibt es immer wieder großen
Applaus das liegt daran dass Andre
Ventura von der portugiesischen Partei
scheger gerade gesprächiger das heißt
auf portugiesische so ungefähr ist ist
genug er ist Abgeordneter im
portugiesischen Parlament und wir würden
Ihnen gerne die Rede zeigen allerdings
gibt es hier keine Übersetzung und das
ist dann etwas schwierig das spontan für
uns zu gestalten und deswegen nutzen wir
die Zeit und zeigen Ihnen noch einmal
die Rede des AFD ähm geschäftskino
propala seine Eröffnungsrede heute
morgen beim 14 Bundesparteitag der AFD
gerne ihr wisst alle wir haben ein
straffes Programm wir haben zwei
vollgepackte Wochenenden wir wollen
Programmarbeit leisten wir wollen unser
Verantwortung gerecht werden und den
Wählern hier auch zeigen für was für
stehen mit welchen Kandidaten wir stehen
und mit welchen Kandidaten wir zur
europawahlversammlung antreten wollen
also von daher bitte ich wirklich um
Disziplin und das ist auch der Aufruf
des gesamten Bundesvorstandes an sie an
euch dass wir diese zwei Wochenenden in
Disziplin in Einigkeit in Harmonie so
wie wir es das letzte Jahr bereits Leben
auch hier heute und nächste Woche
gestalten wollen liebe Freunde
ich möchte mich
bevor ich einige inhaltliche Punkte hier
ansprecher zuallererst natürlich bei den
Organisatoren auch noch denjenigen
bedanken von der Bundesgeschäftsstelle
die es möglich gemacht haben diesen
Bundesparteitag so auszuschaffieren und
auch diese Vorbereitung zu treffen was
mittlerweile in den heutigen Zeiten sehr
schwer und schwierig ist was viel Mühe
und Anstrengung bedeutet auch mit vielen
ehrenamtlichen Helfern für die ich mich
hier im Namen des gesamten
Bundesvorstandes bedanken möchte ich
möchte mich aber auch
gleich Wohlen
[Applaus]
bei der Polizei bedanken die uns und für
uns die Sicherheit hier gewährleistet
einer demokratische legitimierten Partei
diesen Parteitag hier zu ermöglichen
dass wir diesen hier auch durchführen
können und abhalten können dafür vielen
Dank an die Polizei für die Sicherheiten
auch für die nächsten Tage
ja und ich habe es eingangs gesagt wir
sind jetzt zehn Jahre alt hinter mir
stehts diese zehn Jahre heißen natürlich
auch für uns dass wir erwachsen geworden
sind mittlerweile sind wir nicht mit die
junge Partei wir sind eine
gesamtdeutsche eine neue Partei aber
nicht mit die junge Partei aber was
haben die erreicht wir haben keinen
Streit mehr in der Öffentlichkeit keine
entzweihung mehr in Sachfragen
stattdessen Harmonie und Einigkeit und
was wir damit erreichen können was wir
damit erreichen können
sehen wir in aktuellen Umfragen 22
Prozent bei Insa stärkste Partei in
Deutschland wenn man die Kleinstpartei
CSU abrechnet
[Applaus]
ja sogar in Baden-Württemberg sehen und
stehen wir laut einer swr-umfrage bei 19
Prozent und in den Umfragen
zur Europawahl stehen wir bei über 20
Prozent das zeigt wie der Erfolgskurs
der Bundespartei auf ganz Deutschland
ausstrahlt und allen Mitgliedern die
natürlich ihren Anteil haben unsere
Mitglieder unserer Partei zugute kommen
und auch für die vielen ehrenamtlichen
die überall für uns parteipolitisch
aktiv sind auf der Straße möchte ich
mich im Namen des gesamten
Bundesvorstands bedanken auch ihr habt
daran den größten Anteil vielen
herzlichen Dank
ich möchte mich aber auch gleich wohl an
den gesamten Bundesvorstand richten und
mich auch im Namen meiner
co-sprecherin Alice Weidel wenn gesamten
Bundesvorstand für die letzte für das
letzte Jahr bedanken was mit Harmonie in
unserem Bundesvorstand und der super
Zusammenarbeit die ich so vorher noch
nicht kannte wirklich darstellt und was
auch zum Erfolg dieser Partei
beigetragen hat
auch mit der Zusammenarbeit mit meiner
großsprecherin als
Fraktionsvorsitzende aber auch als
Bundessprecherin ich muss wirklich sagen
ich hätte nicht gedacht oder ich habe es
natürlich gedacht aber es hat sich
besser dargestellt als es jetzt
mittlerweile ist diese Harmonie werden
wir auch in die nächsten Wahlkämpfe
tragen und lieber alle ist ich danke dir
und ich freue mich auf die weitere
Zusammenarbeit für die anstehenden
Wahlkämpfe wir werden genau damit Erfolg
haben liebe Freunde
[Applaus]
aber Umfragen sind keine Ergebnisse auch
das muss man klar sagen was die Bürger
was die Wähler mittlerweile von uns
erwarten und was sie zurecht erwarten
dass wir diese Verantwortung natürlich
und dieser Verantwortung auch gerecht
werden das geht hier um Glaubwürdigkeit
und deshalb bitte ich auch alle darum
diese Umfragen auch mit ein Stück weit
Demo zu betrachten mit Demut zu nehmen
wir müssen genauso weitermachen wir
müssen weiter kämpfen der Kurs ist der
richtige das Personal ist das richtige
lasst uns gemeinsam genauso öffentlich
weiter nach vorne treten intern
diskutieren intern streiten das hat uns
stark gemacht und dazu sollten wir auch
weiter beitragen jeder für sich und auch
die nächsten Tage auf unseren Parteitag
und deswegen ist es wichtig und dürfen
wir uns auch auf diesen guten Werten
eben nicht ausruhen da wäre ich auch
immer wieder den Finger in die Wunde
legen genau das eben nicht zu tun in
Bayern und Hessen werden im Herbst neue
Landtage gewählt und nächstes Jahr
können wir in Sachsen Thüringen und
Brandenburg stärkste Kraftwerke können
Regierungsverantwortung übernehmen und
die Wände zum Guten bewirken wir sind
bereit für mehr das ist unser sloggen
dieses Parteitages
und wie ist eingangs sagte müssen wir
dabei eine Devise verfolgen genauso
weitermachen weiter so wir dürfen uns
nicht in zweien das könnte auch das
Motto übrigens des 14 Parteitages wie es
hinter mir steht auch sein und soll es
sein dieses weiter so der Weg den wir
seit Riesa gegangen sind ist genau der
richtige Weg wir haben uns nicht beirren
lassen und auch nicht durch irgendein
Berufe und Umfragen sollten wir uns auch
nicht beirren lassen es hieß wir hätten
unsere Potenziale ausgeschöpft es hieß
wir seien immer nur die dagegen Partei
nein liebe Freunde wir haben mit
Strategie und Programmarbeit haben wir
in kurzer Zeit genau neue Potenziale
erschöpft wir haben gezeigt dass wir die
dafür Partei sind und auf der Seite der
Zukunft stehen die anderen sind von
gestern wir sind von morgen und das
erkennen immer mehr Bürger in diesem
Land liebe Freunde
ja und sogar Friedrich Merz will
mittlerweile lieber Parteichef der AFD
sein
er nennt er nennt die CDU eine
Alternative für Deutschland mit Substanz
und kürzlich sagte er noch dazu im
Sommer Interview ich zitiere es gibt
eine Regierung und es gibt zu dieser
Regierung natürlich eine Alternative für
Deutschland ja Herr Merz da haben sie
natürlich vollkommen Recht diese
Alternative die gibt es und ich bin
stolz ihr bundesprecher zu sein aber
diese Alternative ist einzigartig und
unnahmlich wir sind das Original liebe
Freunde und niemand anderes
und Friedrich Merz hat es richtig
erkannt es war falsch eine Brandmauer zu
unserer Partei zu errichten es war
falsch für Deutschland und vor allen
Dingen auch falsch für die CDU durch die
Brandmauer hat sich März auf Koalitionen
festgelegt die unserem Land Schaden wer
Brandmauern baut lieber Herr Merz bleibt
ein Gefangener grüner Ideologie und das
merken immer mehr Menschen in diesem
Land
und nicht umsonst stemmt sich grünen
Chefin Ricarda lang mit vollen Gewicht
allen Versuchen entgegen die Mauer
umzuwerfen aber die Bürger haben genug
von den Grünen sie haben genug von Krieg
und sanierungszwang von
d-industrialisierung und deshalb rufe
ich allen Patrioten in der CDU zu reist
diese schwarz-grüne Mauer nieder
wir sollten aber nicht den Fehler
begehen uns auf die CDU als einzige
Koalitionsoption festzulegen wir
koalieren mit jedem und das sage ich
ausdrücklich der bereit ist Politik im
Interesse der Bürger zu machen mit
Interesse für diejenigen die es gut mit
Deutschland die ist gut mit unserem Land
meinen und das bedeutet aber auch wir
schließen ganz klar eine Koalition mit
den Grünen aus liebe Freunde
[Applaus]
denn eins ist Fakt und eins ist klar und
auch das sehen immer mehr Bürger in
diesem Land die Grünen sind die
gefährlichste Partei Deutschlands das
zeigen sie in ihrer Regierungsarbeit sie
wollen aus einer Industrienation ein
Trümmerfeld machen sie wollen
einfamilienhaussiedlungen in Bund der
Plattenbauten umbauen sie wollen den
Bürger den Saft abdrehen und die
Identität nehmen die Grünen wollen Krieg
mit Russland und mit China dieses Grün
liebe Freunde ist nicht grasgrün sondern
olivgrün und blau und grün gehen nicht
zusammen das zeigt sich
wir sind Protest und programmpartei
gegen eine weiße Regierungspolitik gehen
wir mit den Bürgern zusammen auf die
Straße und bringen auf dem Bürgerwillen
in die Parlamente das war immer unsere
Aufgabe als Alternative für Deutschland
darauf bin ich stolz und diese
straßenbewegung werden wir auch
weiterhin vollumfänglich unterstützen
weil genau das ist unser wichtigstes Ohr
in die Bürgerschaft in das Volk und
darauf bin ich stolz und das werden wir
auch weiterhin forcieren und vertreten
liebe Freunde
wir haben erfolgreich gegen Impfpflicht
und lockdowns demonstriert mit 100.000
Bürgern haben wir die Impfpflicht
abgewendet während des ukrainekriegs
demonstrieren wir gegen Kriegstreiberei
und Waffenlieferungen und für Frieden
durch Verhandlungen und dabei
präsentieren wir und repräsentieren wir
die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung im
Deutschen Bundestag ja wir sind das Volk
liebe Freunde
aber wir tun noch viel mehr wir
formulieren Konzepte für eine bessere
Politik für eine echte Politik Wende als
einzige Partei in Deutschland vertreten
wir eine interessengeleitete Politik das
sind unsere Alleinstellungsmerkmale und
nicht nur die Fehler der anderen
Parteien das merken immer mehr Bürger
dass wir uns um das weh und Wohl unserer
Bürger kümmern dass wir für Deutschland
kämpfen dass wir die wirkliche einzige
Alternative für Deutschland sind denn
wir sagen Politik muss die Interessen
der Bürger verfolgen wir müssen uns um
gute Beziehungen mit alle Ländern der
Welt kümmern und bemühen anstatt ihnen
westliche Werte aufzuzwingen wir sagen
nein zu Wirtschaftskrieg und Sanktionen
und ja zu freien und friedlichen Handel
mit aller Welt wir fordern das andere
Länder unsere Lebensweise respektieren
umgekehrt lassen wir aber auch andere
Länder so leben wie sie es für richtig
halten und wie Sie es wollen das nenne
ich Respekt und nur darauf lässt sich
eine friedliche Ordnung aufbauen Respekt
und Frieden statt Einmischung und Krieg
und genau diese Werte geleitete Politik
der Grünen ist respektlos und verletzt
die Interessen der Bürger die Grünen
wollen andere Ländern erklären wie sie
zu leben haben bundesaußenministerin
bärburg beweist es ja immer wieder in
ihren außen und Auslandsreisen und sie
wird immer häufiger von Staatschefs oder
von ihren Amtskollegen gar nicht mehr
persönlich empfangen etwa in Brasilien
oder auch in Südafrika offenbar hält sie
das Auswärtige Amt mittlerweile für eine
nicht Regierungsorganisation für
feministische Außenpolitik und genau das
ist falsch
genau das ist falsch ein Außenminister
Deutschlands muss allen Staaten mit
allen Staaten respektvoll umgehen das
erwarten wir von einem deutschen
Außenminister diese Werte geleitete
Außenpolitik hat Deutschland in den
Ukraine kriegt mit hineingezogen ansteht
neutral zu vermitteln hat die andere
Regierung einseitig Stellung für den
Westen bezogen sie missachtet die
Sicherheitsinteressen Russlands und tut
so als wäre der Krieg 2022 aus heiterem
Himmel ausgebrochen dabei haben genau
unsere vorgehenden
Kanzler wie zum Beispiel exkanzlerin
Angela Merkel und Ex-Präsident Francois
doch zugegeben dass minsker-abkommen
hatte 2015 vor allem einen Zweck Zeit zu
schaffen Zeit zu schaffen um die Ukraine
für den Krieg aufzurüsten jetzt sterben
junge Ukrainer in deutschen Panzern im
Kampf gegen Russland das wir Freunde ist
eine Tragödie und ich fordere
ich fordere Respekt für die Ukraine
ebenso wie Respekt für Russland tatsache
ist nämlich auch dass wir nicht mehr
günstiges Gas aus Russland importieren
ist eben keine Reaktion auf den Ukraine
kriegt Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck hat den Krieg zum Anlass genommen
um die Importe zu stoppen aber er hat
dieses Ziel bereits 2016 verkündet und
zwar Zitat weil wir ein Energiewende
Land sind und ohne den Krieg hätten die
Bürger aber nicht hingenommen dass wir
die Lebensader unserer Industrie
durchtrennen das wusste er jetzt liegt
nordstream gesprengt von den USA und
Norwegen oder von der Ukraine auf dem
Meeresgrund und wir importieren teures
dreckiges trekkinggas aus Amerika die
Ampelkoalition hat das Verbot von Gas
und Ölheizungen beschlossen und was
macht die EU
die plant den wärmepumpenzwang für alle
Mitgliedstaaten und hier muss ich noch
mal an die doppelzinglichkeit und die
Doppelmoral der CDU anknüpfen Herr März
sagt er ist gegen dieses Öl und
heizungsverbot was macht aber seine
Kollegin Ursula von der Leyen in Brüssel
in Sachsen plakatiert die CDU
heizungsverbot stoppen was für eine
Doppelmoral genau die gleichen Politiker
wollen dieses Gesetz sogar noch
verschärft im EU-Parlament durchsetzen
und genau dagegen müssen wir auch auf
europäischer Ebene vorgehen und diese
Doppelmoral benennen
und dann schauen wir uns die Geldflüsse
an schauen wir uns die Profiteure an
dieser ganzen Gesetzgebung es ist zum
Beispiel Carrier global der US-Konzern
der das wärmepumpengeschäft des
deutschen Familienunternehmens Viessmann
gekauft hat in havix
Wirtschaftsministerium läuft genau
dieser grüne Sumpf zusammen eine frühere
Blackrock Mitarbeiterin leitet die
Grundsatzabteilung Staatssekretäre
kommen aus dem Netzwerk des us-investors
hellhörig deswegen legen wir den sumpfen
wenn es die Medien nicht schaffen muss
ist die Alternative für Deutschland
machen das ist unsere Aufgabe
und wir sehen es wir sehen es in
Deutschland wir sehen es an unseren
Unternehmen diese grüne Energiewende
macht Energie unerschwinglich und
zerstört unsere Industrie sie macht die
Bürger Arm und führt uns in einseitig
Abhängigkeit vom Westen die Beziehung
auf dem Kontinent Europa sind
mittlerweile unterbrochen im Kontinent
steckt ein Keil die USA haben den Keil
in den Kontinent getrieben und die
polnische Regierung treibt ihn mit einer
aggressiven Politik gegenüber
Deutschland und Russland immer tiefer
hinein und unsere Aufgabe liebe Freunde
besteht darin diesen Teil zu entfernen
wir müssen das Netz an Lebensadern und
Transportwegen in Europa und Asien
erneuern das und nichts anderes sind wir
der Welt Schuldige Freunde
ja und nach Russland wollen die Grünen
sich nun China vorknöpfen die Pläne für
einen Wirtschaftskrieg mit China liegen
schon längst in den Schubladen der
Grünen Ministerien nicht nur von Gas und
ölausrüstung sondern auch von Rohstoffen
und Hightech unseres wichtigsten
Handelspartners sollen wir uns
abschneiden lassen und warum um den
geostrategischen Zielen der USA
vorauseilen zu dienen die Ampel hat nun
jetzt eine china-strategie
veröffentlicht diese Strategie trägt
glücklicherweise nicht nur die
Handschrift der Grünen aufwendige
investitionsprüfungen China sind nicht
vorgesehen und eine Abkopplung auch
nicht gut so muss man dazu erstmal sagen
diese Fragen
so kommt von strategischer Bedeutung und
oftmals wichtiger als die Frage welcher
Parteienfamilie rechnet sich ein
Politiker zu das sage ich ja ganz
deutlich und deshalb auch im
Europaparlament geht es häufig um
Handelsabkommen um Lieferketten die
wertepolitiker mit
menschenrechtsvorbehalten verschießen
wollen das ist nicht im Interesse
deutscher Bürger liebe Freunde und
dieses Interesse steht im Zweifel auch
über Fraktionsdisziplin jeder
Wirtschafts-
auch wenn wir unser 14 Bundesparteitag
im Zeichen der Europa Listenwahl die
morgen ja beginnt steht haben wir heute
eine Vielzahl von wichtigen
Satzungsänderungen auf den Weg zu
bringen wir haben bundesschiedsrichter
und Rechnungsprüfer zu wählen wir sind
in den letzten zwei Jahren zu einer
wichtigen Kraft in Europa geworden wir
haben in Europa wertvolle Zeit verloren
auch das müssen wir selbstkritisch
einräumen wir als Partei um einen kurzen
Ausblick auf das bevorstehende
Wochenende zu geben noch paar
abschließende Worte dazu der Erfolgskurs
der Bundespartei ist in Brüssel eben
noch nicht vollständig angekommen die
Politik der europa-delegation liebt zu
lange der Meuten Ära verhaftet was wir
im Bund und in den Ländern erreicht
haben das müssen wir jetzt nach der
Europawahl 24 auch ins Europäische
Parlament tragen und auch diese Ziele
dort erreichen wir müssen Politik machen
die allein an den Interessen der Bürger
orientiert ist dazu ist eine
generationwechsel
notwendig und die heutige EU ist mit
Frau von der Leyen federführend in einer
desaströsen Migrationspolitik und mit
wirtschaftsfeindlichen
sanktionspolitiken dafür steht diese EU
unter der Präsidentin denn die werden
nämlich genau dort gemacht 11
sanktionspakete gegen Russland wurden
beschlossen sie alle Schaden im Bürgern
in der EU mehr als Russland und das
haben wir von Anfang an kritisiert und
bemängelt und die Schaden vor allem
Deutschland zuallererst und wir sehen
die Zahlen der IWF kognostiziert das
mittlerweile und sagt es auch dass die
deutsche Wirtschaft weiter schrumpfen
wird die hohen Energiepreise zerstören
Existenzen und haha Weg spricht allen
Ernstes von German Angst wir Freunde das
ist die verächtlichungmachung des
Bundeswirtschaftsministers gegenüber der
deutschen Wirtschaft der Industrie der
kmuos den Frieden fleißigen Handwerkern
letztlich von uns allen und deshalb rufe
ich auch hier heute deutlich alle
Interessenverbände
handwerkerverbände Industrieverbände auf
sich endlich lauthals dagegen zu wehren
die Zeit der Kompromisse ist vorbei sie
werden die Kurs sonst nicht ändern
[Gelächter]
denn fest steht auch Sanktionen
schädigen dauerhaft die guten
Beziehungen zwischen Nationalstaaten
machen wir also nicht den Fehler auch
hier Russlands zu früh abzuschreiben in
Südamerika Afrika und Asien entziehen
sie Staaten mittlerweile diesen
Sanktionen sie gründen neue
Organisationen und setzen der unipolaren
Weltordnung eine multipolare entgegen in
dieser Ordnung wird Russland auch in
Zukunft eine wichtige Rolle spielen und
deswegen sage ich auch hier deutlich ja
zur Diplomatie aber auch hier muss man
bei aller berechtigter Kritik am besten
eingestehen das auch Russland bislang
Angebote zu Vermittlungen und
Verhandlungen beispielsweise von China
nicht wahrgenommen hat jedoch ist dieser
gegenseitige Respekt in einer
multipolaren Welt unabdingbar denn
Multipolarität bedeutet nicht mehr eine
einzige Weltmacht beherrscht die Welt
mit ihren Werten sondern mehrere
gleichberechtigte Mächte setzen in ihren
Regionen ihre Vorstellungen von Recht
und Ordnung durch und deshalb früher
oder später wird diese multipolare
Weltordnung auch Europa erreichen und
dann bietet sich die Gelegenheit
einseitige Abhängigkeiten abzustreifen
und neue Optionen zu eröffnen wollen wir
dann
wollen wir dann diejenigen sein die
Brücken gesprengt haben oder wollen wir
diejenigen sein die Brücken gebaut haben
wir wollen das Alternative für
Deutschland Brücken erhalten Brücken
aufbauen das ist unsere Vision für
Europa und dafür kämpfen wir auch im
EU-Parlament
und wir dürfen vor allem die nationale
Frage und die europäische Frage eben
nicht länger getrennt betrachten wenn
wir in Deutschland die Wände zum Guten
bewirken wollen dann müssen wir unsere
Arbeit im Bundestag in den
Landesparlamenten und in den kommunalen
Räten in Brüssel und Straßburg auch dazu
flankieren es wird nämlich keine Wende
in nur einem einzelnen Staat Europas
geben entweder europa-staaten erlangen
gemeinsam die volle Souveränität zurück
und bestimmen wieder selbst über ihre
Geschicke oder europa bleibt in Gänze
ein Anhängsel des Westens das ist die
bittere Wahrheit liebe Freunde meine
Damen und Herren in der wir uns stellen
müssen Europa Politik ist von enormer
Bedeutung hast du einen Opa dann schicke
Ihnen noch Europa so hieß es mal diese
Devise gilt aber schon lange nicht mehr
in Brüssel laufen wie unter dem
Brennglas die weltpolitischen
Entwicklungen zusammen die auch unsere
Politik in Berlin in Dresden in Erfurt
in Mainz in Wiesbaden oder in München
beeinflussen
wollen wir mit unserem erfolgshaus auch
einer Alternative für Europa sein und
werden dann müssen wir in Straßburg und
Brüssel unsere Interessen geleitete
Politik vital und selbstbewusst
vertreten deshalb lasst uns auch die
nächsten zwei Wochenenden kämpfen dafür
für dieses europawahlprogramm für unsere
Kandidaten aber auch auf unserem
Bundesparteitag für Freiheit für
Souveränität für Frieden wir sind bereit
liebe Freunde vielen herzlichen Dank
der Chef der AFD kinoprophaler heute
morgen hat er hier den 14
Bundesparteitag der AFD eröffnet wir
sind mittendrin im Parteitag und hier
stehen noch einige Änderungen an zum
Beispiel soll die Satzung geändert
werden hier unter anderem geht es darum
wie
Mitgliedsbeiträge gezahlt werden sollen
was passiert wird wenn man sie nicht
zahlt und zu welchem Zeitpunkt zum
Beispiel man dazu Träger sie zahlen
sollen die auf die scheint gut im
Zeitplan zu sein so scheint es uns wir
haben hier während des Parteitags
natürlich auch einige Gespräche geführt
und da möchten wir Ihnen gerne noch eins
zeigen und zwar hat Alexander Keller mit
Robert Lambo gesprochen den
Spitzenkandidaten der AFD für die
Landtagswahl in Hessen
sie eigentlich neidisch auf die
Spitzenkandidaten der AFD in Sachsen
Thüringen für nächstes Jahr denn wir
könnten ja den Einzug in die
Staatskanzlei schaffen das würde man in
Hessen wahrscheinlich kaum erwarten
hallo Herr Keller vielen Dank für die
Einladung ich freue mich dass ich
Spitzenkandidat in Hessen bin das ist
meine Wahlheimat ich bin seit 2008 in
Hessen erst in Frankfurt und jetzt seit
zehn Jahren schon in Wiesbaden also ich
fühle mich pudelwohl für die AFD in
Hessen der Spitzenkandidat zu sein
anders als in Thüringen wird es aber
wahrscheinlich keine Möglichkeit geben
die bisherige Koalition aus Schwarz-Grün
oder Jamaika sozusagen zu verhindern da
sind sie weit davon entfernt jetzt ist
ja die Frage gerade in den westlichen
Bundesländern auch wenn ihre Umfrage
Ergebnisse gerade ziemlich gut sind die
wollen sie sich da profilieren da haben
sie doch noch Luft nach oben wenn Sie
sich mit den ostdeutschen
Landesverbänden vergleichen also die
Umfragewerte in Ostdeutschland und in
Westdeutschland die sind hauptsächlich
deswegen unterschiedlich weil in
Ostdeutschland halt viele Menschen noch
die DDR erlebt haben und die haben viel
feinere Antenne für Entwicklungen die
ins Negative gehen wir sehen aber auch
jetzt bei den bundesweiten Umfragen wo
die AFD mittlerweile stabil egal welches
meinungsinstitut bei 20% oder mehr steht
dass ich gerade in Westdeutschland
gewaltig etwas bewegt und wie weit das
noch trägt das ist gar nicht abzusehen
sagen die feineren Antennen der Menschen
in Ostdeutschland wegen ihrer
ddr-sozialisation das heißt die im
Westen haben gar nicht nur noch nicht so
richtig begriffen was eigentlich gut für
sie ist gerade was die Politik der AFD
angeht also meine Wahrnehmung ist dass
es sich gerade in Westdeutschland für
die Partei dreht wir haben eine
unglaubliche Mitglieder Eintrittswelle
und der Schwerpunkt dieser
Eintrittswelle der legt auf den
westdeutschen Landesverbänden deswegen
ist es schwer zu sagen wie sich die
Wahlergebnisse am 8 Oktober darstellen
werden bisher hat halt gegolten dass die
Ostdeutschen da wesentlich kritischer
waren wesentlich feinen Antennen hatten
aber ich glaube dass viele westdeutsche
Bürger aufgewacht sind die Energiepreise
sind mit die höchsten in Europa und der
Welt und eine Mehrheit der Menschen ist
für den Weiterbetrieb von
Kernkraftwerken die AFD ist fast die
einzige Partei die diese politische
Position vertritt
wenn man von dem bundesweiten
Wahlergebnissen ausgeht dass hätte die
hessische um die hessischen Umfragen
sind nicht weit weg davon ich meine ich
bundesweite Wahlergebnisse sondern
Umfragen so um die 20 knapp unter 20%
heißt ja das auch 80% eben nicht AFD
wählen wollen
die Wahrnehmung der AFD gerade im Westen
ist noch nicht so stark wie im Osten da
gehört sie ja sozusagen zu den ganzen
gesellschaftlichen Abläufen im Westen
doch nicht so sehr liegt das vielleicht
auch daran dass für manche weiß ist die
Ostdeutschen Landesverbände zu radikal
sind oder zu radikal daherkommen also
ich sehe in Ostdeutschland dass die 40
Jahre
unterschiedlicher Sozialisation einfach
auch ein bisschen unterschiedliche
Mentalitäten hervorgebracht haben und
wenn sie bei den anderen Parteien gucken
sind die Ostdeutschen Landesverbände
dort auch ein bisschen kerniger das ist
keine Spezialität der Alternative für
Deutschland
jetzt scheint ja bei der AFD auch etwas
Partylaune zu herrschen nicht nur weil
heute Abend noch zehn Jahre AFD gefeiert
wird sondern auch wegen der guten
Umfrageergebnisse auch wegen der Fehler
die die Konkurrenz im Umgang mit der AFD
macht diese Gefahr dass die Partei
möglicherweise da etwas zu euphorisch
wird auch zu selbstgefällig zu sie
gesichert und das böse Erwachen kommen
dann am Wahlabend also Wahlumfragen sind
keine Wahlergebnisse das ist etwas was
die Grünen ja immer wieder erleben die
da sehr überschätzt werden und dann
Wahlabend viel geringer abschneiden
ich bespreche mit meinen Kollegen schon
seit längerem dass
Wahlumfragen in dieser Höhe wie wir sie
in Hessen haben erst einmal eine enorme
Verpflichtung sind da sind viele
Menschen die setzen ihre Hoffnungen in
uns die haben sehr stark das Gefühl dass
es gegen sie geht das immer weniger Geld
im Geldbeutel bei ihnen übrig bleibt
dass sie oft nicht mehr wissen
Monatsende wie sie sich das Geld
einteilen sollen die Energiekosten sind
hoch sie sehen bei der Ampel das wenig
Rücksicht genommen wird und sagen dann
wähle ich jetzt mal die Alternative für
Deutschland und dieser Verantwortung das
ist ganz ganz wichtig der müssen wir uns
dann auch als gerecht erweisen Boris
rein der Spitzen kann ja der Union und
amtierende Ministerpräsident der hat ja
gesagt die Brandmauer zu AFD steht er
meinte natürlich in der ersten die
Landespolitik sollte jetzt zum Beispiel
was ja nicht unwahrscheinlich ist
Schwarz-Grün keine Mehrheit mehr haben
nach der Wahl werden Sie Boris rein
trotz dieser Absage und dem Stühlen vor
die Tür stellen sondern die Jungs
Gespräche anbieten also erst einmal gilt
es war in Deutschland noch nie eine gute
Idee Mauern zu errichten
Boris rein hat von uns einige Themen
übernommen er möchte die
Grunderwerbsteuer in Hessen
reduzieren er ist für den Weiterbetrieb
oder die Wiedereinstieg in die Kernkraft
grundsätzlich in vielen Punkten in einer
Richtung wo ich ganz klar sage das kann
er inhaltlich am besten mit der AFD in
Hessen Umsetzen in einer Neuauflage der
schwarz-grünen Koalition eher nicht und
insofern ist es eine Frage ob er sich
von solchen ideologischen
Überlegungen löst und dann ist die
Alternative für Deutschland eigentlich
thematisch am dichtesten bei seinen
politischen Vorstellungen dran aber er
hat die Brandmauer gerade erneut
bekräftigt ja wenn Boris rein genau
schaut dann gibt es auch in Hessen
bereits auf kommunaler Ebene die ein
oder andere Zusammenarbeit zwischen der
CDU und der AFD
das Interview mit Robert Lambro dem
Vorsitzenden der Landtagsfraktion in
Hessen und auch der Spitzenkandidat der
AFD für die Landtagswahl in Hessen
hier ähm der Halle in Magdeburg steht
gerade wieder eine Wahl an wir sind
immer noch bei der Wahl der
bundesschiedsrichter und ein Ergebnis
möchte ich Ihnen gerne nachtragen es
geht um den 2 Bundesliga da hatten sich
Nils Rosengarten und Gerald Hohmann
beworben und die kann die die
Delegierten haben für Gerald Hohmann
gestimmt so dass er nun zweiter
bundesschiedsrichter der AFD ist nun
geht es um die dritte Position
da sind gerade schon die Wahlhelferinnen
und Wahlhelfer in den Saal gekommen
wieder sehr gut erkennbaren orangenen
Westen und werden nun bei dieser Wahl
behilflich sein
ich habe es schon mal gesagt ein
Parteien Schiedsgericht und ein Partei
Schiedsgericht ist
notwendig das Parteiengesetz
verpflichtet Parteien dazu ein
Schiedsgericht einzurichten das ist zur
Schlichtung von Streitigkeiten und
natürlich auch bei der Entscheidung
relevant oft geht es um Partei
schädigendes Verhalten und bis zur
Entscheidung ob ein
parteiausschussverfahren
rechtens ist ob ein Mitglied
ausgeschlossen wird
die AFD hat sich darauf geeinigt dass
hier jeder der sich vorstellen kann vier
Minuten hat auch zwei Fragen beantworten
kann
und auch obwohl sie hier
die Richtlinien die Ansprüche an die
bundesschiedsrichter geändert hat so
fragt sie doch alle Kandidierenden noch
ob diese in der Vergangenheit oder
aktuell eine bezahlte Tätigkeit für
einen Mitglied ein des Europäischen
Parlaments oder z.B eines Landrat eines
des Bundestages
die Frage
bei der Wahl wird auch darauf geachtet
ob jemand einen Volljurist ist pro kann
man darf maximal eine Person nicht
Volljurist sein es gibt drei Kammern bei
ersatzrichtern ist das nicht relevant
aber bei diesem Platz ist es noch
wichtig
und es wird auch auf den länderproports
geachtet insgesamt dürfen maximal drei
Richter aus einem Landesverband kommen
sie werden eventuell es schon gesehen
haben an den Bannern die hier aus liegen
und auch an den
diversen Flyern dass die AFD 10 Jahre
Partei Bestehen feiert am 14 April 2013
war der Gründungsparteitag mit Bernd
Lucke Konrad Adam und Alexander gauland
besonders Bernd Lucke wird vielen im
Gedächtnis geblieben sein erst Partei
Vorsitzender und Aushängeschild der
Partei damals noch ganz klar als Partei
die sich hauptsächlich gegen die
gemeinsame europäische Währung stellt
und gegen die gemeinsame Europa
Rettungspolitik
und der dann ausgetreten ist genauso wie
die Parteivorsitzenden Frauke Petry und
Jörg Meuthen die mittlerweile nicht mehr
teilt der Alternative für Deutschland
sind
vor zehn Jahren waren 1500 Mitglieder im
Hotel Intercontinental in Berlin
darunter auch viele ehemalige CDU und
FDP Anhänger
und
heute sind hier in Magdeburg
600 Delegierte eingeladen worden es sind
nicht alle gekommen
Delegierte wurden hier angesagt sind
hier stimmberechtigt angemeldet und
stimmen hier über satzungsfragen ab und
momentan eben gerade über die Person die
dem bundesheetsgericht in Zukunft
angehören sollen man versucht sich an
den Zeitplan zu halten denn heute Abend
möchte die Partei noch ihr zehnjähriges
Jubiläum feiern
morgen früh soll es dann trotzdem aber
pünktlich um 10 Uhr wieder weitergehen
dann ist nicht mehr Bundesparteitag
sondern dann ist die
europawahlversammlung der AFD da geht es
dann um die Kandidierenden und das
Programm für die Europawahl 2024
die Delegierten sind hier noch bei der
Wahl und
weil eben heute hier auch zehn Jahre AFD
gefeiert wird möchte ich auch schon mal
darauf hinweisen auf ein Interview dass
wir in ca einer halben Stunde führen
werden mag yongen ist einer der
Mitglieder der Partei der auch schon
seit
2013 hier aktiv in der Partei ist ist
auch Mitglied des Bundestags gegen 17:30
Uhr wird Alexander Keller in
interviewen und während ihr die Wahl
läuft möchten wir ganz gerne noch einmal
auf eine Debatte schauen die doch schon
im Vorfeld für viel Diskussionsstoff
gesorgt hat denn die AFD hat heute
darüber abgestimmt ob sie sich einer
europäischen Partei anschließen möchte
der Partei Identität und Demokratie
dieses Programm entspricht in vollem
Umfang unsere Ausrichtung
es lehnt die Bildung eines
eu-superstaates vehement ab
betont die Souveränität der
Nationalstaaten und Völker
wendet sich gegen unkontrollierte
Zuwanderung
und will die Identität der Völker und
Nationen Europas bewahren
und schließlich
sollte in Zukunft wirklich irgendeines
der heute von manchen
befürchteten Gespenster vom Dachboden
herabsteigen und Wirklichkeit werden
dann können wir als AFD nach einem
entsprechenden
Parteitagsbeschluss auch jederzeit aus
dieser idee-partei wieder austreten
was aber spricht nun für einen Beitritt
im Vordergrund steht die weitere
Vernetzung mit unseren europäischen
Schwesterparteien
insbesondere mit solchen
die schon in ihren Ländern
Regierungsverantwortung übernommen haben
oder übernehmen werden
mit Ihnen wollen wir gemeinsame
Politiken entwickeln und im
Europaparlament und in den nationalen
Parlamenten umsetzen
gegen uns stehen gewaltige
Organisationen
fast unbegrenzte Finanz- und
Propagandamittel und hier in Deutschland
mit dem sogenannten Verfassungsschutz
auch noch einen ganz offensichtlich
missbrauchter Geheimdienst
es kann nur hilfreich sein in diesen
Kämpfen Verbündete zu haben
die Idee Partei erhält zweitens
erhebliche Finanzmittel aus dem
EU-Haushalt zur Umsetzung ihres
Programms dass ich ihnen gerade auch
schon vorgestellt habe und zwar abhängig
von der Anzahl der Europaabgeordneten
ihrer mitgliedsparteien
warum bitte sollen wir diese
Möglichkeiten nicht für unsere
politischen Ziele nutzen
die einst Neigel voraus für seine
brexit-kampagne
und sollte die EU eines Tages
tatsächlich
transnationale Listen teilweise oder
sogar ausschließlich für die
Europawahlen einführen dann hätten wir
als Mitglied der id-partei zumindest
eine Teilnahme Option
und deshalb bitte der Bundesvorstand sie
dem Beitritt zur idee-partei zuzustimmen
vielen Dank
vielen Dank an Herrn Dr Hartwig für die
Begründung des Antrags SN1 für den
Bundesvorstand wie schon angekündigt am
Anfang zwar dagegen argumentiert aber
dann doch für den Bundesvorstand also
argumentiert die dass die afd-fraktion
der Partei Identität und Demokratie
beitreten soll
meine Damen und Herren wir haben jetzt
viele Vorteile gehört für diesen Antrag
aber die muss man revidieren wir haben
heute viel vom Europa der Vaterländer
gehört das ist unsere Position die
wollen wir auch weiterhin nach außen
tragen ist uns aber dann bewusst dass
die Satzung die eigentlich gar keine
Satzung muss ein querverordnung unter
der Prämisse EU-Verordnung
204 und 2003 sich darunter unterwirft
das heißt wir anerkennen diese EU und
wollen sie das tatsächlich dass wir
unsere Glaubwürdigkeit als exit-
[Musik]
wollen wir uns dem schlöten Mammon
unterwerfen wie damals in Erfurt wo uns
erzählt wurde eine Stiftung bekommt viel
Geld vom Bund bis heute sind keine
Gelder geflossen die Frage stellt sich
wollen wir wieder in die gleiche Falle
treten nur um diese Idee zu verfolgen
und dann frage ich die Antragstellerin
warum diese Satzung nicht hier
diskutiert wurde der it-partei sondern
sie wurde nur mehr oder weniger
hervorgehoben und warum hat die IDE
Partei eine Woche vor diesen Parteitag
Ihre Homepage abgeschaltet damit man die
Ziele lesen kann und jeder der hier über
Ziele spricht kann die gar nicht
vorweisen es gibt nur eine Antwerpener
Resolution die ganz andere Werte aufruft
als die hier vorgeführten deshalb meine
Damen und Herren diese idee-partei ist
eine schlechte Idee und muss auch nicht
vollzogen werden wir verlieren unsere
Glaubwürdigkeit und die Glaubwürdigkeit
ist die einzige Position die uns jetzt
in den letzten Jahren nach vorne
gebracht hat nach vorne gebracht auf die
Position nämlich 22 Prozent zu erreichen
bundesweit und in jedem Bundesländern
geht es aufwärts und jetzt stelle ich
die Frage wollen wir uns tatsächlich
einem Zentralstaat wegen einem stöden
Mammuts unterwerfen ich denke das
sollten wir nicht tun die Argumente
gegen diese idee-partei
für die idee-partei sind keine tragenden
Argumente und sie gehören mehr oder
weniger
ins Abseits noch eine andere Wirkung
diese Entscheidung ist so weitragend
dass ich meine dass dort eine zwei
Drittel Mehrheit
bindend ist vielen Dank
Emil Sense war das Vorsitzender der AFD
in Baden-Württemberg und damit starten
jetzt mit der Aussprache der Delegierten
Mikrofon in dem Fall rot weiter bitte
sehr sicher Liebe
[Musik]
Freunde harte Kämpfe gefochten in der
Vergangenheit um eine Alternative für
Deutschland zu bleiben Lücke wollte
unsere Ideale verraten um uns
koalitionsfähig zu machen Petri auch und
auch Meuthen und es waren harte Kämpfe
die wir gemeinsam gefochten haben weil
wir uns nicht an andere Parteien oder
Gruppierungen Anbietern wollen weil wir
wirklich für Souveränität Freiheit und
Demokratie einstehen und ist da keine
Kompromisse und keine Anbiederung geben
darf
die anderen Parteien bestehen aus
Europäern und setzen sich für Europa ein
wir die AFD sind die einzige Partei die
von ihrem Selbstverständnis her sich aus
Deutschen besetzt und sich für
Deutschland einsetzt wir liebe Freunde
sind der Anwalt des deutschen Volkes
wir stehen für unsere Kinder unser Land
und unsere Mitbürger bedingungslos ein
wir stehen momentan bei über 20 Prozent
weil wir geradlinig sind und nicht
käuflich und jetzt sollen wir unseren
Markenkern aufgeben eine rein deutsche
Partei zu sein die kompromisslos für die
deutschen Eintritt wir sollen uns
verkaufen nur weil irgendwer in Brüssel
mit dem checkbuch winkt damit wir
demnächst ein paar Flyer mit einem Logo
der Idee die in Deutschland eh keiner
kennt verteilen können vielleicht noch
mit einer Widmung gesponsert durch die
EU liebe Freunde geht noch wir sind die
Alternative für Deutschland nicht die
Alternative für Europa treten wir eine
europäischen Partei bei und das weiß
jeder von euch der Partei Erfahrung hat
dann muss man Kompromisse an die anderen
Mitglieder in dieser Partei machen
die Mehrheit dominiert in Parteien immer
die Minderheit und jeder Kompromiss und
das muss ganz klar gesagt werden jeder
Kompromiss den wir dort machen ist ein
Verrat an den deutschen Wäldern
wir wollen die EU nicht und wir wollen
nicht unsere Seele führen paar Almosen
aus Brüssel verkaufen liebe Freunde
lasst uns die Alternative für
Deutschland bleiben der Anwalt des
deutschen Volkes und dazu passt auch
dass jeder Delegierte hier einen Button
gekriegt hat unser Land zuerst lasst
unser Land zuerst weiterhin unser Motto
sein vielen Dank
vielen Dank
aus Bayern aus dem Landesverband Bayern
hier mit einer Rede gegen den Eintritt
wurde ist wir würden uns verkaufen wenn
man einer europäischen Partei beitreten
eine europäischen Partei ist zum
Beispiel jemand wie ein beigetreten man
kann ihn glaube ich vieles unterstellen
aber man kann ihn ganz bestimmt nicht
unterstellen dass sie sich an die EU
verkauft hat
und es ist ehrlich gesagt auch ziemlich
unverschämt dass unseren Freunden
national oder von der FPÖ zu
unterstellen die immer
die immer das will ich mal betonen an
unserer Seite gestanden sind von Anfang
an als wir noch eine kleine unbedeutende
Splitterpartei waren bis heute und was
ist das für ein Zeichen dass wir heute
setzen dass wir sagen nein mit euch
wollen wir nicht zusammenarbeiten meine
Damen und das wäre unverantwortlich es
wäre dumm
und es wäre der größte gefallen den wir
unseren Gegnern und den Altparteien in
Deutschland und Europa machen können wir
brauchen starke Partner alleine können
wir Europa nicht verändern vielen Dank
danke schön
für Vorwände Debatte fortfahren
kein Antrag dann am roten samenmikrofon
noch mal bitte sehr
meine Partei meine Lieben Partei von ich
kann den Vorredner nur zustimmen wir
sind nicht alleine in Europa
wir sollen ein Europa der Vaterländer
und darum müssen wir mit den anderen
Parteien in Europa zusammenarbeiten also
Courage ist das beste Beispiel dafür
dass der die Europäische Union die
Möglichkeiten dort genutzt hat um die
Souveränität seines Landes
wiederherzustellen und eine Sache die
möchte ich euch auch noch kurz erklären
wir haben hier in Deutschland den
schlimmsten Inlandsgeheimdienst
überhaupt den Verfassungsschutz und ihr
glaubt ja wohl nicht dass die uns auch
noch irgendeiner Form verbieten können
wenn wir Mitglied in dieser europäischen
Partei sind dann haben wir sozusagen den
Schutz der anderen um Politik für dieses
Land zu machen zweiter Punkt ist ich
sage auch Nummer eins Perspektive ab 20
25 kommt der Bundeskanzler oder die
Bundeskanzlerin auf diesem Saal aus der
AFD da müssen wir auch zeigen dass wir
mit den anderen europäischen Ländern
zusammenarbeiten wollen das heißt nicht
dass wir im Gegensatz zu den Altparteien
und ausverkaufen wollen wir werden den
zeigen dass es ein anderes Deutschland
gibt eine Europa deutsche und Europa der
gesicherten Grenzen aber wir werden mit
denen dann zusammen arbeiten müssen auf
Augenhöhe nicht als wirklich nicht als
ausver
Kauf aber wir brauchen diese
deswegen kann ich nur dafür appellieren
der Partei beizutreten vielen Dank
danke schön Herr Dr
Herr Dr spannel bitte ja vielen Dank für
das Wort wir haben nun einige Argumente
gehört die dafür sprechen dieser Partei
beizutreten und wir haben einige
Argumente gehört die dagegen sprechen
das ist eine für unsere Partei
weltanschaulich sehr wichtige
Entscheidung und in einer so wichtigen
Frage wie dieser ist unsere Partei und
das hat man hier an dem applausbild auch
denke ich ganz gut gehört doch nicht
einig zumindest nicht so einig wie sie
sein müsste um hier mit einer
geschlossenen Meinung einer Zeichen von
Stärke herauszugehen und ich möchte alle
bitten die dafür und dagegen geredet
haben Verständnis dafür zu haben wir
müssen uns heute und hier nicht
entscheiden zu diesem Thema und ich
bitte alle ich bitte alle doch hier in
dieser fundamental wichtigen Frage die
ich nicht mit der Brechstange auf diesem
Parteitag durch Saarbrücken wir kennen
viele Argumente pro und contra nicht wir
haben die Möglichkeit diese Frage bis zu
Europawahl in unseren Gremien zu
diskutieren und ich spreche sicherlich
für die Mehrheit der Delegierten hier
dass alle Argumente drohen contra den
aller wenigsten ich möchte fast
behaupten fast niemandem geläufig sind
teilweise kennt man die Argumente und
ich plädiere dafür und das ist jetzt
mein Antrag hier und heute salomonisch
mit nicht Befassung rauszugehen vielen
Dank ich stelle diesen Antrag auf nicht
Verfassung
Spanien war das und wir sehen dass diese
Debatte Hits dann doch die Gemüter es
gibt noch viele Redner die hier anstehen
die sich noch zu dieser Debatte äußern
wollen ob die AFD eine europäischen
Partei Beitritt
mit den Anträgen sn12
liebe Freunde wir müssen uns mit diesem
Antrag befassen denn wir brauchen in
Europa starke Partner
[Applaus]
wir sind nicht mehr so klein
wir wollen keine randständige Partei
sein wir wollen in Europa Mehrheiten
haben gegen die etablierten Parteien die
sich Europa zur Beute gemacht haben
darum plädiere ich für Befassung und
Abstimmungen bei diesem Antrag
vielen Dank wir haben damit die
Gegenrede gehört und kommen zur
Abstimmung des Antrags auf
Nichtbefassung mit den Anträgen SN1 und
2 wer ist dafür sich nicht mehr weiter
mit diesen Anträgen zu befassen
danke wer es dagegen und möchte darüber
weiterverhandeln
Dankeschön Enthaltungen danke das war
eine deutliche Mehrheit gegen die nicht
Befassung wir beraten weiter am roten
Saal Mikrofon geht's weiter ja vielen
Dank Stefan Kreuter kreisverwalt Essen
liebe Freunde ich Vertreter bei der
Parlamentarischen Versammlung der OSZE
unsere Bundestagsfraktion und wenn ich
dort tätig bin spüre ich regelmäßig dass
wir als afd-vertreter eines Skepsis
entgegenschlägt eine Skepsis weil viele
unserer europäischen Partner das
Bekenntnis zu der konservativen
Wertegemeinschaft der europäischen
Parteien der europäischen Partner
vermissen aber auch eine Skepsis weil
sie durch viele andere Vertreter gerade
der CDU gestört werden nach dem Motto
wenn ihr mit konservativen redet redet
mit uns lass die AFD außen vor das hat
schon zur Ausladung geführt das führt zu
Ausgrenzung und es ist eine
Sisyphusarbeit dafür einzutreten dass
wir als AFD als konservative Kraft ernst
genommen werden dieses Vertrauen was wir
uns hier bei der OSZE Organisation für
Sicherheit und Zusammenarbeit in Europa
aber auch im Europarat mit unserem
konservativen Partnern zusammen
erarbeiten das dürfen wir nicht
gleichwertig verspielen deshalb plädiere
ich dafür lasst uns hier ein klares
starkes Zeichen setzen wir geben unsere
Eigenständigkeit nicht auf dass wir mit
unseren konservativen Partnern in Europa
diese Europäische Union wieder von dem
Kopf auf die Füße stellen wollen
lasst uns Teil dieser europäischen
Konservativen Revolution sein und die
deutschen Beitrag dazu liefern und
nebenbei das letzte Schwert was diese
Regierung mit ihrem instrumentalisierten
Verfassungsschutz noch hat ist ein
Verbotsverfahren und wenn wir unter dem
Schutz stirbt unsere starken
europäischen Partner sind die häufig
schon die Mehrheiten in ihren Ländern
stellen und an Regierung beteiligt sind
dann wird das ein unmögliches Vorhaben
ich plädiere dafür lasst uns unter den
europäischen Schirm unserer
konservativen Partner schlüpfen und
lasst uns unseren konservativen Beitrag
leisten vielen Dank
vielen Dank nächster auf der Rednerliste
ist noch mal das rote sagen Mikrofon
hallo Martina
im Landesvorstand AFD BW ich habe gerade
gehört wir schlüpfen unter den Schirm
unserer starken Partner wer unter einen
Schirm schlüpft ist der noch
selbstständig
zweitens es ist doch einfach etwas sehr
wagemutig die Katze im Sack zu kaufen
wenn ich einen Vertrag mit jemanden
schließe dann habe ich die essential ja
negozi i davor ansonsten habe ich blind
zugestimmt das ist doch logisch und
natürlich wollen wir mit unseren
europäischen Partnern agieren aber dazu
unter werfe ich mich doch nicht im
Vorfeld das mache ich doch nur dann wenn
ich noch was zum Verhandeln habe und
deswegen würde ich dafür plädieren dass
wir diese Frage durchaus diskutieren
vielleicht auch später gar nicht
ablehnen oder hinten anstellen das wäre
Quatsch ganz alleine vorzugehen es ist
Harakiri aber doch bitte sauber und
solide und nicht mit einer Art Überfall
vielen Dank
vielen Dank zur Geschäftsordnung der
Kollege Gottschalk
also ich denke die Argumente sind
ausgetauscht unser Bundesvorstand hat
hier ein klares Statement abgegeben ich
glaube wir wollen auch mit einem Herbert
Kickl weiter zusammenarbeiten und auch
eine Bank die unter allen Schutzschirm
steht bleibt eigenständig der wird nur
geholfen wie es eben angedacht wurde
deswegen stelle ich den
Geschäftsordnungsantrag Ende der Debatte
und sofortiger Abstimmung über den
Antrag
Gegenrede Karsten Hülse
steht Antrag Aufschluss der debat
Gegenrede sind noch nicht alle Argumente
ausgetauscht aus meiner Sicht es gibt
viele hier in diesen Saal die in der in
diesem Beschluss dass wir dieser Idee
Partei beitreten sollen schon die
Grundlage dafür sehen dass wir unser
Parteiprogramm aufweichen und in unserem
Parteiprogramm zumindest in unserem
Wahlprogramm stand steht seit Dresden
dass wir aus dieser korrupten EU
austreten wollen und wenn wir jetzt
dieser Idee verteilt beitreten ist das
die Grundlage um diesen Programmpunkt
aufzuweichen deswegen bin ich darum
weiter zu debattieren Kurve gekriegt
vielen Dank dann kommen wir zur
abstimmungsantrags Aufschluss der
Debatte zu den Anträgen ist eins und
zwei wäre es für Schluss der Debatte
jetzt sofort
ihr seid alle wahnsinnig
danke wer ist gegenschluss der Debatte
danke Enthaltungen
dankeschön das war eine Mehrheit für
diesen Antrag die Debatte ist
geschlossen willkommen zur Abstimmung
des Antrages SN1 und im Falle dessen
Ablehnung des Antrages SN2 ich bitte den
Antrag SN1 einzublenden
damit auch für jeden klar ist wo
bewerbsteuer 1 ist der Antrag des
Bundesvorstands dass die AFD der
europäischen Partei Identität und
Demokratie Beitrag
auf Beitritt zur idee-partei seine
Zustimmung erteilen möchte den bitte ich
jetzt um die blaue Stimmkarte
danke wer ist gegen diesen Antrag
danke Enthaltungen danke schön wir
stellen fest das war eine deutliche
Mehrheit für den Antrag der Antrag ist
angenommen
damit tritt die AFD eine europäischen
Partei bei
und möchte damit also sich mit
europäischen Partnern zusammen tun um
gemeinsam für eine Sache zu kämpfen
natürlich ist das eine gewisse Ironie
dabei bei dieser Partei die zum Teilen
die Europäische Union abschaffen möchte
so weit die Debatte vor einiger Zeit zum
Beitritt der AFD in die europäische
Partei Identität und Demokratie und
jetzt sind wir wieder live auf dem 14
Parteitag der AFD in der Messe am
Magdeburg hier in der Landeshauptstadt
haben sich
553 Delegierte versammel dazu Gäste und
natürlich auch Presse denn die AFD hat
einiges zu beschließen es geht um einige
Satzungsänderungen und die das
bundesheetsgericht muss neu gewählt
werden und dann ab morgen
starten 5 Tage mit denen in denen sich
die AFD für die Europawahl aufstellen
möchte einerseits personell mit den
Kandidaten und dann auch programmatisch
man möchte dort über den Leitantrag
diskutieren den der Bundesvorstand schon
Delegierten vorgelegt hat Samstag und
Sonntag geht es noch weiter und dann
nächste Woche ab Freitag wird hier
debattiert
sie sehen dass wir hier immer noch in
den Wahlen sind die Wahlen zu den
Bundes-
[Musik]
und hier muss doch etwas geklärt werden
das wird aber anscheinend im bilateral
gemacht dann kann ich nur kurz erklären
was hier gerade zur Debatte stand es hat
sich nämlich ein Delegierter aus
Schleswig-Holstein hier als Kandidat
gemeldet Jens görtzen er ist allerdings
bei sich Mitglied eines Vorstands hat
dort an das Amt des Beisitzers inne und
das die Bestimmung der AFD sagen dass
der einen Mitglied des Schiedsgerichtes
nicht gleichzeitig auch Mitglied eines
Vorstands sein kann natürlich kann man
sich trotzdem bewerben nur es ist dann
so wenn nun in diesem Fall Jens görtzen
gewählt wurde dann müsste er von seinem
anderen Amt zurücktreten das hatte hier
noch einmal für Verzögerungen gesorgt
bzw das musste dann erst noch einmal
geklärt werden aber jetzt wird noch
einmal bilateral mit davon gesprochen
und wenn sich dann der die
Sitzungsleitung und der Kandidat einig
sind dann wird hier über Platz 4 des
bundesschichtsgerichts abgestimmt wir
haben drei Kandidierende die sich hier
gemeldet haben die sich vorgestellt
haben und auch auf Fragen der
Delegierten geantwortet haben dann kann
der Wahlgang beginnen
wie gesagt hält die Wahl findet jetzt
schon seit einiger Zeit statt aber das
bundesheetsgericht nimmt natürlich eine
wichtige Rolle
in einer Partei ein und deswegen möchte
die Partei und muss die Partei dort
natürlich auch die nötige Sorgfalt
walten lassen
ansonsten haben sich noch Tobias geil
beworben und Richard Albrecht Richard
Albrecht aus dem Landesverband
Schleswig-Holstein ist nicht vor Ort
könnte dementsprechend auch hier keine
Fragen beantworten aber auch das ist
möglich
Tobias Gall ist aus dem Bezirksverband
Charlottenburg Wilmersdorf seit 2019
Mitglied in der AFD also
für die war jetzt auch schon sogar die
Hälfte der seit bestehende AFD in die
AFD feiert ja heute hier auch ihr
zehnjähriges Bestehen das soll heute
Abend hier noch gefeiert werden
allerdings stehen vorher noch einige
wichtige Fragen an unter anderem geht es
darum wann die Mandatsträger Beiträge
gezahlt werden müssen und es geht auch
bei den landesschiedsgerichten einen
Antrag der fordert dass es
Kontrollmöglichkeiten über die Tätigkeit
der landesschiedsgerichte geben soll da
gibt es wohl
Schwierigkeiten mit einigen
Entscheidungen und deswegen fordern
einige Delegierte dass dort
Möglichkeiten geschaffen werden auch die
Landesgerichte zu kontrollieren
ganz konsten ist noch die Frage wie die
Delegierten ähm beschlossen werden
wieder Delegierten Schlüssel beschlossen
und errechnet wird auch das wird noch
eine Rolle spielen auf diesem Parteitag
da gibt es die Frage ob das tatsächlich
an den Mitgliederzahlen der
Landesverbände errechnet wird oder an
den stillenden
Mitgliederzahlen denn so im Antrag das
steht ist dass man keinen negativen
Anreiz für Landesverbände setzen möchte
dass diese etwas nachlässiger mit der
Zahlungsmoral umgehen und dann auf einen
Parteitag mehr Delegierte
hinschicken können sondern stattdessen
möchte man eben den Delegierten
Schlüssel in Zukunft
so ausrichten dass nur zahlende
Mitglieder dort auch eingerechnet werden
hier scheint es noch Klärungsbedarf zu
geben auf die Wahlhelferinnen und
Wahlhelfer sind noch nicht im Saal und
sie sehen ja auch die Ankündigung dass
der Wahlgang in Kürze beginnt deswegen
schauen wir schon mal auf die
Tagesordnung Morgen und 10 Uhr soll es
losgehen und da gibt es
selbstverständlich wieder die Begrüßung
durch den Bundessprecher und weil es
eben ein komplett neuer Parteitag
eigentlich ist also eine
europawahlversammlung und nicht wie
heute der Bundesparteitag der 14 wird
auch dort wieder ein Versammlungsleiter
gewählt die zielkommission
mandatsprüfungskommission
Antragskommission all das muss morgen
wieder gewählt werden ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass das allerdings relativ
zügig vonstatten geht weil das heute ja
schon eingeübt wurde und wir doch von
ähnlichen Personal ausgehen können dann
wird über die Tagesordnung abgestimmt
die wahrscheinlich so geändert wird das
zuerst über die Kandidierenden
entschieden wird und erst danach das
Programm
zur Debatte steht übrigens bei den
Kandidierenden
gibt es schon noch viele Diskussionen
wer sich da nun aufstellt
mehrere Namen wurden im Vorfeld schon
genannt Maximilian grade
Europaabgeordnete wurde immer wieder als
designierter Favorit genannt aber zum
Beispiel
gibt es mittlerweile auch ähm Anzeichen
dass Norbert Kleinwächter kommt
erst hier nicht Delegierter wird aber
morgen hier dann zur europa-versammlung
kommen und sich auch aufstellen lassen
ob er direkt
als
Kampfkandidatur kommt zu Maximilian
grade das werden wir dann morgen sehen
jetzt werden wir aber erst einmal über
den heutigen Parteitag sprechen mit Mark
jungen das macht Alexander Keller
ja hier wird nach Beendigung des ersten
Tages in der Halle hier auf dem
Messegelände eine große Sause
stattfinden zehn Jahre Feier für die AFD
und sie hat ja im Moment wirklich Grund
zu feiern wir wollen das jetzt mal zum
Anlass nehmen einen Rückblick zu nehmen
auf diese zehn Jahre wie konnte es
soweit kommen bis zum heutigen Tag und
da sind wir uns eingeladen Mark jungen
Bundesvorstand Beisitzer dort sind
Mitglied der bundesprogrammkommission
und
sie sind in der Partei gelten sie so als
chef-idiologe und Partei Philosoph
Mitglied im Bundestag sind sie ja auch
noch jungen wenn man sich die Motivation
ansieht
der AFD im Jahre 2013 was zu Gründung
der Partei geführt hat ist dieser Anlass
immer noch gegeben oder ist ihre
Parteien zwischen eine ganz andere
Partei geworden
sie ist sicher keine andere Partei
geworden aber sie hat neue Themen
hinzubekommen und hat sich sozusagen
entwickelt und hat auch auf die Zeit
Geschehnisse natürlich reagiert wir
hatten damals das eurothema sehr stark
im Vordergrund und diese permanente Euro
Rettungspolitik die für unsere
Wirtschaft und für ganz Europa
eigentlich sehr schlecht ist das sehen
wir nach wie vor so und ist nach wie vor
ein wichtiges Thema für uns aber es kam
natürlich die migrationskrise es kommt
jetzt die Energiekrise die auch Großteil
selbst gemacht ist die ist auch schon
eine ganze Weile da und darauf haben wir
natürlich in der reagiert und haben
unsere unsere Programmatik entsprechend
aufgebaut aber der Kern dass wir für die
Anliegen der Bürger und eine einstehen
und eine vernünftige bürgerliche Politik
machen der ist gleich geblieben
tatsächlich eine große Kontinuität
gibt es diese frontziehung noch in der
Partei zwischen bürgerlich konservativ
und völkisch neu rechts
also die habe ich in dieser Weise noch
nie so gesehen dass vieles auch
aufgebauscht worden völkisch das Wort
ist nicht passend wir stehen dafür dass
wir unsere Kultur unsere Nation erhalten
daran ist nichts völkisch und das
verbindet uns glaube ich alle es gibt
liberalere und etwas mehr soll man mal
sozialpatriotischere Mitglieder in
unserer Partei aber ich sehe sie uns
jetzt so aufgestellt dass wir doch alle
gemeinsam an einem Strang ziehen
sozialpatriotisch das äh verbindet man
vor allem mit dem Namen Björn höcke
präsentiert er nach dem Abgang von Jörg
Meuthen inzwischen sozusagen den
Mainstream in der Partei
der Mainstream in der Partei wird nicht
von einer Person oder von einem
Landesvorsitzenden repräsentiert er ist
ein Teil dieser Partei
selbstverständlich aber wie gesagt es
sind sehr viele hier Strömungen oder
Landesverbände zu berücksichtigen und
gemeinsam
bilden wir hier sowas wie einen
Mainstream also da kann man nicht von
einem vorräter oder dergleichen sprechen
der Hintergrund der Frage war ja das von
ihm im nächsten Jahr der Durchmarsch an
die Parteispitze erwartet wird es gab ja
eine Satzungsänderung das ist in Zukunft
auch nur einen Parteivorsitzenden gibt
erwarten Sie das wird das
wirklicherweise nach dem nächsten
Parteitag wenn der Vorstand neu gewählt
wird einen alleinigen Parteivorsitzenden
geben
das kann es geben nach der Satzung wäre
das aber sein wird darüber werde ich
mich jetzt hier keine Spekulationen
hingeben wir haben viele gute Kandidaten
aber vor allem haben wir zwei sehr sehr
gute Vorsitzende zurzeit und ich sehe da
auch keinen Grund daran was zu ändern
windfall profits über so schön sagt die
heben ja gerade die um die AFD in den
Umfrage Himmel kann man sagen das
politische Geschäft ihrer Partei besorgt
im Moment der politische Gegner wie
lange wird dieser Umstand noch anhalten
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das nur der
politische Gegner besorgt sondern die
Bürger merken ja mehr und mehr dass wir
gute Politik Angebote machen und dass
wir Lösungen für die brennenden Fragen
parat haben die alle Bürger bewegen
natürlich ist das Versagen dieser
Ampelkoalition offensichtlich und die
reiten Deutschland in den Abgrund das
ist so das wird immer offensichtlicher
und das bewirkt dass die Menschen sich
woanders hin nämlich zur einzigen
Opposition hin orientieren aber dort
finden sie eben auch die richtigen
Angebote das muss man ganz klar
feststellen Amerika Hassan Putin Freunde
die melden sich in der Partei immer
lautstark zu Wort ist nicht so ganz klar
ob sie tatsächlich die Mehrheit bieten
aber bilden aber sie wollen ja in
Zukunft auch das wird ja hier immer
wieder gesagt mit anderen Parteien
Regierungen bilden diese Positionierung
die wird Ihnen aber nicht helfen an
politische Macht und an politische
Verantwortung zu gelangen
also ich muss das zurückweisen Amerika
hasse und Putin Freunde das stimmt so
überhaupt nicht niemand in der AFD hasst
Amerika wir sehen vieles kritisch was
die jetzige amerikanische Regierung tut
aber wir haben natürlich großes
Interesse auch mit Amerika und mit den
USA ein eine gute Verbindung und eine
gute Zusammenarbeit zu pflegen und was
Russland angeht Russland wird nicht von
europäischen Karte verschwinden wir
müssen auch jetzt in der schwierigen
Situation darauf sehen darauf achten
dass irgendwo dann auch nach diesem
Krieg der hoffentlich bald enden wird
auch Beziehungen zu Russland wieder
möglich sind und vor allem
Handelsbeziehung das ist unsere
vernünftige Position dazu wenn ich mir
heute die Rede von Kinoprogramm am
Anfang des parteiwerks angesehen hat er
hat von Kriegstreiben gesprochen gegen
die Partei ist im Kontext war ganz klar
dass er damit den Westen die USA meint
sie müssen kinopala zu sein und Worten
befragen er vertritt ganz klar die Linie
die ich jetzt auch hier aufgezeigt habe
und damit ist dazu eigentlich alles
gesagt er gibt es noch genügend
Transatlantiker in der AFD
ich glaube wir müssen nicht nach
transatlantikern suchen oder darum darin
unser Heil sehen sondern wir müssen
darauf achten dass Deutschland wieder
stärker wird stark wird dass wir auch
wieder eine bärfähige Armee bekommen und
vor allem das Europa ein Faktor wird in
der Weltpolitik der ernst zu nehmen ist
und der weder unter dem Einfluss der USA
noch sonst irgendeinem Einfluss aus dem
ferneren Osten steht sondern wir müssen
eigenständig stark werden dafür stehen
wir von der AFD ich habe am Anfang
gesagt sie sind ja auch Mitglieder der
bundesprogrammkommission also die das
Grundsatzprogramm und Wahlprogramme
erarbeitet es geht jetzt auch in den
nächsten Tagen ja darum darüber zu
diskutieren wie sich die AFD Europa
politisch aufstellt da ist immer noch
ein Begriff drin in diesem Entwurf ich
glaube sogar eine Beamte da steht drin
eine geordnete Abwicklung der
Europäischen Union es wird von einer
zukünftigen Werte und Interessen
Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft Gerede die aber
sehr die Fuß bleibt wie die AFD wirklich
eine Europa politisch orientierte eine
Partei bleiben oder schwebt ihn
eigentlich da was ganz anderes vor
wollen sich ein Stück weit von Europa
auch zurückziehen ganz im Gegenteil wir
wollen Europa wieder stark machen wie
gesagt wir finden aber dass der Kurs der
gegenwärtigen EU nämlich einen
EU-Superstaat allmählich zu errichten
und die Souveränität der Nationalstaaten
zu entziehen dass das der falsche Weg
ist und wir haben hier Zweifel
angemeldet ob die EU noch fähig ist sich
selbst zu reformieren wir halten diese
Reform für essentiell wichtig wir müssen
sozusagen die europäische Zusammenarbeit
auf eine neue Basis stellen und diese
Basis muss lauten Subsidiarität
Souveränität bei den Nationalstaaten und
Zusammenarbeit in den Bereichen wo es
wirklich notwendig ist spricht
gemeinsame Verteidigung der Außengrenzen
freie Handel zwischen den einzelnen
Staaten aber nicht darüber hinausgehen
und eine gemeinsame Sozialpolitik
Steuerpolitik etc diesen Weg geht die EU
zur Zeit das lehnen wir ab und das
machen wir in unserem Wahlprogramm
deutlich die Frage nicht ob die wirklich
viel alle zusammenrücken muss dass die
nationalstaatliche Weg eigentlich der
falsch ist für die einzelnen 27
EU-Mitglieder wir sagen wir müssen im
weltweiten Wettbewerb mithalten mit USA
mit Russland mit China dann Streben
lauter kleine zum Teil auch kleine
europäische Nationalstaaten mit auf von
Luxemburg über Lettland bis malta ist
das wirklich so sinnvoll dass in die
nationalstaatliche Souveränität
zurückzuführen angesichts der weltweiten
Konkurrenz auch der globalen Konkurrenz
mit der wir rechnen müssen das ist ja
das Argument dass immer wieder
vorgebracht wird von denen die die
einfach closer Union wollen aber ich
glaube dieses Argument ist grundsätzlich
falsch in den Bereichen wo wir ein
gemeinsames Auftreten nach außen
brauchen und das sinnvoll ist dort
wollen wir daran auch nichts ändern aber
es ist klug und gesund wenn man einen
gewissen Wettbewerb auch zwischen den
einzelnen Staaten hat z.B
Steuerwettbewerb wenn einzelne Staaten
ihre eigene Währungspolitik noch
selbst bestimmen können
damit schaffen wir ein viel stärkeres
Europa als jetzt wo wir beispielsweise
starten in einen Euro hineinzwingen die
dort damit gar nicht umgehen können und
denen das nur massive Nachteile bringt
also im Grunde wir wollen Europa stärken
aber nicht auf dem Weg wie es die EU zur
Zeit tut wir glauben dass das eine
Schwächung und letztlich eine Schädigung
der europäischen Länder ist bei der EURO
ja der deutschen Wirtschaft durchaus
geholfen hat andere Länder können nicht
mehr abwerten um ihre Produkte besser
verkaufen zu können ja also wenn Sie der
Meinung sind dass die deutsche
Wirtschaft jetzt so gut dasteht wie nie
dann ist das vielleicht Ihre Antwort
früher so
früher hatten wir die D-Mark und die
D-Mark hat uns stark gemacht andere
Länder haben sich daran orientiert haben
sich auch an unsere währungsdisziplin
gehalten jetzt ist das alles hier dahin
die Tage zahlten häufen sich auf und wir
haben unendlich schulden wir Billionen
von Schulden wenn man das alles
zusammenzählt wir haften für europäische
Schulden dem
deutschen Bürger ist anderes versprochen
worden und die Rechnung wird hier noch
bitter sein und groß sein wir wollen das
verhindern und wir wollen das
Deutschland wieder stark werden und das
geht nur wenn wir Souveränität
zurückgewinnen aber im Verein mit den
europäischen Partnern wollen wir dazu
kommen und nicht dagegen das war jetzt
ja auch der Gründer der gründungsmotor
der AFD darum ging es ja auch in diesem
Gespräch Anlass war ja die Kritik an der
Europolitik der Europäischen Zentralbank
und der EU-Länder Markierungen im
Gespräch bei völlig danke dass sie da
waren
so und wir geben jetzt oder gehen jetzt
gleich zurück zu Katharina kühn
möglicherweise hat jetzt so die letzte
halbe Stunde hier auf dem Parteitag
begonnen
ja vielen Dank und ich kann Ihnen sagen
während hier das Interview geführt wurde
haben sie keine bahnbrechenden
Entwicklungen verpasst auf diesen
Parteitag denn hier musste intern noch
einiges geklärt werden eben wegen dieser
Unvereinbarkeit die ich vorhin schon
erklärt hatte eines Postens in einem
Vorstand und dann eben das Postens im
bundesschichtsgericht und jetzt ist es
so dass einer der drei Kandidaten
dementsprechend auch seine Kandidatur
zurückgezogen hat wobei jetzt nicht
erwähnt wurde warum er seine Kandidatur
zurückgezogen hat aber vorher wurde das
hier noch einmal betont dass man sich
darüber noch einmal
klar werden muss das ist eben nicht
möglich ist beide Posten zu behalten und
dementsprechend wurde hier immer noch
nicht gewählt der Platz vier für den ist
nur noch zwei Kandidaten gibt es
Schiedsgericht es gibt auch noch die
Stellvertreter die müssen auch noch
gewählt werden also hier es stehen noch
einige Abstimmungen an wir werden nun
allerdings nicht die ganze Zeit den
Abgeordneten dabei zuschauen während sie
auf die Abstimmung warten sondern wir
wollen ganz gerne noch einmal ein
Grußwort zeigen hier auf dem Parteitag
hat sich die AFD von mehreren
europäischen Politikern grüßen lassen
und für die Partei
dem Identität und Demokratie hat ihr
Vorsitzender gesprochen Gerolf annemanns
hier in Magdeburg
meine Damen und Herren liebe Freunde was
für eine Ehre und Freude mich für mich
persönlich aber auch für meine
Nationalpartei Flames Belangen
hier und heute heute mit Ihnen diesen
Jahrestag fallen zu dürfen und dabei die
Größe parteiflanden und vielleicht auch
noch Belgiens zu vertreten ein
herzlichen Dank der alles und dir an der
Tino für diese freundschaftliche
Einladung
vier vier von Pflanz Belangen sind tief
und innig überzeugt das Belgien für
läufig noch Mitgliedsstaaten der
Europäischen Union ein historischer
Fehler war und dass wir Flammen in einem
verkehrten und naturwidrigen Staat
geraden sind
wir von Pflanzen Belangen sind deshalb
bestrebt diesen Fehler durch die
geordnete Aufteilung Belgiens zu beheben
genau wie die denen
genau wie die Luxemburger die Franzosen
und die Deutschen wollen wir unser
eigenes unabhängigen Staat deshalb
übermittle ich Ihnen hier und heute in
freundschaftlicher und stolzer
Verbundenheit meine herzliche Grüße und
Glückwünsche auch im namens
ich bin da ich bin ja nicht mehr der
Jüngste und könnte schon lange vor der
Friede Vereinigung von Ost und
Westdeutschland hautnah die politischen
Bestrebungen miterleben Parteien und
Bewegungen in Deutschland zu gründen die
den Begriff kulturell Identität
politisch verankern und das in Zeiten
zunehmender Einwanderung und verstärkter
bürosentralisierung der politischen
Macht es war nicht einfach in diesem
Umfeld eine stabile politische Partei
aufzubauen die ein Gefühl der Nähe und
Verbundenheit mit den Wählerinnen und
Wähler der Mittelschicht schafft eine
große Partei die dazu in der Lage ist um
endlich die Machtverhältnisse zu
verschieben wie wir dies schon in
Frankreich in Österreich den
Niederlanden und den Flandern beobachten
könnten
dass sie Bestrebungen hier erst einmal
einige Rückschläge hinnehmen mussten und
letztendlich doch gefürchtet haben ist
das größte Verdienst große Verdienst der
AFD und das ist auch der Grund warum wir
sie von ganzem Herzen und mit und
Mitgefühl diesen wohlverdienten
Jahrestag beglückwünschen dürfen
mit der mit der Feier zu ihrem
zehnjährigen Bestehen und in dem Wissen
dass sie nächstes Jahr vor einem großen
Durchbruch stellen möchten wir Sie
weiter in ihrem Mut und Vorhaben
bestärken Deutschland ist ein Vielfaches
größer
Flandern und ihre Verantwortung und Ihre
Herausforderungen haben natürlich eine
andere große
Größenordnung also bei uns das ist uns
sehr wohl bewusst aber wir bringen gerne
unser erfahren mit und unsere
Bereitschaft den Aufbau unserer
europäischen Zusammenarbeit weiter voran
zu bringen auch wenn dies so wie es in
unserer DNA programmiert ist eine
europäischen Zusammenarbeit in
Unabhängigkeit und Freiwilligkeit ist
[Applaus]
denn allen voran und hier spreche ich
als jemand der 40 Jahre lang zielstrebig
am Aufbau einer inzwischen stabilen
rechten Volkspartei für flanderen
gearbeitet hat und sich dabei oft auf
Wagen terrellen bewegen musste allem
voran bringe ich Ihnen etwas mit das
beim Aufbau einer solche Partei wichtig
und notwendig ist nämlich die
Freundschaft europäischer
Gleichgesinnter die sie in dem unter in
die sie
in dem unterstützen was sie und wer Sie
sind
[Musik]
denn immer mehr Mitgliedstaaten haben
wir nun ein mündiger Rechte Kraft im
Land die in der Lage ist die alten
Mächte zu vertreiben und einen neuen
Kurs einzuschlagen die alten
machtparteien Christen Demokraten und
Sozialisten die noch aus dem 19
Jahrhundert stammen und nicht mehr
imstande sind eine klare Vision für die
Probleme des 21 jahrhunderts zu
entwickeln sie sind nicht mehr klar und
ihrer angeblichen politischen
Korrektheit lassen sie sich Liebe von
Grünen und teilweise sogar Kommunisten
an die Karren spannenden als das zu tun
was die Bürger wirklich wollen mit
Parteien
mit Parteien
mit Parteien wie denn unsere haben die
Bürger jetzt die Möglichkeit den Wunsch
der arbeitenden Bevölkerung demokratisch
durchzusetzen unsere idee-fraktion im
Europäischen Parlament und unsere
europäische politische parteiidee mögen
in der angeblich politisch korrekten
Welt der Mächtigen und Medien als
Rebellen gelten doch der Gesellschaft
sind wir eine immer breitere Strömung
die unsere Länder in die richtige
Richtung führt wir allen in die
idee-partei werden unseren auffreuen auf
den Beitritt unserer natürlichen
deutschen Partner AFD es ist eine
Verstärkung unserer Zusammenarbeit auf
europäische Ebene es ist natürlich eine
Bestätigung der Grundlage unserer
Zusammenarbeit um im idefraktion des
Europäischen Parlament und für alle
Partner in Idee ein Zeichen dass sie AFD
nicht nur technisch aber politisch eng
mit uns verbunden ist und es auch sein
möchte danke
deshalb
deshalb sage ich hier im Namen der
idee-bewegung Fraktion sowie Partei
insgesamt und natürlich auch im Name vom
Slams Belangen es lebe unsere
europäische Freundschaft es lebe die AFD
lang lebe die AFD lang lebe Pflanzen
Deutschland es lebe für anderen
[Musik]
dann dürfen
so weit also hier der Rückblick und zwar
war das das Grußwort von Gerolf
annemanns der Vorsitzende der Partei
Identität und Demokratie und auch
Mitglied von Flames Belang also ein
belgischer Politiker der sich hier auf
dem 14
afd-bundesparteitag auch geäußert hat
wir sind immer noch in der Abstimmung zu
einem
bundes-richter ein Kandidat hat schon
die erforderliche Mehrheit gewonnen und
zwar ging es um Platz 3 im
Bundesschiedsgericht Roman Golombeck
hatte keine Gegenkandidaten und wurde
gewählt aus dem Landesverband Sachsen
und ist jetzt Teil des
bundesschichtsgerichts
wir wollen noch einmal uns eine
Zusammenfassung des bisherigen
Geschehens anschauen die hat Marion
Kerst heute erstellt
die guten Umfragewerte heben die
Stimmung hier beim Bundesparteitag in
Magdeburg doch gleich zu Beginn mahntino
kropalla der die Partei gemeinsam mit
Alice Weidel führt darauf dürfe sich die
Partei nicht ausruhen
und Hessen werden im Herbst neue
Landtage gewählt und nächstes Jahr
können wir in Sachsen Thüringen und
Brandenburg stärkste Kraftwerke können
Regierungsverantwortung übernehmen und
die Wende zum Guten bewirken wir sind
bereit für mehr das ist unser Slogan
dieses Partei Tages eine große Rolle
spielt die Haltung der AFD zur
Europäischen Union viele in der Partei
sehen die EU kritisch wollen sie radikal
umgestalten so auch der derzeitige
EU-Parlamentarier und mögliche
Spitzenkandidat für die kommende
Europawahl ich sage immer stärker raus
Stecker rein und neues Betriebssystem
also wir brauchen Europa Politik wir
brauchen europäische Institution aber
das was wir zur Zeit aus Brüssel haben
ist für Deutschland schädlich das heißt
also es geht so wie es jetzt ist sicher
nicht weiter laut das Programm Entwurf
zur Europawahl fordert die AFD auch die
Auflösung des EU-Parlamentes und einige
in der AFD wollen sogar das Deutschland
aus der EU austritt
wohin das führt lässt sich sehr leicht
am Fall von Großbritannien ablesen
nämlich eben gerade nicht zu
Wirtschaftswachstum und die
Verflechtungen sind so eng dass man sich
die damit verbundenen Folgen
voraussichtlich im Augenblick gar nicht
klar macht morgen beginnt die
Kandidatenkür für die Europawahl für die
voraussichtlich 30 Listenplätze gibt es
70 Bewerber
also soweit als ich hier eine erste
Zusammenfassung von diesem Freitag in
der Messe in Magdeburg hier auf dem
afd-parteitag den Patienten
Bundesparteitag ist der letzte Wahlgang
für die bundesschiedsrichter gerade zu
Ende gegangen allerdings stehen jetzt
die Stellvertreter an so dass es hier
noch zu einigen Wahlen kommen wird und
das ist ja schon ein guter Vorgeschmack
für morgen denn morgen stehen ja auch
einige Kosten an nämlich man möchte dort
die Kandidierenden für die Europawahl
aufstellen und wählen 20 Kandidaten
posten sollen vergeben werden denn so
viel erhofft die AFD angesichts der
aktuellen guten Umfragewerte dass sie
eventuell mit 20 Personen ins
Europaparlament einziehen kann
wir
schreiten auf die 18 Uhr zu und das
bedeutet für mich dass ich mich schon
mal von ihnen verabschiede für heute
aber Alexander Keller der wird noch ein
Gespräch führen
ja liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer
das was jetzt jedoch besprochen wird auf
den Parteitag und möglicherweise
interessant wird werden wir in morgen in
einer kurzen Zusammenfassung auch noch
präsentieren die wesentlichen Dinge
dieses Parteitags das habe ich
versprochen werden Sie auf jeden Fall
mitbekommen wir wollen ein
Abschlussgespräch mit unseren beiden
journalistischen Kolleginnen und
Kollegen an Kathrin Müller vom Spiegel
und Alexander von der 90er Zeitung
machen mit einem erstmal im Rückblick
auf den heutigen Tag da ist ja eine
Sache aufgefallen da gab es ja auch
Diskussionen dass die AFD ja der
europäischen parteifamilie Identität und
Demokratie beitreten will
Alexander das war ja durchaus heftig
diese Diskussion also so richtig einig
ist man sich nicht oberhalb der
nationalen Ebene noch weiterhin
politisch aktiv zu sein ja das bleibt ja
genau die spannende Auseinandersetzung
auch wenn wir am nächsten Wochenende
dann die Debatte über das
europawahlprogramm haben werden wird
genau dass die Frage sein wie weit will
die AFD sich integrieren in einer
europäische Parteienfamilie wie weit
will sie ein eigenständigen Weg gehen
das wird sich auch einer Personalien
mutmaßlich morgen zeigen es ging damit
ungefähr sagen zwei Drittel mehr hat
durch der Zutritt zur Partei in der
Fraktion Idee ist man ja schon und die
Gegenrede hat geheißen man würde den
Verrat begeht einem Prinzipien
Kompromiss sei Verrat also da war
ungefähr noch ungefähr ein Drittel der
Partei dieser Meinung kein Kompromiss
nur für Deutschland eintreten aber zwei
Drittel haben sich durchgesetzt es ist
doch eine Sache Wende zu etwas mehr
Realpolitik in Europa das heißt es ist
sehr stark nationalistisch nach wie vor
in der AFD auch geprägt mit Blick auf
Europa
ja man hat gemerkt dass die paar die da
eben gegenargumentiert haben und die
dann etwa ein Drittel oder ein bisschen
mehr hatten dass die eben versucht haben
dieses Bild zu zeichnen wir wollen doch
nur für Deutschland da sein nur für die
deutschen und dass sie damit aber auch
gescheitert sind weil sie selber das
beste Gegenargument geliefert haben
nämlich dass auch Geld lockt wenn man
eben dieser Partei Beitritt und so war
dann eben auch die Stimmung dass man da
lieber beiträgt gegen Argument gegen
diesen Beitritt dass man zu sehr sich
dann auf
Programmatiken einlassen muss auf der
europäischen Ebene die gar nicht im
Sinne der AFD ist da gibt es ja durchaus
auch Kontroversen rechtskonservativen
Lager das heißt die AFD müssen sich dann
schon ein bisschen in diese europäische
Parteien Familie auch einordnen wenn sie
mit einer Stimme sprechen ja das ist
sehr schwierig wir hatten am Anfang
Gerede von der Propeller und hatte ja
eigentlich Gewehr oder deutlich gesagt
also die Interessen gehen auch vor der
Fraktionsdisziplin also nach dem Motto
daran wird er gedacht haben Ukraine
Krieg müssen wir schauen dass wir als
Friedenspartei gehört unseren Russland
freundlichen Kurs durchhalten auch wenn
innerhalb der Fraktion oder jetzt sogar
innerhalb der Partei die stärkere Flügel
auf der Seite der Ukraine sich befindet
das wird noch schwierig es muss ja ganz
viele Zustände in dieser Fraktion im
Europäischen Parlament geben da wo die
AFD ja schon Mitglied ist in dieser
Fraktionsgemeinschaft der Parteien
Identität und Demokratie der der sich
jetzt gerade anschickt Spitzenkandidat
zu werden morgen Maximilian Graf der hat
ja im französischen
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf gar nicht
seine Parteifreundin oder von der vom
Restaurant National Marine unterstützt
die ja mit Abgeordneten vertreten sind
in der gleichen Fraktion sondern der
politischen Gegner ehrlich sind nur da
hat sich ja schon gezeigt dass es da
auch Ausschläge gibt wird diese Spannung
erhalten bleiben
allerdings auch dass es möglich ist
während man in der Fraktion ist jemand
anderen zu unterstützen und sich eben
anders zu äußern es wurde auch von den
Befürwortern direkt gesagt wir können
auch wieder austreten wenn es nicht
funktioniert wenn wir uns zu sehr
mäßigen sollten also insofern ist es
jetzt der Versuch sich da europäisch
besser zu vernetzen gerade mit der FPÖ
und anderen und da eben auch das Geld
eben abzustauben und dann aber im
Zweifel auch andere Positionen zu
vertreten die eben noch weiter rechts
sind wie sieht das aus mit den Chancen
von Maximilian Grah der ja in der AFD
nicht unumstritten ist in Brüssel nicht
er war ja wegen dieses illoualen
Verhaltens auch zeitweise suspendiert in
dieser Fraktion im Europäischen
Parlament jetzt schickt er sich an die
AFD in Brüssel zu repräsentieren wird
das Auswirkungen haben hat er dann eine
Chance gewählt zu werden es gibt ein
ganzes Bündel von Vorwürfen können wir
jetzt gar nicht alles in der kürzeste
Zeit hier referieren diese Vorwürfe
machen auch hier die Runde auf den
Gängen das merkt man wenn man mit den
Delegierten spricht gestern Abend hätte
ich gesagt er geht glatt durch heute
hört man so mein persönlicher Eindruck
vom stimmbild das ist doch längst nicht
sagen sicher ob er wirklich die nötige
Mehrheit die absolute Mehrheit der
abgegebenen Stimmen erhalten wird es
wird sich heute Abend morgen früh zeigen
ob es einen Gegenkandidaten gibt und
falls das eine eloquente Person ist die
genau nicht diesen Ballast mit sich
herumschleppt und also keinen Blues
kennen wollten wissen ist hätte dieser
Gegenkandidat durchaus Chancen und Herr
Kabel ist auch ein Apfel beißen sehr
sehr spannend
AFD hat sich jetzt durch diesen Beitritt
zur Parteienfamilie ja zu europäischen
Identität bekannt wird sie die wirklich
leben hier in ihrem Partei Leben ich
glaube es wird sich nicht so viel ändern
also sie ist auch jetzt schon so
unterwegs dass sie sagt sie möchte eine
Art Europa der Vaterländer sie möchte
eben da eine Zusammenarbeit mit dem
Parteien die nahe stehen aber nicht
unbedingt mit allen Ländern sie möchte
unser Land zuerst weiterhin nach vorne
stellen auch das wurde gesagt und dann
ist eben die Frage in Kooperation mit
welchen Ländern man sucht ja auch
weiterhin die Zusammenarbeit mit
Russland man geht Richtung China also da
gibt's ja auch außerhalb der EU noch
mögliche Partner
zu dem was da uns in den nächsten Tagen
erwartet zunächst ist ja ursprünglich
geplant über das Wahlprogramm zur
Europawahl zu reden danach die
Nominierung jetzt wird das alle
höchstwahrscheinlich umgedreht es liegt
ein Antrag vor der wahrscheinlich
durchgeht also erst die Nominierung
aller Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten um
auf der rechtlich sicheren Seite zu sein
sonst könnte sein dass es auch
Einsprüche gibt wenn man auf diesen
Parteitag nicht alle Kandidaten benennen
kann und danach erst das Wahlprogramm
jetzt kommt man in die interessante
Situation dass jemand kandidiert setzt
sich durch und dann wird er ein
Wahlprogramm verabschiedet dass er gar
nicht vertreten kann ja obwohl man ja
sagen muss dass die Position gar nicht
so weit auseinander sind das ist
natürlich ein Unterschied wenn man sagt
man will ganz aus der EU raus oder man
will die EU sozusagen von innen
reformieren aber es sind ja jetzt nicht
komplett verschiedene Parteiprogramme
die da vorgelegt werden sondern in den
Nuancen unterschiedliche Anträge und
insofern muss dann der jeweilig gewählte
das im vertreten was die Partei gemacht
hat bzw in der Vergangenheit haben wir
gesehen dass es bei der AFD auch nicht
so schlimm ist wenn man eine etwas
andere Position vertritt als das was auf
dem Papier steht
in der Tat ja zu erwarten dass es gerade
in der Frage zu Europa zur
westverankerung Deutschland doch
durchaus heftige Diskussion gibt mehr
als heute noch und da gibt es ja auch
wirklich Kontroversen innerhalb der
Bundestagsfraktion die auch innerhalb
der Parteiorganisation das hat sich ja
bis in die Bundesprogramm Kommission
fortgesetzt da ist man sich nicht so
ganz klar was man eigentlich jetzt will
und über was dann auch abgestimmt werden
soll das heißt es könnte dadurch aus
noch zu erheblichen Verschiebungen
kommen in der in der inhaltlichen
Diskussion der nächsten Tage also ich
würde ja keine Prognosen abgeben aber
das personaltor- welche programmatischen
Blöcke man wirklich einschlagen will man
hört von vielen Delegierten hier dass
sie nicht sehr glücklich gewesen sein
mit der Formulierung von Propeller der
Deutschland dürfen nicht zum Anhängsel
des Westens werden also diese ganz
starken Anti westlichen teilweise
anti-amerikanisch zugespitzensten
Polemiken fallen nicht überall auf
fruchtbaren Boden je nachdem wer sich
auf welcher Position durchsetzt wird
dann auch die Gegenseite in
Anführungszeichen darauf pochen das auch
aus ihrem personalverbot jemand den Sieg
davon trägt also ich glaube bei der AFD
sieht man ein Programm Politik wird über
Personen gemacht und die Personen werden
an diesem oder am nächsten Wochenende
festgezogen wird bei anderen Leuten
gesprochen als ich weil die fanden das
eigentlich ganz gut dass die beiden
und offensichtlich hat es ja insgesamt
dadurch das propala und andere an der
Spitze sind schon auch die
russlandfreundlichere sich durchgesetzt
da gibt es ja immer wieder Streit in der
Partei aber die transatlantica werden
halt immer weniger oder immer leiser
Anhänger haben sie gesagt will man nicht
sein des Westens ein bisschen putzig
diese Äußerung ist Parteivorsitzenden
denn seit 1949 sind wir Bestandteil des
westlichen Bündnisses auch der
westlichen Wertegemeinschaft das heißt
also die AFD will Deutschland ein Stück
weit rausbrechen naja es läuft ja immer
das Stichwort der der Souveränität der
nationalsouveränität ist strategischen
Souveränität und natürlich schwingt im
Hintergrund auch schon die nahto Debatte
mit also man fragt sich immer in der
Natur drin bleiben bisher sehe ich keine
mehr die für den Austritt ist aber ein
bisschen abwarten wir sehen uns morgen
wieder an Kathrin Müller und Alexander
Liebe ZuschauerInnen Zuschauer das war's
jetzt für heute vom AFD Bundesparteitag
morgen beginnt die europa-versammlung
live ab 10 Uhr bei Phoenix wir haben
gleich damit Besuch alles weiter wird
uns beehren und ähm wir werden dann
morgen also mit der europa-versammlung
als der inhaltlich fast wichtigeren
dieses Parteitags oder dieses
Zusammentreffens hier
uns beschäftigen radikale Staatsdiener
der AFD oder Titel einer Dokumentation
jetzt bei Phoenix bleiben Sie bei uns